WHEN I TAKE A MOMENT TO
APOLOGIZE WE APOLOGIZE FOR
KEEPING YOU ALL WAITING?
WE ALSO WANNA IS A THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE TODAY WE APOLOGIZE IT
MANY OF YOUR STANDING AS WE HAVE
A BUSY CALENDAR HERE TODAY.
WEHAD TWENTY SIX WE ARE NOW
DOWN TO TWENTY FIVE BILLS THAT
WILL BE IN FRONT OF THIS.
ITEM TWENTY TWO AB SEVENTEEN
THIRTY ONE HAS BEEN PULLED FROM
TODAY'S AGENDA AT THE REQUEST OF
THE AUTHOR.
WE HAVE TWO BILLS THAT ARE ON
CONSENT THIS MORNING ITEM NUMBER
FIVE AB.
ONE SEVEN SIX IN ITEM NUMBER.
SEVEN EIGHTY FOUR ONE FOUR DAYS
IN GERMAN WE'D LIKE TO BE ABLE
TO START ON ITEM NUMBER TWENTY
THIS ISAB.
FIFTEEN EIGHTY THREE AS A MEMBER
EGGMAN AND WE ALWAYS LOVE IT
WHEN OUR STATE TREASURER IS IN
COMMITTEE.
WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL THAT MISS
Mà IS HERE IS WELL WE WELCOME
AS A MEMBER EGGMAN AT TO
COMMITTEE THE FLOOR IS YOURS
MA'AM THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
AB FIFTEEN EIGHTY THREE WOULD
ESTABLISH THE CALIFORNIA
RECYCLING MARKET DEVELOPMENT ACT
FOR EMMA AS WE LIKE TO TALK HELP
COLLEGE WHICH SEEKS TO BALANCE
CALIFORNIA'S AMBITIOUS ORGANIC
WASTE DIVERSION GOALS WITH
CHANGING MARKET REALITIES.
ARE STATES TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
ORGANIC DIVERSION RATE GOAL OF
75% IS RAPIDLY APPROACHING.
MEANWHILE TRYING TO SORT POLICY
HAS CRIPPLED ARE RECYCLING
SECTOR AND AS A RESULT OUR
LANDFILLS ARE BACK TO
OVERFLOWING.
IF WE ARE SERIOUS ABOUT FIXING
THE PROBLEM THAT WE NEED TO
START ADDRESSING RECYCLING IN A
COMPREHENSIVE MANNER.
RESPONDING TO THE CONTAMINATION
LEVELS OR RECYCLED EXPORTS
WITHOUT MARKET AND
INFRASTRUCTURE DEVELOPMENT WILL
NOT SOLVE THIS CRISIS.
AB FIFTEEN EIGHTY THREE SIX TO
TACKLE THESE ISSUES BY
ADDRESSING THE ENTIRE WAY STREAM.
THIS BEGINS BY EDUCATING THE
PUBLIC THROUGH OUR CURBSIDE
RECYCLING COMMISSION AND
ENCOURAGING MARKET DEVELOPMENT
AND TECHNOLOGY ADVANCEMENT SIR
WHEN CENTER PROGRAM SUCH AS KATE
FOR A AND THE R. M. DZ LOAN
PROGRAM.
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY AS
STATE CALIFORNIA STATE TREASURER
FIONA MA. ONE OF OUR SPONSORS AT
NICK LAPIS WITH CALIFORNIA'S
AGAINST WASTE -- AND THE
DIRECTOR OF OUR KEEP FOR PROGRAM
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU SO
MUCH GOOD MORNING MADAM TREASURE
THE FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS --
I'VE HAD A KEEN.
INTEREST IN GARBAGE AND
RECYCLING SINCE MY TIME ON THE
SAN FRANCISCO BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN 200-022-2000 SIX
WHEN.
OUR ALTAMONTE LAND FILLED WAS --
ALMOST AT CAPACITY AND SINCE
THEN -- WE HAVE BEEN WORKING
VERY CLOSELY WITH MEMBERS HERE
ON TRYING TO FIGURE OUT.
HOW TO ADDRESS THE RECYCLING?
CRISIS THAT WE HAVE -- FACING US
HERE IN CALIFORNIA I'M HERE TO
TESTIFY ON ONE OF THE PROVISIONS
IN THIS BILL WHICH EXTENT
EXTENDS A SUNSET DATE FOR SALES
AND USE TAX EXCLUSION. FOR
CERTAIN MANUFACTURERS TO JANUARY
TWENTY THIRTY THAT IS
ADMINISTERED -- AND CHAIRED BY
MY OFFICE THE CALIFORNIA
ALTERNATIVE ENERGY AND ADVANCE
TRANSPORTATION FINANCING
AUTHORITY.
ON NAME TO KATE.
FAR.
UP WHICH NOW ALSO INCLUDES
ADVANCED MANUFACTURING AND
RECYCLING -- SO GIVEN THAT THIS
IS A GREAT.
NEED IN A CRISIS IN OUR STATE --
WE APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR OF FOR
PUTTING IN THIS SENSE AT
EXTENSION ENTER HER BILL TO
CREATE A GREATER NEXUS TO
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMIC INCENTIVES
OF FOR ALL OF THESE FOUR
INDUSTRIES AND WITH ME HERE IS
TINA.
CARRILLO WHO CAN I TALK ABOUT
THE PROGRAM SINCE WE STARTED IN.
TWENTY TEN AND ALL OF THE
PROJECTS THAT WE HAVE FUNDED AS
WELL AS THE ECONOMIC.
BENEFITS TO THE STATE.
ENTER YOUR THANK YOU SO MUCH AS
GRILL WOULD YOU LIKE TO BE TO
SAY A FEW WORDS ABOUT THEM
BEYOND WHAT THE TREASURE IT SAID.
I THINK SHE SUMMED IT UP VERY
WELL IN THIS TIME OF A RECYCLING
CRISIS HERE IN CALIFORNIA THIS
IS THE NECESSARY TOOLS.
LOCAL GOVERNMENT RECYCLING GOALS
AND I CAN HELP ANSWER ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT
HAVE ON THE PROGRAM THANK YOU SO
MUCH WE'RE GRATEFUL YOU'RE HERE
IS GOOD TO SEE YOU GOOD MORNING
SIR YOU HAVE AYE TWO MINUTES AND
YOU HAVE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN
THE THE COLLAPSE OF CALIFORNIANS
AGAINST.
WASTE I'LL KEEP IT BRIEF TO ADD
ON TO THE THE SPECIFIC.
BENEFITS OF THE KEEPER PROGRAM
ALL TOUCH ON OTHER PARTS OF THE
BILL.
ON IT CALIFORNIA'S HAD A VERY
SUCCESSFUL RECYCLING SYSTEM OVER
THE LAST THIRTY YEARS AND A LOT
OF THAT HAS COME FROM OVERSEAS
MARKETS BEING ABLE TO TAKE OUR
MATERIAL.
FURTHER SORT IT MAKE IT INTO A
VALUABLE PRODUCT -- WITH WITH
THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT SAYING
THEY NO LONGER WANTED OUR
RECYCLABLES.
I THAT SET OFF A DOMINO EFFECT
ALL OVER SOUTHEAST AND EAST ASIA.
WHERE OTHER COUNTRIES -- HAVE
ALSO SAID THEY NO LONGER WANT
ARM MAKES WASTE MATERIAL.
AND AS A RESULT WE NEED CLEANER
MATERIALS IN ORDER TO KEEP
RECYCLING.
AND THE BILL -- HANDLES THAT
ANSWER FOR TWO DIFFERENT WAYS OR
SAW BY CREATING INCENTIVES FOR
MANUFACTURERS.
IN CALIFORNIA TO USE RECYCLED
CONTENT THROUGH THE CASE FOR
PROGRAM.
AND THE REVOLVING LOAN PROGRAM
AT OUR END EASY.
AND BY.
REDUCING CONSUMER CONFUSION
ABOUT WHAT GOES AND WHAT BEEN.
BY GETTING RID OF THE CHASING
ARROWS ON PRODUCTS THAT ARE NOT
RECYCLABLE RIGHT NOW WE HAVE A
MANDATE THAT ANYTHING PLASTIC
MUST HAVE THE CHASING ARROWS.
AND EVEN THE MAIN FACTORS ARE
NECESSARILY WANT TO PUT THAT ON
PRODUCTS THAT ARE NOT RECYCLABLE.
AND FINALLY CREATES A COMMISSION
TO HELP INFORM STATE EDUCATION
EFFORTS ON WHAT IS AND ISN'T
RECYCLING CALIFORNIA.
BECAUSE WE CAN'T.
DO ANY KIND OF PUBLIC EDUCATION
IF WE DON'T ACTUALLY KNOW.
WHAT SHOULD BE GOING INTO
DIFFERENT BANDS?
THANK YOU SO MUCH SIR WE'RE
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
WE'RE NOT GONNA.
WELCOME ANYONE ELSE WOULD LIKE
TO GO TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL FIRST AND LAST NAME AN
ORGANIZATION GOOD MORNING SIR
GOOD MORNING SIR CHECK HELD
ADVERT REPRESENT REPUBLIC
SERVICES AND IN SUPPORT OF THIS
VERY IMPORTANT.
PIECE OF RECYCLING LEGISLATION
THANKS RUSSIA HEY GOOD MORNING.
MORNING MELISSA ROMERO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING JOHN
KENNEDY WITH RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES THE CALIFORNIA
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU DON'T
THINK YOU.
WE'RE LOOKING FOR ANYONE ELSE IS
GONNA BE LAST CALL FOR SUPPORT.
MORNING GOOD MORNING TREES THE
REGULARS ON THE HAPPY CALIFORNIA
COMPOST COALITION IN THE LOCAL
ADMINISTRATORS OF ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH AND SUPPORT YOUR GOOD
IT'S A BUSY DAY THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
ARE WE NOW GOING TO TURN IT OVER
TO THOSE WHO MAY BE OPPOSED IF
YOU COULD PLEASE COME FOR THIS
TIME.
GONNA MAKE ROOM FOR MISTER
CHARACTER PLEASED TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE A SEAT AT THE DíAS ONE OF
OUR WITNESSES.
THANK CARE REPRESENTING THE
COMPANY LEAGUE CITIES WE WELCOME
TO COMMITTEE IN OPPOSITION
FLOORS YOUR SIR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
DAN KERRIGAN BEHALF OF LEE A
CALIFORNIA CITIES -- WE
CERTAINLY A SUPPORT THE GOALS OF
THE AUTHOR OF THIS BILL IN TERMS
OF TRYING TO ADDRESS THE
CHALLENGES THAT -- THE STATE AND
LOCAL AGENCIES ARE FACING ON
RECYCLING -- THE BOTTOM ONE
CONCERN FOR US THOUGH IT IS
ABOUT YOU KNOW WITH WITH THIS
BILL IS -- WHO'S PAYING FOR FOR
THE EXTENSION OF THIS KATE FOR
PROGRAM -- THIS PROGRAM IS
CURRENTLY AUTHORIZED AT A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS YEAR THE
SALES AND USE TAX EXCLUSION
PROGRAM -- IN IN ONE PROVISION
OF THE BILL ACTUALLY EXTENDS ITS
PROGRAM FOR TEN YEARS SO THAT'S
ABOUT A BILLION DOLLARS -- AND
IF YOU LOOK AT THE ANALYSIS.
WHICH IS VERY WELL DONE.
ON THE FIRST PAGE I MEAN OUR OUR
SALES AND USE TAX ALEC.
ALLOCATION IS GETTING PRETTY
CHOPPED UP OVER THE YEARS IN
TERMS OF WHERE DOLLARS GO.
BUT IS IT GIVES YOU CAN TELL THE
THE STATE GENERAL FUNDS IMPACT
IS THREE POINT 93%.
ALL THE OTHER IMPACTS OF A SALES
AND USE TAX EXCLUSION OF FALL ON
LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
AND ACTUALLY BELOW THE LINE IF
YOU LOOK ON THE FIRST PAGE SEVEN
POINT 25% YOU HAVE LOCAL
TRANSFER TRANSPORTATION TAX
MEASURES OTHER LOCAL TRANSACTION
USE TAX MEASURES THAT APPROVED
BY LOCAL VOTERS.
SO WHEN YOU EXCLUDE AVENUE THE
SALES TAX AND USE TAX EXCLUSION.
THERE'S A LOT OF IMPACTS ON
LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
THE SECOND THING IN THIS
ANALYSIS THAT I WANT YOU TO MAKE
SURE THAT YOU -- FOCUS ON IS
WHEN IT TALKS ABOUT STATE
REVENUE IMPACT -- IT COULD BE
GIVEN THAT.
MANY OF THESE -- OF THESE
INVESTMENTS COULD COULD
CURRENTLY QUALIFY FOR THE
MANUFACTURERS EXEMPTION THAT WAS
EXTENDED A COUPLE YEARS AGO.
THE REVENUE IMPACT -- FOR THE
STATE OF FOR THIS BILLION DOLLAR
ON EXTENSION IS UNDER TEN
MILLION PER YEAR.
AND THEN ON COMMENT NUMBER FIVE
IT IT IT DOES OUTLINE THAT.
MOST OF THE IMPACT OF EXTENDING
THIS PROGRAM -- UP TO FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR
FALLS ON LOCAL GOVERNMENT SO ON
WE DON'T LET'S A LOT OF MONEY.
AND SO WE DO HAVE A LOT OF
CONCERNS WITH -- THAT KIND OF
REVENUE IMPACT OF WITH THIS
PROGRAM -- THE OTHER THING.
THAT IS -- CHALLENGING WITH --
THIS PROGRAM FROM ALL OVER A TAX
PERSPECTIVE IS.
THE OFTENTIMES WITH ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT THERE IS A NEXUS
BETWEEN WHERE THE THE COMMUTERS
THAT'S GETTING THE BENEFIT OF
THE INVESTMENT AND THEN WERE THE
TAX DOLLARS ARE COMING FROM.
UNDER THIS PROGRAM FOR THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT PERSPECTIVE.
CITY A MAY BE GETTING THE NEW
INVESTMENT BUT CITIES B. C. AND
D. OR THE ONES THAT ACTUALLY ARE
PAYING FOR IT SO FOR THOSE
REASONS WE HAVE SIGNIFICANT
CONCERNS WITH.
THE EXTENSION OF THAT PROGRAM.
HE'S MUCH AS CHARACTERS CARE
WERE HAVE YOU HANG THERE FOR
WITH US I JUST CASE ANYONE HAS
ANY QUESTIONS WE'RE GONNA GO TO
THOSE.
WHO MAY STILL BE IN OPPOSITION
THEY WERE IN TURN OVER THE SILLY
WOMAN TO BE ABLE TO HAVE SOME
COMMENTS?
THANK YOU VERY SEE THIS IS GOING
TO BE IN OPPOSITION IF YOU COULD
PLEASE COME FORWARD THIS TIME.
WHERE DO LAST CALL FOR
OPPOSITION?
THANK YOU SO MUCH CAN AS THE
SERGEANTS MAKER MIKE'S WITNESSES
MIKE'S IN THESE ARE JUST A
LITTLE LOW BUT IF.
WE CHECK IT OUT IN WILL TURN
OVER TO THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN I TO
BE ABLE TO RESPOND THEN WE'LL%
OPEN IT UP.
FOR QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE NOW IT MADAM SOME
NUMBER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANNA AND I
WILL ALSO.
MAKE TIME.
FOR OUR OUR WITNESSES TO SPEAK
UP BUT I WILL SAY AS AT LIKE
LIKE LIKE THAT THE OUR STATE
TREASURER I ALSO CAME FROM WILL
LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
I WHEN YOU GO WORK FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND YOU ARE AT
ELECTED OFFICIAL ON A CITY OR A
COUNTY -- YOU KNOW FROM THE
GROUND UP THE PROBLEM OF TRASH
AND RECYCLING IN BEING ABLE TO
HAVE THE INFRASTRUCTURE AT TO
TAKE CARE OF YOUR CITIES NEEDS --
ESPECIALLY IF YOU LIVE IN AREAS
WITH A LOWER SOCIOECONOMIC
PROFILE.
AND WHILE ANY KIND OF DIVERSION
OF TAX DOLLARS WE UNDERSTAND IS --
IS IMPORTANT -- WE ALSO KNOW
THAT IF WE DON'T HAVE THE CARE
IT TO BE ABLE TO DEVELOP.
THE INFRASTRUCTURE TO BE ABLE TO
MAKE THINGS WITH OUR TRASH MAKE
THINGS WITH OUR WAYS TO TURN
THOSE INTO GOOD MANUFACTURING
JOBS IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
TO MORE EFFECTIVELY AND
EFFICIENTLY.
WORK TO REDUCE OUR WASTE THEN
THAT WE'RE NOT DOING ANYTHING --
SO WHILE CITIES AB AND C. MAY
NOT GET THE ACTUAL BENEFIT I
WOULD BUT I WOULD BET YOU THAT
THEY ARE WE REAPING THE BENEFIT
BY THE WHOLE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
BEING ABLE TO REDUCE.
THE AMOUNT WE'RE PUTTING INTO
OUR LANDFILLS AND INCREASE THE
AMOUNT OF MANUFACTURING JOBS
THAT WE'RE CREATING AS WE CREATE
OUR OWN CLOSE SYSTEM CYCLE.
AND I DO WANT TO ADD THAT ON
THIS PROGRAM IS WORKING IT IS
WORKING TO KEEP JOBS HERE TO
BRING A CERTAIN COMPANIES --
WITH TECHNOLOGY TO MEET OUR A.
B. THIRTY TWO MANDATES AND ALL
THE OTHER -- MANDATES THAT WE
HAVE BEEN APPROVING HERE SO JUST
WANNA GIVE A COUPLE OF
STATISTICS AT THE END OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN KATE HAD APPROVED A
TOTAL OF TWO HUNDRED ONE PROJECT
APPLICATIONS HELPING TO PURCHASE
OVER EIGHT POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS.
IN EQUIPMENT AND MACHINERY --
THERE ARE ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
NINE ACTIVE INCOMPLETE PROJECTS
THAT WERE APPROVED FOR A TOTAL
OF SIX POINT. TWO FIVE BILLION
IN ANTICIPATED QUALIFIED
PROPERTY PURCHASE IS ESTIMATED
TO RESULT IN APPROXIMATELY FIVE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FOUR MILLION
IN STATE TAX EXEMPTIONS.
THESE PROJECTS ARE LOCATED
ACROSS THIRTY THREE COUNTIES
THEIR ESTIMATED TO RESULT IN THE
RETENTION AND CREATION OF FORTY
FIVE THOUSAND JOBS.
WITH TWENTY TWO HUNDRED OF THESE
JOBS IT SHOULD BE ABLE TO THIS
STATE TAX EXEMPTION PROGRAM --
SO IT IS WORKING -- WE HAVE
FUNDED PROJECTS IN ALL OF THE
DISTRICTS -- NOT ALL OF THEM ARE
RELATED TO ONE COUNTY -- AS WE
ALL KNOW WASTE IS A STATE WIDE --
ISSUE WE HAVE AN INTEGRATED
WASTE MANAGEMENT BOARD
SPECIFICALLY TO EQUALIZE WHERE
ALL OF OUR TRASH GOES TO AND I'M
MORE THAN HAPPY -- TO CREATE
WHAT WE CREATE WHERE EVERYBODY'S
TRASH GOES TO TO SHOW THAT YOU
KNOW THIS AND OTHER ISSUES --
SHOULD BE A STATEWIDE.
PROBLEM IN WITH SOLUTIONS AND
NOT JUST A COUNTY BY COUNTY --
SOLUTION SO I APPRECIATE -- THE
TIME HERE BUT THIS PROGRAM IS
WORKING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
TREASURE LET'S OPEN UP THE
COMMITTEES IF ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
THIS IS A VICE CHAIR.
THERE SEEMS TO BE YOU INEQUITIES
IN SALES TAX LAW.
AMAZON WAREHOUSES IN CERTAIN
CITIES.
BUT YOU HAVE A AMENDMENT THAT
YOU WOULD PROPOSE LIKE THAT THAT
THE STATE REIMBURSES YOU YOU'RE
ONE PERCENTER.
WELL THAT WOULD BE A GOOD
AMENDMENT. TO OUT WE GET IT --
BUT IT'S IT'S A HARD ONE WHAT'S
REALLY CHALLENGING ON SENATOR
WITH THE BILL IS.
AGAIN -- IT TO THE EXTENT
THERE'S A LOCAL REVENUE IMPACT --
AGE I THINK THAT TO THE EXTENT
THAT THE THE LOCAL COMMUNITY
THAT WAS RECEIVING THE
INVESTMENT THE JOBS ANOTHER DOG
DIRECT BENEFITS TO THE EXTENT
THERE WAS A CLOSER NEXUS.
AND THE BENEFIT OF THE AND I
THINK IT MIGHT BE MORE WORKABLE
IT'S PRETTY HARD -- THE WAY THE
PROGRAM WORKS IS A MANUFACTURER
WILL HAVE A LIST OF THINGS.
THAT THAT THEY'RE GOING TO USE
FOR FOR FOR THE FOR THE FOR THE
PROJECT AND THE AND IT'S UP TO
THE MANUFACTURER IN TERMS OF
WHERE THEY BY THOSE PRODUCTS SO.
THE THE THE TAX THE IMPACT OF
THE TAX REDUCTION IS COULD BE
SPREAD ALL VER THE PLACE WHERE
THE IF YOU LOOK IN THIS IN THIS
ANALYSIS IT TALKS ABOUT TESLA
GETTING A COUPLE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS OVER THE LIFE OF THE
PROGRAM.
WILL CLEARLY SAID THE CITY OF
FREMONT IS BENEFITING A LOT FROM
THOSE THOSE INVESTMENTS IN THOSE
DOLLARS THE QUESTION IS WHERE.
WE'RE OR THE LOCAL TAX
CONTRIBUTIONS COMING FROM.
IT'S VERY HARD IN THIS PROGRAM
TO TRY TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
RESTRUCTURING SO THERE'S A
CLOSER NEXUS BETWEEN -- THE
CONTRIBUTORS AND AND THE BENEFIT.
SO WE HAVE A BIG ISSUES THEN TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO IMPROVE.
SALES AND USE TAX BECAUSE WE'VE
GOT CITIES AND GETTING GOBS OF
SALES TAX BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE
THE WAREHOUSES AND THE CITIES
THAT ARE ACTUALLY PURCHASING THE
GOODS ARE GETTING THE BENEFIT
EITHER SO HOW DO WE HOW DO WE
FIX THE SYSTEM.
WHO ARE GONNA BE DONE IN THIS
BILL?
THE COMMITTEE DID -- SUPPORT BY
SENATOR GLAZERS BILL EARLIER
THIS YEAR THAT ADDRESSES THAT IN
OUR OPINION AT LEAST SOME OF THE
THE ISSUES WITH THE WAREHOUSES.
AND WE SUPPORT THAT BILL.
THE COMMISSION THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THAT TO BE TURNED OVER TO
THE MINISTRY TO THE PROGRAMS
CARILLO TO BE IN THAT PROVIDE TO
US -- COMMENTARY ON THE PROGRAM
IN THE DETAILS OF IT PLEASE
THANK YOU FOR THAT FOR THAT I
WOULD LIKE TO JUST ADD A LITTLE
CLARITY -- THIS IS NOT A BROADLY
PULL THE MIKE CLOSER I'M SURE
THANK YOU SO MUCH AGAIN -- THIS
IS DINA CARILLO EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR KEEP THAT -- TED TO
CORRECT AT A FEW ISSUES THIS IS
NOT A BROAD ENTITLEMENT PROGRAM
THIS IS A PROGRAM WHERE SPECIFIC
RECYCLERS MANUFACTURERS CAN COME
IN AND WE ASSESS THE NET BENEFIT
WHETHER THE FISCAL.
BENEFIT OF THE PROJECT WILL
OUTWEIGH THE FOR GONE SALES AND
USE TAX IN DOING THAT WE LOOK AT
EMPLOYEES SALARIES INCREASES IN
PROPERTY TAX -- I AM --
SYMPATHETIC TO THE ISSUE RAISED
BY THE CITIES AND THE TAX RATE I
WOULD SAY THAT THIS PROGRAM IS A
DIFFERENT.
IN THE SENSE THAT THIS IS A
POTENTIALLY A ONE TIME LOSS THAT
IS NOTED.
IN THE STAFF REPORTS WHAT'S NOT
NOTED AS A LONG TERM FISCAL
BENEFIT OF THE JOBS -- THE
INCREASE PROPERTY TAXES OVER
TIME EVEN IN THOSE SUPPLIER
ENTITIES LOTS OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE EXCITED TO BE
THOSE SUPPLIER CLUSTERS PROTEST
Là -- BECAUSE THEY WILL GROW IN
THEIR OWN REGIONS AND CREATE
REGIONAL CLUSTERS THAT CREATE
LONG TERM JOBS -- MINUS ONE
DOLLAR LOSS OF THE GENERAL FUND
OF THAT YEAR I'M INCREASING
PROPERTY TAX I WOULD SAY IN A
OVERALL IMPACT.
I WOULD LIKE TO NOTE THAT
DISTINCT DIFFERENCE AND ALSO
CLARIFY THAT AS A RECYCLING
CHALLENGES HAVE BECOME GREATER
WE NEED GREATER TECHNOLOGY --
FOR THE ORGANICS WASTE TO CREATE
THE BIO FUEL TIM TO DIVERT FROM
LANDFILLS AND I'VE HEARD FROM
THESE COMPANIES THAT THAT --
STATE LOCAL IMPACT DOES MAKE A
DIFFERENCE WELL THERE IS A
REFERENCE TO THE LA A REPORT
ABOUT BEING SOMEWHERE PROGRAMS
WE HAVE REALLY SEEN THAT THAT
THIS PROGRAM CAN BE THE
DIFFERENCE IN A PROJECT MOVING
FORWARD OR NOT.
AND MANY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND
CITIES APPLY -- BECAUSE THE THE
THE DYNAMICS AND THE ECONOMICS
OF EACH OF EACH PROJECT IS IS
THAT WHEN WHEN IT COMES TO
MEETING CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSION
RIGHT.
YOU SO MUCH MISS KOREA.
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO RECEIVE ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS UP FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
THEN WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM AND THEN AND
AND A GREAT RESPECT TO THIS IN
THE WOMAN THE TREASURE OF BE
OKAY WE LIKE TO BE TO TAKE UP
THE CONSENT COUNTER BECAUSE WE
HAVE TO GET A BILL OVER TO
HEALTH.
I THAT IS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR -- IN THEY ARE ASKING
FOR IT NOW.
I'M SO LAYS IN GENERAL WHAT WE
ESTABLISH A QUORUM OF THE
COMMITTEE MISSING CHESTER IF YOU
CAN PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
WIRE HERE.
MORE ARE.
PRESENT BILL WHICH BURKE
BRITTONUM.
OUR PRESENT NIELSEN.
NIELSEN PRESENT WIENER.
YOU FOR THANK YOU SO MUCH MISS
LANCASTER A QUORUM IS BEEN
ESTABLISHED OF THE GOVERNANCE
AND FINANCE COMMITTEE WE NOW
WOULD LIKE TO BE TO TAKE UP THE
CONSENT CALENDAR THERE WE HAVE A
MOTION BY A AT THE VICE CHAIR AB.
ONE SEVENTY SIX IN AB.
FOR ONE FOUR SCIENTISTS HAVE YOU
COULD PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
REQUIRE HI WHERE I AM OR NOT.
WE'RE GONNA GUIDE DOWN.
HERTZBERG RICARDO.
NO I NIELSEN.
NIELSEN AYE WIENER.
THE FOUR ZERO VOTE WE'RE GONNA
KEEP THE ROLE OPEN WE'RE GONNA
TURN OVER IN A SEGMENT GO TO
MAKE ANY CLOSING COMMENTS IN THE
TO THE TREASURE.
AT THAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
I WOULD JUST THAT THANK YOU FOR
THIS THE FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TALK ABOUT THIS TODAY AND JUST
TO MAKE THAT FINAL POINT THAT
FOR THE KEEPER PROGRAM AND HAS
TO PRODUCE A NET BENEFIT -- AND
LOOKING AT THE MEMBERS UP HERE I
CAN GUARANTEE YOU.
CAN GET TO YOU I CAN PRETTY MUCH
GUARANTEE YOU THAT THERE HAVE
BEEN A PROJECTS AT ALL OF YOUR
DISTRICTS.
WOULD GUARANTEE IT AND ALL OF
YOUR DISTRICTS BASED ON THIS
PROGRAM THESE ARE THESE ARE
BREAD AND BUTTER OF
MANUFACTURING RECYCLING KINDS OF
JOBS THAT ARE GOOD WORKING CLASS
JOBS THAT WE'RE TRYING TO CREATE.
A AND AND WITH THE ADDED BENEFIT
THAT IT IS ALSO THEN TAKING CARE
OF OUR WASTE -- SO THIS IS A A
LARGER BILL WE TALKED A LOT
ABOUT KATE FOR A BUT I THINK
THIS IS ONE OF THE CORNERSTONES
THAT WE NEED TO BE ABLE -- TO
TAKE US INTO THE NEXT CENTURY AS
WE TAKE CARE OF OUR WASTE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU ABOUT THANK
YOU SO MEMBER MENTORSHIP.
AND AND NOT AND YOU ALL KNOW WE
ARE COMPETING AGAINST OTHER
STATES FOR SO MANY O THESE JOBS
AND I ALWAYS A 0% OF ZERO IS.
ZERO IF COMPANIES ARE NOT HERE
THEY'RE NOT BUYING EQUIPMENT
THEY'RE NOT CREATING JOBS WELL
THAT'S LIKE A NET LOSS FOR THE
STATE AND SO THIS PROGRAM IS
WORKING I HAVE FULL CONFIDENCE
IN MY STAFF -- THAT THEY HAVE
DONE REALLY EXCELLENT VETTING OF
ALL THE PROJECTS THAT
POTENTIALLY YOU KNOW WANT TO
COME HERE WANT TO EXPAND HERE --
SO THAT WE ARE ACTUALLY MEETING
ALL THE MANDATES IN THE GOALS
HERE. FOR THE STATE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH YOU'RE SHERMAN
IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU THANK YOU
SO MUCH IS THE NUMBER WE HAVE A
MOTION BY THE VICE CHAIR THE
MOTION IS TO PASS THROUGH
APPROPRIATIONS.
THANK YOU SHOULD BE GOOD PLEASE
CALL REQUIRE I REQUIRE I'M MORE
LOCK.
LOCK AYE BELL HERTZBERG RICARDO.
SO I NIELSEN.
NIELSEN AYE WIENER. FOUR ZERO
THANK YOU SO MUCH OF HIS -- OPEN
THANK YOU THINKING ISRAEL VERY
MUCH.
KEEP IN THAT ROLE OPEN AND AB
FIFTEEN EIGHTY THREE THAT IS A
GENTLEMAN WE ONLY HAVE TWENTY
FOUR BILLS MORE TO GO SO WE'RE
NOW MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER.
ONE AB.
SIXTY EIGHT SIMILAR PERTAINING
AND THEY WERE GOING TO GO
STRAIGHT TO MISS CRISTINA GARCIA
AB.
ONE FOUR TWO WE'RE NOW ON ITEM
NUMBER ONE AB SIXTY EIGHT IS THE
NUMBER GOOD MORNING THE FLOOR IS
YOURS GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR --
LET ME JUST THANK YOU AND YOUR
COMMITTEE FOR YOUR HELP ON THIS --
BILL AS YOU KNOW THE STATE IS
FACING A HOUSING AFFORDABILITY
CRISIS.
WE THINK EIGHTY USE CAN BE ONE
KEY COMPONENT TO HELP GET US.
TO MORE GIVE US MORE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING QUICKER.
AND FASTER -- EIGHTY USE CAN BE
BUILT IN PEOPLE'S BACKYARDS THEY
CAN BE BUILT TO PEOPLE'S GARAGES --
THESE ARE GREAT UNITS -- GREAT
WORK HAS BEEN DONE BY.
BY THIS LEGISLATURE OVER THE
LAST COUPLE YEARS UNFORTUNATELY.
CITIES HAVE REACTED BY.
AGAIN DE FACTO BANNING EIGHTY
USES HER CIRCUMSTANCES ARE
LEGISLATION.
CUTS THAT PERMITTING TIME AND
HAVE.
A PROHIBITS LOCAL ORDINANCES TO
RESTRICT LOT SIZE YOU HAVE SOME
CITIES RESTRICTING EIGHTY USE
FROM LOTS.
UNDER EIGHT THOUSAND SQUARE FEET
WHICH IS QUITE LARGE THEY ALSO
LIMITS REQUIREMENT FOR PARKING
SPACES BE REPLACED BY GARAGE
CONVERTED TO AN EIGHTY YOU.
AND ALSO ALLOWS FOR MINISTERIAL
APPROVAL FOR EIGHTY USE AND
JUNIOR EIGHTY USE WITHIN AN
EXISTING SPACE -- TO AN EIGHTY
YOU THAT IS NEW CONSTRUCTION OF
UP TO EIGHT HUNDRED SQUARE FEET.
AND THEN ALSO EIGHTY USING MULTI
FAMILY.
BUILDINGS WITH THAT WE RESPECT
TRANSCRIBE VOTE FOR AB SIXTY
EIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH SOME AND
WE APPRECIATE YOUR HARD WORK ON
THIS ISSUE THIS IS BEEN ONE
THAT'S BEEN VERY PERSONAL AS A
MEMBER TING -- ALONG WITH --
THERE'S A COUPLE SENATORS AS
WELL AND IS A MEMBER WE'RE
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR HARD WORK
WE'RE GONNA TURN IT OVER TO THE
GOOD FOLKS FROM YOU BE WE
WELCOME YOU TO COMMITTEE SIR YOU
PRETTY MUCH LIVE HERE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR -- LOUIS
MARIN'S A WITH CALIFORNIA BE --
VERY HAPPY TODAY TO SUPPORT AB
SIXTY EIGHT HERE.
LIKE THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MENTIONED AB AB SIXTY A AN
ACCESSORY DWELLING UNITS ARE
IMPORTANT.
A MARKET DRIVEN STRATEGY FOR
PRODUCING MORE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING RESEARCH FROM UC
BERKELEY SHOWS THAT EIGHTY USE
COST LESS TO BOTH BUILD AND TO
RENT -- THAN COMMENSURATE --
APARTMENT UNITS MAKING THEM IN
AFFORDABLE AND ECO FRIENDLY
SOURCE -- FOR NEW HOUSING --
WE'RE SUPPORTING AB SIXTY EIGHT
TODAY ALONG WITH -- OTHER --
EIGHTY BILLS AS YOU MENTIONED
CURRENTLY FROM -- OTHER MEMBERS
OF THE LEGISLATURE I THINK
THERE'S A LOT OF INTERESTING
COMBINING THOSE BILLS OVER THE
SUMMER -- EXCITED TO WORK WITH
THE COMMITTEE ON THAT -- AND
WITH ALL THE MEMBERS INVOLVED --
BY THE END SESSION -- STRONGLY
URGE YOUR SUPPORT THIS MORNING
THANK YOU SO MUCH SIR THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE WE'RE NOT GONNA
LOOK FOR THOSE WHO ARE IN
SUPPORT COME ON DOWN WELCOME
FIRST LAST ORGANIZATION THANKS
FOR BEING WITH US TODAY.
YOU TURN NUMBERS NIKITA CRIED
WITH THE NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL IN SUPPORT
EIGHTY USER CLIMATE SMART --
STRATEGY TO HELP REDUCE
EMISSIONS THANK YOU SEE THANK
YOU HEY GOOD MORNING.
HOLLY FOR MANY ON BEHALF A
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY CALIFORNIA
AND THE NONPROFIT HOUSING
ASSOCIATION NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
AND SUPPORT THANKS FOR BEING
HERE GOOD MORNING.
THE MORNING SILVIO FOR ON BEHALF
OF FACEBOOK IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THE MORNING THE MORNING MADISON
BY ON BEHALF THE SILICON VALLEY
COMMUNITY FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
THE MORNING MORNING DAVID GARCIA
TURNER CENTER FOR HOUSING
DIVISION AT UC BERKELEY IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GOOD MORNING MORNING KEEP THE
ROUTE WITH ENTERPRISE CAN BE
PARTNERS IN SUPPORT YOU SEE GIVE
A THANK YOU MORNING.
A SEVENTY I WAS WORKING
PARTNERSHIPS IN SANTA CLARA
COUNTY IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU SO MUCH [inaudible]
THANK HEAVENS.
MR CHEN MEMBERS AARON EVANS ON
BEHALF OF SILICON VALLEY AT HOME
AND TMZ PARTNERS AND SUPPORT IT
IS YOU.
MORNING GOOD MORNING SYLVIA
SOLUTION ON BEHALF OF CITY OF
LOS ANGELES MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WARNING WARNING DOOR ROSE THE
GIVEN VOTERS THE CALIFORNIA
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH
GOOD TO SEE YOU MORNING SIR.
HI DAVID ON THE OF THE BAY AREA
HOUSING ADVOCACY COALITION IN
SUPPORT THANK SON [inaudible]
EGGMAN SIR [inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING SEAN MCKENNA FROM
THE BAY AREA COUNCIL IN STRONG
SUPPORT YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING
HERE [inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
YOU MIGHT AS HE SETTLES ON
BEHALF OF THE COULD SEE THE
COALITION AND SUPPORT THANK YOU
SO MUCH.
WHERE DO A LAST CALL FOR THOSE
WHO ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE COULD
PLEASE COME FOR THIS TIME?
NOT GONNA LOOK TO THOSE WHO MAY
BE POSTED COULD PLEASE ADVANCE.
WE'RE GONNA WALK ME TO THE TABLE
SIR WELCOME WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER JONES FLOOR IS
YOURS THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS DAVID JONES ABOUT THE
CITIES OF BURBANK SAN MARCOS IN
THE MARIN COUNTY COUNCIL OF
MAYORS AND COUNCIL MEMBERS IN
OPPOSITION WE APPRECIATE THE
MOVEMENT THE AUTHORS MADE ON THE
BILL'S GOTTEN MUCH BETTER AS IT.
WENT TO THE PROCESS WE STILL
HAVE SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS ABOUT
PARKING -- SAN MARCOS IS A CITY
IN SAN DIEGO EIGHTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE THEY HAVE THREE COLLEGES
THE BLAST OF THREE COLLEGES
HOWEVER THE IMPACT ON THEIR
NEIGHBORHOODS RESIDENTIAL
NEIGHBORHOODS OF STUDENT HOUSING --
COUPLED WITH THIS EIGHTY YOU
WHERE YOU CAN HAVE A TRI PLEX ON
AN EXISTING SINGLE FAMILY.
UNIT -- THEY ARE HEAVILY HEAVILY
IMPACTED BY TRAFFIC IMPACTS OUR
PARKING IMPACTS.
SO THE WAY THAT THE BILL IS
CRAFTED RIGHT NOW WILL HAVE A
VERY VERY DIFFICULT -- IMPACT ON
NEIGHBORHOODS ARE ALREADY OVER
SATURATED WITH LACK OF PARKING.
OF FIRE SAFETY OF HAVING.
NOT HAVING -- REQUIREMENT FOR
OFF STREET PARKING IN CERTAIN
NEIGHBORHOODS -- IN MARIN WHERE
YOU HAVE HI FI HIGH FIRE DANGER
THEY ARE THERE IS STILL CONCERN
ABOUT THAT LACK OF ABILITY. FOR
A FIRE TRUCK TO NAVIGATE VERY
NARROW STREETS IN CERTAIN AREAS
SO WITH THOSE CONCERNS WE
CONTINUE TO BE OPPOSED AND WOULD
ASK FOR A NO VOTE.
THANKS SO MUCH SIR THANK YOU
MISTER JONES.
WE'RE STILL IN OPPOSITION WE'RE
GONNA WELCOME ANYONE WHO'D LIKE
TO SPEAK FIRST CLASS
ORGANIZATION WELCOME SIR. FOR
THE REASONS STATED BY MISTER
JOHNSON THANK YOU SO MUCH
SELLING.
A GOOD MORNING.
MISTER CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE
PARKINS ALL THIS TODAY ON BEHALF
OF THE CITIES OF CAMERAS SANTA
CLARITA RANCHO CUCAMONGA AND
TORRANCE WE SHARE THE SAME
CONCERNS OF MISTER JONES OUTLINE
AND WE ASK FOR YOUR NO VOTE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WHERE DO A LAST CALL FOR THOSE
WHO MAY BE OPPOSED LAST CALL?
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE TO BE
TO SEE IF WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
CONVERSATION OR DO WE HAVE A
MOTION.
THE MOTION BY THE GOOD SENATOR
FROM SAN JOSE MISTER BELL THANK
YOU SO MUCH ANY OUR CONVERSATION
BY COMMITTEE TO SIGN.
CURRENCY NO CONVERSATION BY
COMMITTEE WILL TURN OVER THE
SIMILAR MEMBER OUT FOR ANY
CLOSING COMMENTS.
THANK YOU CENTER AGAIN WE THINK --
IF YOU DO USE HAVE THE MOST
MINIMAL IMPACT WITH THE GREATEST
OPPORTUNITY TO BUILD MORE
HOUSING -- IN THIS STATE IN SAN
FRANCISCO WHAT WE FOUND WITH
EIGHTY USE IS THAT BEFORE WE
ACTUALLY HAD A PROCESS TO
LEGALIZE EIGHTY USE WHAT
HAPPENED PEOPLE JUST DON'T THE
MINIBUS.
SO THIS PARKING ISSUE.
WAS CREATED WHETHER OR NOT THERE
WERE LEGAL OR ILLEGAL EIGHTY USE
THEY GOT BUILT.
OVER THE PARKING.
I THINK MY CITY PROBABLY FACES
AS BIG A PARKING CHALLENGES AS
ANY CITY IN THIS PARTICULAR
STATE.
THAT WE HAVE HAD THAT DEFINITELY
MANAGED THROUGH WE DEFINITELY
RESPECT ALL THE ALL THE CITIES
AND THEIR CONCERNS ABOUT A
PERSON AND I THINK -- IS
SOMETHING THAT REALLY HAS TO BE --
MITIGATED AT THE LOCAL LEVEL AND
REALLY NEEDS TO BE MANAGED
ESPECIALLY IF WE WANT TO BE ABLE
TO BUILD A HOUSING THAT IS
DEMANDED IN THE STATE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER KING WE
DO HAVE A MOTION ON THE FLOOR
THAT MOTIONS BY SENATOR BAIL THE
MOTIONS DO PAST APPROPRIATIONS
MISS LANCASTER BECOME PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
HI.
I'M MORE LOCK.
L..
L. I. HERTZBERG HER CONDO.
RICARDO I NIELSEN AYE NIELSEN
AYE WIENER HIM. FOR IS ZERO VOTE
WE'RE GONNA HOLD THAT BILL AT
THE MOMENT KEEP THE ROLE OPEN IT
WILL ADD ON IS FOLKS COME BACK
THINK AS MUCH AS A MEMBER.
WE WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT TO SAY
THANK YOU TO A CERTAIN NUMBER
CRISTINA GARCIA SHE'S BEEN
INCREDIBLY PATIENT -- THIS
MORNING WE APOLOGIZETO YOU --
BETTER MISSING NUMBER.
THIS IS ITEM NUMBER TWO ON OUR
DOCKET THIS IS AB.
ONE FORTY TWO THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN
HAS BEEN WORKING HARD ON THIS
ISSUE -- DURING HER TENURE IN
THE LEGISLATURE WE APPRECIATE.
HER LEADERSHIP.
WE'RE GONNA TURN IT OVER TO THE
SIM NUMBER TO BE ABLE TO PRESENT
AN ITEM NUMBER TWO AB ONE FORTY
TO THE FLOOR IS YOURS MA'AM.
I THINK YOU WANT TO START BY
THANKING THE STAFF FOR THE WORK
ON THE BILL AND I AM ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS ON PAGE
FIVE AND SIX THANK YOU AGAIN.
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN WE
PASSED AB TWENTY ONE FIFTY THREE
THAT ALLOCATED A FEE THAT WAS
ALREADY IMPOSED ON CAR BATTERIES
TO FUND THE CLEANUP
CONTAMINATION CAUSED BY LEAD
ACID BATTERIES.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE THIS BILL
IS CREATED IN RESPONSE TO THE
MAN MADE ENVIRONMENTAL DISASTER
EXCITED.
IN MY BACKYARD.
AB ONE FORTY TWO ADDRESSES
TECHNICAL PROBLEMS THAT WERE
IDENTIFIED IN THE IMPLEMENTATION
BUT I BUY THE CD TFA.
IT ALSO THAT'S A PROCESS FOR
THIS CD TFA TO BETTER TRACK THE
EXEMPTIONS.
UNDER CURRENT LAW AT THE POINT
OF SALE ONE DOLLAR FROM THE
CONSUMERS DEPOSIT WILL GO TO THE
CLEAN UP FINE.
MANY FACTORS ALSO PAY A ONE
DOLLAR FEE ON ALL BATTERY SOLD
IN THIS STATE. THIRTEEN ABLE
TWENTY SECOND THE CONSUMER FEE
INCREASES TO TWO DOLLAR.
AND THE MANUFACTURE FEE SENSE IT.
THIS BILL SIMPLY STARTS TO MAKE
SURE WE KEEP EQUITY BETWEEN THE
CONSUMER AND THE MANUFACTURERS
AND SETS THE MANUFACTURE OF THE
EQUAL TO THE CONSUMER FEE.
WE NEED AS MANY NIGHTS AS THE
CLEANUP BACKSIDE BUT ALL THE
OTHERS MOTHERS IN THE STATE WE
KNOW OF AT LEAST FIFTEEN OTHER
SMELTERS WE HAVE ONE HERE IN
WITH.
SACRAMENTO WE HAVE ONE IN
ALAMEDA WE HAVE NUMEROUS AN
ALLEY COUNTY THIS PHONE WOULD
HELP CLEAN UP ALL OF THOSE
DIFFERENT SITES I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AS A MEMBER
WE'RE GONNA LOOK TO ANYONE ELSE
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL.
WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING MELISSA ROMERO WITH
THE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT
THANKS MELISSA.
HEY GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING
BRINGS TO GO BEHALF OF LA COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
GOOD MORNING BRING ME NUMBER
HAVE BREAST CANCER PREVENTION
PARTNERS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
A GOOD MORNING.
HI CLICK CUSTOM HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA NEW CAR DEALERS AND
SUPPORT THANKS CASA [inaudible]
THE MORNING.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE PLUGINS OFFICER TO
ABBY ON THE SOUTH COAST AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT AND
THE CITY OF TORRANCE AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU SO MUCH THE MORNING.
MORNING PATTERSON BEHALF THE
BETTER CANCEL INTERNATIONAL --
WE ACTUALLY HAVE A NEUTRAL
POSITION ON THE BILL.
AND LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR ON THE
MORE TECHNICAL ELEMENTS OF THE
BILL AS IT MOVES FORWARD AND
THANK YOU THINK AS MUCH YOU'RE
CHARGED UP -- LIKE TO BE TO SEE
IF THERE'S ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT -- BE HERE ALL DAY.
AND THAT'S TRUE OKAY -- HERE IS
SEEN NO ONE ELSE -- IN SUPPORT
WOULD LIKE ME TO SEE IF ANYONE
IS OPPOSED OR OPPOSED TO DAD
JOKES SO -- MISTER CHAIRMAN --
HEY MISTER WOLF I'M EXCITED TO
SEE IS THERE HI ALL RIGHT COULD
YOU SEE I'M I'M VERY AMPED UP
TODAY WOULD YOU -- JESUS IS
GOING TO ASK IF YOU HAVE ANY
TIMES VISIBLE THE FLOORS SO I
ALWAYS HAVE PLANS ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU SIR THE FOR SERVICE AS
THANK YOU MEMBERS GOOD MORNING-DAVID WILL FOR THE OUR JARVIS
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION -- WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL -- MEMBERS
SO TOUGH ONE FOR US BECAUSE
OBVIOUSLY WE DO UNDERSTAND --
WHAT WAS GOING ON WITH THE
EXCITED YOU KNOW BATTERY PLAN IN
THE CITY OF VERNON AND THE
ISSUES THERE AND -- AND
OBVIOUSLY CLEAN UP OF THAT
FACILITY IS VERY EXPENSIVE
LOOKING AT UPWARDS OF FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS TO CLEAN.
YOU KNOW THE LEAD CONTAMINATED
UNDERSTAND THAT.
HOWEVER WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
THE ADDITIONAL CONSUMER IMPACT
THAT -- THIS BILL BRINGS FORWARD
YOU KNOW ESPECIALLY IN LIGHT OF
AGAIN CALIFORNIANS THE TWENTY
BILLION DOLLARS SURPLUS OUT OF
THE BUDGET THAT WAS JUST PASSED.
AND AND AND YOU KNOW IT'S ALSO
WORTH NOTING YOU KNOW EVEN AS
THE AUTHOR MENTIONED THAT WE'VE
NOW GONE FROM THE CITY OF
EXCITED TO YOU EIGHTEEN
DIFFERENT BATTERY FACILITIES.
UP AND DOWN THE STATE AND IF
THIS IS A PROBLEM MEMBERS
STATEWIDE SHOULD THIS NOT BE
FUNDED OUT OF THE STATE GENERAL
FUND BECAUSE IT IS A MATTER OF
STATEWIDE CONCERN.
AND WE SHOULDN'T BE FOISTING
ADDITIONAL FEES ON CONSUMERS
THAT MIGHTNOT HAVE BATTERY
PLANTS IN THEIR GIVEN GEOGRAPHIC
AREAS SO REALLY FOR US IT'S A
QUESTION NOT SO MUCH OF THE FEE
INCREASES JUST EQUITY IN GENERAL.
FOR THOSE REASONS ASK FOR NOVA.
MR WILL FORGIVE YOU HANG HERE
JUST IN CASE THERE'S ANY
QUESTIONS IF YOU DON'T MIND
WE'RE GONNA OPEN UP TO ANYONE%
ELSE WHO MAY BE OPPOSED IF YOU
COULD PLEASE ADVANCE.
LOOKING FOR OPPOSITION.
WE'RE GONNA DO LAST CALL. TO
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE TO
SEE IF WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS WE DO HAVE A MOTION A
MOTION ON THE FLOOR BY CENTER
TITLE IS VICE CHAIR [inaudible]
FOR MR -- IT ALWAYS SEEMS THAT --
WHEN WE GET A YEAR TAX INCREASE
IT TO IT'S A BIG ONE IT'S IS
UNDER PERCENT ALTHOUGH JUST A
DOLLAR?
AND SO I'M JUST WONDERING --
USING THE ARGUMENT IS WELL WE
HAVEN'T RAISED IT IN A LONG TIME
THEREFORE WE GOT A REALLY CATCH
UP.
IS THERE A WAY TO MAYBE MODIFY
THE BILL TO DO IT INCREMENTALLY
OVER TIME.
THE PROBLEM IS THAT IF WE ALLOW
THE FEE TO BE AT THE RATE AT
WHICH IS COMING IN.
WE WOULD HAVE -- OVER THIRTY
YEARS BEFORE WE COULD FINISH THE
CLEANUP AND SO WE CONTINUE TO
PUT PEOPLE ARE ASSN THE HEALTH
AT RISK.
AS THE FOR YOU -- LET THE
CHILDREN OUT THERE BEING BORN
PRETTY DETRIMENTAL WE AND WE'RE
ALSO TRYING TO MAKE SURE THE
CONSUMER FEE IS EQUITABLE UNABLE
TO THE MANUFACTURE FEE.
I UNDERSTAND THAT THINGS AREN'T
ALWAYS A DEAL IN IN THE
LEGISLATURE -- BUT THERE IS A
SENSE OF URGENCY ACROSS THE
STATE NOW THAT WE KNOW THE
EFFECTS OF LED OUT THERE AND AND
A SENSE TO HURRY UP AND TAKE
ACTION AS SIMPLY AS POSSIBLE.
THANK YOU MISTER THANK YOU
VENTURE AS A MEMBER LOOK I I
THINK YOU WOULD BE THE FIRST TO
ADMIT YOUR CONTINUE TO WORK ON
THIS ISSUE -- AND THERE'S MORE
WORK TO COME IN REGARDS TO THE
FEET I THINK THE CHALLENGE THAT
YOU HAVE RIGHT NOW.
NOT ENOUGH MONEY. TOO MUCH
SUFFERING IN SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGES ON THE GROUND IF YOU
CAN JUST TALK TO US ABOUT
EXITING THIS PROCESS IS GOING TO
CONTINUE.
YES -- WE HAVE AT LEAST TEN
THOUSAND HOMES THAT ARE
CONTAMINATED BY EXIDE WE HAVE
OVER TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED ARE
LEVEL ONE WHICH MEANS THAT THERE
ARE OVER A THOUSAND PARTS PER
MILLION WHICH IS TOXIC DUMP
LEVELS.
THIS IS A WORKING CLASS
COMMUNITY WE HAVE AN
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE OF ABOUT 7% IN
THE CITY OF COMMERCE WHICH IS
ONE OF THE CITY'S AFFECTED.
WE HAVE -- WE HAVE. 70% OF THE
POPULATION THAT LIVES BELOW
POVERTY INSIDE THE ABILITY FOR
THE COMMUNITY TO COME UP WITH
THE POLICY THE CLEAN UP.
IT SEEMS NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE AN
ADDITION TO THE FACT THAT WE
HAVE FOLKS ARE BEING SICK WE
KNOW WE HAVE CLOSEST OF CANCER.
OF FOR A LONG TIME WE WERE TOLD
WE WERE CRAZY IN AND THAT THIS
IS A TRUE BUT THE TESTING NOW
THE INFORMATION IS OUT THERE.
THE CLEANUP HAS BEEN SLOW THIS
IS THE FIRST TIME THE STATE IS
DOING ANY SORT OF A CLEAN UP OF
THE STORE.
THE THING ABOUT THOSE LAWS WE
TRY TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO DO IT
AND DO IT RIGHT HI BUT HE SAID
THAT THAT WE'RE FINALLY DOING IT
MUCH BETTER AND IT'S BEATING UP.
ON AND THIS AREA HAS BEEN
TREATED LIKE GO AWAY SLAM PEOPLE
HAVING TO LIKE THEIR DISPOSABLE
LET IS ONE OF THE MANY TOXIC
THAT WE'RE DEALING WITH ON A
REGULAR BASIS.
AND MY SISTER AND I ALWAYS JOKE
WE GREW UP IN THIS COMMUNITY
THAT IT WOULD AND GREW UP IN
THIS COMMUNITY.
MAYBE WOULD BE GENIUSES AS WE
KNOW WE HAVE SO MANY DIFFERENT
TOXICS AND AS BUT ALL THESE
TALKS SIX DO.
PT YOUR ABILITY WHEN YOU'RE
DEVELOPING -- IN YOUR BRAIN
MATTER WHEN YOU DEVELOP THE AND
THAT'S PARTICULARLY TRUE.
OF ALADDIN SO IT'S JUST
IMPORTANT THAT WE TAKE ACTION --
NOTHING'S PERFECT HERE AND SO I
AM CONSTITUENTS FIGURE OUT HOW
TO BE GOOD ENOUGH AND KEEP
THINGS GOING FORWARD WE CAN'T
WAIT ANY LONGER ACCEPT
CONTAMINATED US FOR THREE
DECADES WE HAVE TOXIC THAT HAVE
BEEN THERE ALL MY LIFE AND ARE
ONLY GETTING WORSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE.
VOTE THANK YOU SO MUCH AS A
MEMBER THAT WILL COUNT AS THE
CLOSING STATEMENT DO APPRECIATE
ALL YOUR WORK THROUGH THE ON
THIS ISSUE.
THE MOTION IS FROM CENTER TADO
THE MOTION IS DO PASSES AMENDED
THEIR PREPARATIONS.
THE SCIENTISTS ARE GONNA HAVE
YOU CALL THE ROLL.
THANK YOU SIR [inaudible]
MCGUIRE.
L..
L. ALL RIGHT HERTZBERG RICARDO --
I NIELSEN [inaudible]
WIENER.
CURRENTLY ENJOYS A THREE ZERO OR
KEEP THEM -- BILL ON CALL THANK
YOU SO MUCH [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
WE ARE NOW GOING TO BE MOVING ON
TO THE CHAIRWOMAN OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT WE LOVE IT WHEN SHE'S
HERE TWO WEEKS IN A ROW WE ARE
EXCITED ABOUT IT.
WE HAVE A DOUBLE HEADER GOING ON
FOR MISS AGUIAR-CURRY WE HAVE
ITEM NUMBERS THREE E. ITEM
NUMBER THREE MADAM CHAIR.
IS RECEIVING BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
WE ALSO GONNA BE TAKING UP ITEM
NUMBER TEN WHICH WERE LOOKING
FOR FULL PRESENTATION ON THE
WE'RE GONNA FIRST START WITH
ITEM NUMBER.
THREE EIGHTY ONE SIXTY EIGHT AB
ONE SIXTY EIGHT ENJOYS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT WE'RE GONNA
TURN IT OVER TO THE ASSEMBLY
WOMAN UP FOR PRESENTATION
WELCOME GREAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AB ONE
SIXTY EIGHT GAMES TO ENSURE THAT
THE NATIVE AMERICAN TRIBAL
CULTURE RESOURCES.
AND SACRED SITES WILL BE
PROTECTED UNDER NEW STREAMLINED
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT LAW.
OR THANK YOU WE ARE SEEKING TO
PROVIDE A TEMPLATE THAT CAN BE
USED FOR IN FUTURE STREAMLINING
LAWS.
I'M GONNA TRY TO MAKE THIS SHORT
WE HAVE A COMMITMENT FROM THE
SENATE HOUSING CHAIR AND THAT WE
WILL WORK WITH TRIBAL ATTORNEYS
LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL.
AND COMMITTEE STAFF TOOK-CALIFORNIA'S TRIBAL COMMUNITIES
AGREE THAT WE HAVE A PRODUCT THE
TRULY PROTECTS OUR CULTURAL READ
THE TRIBAL CULTURE RESOURCES --
I WANT TO THANK YOU AS WELL AS
OTHERS THAT HAVE WORKED ON THIS
THIS IS BEEN -- JUST KIND OF GOT
SLIPPED THROUGH AS WE FORGOT
ABOUT MAKING SURE WE HAVE THE
TRIBAL SITES TAKEN CARE OF THE
TRIBES MUST HAVE THE ASSURANCES
THAT ON THE FORCE ABILITY OF
THIS LANGUAGE THAT WE PUT IN THE
BILL.
THEY NEED TO GUARANTEE THAT
TRIBAL CULTURE RESOURCES WILL
GET THE SAME PROTECTIONS THAT
ARE CURRENTLY RECEIVING AB --
FIFTY TWO I THANK YOU FOR
HELPING US -- AS WE HAVE ENGAGE
THE LARGER COMMUNITY TRIBAL
STAKEHOLDERS I HAVE EVERY
CONFIDENCE THAT TOGETHER IN IN
THE PARTNERSHIP WITH THE TRIBES
WE WILL ACCOMPLISH THE GOALS OF
THIS BILL.
I ASK YOU FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH YOUR WOMAN --
THIS IS BEEN A BIG ISSUE SHE'S
ALSO BEEN WORKING WITH CENTER
WINNER ON IN.
APPRECIATING GAUGE WHEN THIS IS
A BIG ONE FOR THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN
WITH MANY TRIBES.
WITHIN HER HOME DISTRICT IN ONE
AND MAKE SURE THAT WE GET THIS
RIGHT TO DEPRECIATE WORK ON THAT
MADAM CHAIR WE'RE GONNA LOOK TO
THOSE TRANSPORT FIRST AND LAST
ORGANIZATION CORNING MISTER TURN
MEMBERS MELANIE GRIFFITH.
CUEVAS WITH CAN TANA WHAT'S IN
HER MAN ON BEHALF OF THE UP
REALLY TRIED STILL GOING OVER
THE NEW AMENDMENTS WITH A FINE
TOOTH COMB BUT WE REMAIN VERY
SUPPORTIVE IN CONCEPT.
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
AUTHOR ON THIS IMPORTANT PROJECT
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HEY MISTER TERM MEMBERS MADISON
DRY ON BEHALF OF WILL RENTERIA
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL IF YOU CAN PLEASE COME
FORWARD.
AFRICA YOU COME IN ON ANY NOW
RIGHT OKAY THEY SIT RIGHT ON
TIME [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
WE DO A BI PARTISAN SUPPORT SIR.
WONDERFUL THEN KEEP IT SHORT
EFFORT WORKERS HERE IN SUPPORT
THE WONDERFUL WORK IN PROGRESS.
LOOKING FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH ALL OF OUR PARTNERS IN
INDIAN COUNTRY AND IN THE
BUILDING.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AS VEGAS IS
COULD YOU SEE HERE IT IS A BUSY
DAY AROUND THE BUILDING.
WE'RE GONNA LOOK TO ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT LAST CALL WE'RE NOT
GONNA TURN OVER THOSE WHO MAY BE
OPPOSE IF YOU COULD PLEASE
ADVANCE THIS TIME WE'RE LOOKING
FOR OPPOSITION.
THE LAST CALL FOR GONNA BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE IF WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR WILL
WELCOME THE MOTION.
WE HAVE A I I DO APOLOGIZE WE
HAVE -- CENTRE BELL CENTRE BELL
HAS THE MOTION THE MOTION IS TO
PASS APPROPRIATIONS.
BENCH HERE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE ASSEMBLY A SUPER AYE VOTE
THIS IS A REALLY IMPORTANT BILL.
WE DIDN'T WANT TO GET -- FALL
THROUGH THE CRACKS AND I
APPRECIATE YOU VOTING FOR THE
CITY THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU SIR IF YOU COULD
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL MCGUIRE HI
WHY I'M MORE LINE.
I'M HERTZBERG AUTO.
NIELSEN.
NIELSEN ONLINE WIENER.
WE GOT A FOUR IS ZERO VOTE DO
APPRECIATE THE WORK THANK YOU
VERY.
YEAH THANK YOU VERY MUCH THREE
WORK WE'RE NOT GONNA BE MOVING
ON TO OUR SECOND OF A TWO FOR
THIS IS ITEM.
TEN EIGHTY FIVE SEVENTY BUT I'M
SURE THE FLOOR IS YOURS THANK
YOU AGAIN MISTER CHAIRMAN
SENATORS AB FIVE SEVENTY IS A
COMPANION BILL TO MY BUSIER MUCH
MY BILL ACA ONE THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT INVESTMENT ACT.
THIS BILL WILL ONLY BECOME
OPERATIVE IF ACA ONE IS APPROVED
BY THE VOTERS.
BUT IS NECESSARY TO CODIFY
IMPLEMENTATION DETAILS AND
CLARIFY TERMS IN A CA ONE THAT
MAY NOT BELONG IN THE
CONSTITUTION.
AB FIVE SEVENTY DEFINES
AFFORDABLE HOUSING TO ADDITIONAL
INCLUDE A FIRST TIME HOME BUYER
PROGRAM OFFERED BY A LOCAL
AGENCY.
SB FIVE SEVENTY ALSO CLARIFIES
THAT A PARCEL TAX IMPOSED
PURSUANT TO A CA ONE MAY INCLUDE
EXEMPTIONS FOR SENIORS.
AND DISABLED PERSONS WHICH IS
CONSISTENT WITH THE EXISTING LAW.
PURPOSES OF TODAY'S HEARING IT
IS IMPORTANT THAT THIS BILL
CONTINUE TO MOVE ALONG TO MEET
LEGISLATIVE DEADLINES.
HOWEVER I WILL NOT MOVE THIS
BILL OFF THE SENATE FLOOR INTO A
CA ONE IS ALSO THERE.
I ASK FOR YOUR IBM.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MADAM CHAIR
WE'RE GONNA TURN IT OVER TO ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT BURN A
WELCOME OF THIS MOMENT TO THAT.
STAGE HERE WELCOME THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. TO MAKE YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE CHRISTY
BOMB ON THE OF THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS.
IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE. TO
JUST REINFORCE WHAT THE AUTHOR
HAS STATED WE ARE STRONG
SUPPORTERS OF A CA.
ONE OF VERY OPTIMISTIC THAT THAT
BILL WILL BE.
PASSED IN THE ASSEMBLY IN OVER
HERE AND SO WE URGE YOU TO PASS
THIS BILL TODAY AS WELL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AS PANEL WE'RE
GONNA TURN OVER TO THOSE WHO ARE
ALSO IN SUPPORT PERSON LAST
ORGANIZATION WELCOME MISTER
MISTER MEMBERS SHE'S FRIENDLY
CALIFORNIA CITIES WERE ALSO
SUPPORT THANK YOU SEE.
HEY GOOD MORNING.
MORNING JEFF NEAL CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES IN
SUPPORT AND ALSO EXPRESSING
SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF MY
COLLEAGUES IN THE CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION
WHO COULDN'T BE HERE TODAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT THIS IS
GONNA BE LAST CALL.
WE NOW THEIR TURN IT OVER TO
THOSE WHO MAY BE OPPOSE WE'RE
GONNA TURN OVER TO MISTER WOLF
WELCOME BACK SIR MISTER CHAIRMAN
THANK YOU I MEMBERS MORNING
DAVID WOLF AGAIN WITH OUR JARVIS
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION -- POSED
AB FIVE SEVENTY MISTER CHAIRMAN
JUST BRIEFLY ON THIS WE ARE
OPPOSED TO A CA ONE AND WE
REALLY LEGISLATIVE DEADLINES
ASIDE DON'T SEE A NEED FOR THIS
BILL MOVING FORWARD IN AUSTIN
UNTIL A CA.
ONE IS APPROVED BY VOTERS -- AND
ACCORDING TO RECENT PPA SEE
POLLS MAJORITY OF CALIFORNIA
VOTERS OPPOSE DECREASING A TWO
THIRDS THRESHOLD 255% FOR
PERSONAL TAXES SO AGAIN REALLY
DON'T SEE THE NEED FOR THE BILL
AT THIS TIME IT IS PREMATURE ASK
FOR NUMBER.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER WOLF WE
DO HAVE A MOTION ON THE FLOOR BY
SENATOR B<c.cyan> WE'RE GOING TO ASK</c>
ANYONE OUT TO MAY BE OPPOSED TO
THE BILL.
IF YOU COULD PLEASE COME FOR
THIS TIME LOOKING FOR OPPOSITION.
LAST CALL FOR OPPOSITION.
PLEASE SIR MISTER CHAIR LEWIS
PARTY WITH CALIFORNIA BE SORRY
WERE LATE WORD SUPPORT THOUGH
WANTED TO GET THAT ON THE RECORD
THANK YOU I THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GLASCOFF PROPOSITION.
TURN IT OVER TO COMMITTEE TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE.
WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE FLOOR BY
SENATOR BELL.
BUT I'M SURE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE YEAH I I REALLY APPRECIATE
YOU CONSIDERING THIS I WOULD
LIKE TO CLOSE BY READ IT
REITERATED THAT THIS BILLS ONLY
OPERATIVE IF AC ONE GOES INTO
EFFECT.
I'VE WORKED REALLY HARD ON THIS
BILL AS WELL AS A CA ONE WERE
NOT THERE QUITE YET BUT WE DOT
UNDER EYES CROSSED OR TEASE AND
DIDN'T WANT LET ME WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE EVERYBODY WAS INCLUDED
AND THIS WAS.
THE THE BILL THAT WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE WE DID THAT WORK SO.
I APPRECIATE YOUR AYE VOTE THANK
YOU THANKS FOR ALL YOUR WORK ON
THIS AND KNOW THAT THERE'S MUCH
MORE TO COME APPRECIATE IT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER WOLF ALWAYS
GOOD TO HAVE YOU HERE.
IN JUST A FEW COULD PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL WIRE HI WHY I'M MORE
LOCKED.
OR UNLOCKED NOBEL.
WELL I HERTZBERG.
HELLO NIELSEN.
NIELSEN AYE WIENER.
WE HAVE A THREE ONE VOTE A THREE
ONE VOTE WE'RE GOING TO KEEP THE
ROLE OPEN AND ADD FOLKS ON AS
THEY COME THROUGH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH HAVE A GOOD
DAY THANK YOU.
WE'RE NOW MOVING ON TO ITEM
NUMBER ELEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN
TWENTY THREE SUPPORT.
COME ON DOWN [inaudible]
THE COURT.
FOCUSING ON ISSUES.
TRANSACTION TO NEW SAXES.
WITHIN THE CITY FREMONT MCALLEN
COUNTY OF ALAMEDA THIS QUIRK WE
WHAT YES -- AND WELCOME MISTER
WOLF WE WE WE KNOW EACH OTHER
WELL FROM REVENUE TAXES ASSEMBLY.
AND I EXPECTED HIM TO BE HERE
AND HE'S HE'S A GOOD FRIEND THAT
WE NEVER SUPPORTS THE SAME BILLS
SIDE -- ITSELF THANK YOU.
SENATORS IN CHAIR -- EIGHTY
SEVEN TWENTY THREE WILL
AUTHORIZE VOTERS IN ALAMEDA
COUNTY AND THE CITY OF FREMONT --
TRANSACTIONS AND USE TAX
INCREASE IN ORDER TO GENERATE
MORE FUNDS FOR THEIR COMMUNITIES.
CITIES AND COUNTIES ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR PROVIDING A WIDE
RANGE OF SUPPORT SERVICES SUCH
AS SHELTERS FOR THE HOMELESS.
POLICE AND FIRE SERVICES.
CONSTRAINTS FROM PROP THIRTEEN
OF INCREASED RELIANCE ON RAISING
TAXES TO SUPPORT THESE MEETINGS
SERVICES -- THIS ADDITIONAL
REVENUE WILL ENABLE THESE
LOCALITIES TO PROVIDE MUCH
NEEDED GENERAL PURPOSE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT SERVICE SERVICES.
SUCH AS ROAD REPAIRS PARK
MAINTENANCE AND HOMELESS
PREVENTION.
WITH ME TODAY IS THE MAYOR
FREMONT MY GOOD FRIEND MAYOR
LILY MAY.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THIS MEASURE THANK YOU
SO MUCH A SIMILAR APPRECIATE
YOUR WORK ON THIS WE DO HAVE A
MOTION THE FLOOR THE MOTION IS
BY SENATOR BALBOA WE'RE GONNA
HEAR FROM THE MAYOR FOR SO WE
WELCOME THE MERRY OF TWO MINUTES
MOMENT THANK YOU. FOR MAKING THE
DRIVE SACRAMENTO TODAY THE FLOOR
IS YOURS THANK YOU SO
CHAIRPERSON MCGUIRE AND MEMBERS
OF THE SENATE GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
LILY MAY.
AND I'M THE MAYOR OF THE CITY OF
FREMONT.
THE CITY OF FREMONT IS THE CO
SPONSOR OF ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN
TWENTY THREE AND I WANT TO THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP IN THIS BILL -- AB
SEVEN TWENTY THREE WILL CREATE A
STATUTORY WAIVER OF THE CURRENT
TRANSACTIONS AND USE TAXES
SPECIFICALLY FOR THE CITY OF
FREMONT.
WHICH WILL THEN PROVIDE THE CITY
WITH THE OPPORTUNITY TO BRING.
A SMALL TAX INCREASE BEFORE THE
LOCAL LETTERS.
THIS MEASURE IF APPROVED BY THE
VOTERS WILL GENERATE MUCH NEEDED
LOCAL FUNDING THAT WILL HELP.
RETAIN POLICE OFFICERS AND
FIREFIGHTERS.
INFRASTRUCTURE AND HELP ADDRESS
TRAFFIC -- AND ARE HOMELESS
ENCAMPMENTS AND HELP PROVIDE
ALSO SUPPORT FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES.
THE CITY OF FREMONT CURRENT TAX
RATE IS AT NINE POINT TWO FIVE
WHICH IS EXACTLY 2% ABOUT THE
CURRENT STATE WIDE OF SEVEN
POINT 25%.
BY ALLOWING FREMONT VOTERS TO
IMPOSE A INCREMENTAL RATE OF NO
MORE THAN 1%.
OF THE CURRENT USE.
THE OVERWEIGHT BRING US THE CITY
RATE TO TEN POINT 25% WITH THIS
POTENTIALLY ENHANCED VOTER
APPROVED FUNDING THE CITY WOULD
DIRECT THESE FUNDS.
TOWARDS MAINTAINING VITAL
SERVICES FOR COMMUNITY VALUES
INCLUDING PUBLIC SAFETY AS AN
EXAMPLE A COUPLE OF THE PUBLIC
SAFETY PROGRAMS THAT WE'VE BEEN
IMPLEMENTING THEM CURRENTLY
ENJOY.
THAT WOULD BENEFIT FROM
EXPANSION ARE THE MOBILE
EVALUATION TEAM WHICH THE MAT
TEAM FOLLOWS A CO RESPONDER
MODEL WHERE LAW ENFORCEMENT.
PARTNERS WITH A MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONAL TO RESPOND AND
DELIVER SERVICES TO COMMITTEE
MEMBER SUFFERING A MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS.
AND THE BUILDING BRIDGES PROGRAM
WHERE ARE.
VISIT THE ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS AND
THE GOAL IS TO BUILD
RELATIONSHIPS BETWEEN POLICE
OFFICERS AND STUDENTS THAT ARE
POSITIVE AND EARLY AGE -- WE
NEED.
JUST LET OF TORY FOR AN INCREASE
TO THE CURRENT TRANSACTIONS AND
USED TAXES AND AB SEVEN TWENTY
THREE WILL CREATE THE OPTION
SEVEN FREMONT VOTERS THEMSELVES
CAN DECIDE.
WE'RE NOT ASKING THE LEGISLATURE
TO RAISE OUR SALES TAX ALL WE'RE
ASKING FOR IS THE STATUTORY
WAIVER OF THE SALES TAX CAP.
SO THAT WE CAN HAVE THE VOTERS
DECIDE.
IN CLOSING BY PROVIDING THE CITY
WITH THE OPPORTUNITY TO BRING A
LOCAL REVENUE MEASURES BEFORE
THE LOCAL VOTERS THIS WILL
GENERATE MUCH NEEDED FUNDING.
THAT WILL HELP RETAIN POLICE
OFFICERS FIREFIGHTERS AND HELP
ADDRESS ARE HOMELESS ENCAMPMENTS.
AND PROVIDE SUPPORT TO SMALL
BUSINESSES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME TODAY.
THINK IF YOUR TESTIMONY AT IN
FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS BILL SKI
TO SEE PLEASE PASS OUR THANKS TO
CITY COUNCIL AS WELL WITH
ECSTASY THERE'S ANYONE ELSE
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING AT MR TERM MEMBERS
MONICA MILLER REPRESENTED THE
COUNTY ALAMEDA AND WE ARE A CO
SPONSOR OF THIS MEASURE WE WHEN
I THINK THE AUTHOR AND HIS STAFF.
ON FOR CARRYING THIS FORCE AGAIN
THIS IS ONLY ALLOWING US TO GO
TO THE VOTERS THE VOTERS WILL
DECIDE WHETHER OR NOT THEY WANT
TO TAX THEMSELVES.
IN OUR CASE IN ALAMEDA WE'RE
GOING TO USE IT ON ANOTHER TOUR
TITLED BOX. FOR OUR INDIVIDUALS
THAT ARE ON THE VERGE OF
BECOMING HOMELESS SO PROVIDING
ON THE FRONTAL SUBSIDIES --
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES MY
FLEXIBILITY ETCETERA SO WE URGE
IN EITHER TODAY NAY HAPPENING
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU
BECAUSE WE ARE WE'RE GONNA TURN
OVER ANYONE ELSE WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
PLEASE COME FOR THIS TIME
LOOKING FOR THOSE WHO MAY BE IN
SUPPORT.
FIRST CLASS ORGANIZATION.
WELCOME TO DAVID ON THE OF THE
BAY AREA HOUSING ADVOCACY
COALITION IN SUPPORT.
WHERE TO LOOK FOR A LAST CALL
FOR THOSE WHO ARE IN SUPPORT?
MISSY NEVER IN TURN OVER THOSE
WHO MAYBE OPPOSE ITS ROOF THE
FLOORS ARE SIR MISTER CHAIRMAN I
FEEL LIKE -- DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND APPROPRIATIONS HEY
YOU'RE GOOD YOU'RE GOOD NOW.
GO TO GET YOUR NAME PLATE I
ABSOLUTELY.
AREA.
AT MEMBERS THE MORNING THE AND
DAVID WOLFF HOWARD JARVIS
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION AND I
WOULD LIKE TO YOU APOLOGIZE TO
THE AUTHOR FOR THE LATE
OPPOSITION ON THE BILL THE BILL
WAS JUST AMENDED LAST WEEK OF
COURSE SO -- THAT WAS THE REASON
FOR THAT -- WE ARE OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL FOR A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT REASONS MEMBERS LESSEN
THE BRADLEY BURNS RATE -- FOR
LOCAL TAXES STATEWIDE HAS BEEN
SET AT 2% FOR THE BETTER PART OF
DECADES THERE HAVE BEEN BILLS
PREVIOUSLY TO TRY AN INCREASE
THIS STATEWIDE 183% AND THAT WAS --
WERE VETOED BY GOVERNOR BROWN
PREVIOUSLY SO CLEARLY THERE'S
NOT.
SORT OF AN IMPETUS TO PUSH HESE
LOCAL TAXES UP 23% SO WE
CONTINUE TO HAVE THESE CARVE
OUTS AND EXEMPTIONS FROM VARIOUS
MUNICIPALITIES ACROSS THE STATE --
THE 2% MEMBERS IS IN PLACE FOR A
REASON -- THERE'S COMPLIANCE
ISSUES FIRST OF ALL WINNERS AND
LOSERS IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR YOU
HAVE YOU KNOW SOME
MUNICIPALITIES INCREASING TAXES
AT HIGHER RATES THAN OTHERS WHAT
THAT LEADS TO ITS CONSUMERS JUST
JUMPING AROUND FROM MUNICIPALITY
TO MUNICIPALITY TRYING TO GET
THE BETTER DEAL -- THERE'S
COMPLIANCE ISSUES THERE -- AND
UNIFORMITY ISSUES WHICH IS WHY
THE BRADLEY BURNS HAS ALWAYS
BEEN IN PLACE FOR YEARS AND
YEARS -- THERE'S ALSO JUST THE
CONCEPT OF REGRESSIVE TAXES WERE
TALKING ABOUT THE CITY OF
FREMONT NOW WITH.
IF THEY WERE TO GET A GENERAL
TAX APPROVED HAVE A SALES TAX
pTHERE'S ONLY TWENTY FIVE CITIES
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WITH
THE SALES TAX RATE OF OVER 10% --
THAT'S A HUGE HUGE THRESHOLD FOR
A REGRESSIVE TAX -- AND AGAIN WE
SIMPLY DON'T SEE IT AS NECESSARY
IF IT IS NECESSARY INCREASE THE
STATE WATER IT 23% LET'S STOP
DOING THESE CAR ABOUT -- AND SO
WE JUST WERE NOT IN FAVOR JUST
CONTINUE TO REGRESSIVE TAXATION
AND WITHOUT IT ASK FOR NOVA.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER WOLF
WE'RE GONNA TURN IT OVER TO
ANYONE ELSE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION IF YOU COULD
PLEASE COME FOR AT THIS TIME.
LOOKING FOR OPPOSITION -- TURN
IT BACK TO COMMITTEE WE O HAVE
A MOTION THE FLOOR BY CENTER
ABOUT WHERE.
TO HEAR FROM THE VICE CHAIR
MISTER VICE CHAIR FLOORS ARE SIR
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- FOR
THE COUNTY OF ALAMEDA IS THAT
JUST FOR THE UNINCORPORATED AREA
[inaudible]
CORRECT [inaudible]
AND THEN.
THE CITY OF FREMONT -- YOUR NAME
IS INVOKED EARLIER THIS MORNING --
BECAUSE YOU HAVE TESLA AND YOU
SHOULD BE DOING GREAT -- SO
WHAT'S HAPPENING.
WITH REALLY WHAT'S HAPPENING
REALLY IS TEST FOR NOT.
HOTEL WRITING A PART OF OUR
COMMUNITY WE'RE VERY FORTUNATE
TO HAVE THAT CALL US HOME BUT WE
ALSO HAVE A LOT OF OTHER NEEDS
THAT FAR EXCEED.
AND WE ARE GROWING COMMUNITY
THAT'S TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE ARE PREPARED AND GIVES THE
OPTION FOR A COMMUNITY SHOULD
THEY CHOOSE. TO TO BE ABLE TO
LET A ADDITIONAL RESOURCES THAT
WE NEED FOR PROGRAMS SUCH AS OUR
PUBLIC SAFETY.
AND OUR FIREFIGHTERS TO PLAN
BETTER FOR THE FUTURE.
YEAH THAT THAT THAT.
IS SORT OF THE STANDARD -- BUT
THE OPEN ROOM IS PUBLIC EMPLOYEE.
DEFINED BENEFIT PENSION PLANS
ARE SQUEEZING EVERYTHING OUT
CUTTING EVERYTHING OUT IN.
THE FUTURE WE'RE GOING.
TO TOWNIES CITIES SCHOOL
DISTRICT COMING TO US REAL SOON --
WITH WITH THIS GROWING CONCERN
TO MEET THEIR BUDGETS.
SO -- MISTER CHAIR ANOTHER
QUESTION I WOULD HAVE IS IS
COMPOUNDING IF YOU IF YOU
INCREASE THE COUNTY TAX PLUS THE
CITY TAX ESERVER.
CAN YOU GO ABOVE 2% THEN. TWO
AND A HALF THEIR SEPARATE
JURISDICTIONS OKAY THANKS THANKS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CINNAMON.
OF I AM I'M I'M AWAY OFFER
BECAUSE I'M A LIBERTARIAN.
AND SO THE CITY WANTS TO TAX
ITSELF LEASES TAXING ITSELF
LOCALLY -- BUT WE'VE GOT.
WE'RE DEALING WITH A SYMPTOM AND
NOT WITH.
THE TRUE CAUSE OF WHAT'S CAUSING.
THIS AND SO IT IS REGRESSIVE IN
IT WILL HURT THE POOR.
AND ALL OF THE RESIDENTS OF
FREMONT IN ALAMEDA COUNTY DECIDE.
THANK YOU MISTER NO THANK YOU
MISTER VENTURE FOR YOUR COMMENTS
WOULD LIKE TO RECEIVE ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE CENTER ABOUT.
THE DOG I KNOW I KNOW THE CITY
OF FREMONT SO WELL RUNS EITHER.
YEAH OUT OF STANDING ON
MANAGEMENT AND THEY HAVE THESE
NEEDS -- I THINK IS A REASONABLE
REQUEST TO SUBMIT TO THE VOTERS.
AND ALLOW THEM TO DO SO AND
THAT'S ALL THE MAYORS ASKING.
FOR THE ASSEMBLYMAN -- I THINK
IT'S A REASON SURCHARGE AROUND
US AND CLOSE MY WIFE WAS BORN IN
FREMONT SO AFTER.
ONCE A HUSKY ALL AS A HUSKY OKAY
THERE YOU GO IS THE WASHINGTON
HUSKY RIGHT.
HEY HEY.
BUT I CAN GET.
HEY THANK YOU SO MUCH AS CENTER
BALLOT.
KAREN SEEN NO ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MISTER SOMEONE WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE PLEASE --
THANK YOU CONCERNED ABOUT THIS
BEING A REGRESSIVE TAX WE SHOULD
SIMPLY ALLOW ANY CITY TO IMPOSE.
A INCOME TAX ON ITS RESIDENTS --
THAT COULD BE GRADUATED THAT
WOULD TAKE CARE OF THIS PROBLEM
I HOPE YOU'LL GIVE ME YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THAT NEXT YEAR THANK
YOU.
IN THE AREA THERE'S A YOUNG BILL
IDEAS ARE ALL OVER.
AGAIN THAT.
SENATOR THANK YOU SO MUCH THIS
SAYS -- ITEM.
NUMBER ELEVEN A. B. SEVEN TWENTY
THREE MAYOR THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE TODAY WE'RE GRATEFUL.
THAT WE DO HAVE A MOTION ON THE
FLOOR BY CENTER BELL THE MOTION
IS A TO PASS THE HOUSING THE
SAINT JOSEPH YOU COULD PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
HI WHY I'M MORE LOCK
[inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
HELLO [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
WIENER.
ENJOYS A TWO ZERO VOTE THANK YOU
SO MUCH AS A MEMBER THANK YOU
THANK YOU SENATORS AND WE CAN
DISAGREE AND STILL BE FRIENDS
AND THAT'S ONE OF THE BEST
THINGS ABOUT THIS PLACE YOU'RE
pABSOLUTELY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN WE ARE.
EXCITED THAT IT'S A NUMBER CHAO
IS HERE THIS IS ITEM NUMBER FOUR
ON OUR AGENDA THIS IS AB.
ONE SEVEN THREE WE WELCOME THIS
SUMMER TO COMMITTEE HE'S
FOCUSING ON ALL ISSUES OF MOBILE
HOMES.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS THE MEMBER
THANKS FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND SENATORS IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN THE LEGISLATURE
ENACTED A. B. FIVE EIGHTY SEVEN
WHICH ESTABLISHED A TAX
ABATEMENT PROGRAM.
CALLED REGISTER YOUR MOBILE HOME
CALIFORNIA.
IT IS A PROGRAM FOR MOBILE HOME
OWNERS WHO ARE UNABLE TO
TRANSFER TITLE OF THEIR HOMES
INTO THEIR NAMES DUE TO TAX
DELINQUENCIES THAT WERE INCURRED
BY PRIOR OWNERS.
SINCE THE PROGRAM STARTED IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN MOBILE
HOMEOWNERS HAVE SAVED WALL OVER
ONE POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS.
AND THE PROGRAM IS ON PACE TO
SAVE MOBILE HOMEOWNERS TWO
MILLION DOLLARS BY THE TIME IT
SUNSETS ON DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST.
TWENTY NINETEEN DESPITE THE
SUCCESS THERE ARE STILL TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF HOMEOWNERS WHO HAVE
NOT.
BEEN ABLE TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THE PROGRAM.
AB ONE SEVENTY THREE WAS SIMPLY
EXTEND TO SUNSET.
ON THE REGISTER YOUR MOBILE HOME
CALIFORNIA TAX ABATEMENT PROGRAM
FOR ONE YEAR TO CONTINUE TO HELP
MOBILE HOMEOWNERS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR ARRIVAL --
FOCUS ON THIS ISSUE WE'RE GONNA
TURN OVER TO YOUR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT SIR WELCOME TO COMMITTEE
OF TWO MINUTES.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND SENATORS
OF THE COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS ROGER JOHNSON.
I AM A SENIOR OF VETERAN IN A
MOBILE HOME OWNER.
WHO LIVES IN LAKE VIEW VILLAGE?
IN CITRUS HEIGHTS CALIFORNIA.
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE GOLDEN
STATE MOBILE HOMEOWNERS LEAGUE.
G. S. M. MORAL REPRESENTING
SENIORS VETERANS.
IMMIGRANTS AND OTHER LOW INCOME.
LOW AND MODERATE FIXED INCOME
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES WHO
LIVE IN MOBILE HOME PARKS.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
AB ONE SEVEN THREE WILL HELP
MOBILE HOMEOWNER RESIDENTS WHO
ARE TRYING TO TRANSFER.
TITLE INTO THEIR NAME.
IT ALSO CREATES A WIN FOR THE
STATE.
IN THE COUNTIES.
WHO CAN UPDATE THE RECORDS SO
THAT UNCOLLECTED TAXES AND FEES
CAN NOW BE COLLECTED FROM THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT -- THEM.
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT ON THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
ARE YOU HERE TO BE TO TESTIFY AS
WELL.
YOU'RE NOT HAS FINE.
YES.
OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH DESERVED
JUST CONFIRMING THANK YOU WE NOW
WOULD LIKE TO GET A WELCOME
ANYONE ELSE WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
PERSON LAST NAME ORGANIZATION
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE GOOD
MORNING THANKS FOR HANGING WITH
US.
HI MY NAME IS TONY WALLIS I AM A
PRESIDENT OF THE HOMEOWNER
ASSOCIATION FOR STONE GATE
MOBILE.
PARK IN CITRUS HEIGHTS AND WE
ALL STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU SO MUCH [inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING BEV PRISTELLA
REPRESENTING SACK WHICH IS
SACRAMENTO AREA COALITION OF
MOBILE HOMEOWNERS.
REPRESENTING THREE THOUSAND
HOMEOWNERS AND WE RESPECTFULLY
ASK THAT YOU VOTE YES ON THIS
ISSUE THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY GOOD MORNING.
MORNING.
LEARN TO WORK SUCH AS HARD IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
IF YOUR SERVICE [inaudible]
MORNING.
GOOD MORNING I'M JILL FOLLOWS.
A MEMBER OF DISSIMILARITY MOBILE
COME TO CLUB IN RANCHO CORDOVA
I'M HERE JUST IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL THANK YOU [inaudible]
MORNING.
I AM WHILE FELLOW RANCHO CORDOVA.
ALSO FROM MOBILE COUNTRY COME IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE SIR.
THE MORNING.
MORNING MY NAME IS MERRY
VANKLEEK FILM I LIVE IN A MOBILE
HOME AND I SUPPORT THIS.
YOU SO MUCH.
MORNING SIR ROBERT VAN CLEEF
MOBILE COUNTRY CLUB HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATION PRESIDENT.
ALSO RICH WENT OVER HI SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU SO MUCH IS
PRESENT GREAT FOR HERE MORNING
MA'AM.
THE MORNING PUTTING SOMEONE
FREDERICKS I'M A SENIOR MOBILE
HOME OWNER MY HUSBAND'S A
VETERAN AND WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR GREAT FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY WOULD LIKE ME TO SEE
IF THERE'S ANYONE ELSE.
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
COULD BE A LAST CALL FOR SUPPORT.
WE NOW WOULD LIKE TO WELCOME
ANYONE WHO MAY BE OPPOSE
[inaudible]
SIGN WELCOME. FOR YOUR FIRST.
GOOD MORNING MR TURN MEMBERS
CAROLING OUT OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTY
TREASURER'S AND TAX COLLECTORS.
WE ARE OPPOSED UNLESS AMENDED --
ARE CONCERNED STEM FROM THE USE
OF THE PROGRAM BY MOBILE HOME
PARK OWNERS WE UNDERSTAND THAT
THEY CAN ALL USE AT ONE TIME
WERE CONCERNED THAT THE USE OF
THE WORD HOUSEMAN'S LEAN PROCESS
WHEREBY.
AN ABANDONED MOBILE HOME IS SOLD
AT AN AUCTION FOR DOLLAR. TO A
PARK OWNER AND THEN THEY ARE
ABLE TO THEN APPLY TO THIS
PROGRAM AND WIPES AWAY.
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS OF PROPERTY
TAXES THAT ARE OWED. TO THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT WERE CONCERNED
THAT PARKING OR CERTAINLY KNOW
HOW TO TRANSFER THE THE
PAPERWORK PROPERLY.
WE'RE LOOKING FOR SOME --
LEGISLATIVE ASSISTANCE IN MAKING
SURE THAT THE PROGRAM IS SERVING
THE POPULATION AS INTENDED THE
SUPPORTERS HERE THAT'S GREAT
WEIRD THAT THOSE ARE THE FOLKS
WE WANT TO HELP.
WE OFFERED SUBSTANTIVE
AMENDMENTS TO THE ORIGINAL
VERSION OF THE BILL I AND I
TWENTY SIXTEEN WE PROVIDED A LOT
OF COMMENTATORS CITIES THEY
DEVELOP THE REGULATIONS.
NONE OF OUR SUGGESTIONS WERE
INCORPORATED WHICH IS WHY WE ARE
NOW HERE IN OPPOSITION BECAUSE
WE ARE WATCHING PARKOWNERS USE
THIS TO ENRICH THEMSELVES.
AND ACQUIRE SOMEONE'S FORMER
HOME FOR A DOLLAR IN THE MIDDLE
OF A HOUSING CRISIS SO I WE'RE
ASKING FOR YOU TO EXERCISE THE
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT ROLE THAT
YOU DO ENJOY BY LOOKING AT THESE
FOR THE WAREHOUSE MEANS LEAD TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE RIGHT PEOPLE
ARE USING THEM.
THE PROGRAM AND NOT A RICH IN
THEMSELVES AND THROUGH THIS
THROUGH THIS PROGRAM AND ALSO WE
OBSERVE TO THAT IT'S COST I%
THINK IT'S TO BE ABOUT A HALF A
MILLION DOLLARS TO RUN THE
PROGRAM THEY'VE ONLY BROUGHT IN
TWO HUNDRED AND SOMETHING
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN FEES AS OF
JANUARY.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF THE DOLLARS
THAT HAVE BEEN FORGIVEN OR LOCAL
PROPERTY TAX DOLLARS SO WE'RE
GOING TO BE HAVING TO FORFEIT
THIS ON VOLUNTARILY -- WE WOULD
LIKE TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
ACTUAL INTENDED RECIPIENTS OF
THE BILL ARE THERE ARE THE
BENEFICIARIES.
AND THEN -- WE ALSO WANT TO
OBSERVE THAT THIS DOES NOT
ACTUALLY SOLVE THE PROBLEM OF
MAKING SURE THAT PEOPLE'S HOMES
ARE REGISTERED THERE'S STILL NO
LONG TERM SOLUTION IN THE BILL
IT OPENS A WINDOW THAT FOLKS CAN
GO THROUGH TO GET THEIR TECH
CSUS FORGIVEN.
AND THERE'S NO LONG TERM
SOLUTION TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
PARK OWNERS KNOW WHEN THE MOBILE
HOME IS REGISTERED CURRENT OR
NOT SO UNTIL THE STICKER PROGRAM
IS BROUGHT BACK.
YOU REALLY HAVEN'T SOLVED THE
PROBLEM THAT YOU'RE GIVING AWAY
A LOT OF PROPERTY TAX DOLLARS AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL SO THAT IS WHAT
WE ARE OPPOSED.
I WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE
THE DISCUSSION OVER THE BREAK
THE AUTHORS OFFICE HAS REACHED
OUT AND WE'RE TRYING TO WORK
WITH THEM AS WELL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR SAYING
WE'RE GONNA BE HANG THERE IF
THAT'S OKAY JUST IN CASE YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS WOULD LIKE ME
TO SEE IF WE HAVE ANYONE ELSE.
WHO MAY BE IN?
OPPOSITION OF THE BILL IF YOU
COULD PLEASE COME FORWARD.
THIS CAN BE LAST CALL FOR
OPPOSITION.
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
TO SEE IF WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS.
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
WE HAVE A MOTION A MOTION BY
SENATOR BELL THIS IS A DO PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS. TO MEMBER CHAD
YOU WERE A RESPOND TO MISS
LANE'S COMMENTS PLEASE
ABSOLUTELY -- THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF FOR THE QUESTIONS LET ME
IN ANY -- ADDRESS IT FROM
DIFFERENT ANGLES ON THE FIRST OF
ALL I THINK THE THE OBJECTIVE OF
THIS -- OF OF THIS BILL IS TO
HELP. TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
HOMEOWNERS ARE GET TO TRANSFER
THE TITLE PROPERLY -- AND YOU
KNOW WITHOUT PAYING TAXES THAT
THEY DID NOT A CREW.
NOW UNDER THIS PROGRAM THE
COUNTY SO STILL ELIGIBLE TO
PURSUE ANY BACK -- DELINQUENT
TAXES -- IF THEY WISH SO WE'RE
NOT ACTUALLY LOSING ANY
PARTICULAR BACK TAXES BECAUSE
YOU KNOW THE LAW DOESN'T
PROHIBITIVE FROM GOING AFTER
THESE BAD BAD GUYS.
NOW HAVING SAID THAT -- YOU KNOW
IS A PART OWNER IS A LEGITIMATE
OWNER OF THE UNIT FOR EXAMPLE A
HE OR SHE OUGHT TO BE ABLE TO OF
THE ELIGIBLE FOR THE PROGRAM.
NOW AS TO THE POTENTIAL MISUSE
OF THE PROGRAM.
I THINK THAT -- IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT -- MANY OF
THE PARK OWNERS WORK SIMPLY
HOPING RESIDENTS TO OF FILL OUT
FORMS AND ALSO BECAUSE OF THE OF
THEIR LIMITED.
ENGLISH SKILL LEVEL THEY WERE
NOT ABLE TO DO SO SO THEY WERE
SIMPLY TRYING TO YOU KNOW FILLED
THE FORMS WITH MS AND IN THE
TRANSFER THE TITLE BACK TO THE
PROPER OWNER.
NOW.
IS THE PROGRAM IS MIS USE ALL
THE FIRST ONE TO ME I'LL TRY TO
FIX IT.
SO I AM A VERY WILLING TO SIT
DOWN WITH THE COUNTY SUBSTANCE
FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN CLOSE THAT
LOOPHOLE AS TO THE OUTSTANDING
AMENDMENTS OF SUGGESTED I THINK.
THEY POSE CERTAIN OF PROBLEMS
BOB SO -- I'LL BE HAPPY TO WORK
WITH THEM BUT I JUST WANT TO
ALSO POINT OUT THE FACT THAT
EXISTING LAW MAKES IT A FELONY
FOR SOMEBODY WHO HAS THE INTENT
TO DEFRAUD THE SYSTEM.
BY A TRANSFER TITLE IMPROPERLY
AND THAT'S ON THEIR HEALTH AND
SAFETY CODE -- ARTICLE SEVEN ONE
EIGHT ONE TWO FOUR POINT FIVE SO --
SO THE LAW IS AVAILABLE -- FORCE
TO PURSUE ANY -- BAD ACTORS YOU
KNOW FOR SOMEBODY WHO MISUSES A
THE PROGRAM SO.
WITH THAT I YOU KNOW I I BELIEVE
THAT MY MEETING WITH THE
OPPOSITION IS -- SET FOR THIS
AFTERNOON SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THEM.
AND YOU KNOW CLOSE ANY POTENTIAL
OPPOSE AT THIS PROGRAM TO CREATE
SO WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
PRIVATE THANK YOU SO MUCH AS A
MEMBER I THINK IT'S ALSO
IMPORTANT KNOW THAT THIS IS A
ONE YEAR EXTENSION.
IN OBVIOUSLY THERE'S GOING TO BE
ADDITIONAL CONVERSATIONS HERE
OVER THE SUMMER DURING SUMMER
WORK PERIOD BUT THEN THIS ONE
YEAR EXTENSION IS GOING TO BE
ABLE TO ALLOW. FOR MORE IN DEPTH
THAT CONVERSATION WOULD YOU SAY
THAT'S CORRECT SIR ABSOLUTELY
CORRECT I THANK YOU SO MUCH THAT
ONE YEAR EXTENSION IS IN FRONT
OF THIS.
COMMITTEE HERE TODAY WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THE FLOOR THAT MOTIONS
BY CENTER BATTLE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS OUR
PREPARATIONS WE ARE CLOSING
COMING BY THE AUTHOR SIGN
CHESTER.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL WIRED HIGH
MCGUIRE AYE MORE LOT.
MORE LUCK NOBEL DEL I AM
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HELLO NIELSEN.
NIELSEN AYE WIENER.
CURRENTLY ENJOYS A THREE ONE
VOTE WE'RE GOING TO KEEP THAT
ROLE OPEN -- IN WILL ADD FOLKS
ON THANK YOU SO MUCH IN THE FREE
WORK ON THIS A CENTERS.
THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE TODAY.
MEMBERS ARE NOW CAN BE MOVING ON
TO MISTER COOLEY WE'RE GRATEFUL
THAT AT SOME NUMBER COOLEY IS
HERE.
FOCUSING ON CLIMATE CHANGE
INNOVATION GRANT PROGRAM IN THE
VOLUNTARY TAX CONTRIBUTIONS.
WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR ALL YOUR WORK
SURE THE FLOOR IS YOURS WE
WELCOME YOU.
VERY GOOD -- MISTER CHAIR
PLEASURE TO BE HERE.
HAVE MY FORMER SCIENCE FILL
EMILY BERRY WHOSE ASSIST ME ON
THIS BILL -- PHD SHE ACTUALLY
CENTER AND GOVERNANCE SO I JUST
INVITE ORDER TO SIT HERE. FOR
YOUR MOST AUGUST PANEL.
ALL RIGHT -- HERE TODAY IT WAS
IN AB TWO NINETY SIX AND I WANT
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE COMMITTEES
ASSISTANCE ON AMENDMENTS WORKING
ON TERRIFYING HOW THE PRESSURE.
PROPOSAL WILL WORK AND ACCEPT
THOSE AMENDMENTS.
THIS BILL ESTABLISH THE CLAIM
AND INNOVATION GRANT PROGRAM
WITHIN THE STRATEGIC GROWTH
COUNCIL. TO ACCELERATE AND
SUPPORT THE DEVELOPMENT OF NEW
INNOVATIONS.
THAT IMPROVE ADAPTABILITY AND
RESILIENCE OF THE IMPACTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE -- OBVIOUSLY
IMPACTS FROM GLOBAL WARMING ARE
ALREADY BEING OBSERVED ACROSS
THE NATION THE WORLD.
AND THE TIME TO ACT IS NOW.
IN THEIR MOST RECENT ASSESSMENT
OF CALIFORNIA'S KIND OF POLICIES.
THE LA -- SPECIFIC RECOMMENDS
THAT THE STATE SUPPORT.
PRESERVATION AND ADDRESS OTHER
ENVIRONMENTAL POLLUTION -- AB
TWO NINE SIX AIMS TO DO THIS --
THE BILL INTENSE ROCK UP THE
BEST IDEAS CAN HELP ADDRESS
CARBON THAT IS ALREADY BEEN
COMMITTED.
AND ALSO DRESSED IN VINYL
POLLUTION AIR WATER AND SOIL.
IT'LL USE AND COMPETITIVE
PROCESS TOWARD MATCHING GRANTS
RENOVATIONS IT'S A GREAT BILL I
HAVE GREAT CO AUTHORS -- IN THIS
HOUSE AND MY OWN HOUSE AND I
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU SO
MUCH AS A MEMBER GRATEFUL FOR
YOUR WORK ON THIS CRITICAL ISSUE
WE DO HAVE A MOTION ON THE FLOOR.
MOTIONS BEEN MADE BY SENATOR
BAIL WITH ACTIVATED TURN IT OVER
TO ANYONE ELSE WHO MAY BE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
IF YOU COULD PLEASE COME FOR
THIS TIME.
COME ON DOWN.
THANKS FOR HANGING WITH THIS ONE
AND THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
I'M WORKING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA TROUT IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WHERE DO A LAST CALL FOR THOSE
WHO MAY BE IN SUPPORT?
CURRENCY NINE WOULD LIKE TO TURN
OVER THOSE WHO MAY BE OPPOSED TO
LOOKING FOR OPPOSITION AT THIS
TIME.
WHERE DO A LAST CALL FOR
OPPOSITION?
TURN SEEN NO OPPOSITION WERE IN
TURN OVER THE VICE CHAIR
TOMORROW LOOK.
LIKE YOU NEED SOME OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY.
I DON'T KNOW IF I'VE EVER VOTED
NO.
ON ONE OF YOUR BILL SINCE I'VE
BEEN HERE SO WE CAN CHECK THAT
BOX OFF TODAY YEAH -- SO I JUST
WANNA EXPLAIN MY NOBLE AYE YES
YOUR MIND -- ARE READY I
APOLOGIZE THEY GET A CHANCE.
FIRSTLY -- GERMAN AND I FOR LAST
YEAR'S IN TRYING -- TO VOLUNTARY
CONTRIBUTIONS AND I DID A BILL
THIS YEAR.
TO TRY AND MAKE IT -- MORE
ACCESSIBLE.
TO ALL CALIFORNIA NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS RIGHT NOW.
NO ONE'S CHECK IN THE BOX.
IS IT'S LESS THAN 2%.
SO WERE -- ALL WE'RE DOING IS
WE'RE ADDING MORE PAGES TO THE
FORM FIVE FORTY AND IT'S LIKE
OKAY IF YOU CAN FIND A
LEGISLATOR YOU COULD BUT YOU
KNOW YOUR BOX IN THERE.
AND AND I'D LIKE TO MAKE SOME.
TOLD REFORM SO I GOT STUCK IN.
APPROPRIATIONS PURGATORY I WITH
THE BILL SO THAT MEANS I GET TO
MAYBE DO IT AGAIN.
NEXT YEAR OR TRY AGAIN BUT THE
AND I KNOW OTHERS HAVE TRIED IN
YEARS -- LIKE CENTER WALT -- SO --
I I HAVE BEEN OPPOSING AND AND
WALLY KAHN'S WEEK WE CALLED
WALLY KAHN'S NOW YEAH AND AND
JUST SORT OF DOING A SELF
MORATORIUM.
UNTIL WE REALLY GET IT A FIX
BECAUSE NO ONE'S TOUCH IN THESE
THINGS.
AT TAX PREPARERS AREN'T EVEN
TELLING THEIR CLIENTS THAT THEY
HAVE A CHANCE.
TO YOU KNOW GIVE PART OF THEIR
REFUND TO OF A WORTHWHILE IMPORT
ORGANIZATION.
SO AND TELL UNTIL WE FIX THAT
I'M I'M JUST.
VOTING NO INCLUDING REPUBLICAN
OFFICE.
SO I APOLOGIZE IN ADVANCE FOR MY
OLD THE SENATOR I DID UNDERSTAND.
THAT YOU'VE TAKEN UP THAT ISSUE
AS AN ADVOCATE.
I ACTUALLY KNOW THAT NO CHANGE
HAPPENS INCLUDING THIS BILL BUT
NO CHANGE HAPPENS [inaudible]
IF YOU'RE.
NOT LEADING AUDIT YOU NEED TO
ARGUE FOR ISSUE SO I SORT OF
UNDERSTAND YOU CAN'T PULL AN
UNCERTAIN TRUMPET USED TO BE
SAID.
YOU HAVE TO THE CLEAR WHERE YOU
AREN'T PERSISTENT AT EVERY TURN.
TO START GETTING ATTENTION AND
SO I KNOW IN THIS PROCESS THIS
IS AN ISSUE YOU ARE WORKING ON
SO I TAKE NO OFFENSE I ACTUALLY
DID DAHLE THAT ISSUE IS OUT
THERE I WASN'T.
PLAYING WITH YOU SEE WILL CHECK
THAT BOX OFFICE SORT OF
UNDERSTOOD.
THAT'S AN ISSUE WHERE YOU WERE
GIVING LEADERSHIP.
I ACTUALLY KNOW THIS IS AN
OUTSTANDING BILL.
AND I A YOU KNOW I THINK WE WE
TRIED A EXERCISE OUR PUBLIC
RESPONSIBILITY.
ON BEHALF OF THE FUTURE.
THAT'S WHAT I'M DOING THAT'S
WHAT YOU'RE DOING I RECEIVED
YOUR COMMENTS IN THAT SPIRIT IN
YOUR VOTE IN THAT SPIRIT.
AND IT.
THIS PROCESS ON EVERY FRONT
NEEDS CHAMPIONS.
THOSE ARE LET'S SAY PROCESS THIS
HONOR WE BEND THE CURVE OF THE
FUTURE CHANGE THE CONVERSATION.
SO I'M HONORED TO BE HERE PRISON
THIS BILL I THINK FOR THE MOTION.
AND AYE SIR TO RECEIVE YOUR
COMMENT SORT OF WHAT THAT
UNDERSTAND WHAT WE'RE ALL ABOUT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE THANK
YOU QUESTION I VOTE THANK YOU SO
I SEVEN WOULD YOU WANT TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE VICE
CHAIR THE VICE YEARS BEEN.
WORKING HARD ON THIS ISSUE.
I'M BRINGING ALL STAKEHOLDERS
TOGETHER.
WILLING TO COMPROMISE AS WELL --
IN WHICH HE DID A LOT OF FOR THE
GREATER GOOD TO JUST ONE TAKE
MOMENT I DO HOPE THAT YOU.
BRING THAT BACK NEXT YEAR SO
APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK BY THE
VICE CHAIR THAT ISSUE LIKE TODAY
TO SEE IF WE HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OUR
CONVERSATION FROM THE COMMITTEE
AT THIS TIME.
WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE FLOOR
THAT MOTION -- IS BY CENTER BELL
ANY CLOSING COMMENTS SOME NUMBER
QUESTION I VOTE THANK YOU VERY
BIG THANK YOU SO MUCH THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO CENTER
PREPARATIONS.
SCIENTISTS REPEAT PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL CHOIR HI GLORIA ALLRED
MORE LOCKED.
MORE ON THE BELL.
I HERTZBERG RICARDO NIELSEN.
NIELSEN AYE WIENER. THREE ONE
VOTE WHEN KEEP THAT ROLE OPEN
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE FOR YOUR WORK
IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU.
THANK YOU.
BUT IS IN GENERAL NOT GONNA BE
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
NINE THIS IS AB.
FIVE OH EIGHT THE WELCOME LESSON
NUMBER TWO TWO COMMITTEE WELCOME
BACK SIR IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU.
THIS IS FOCUSING ON DRINKING
WATER IN CONSOLIDATION.
AND EXTENSION OF SERVICE.
THE MEMBER THE FLOOR IS YOURS ON
AB FIVE OH EIGHT WELCOME THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND SENATORS AND
I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB FIVE ZERO
EIGHT WHICH BUILT ON OUR
PROGRESS LAST YEAR. TO PROVIDE
SAFE DRINKING WATER TO
INDIVIDUALS AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITY WHO RELY ON SMALL
WATER SYSTEMS AND DOMESTIC
WHIRLS.
SPECIFICALLY AB FIVE ZERO EIGHT
REQUIRED THE WATER BOARD TO LET
RATE PAYERS RENTERS AND LAND
OWNERS.
IN THE DISTURBANCES COMMUNITY
KNOWS ABOUT WATER QUALITY
CONCERN IN THE AREA.
INFORMATION ABOUT THE HELL SHE
OF CONTAMINANTS AND TO
INFORMATION ABOUT THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR CONSOLE OF THE
OR EXTENSION ALL SERVICES.
THIS FOR A ALSO CLARIFIED THAT
AS A STATE MANDATED
CONSOLIDATION OR EXTENSION.
THE BIG GAINS IT IS A VIOLATION
OF THE LAW FOR A RECEIVING WATER
SYSTEM TO OVER CHARGE BEYOND A
REASONABLE COST. TO PROVIDE
SERVICES TO THE DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES.
FINALLY THIS WILL SET THE
DOWNLINE THE DEADLINE FOR JULY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY FIVE WHICH
TO STAY WATER BOARD.
WILL DEVELOP AND ADOPT A POLICY
FOR MEMBERS OFF TO DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITY TO PETITION.
THE WATER BOARD TO CONSOLIDATION
OR EXTENSION OFFICE SERVICES.
THIS BILL IS SPONSORED BY THE
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL FOR JUSTICE
AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
AND SUPPORTER OF BY
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE GROUPS.
THE CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION AND THE ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES.
AND HAS NO OPPOSITION.
WHO WAS ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT IS FROM MICHAEL CLAIR
BORN PHONE THE LEADERSHIP
COUNCIL FOR JUSTICE?
AND ACCOUNTABILITY AND ALSO --
SASHA SEARCHERS HERE'S ARCHER
HARDEN FROM THE WESTERN CENTER
OF LAW AND PROPERTY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH WE HAVE.
BILL WE HAVE A TWO WITNESSES SO
I JUST WANNA CONFIRM WHO WOULD
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO GO FIRST.
I THINK I'LL START ALL RIGHT HEY
WELCOME YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES OF
YOUR MIND IS INTRODUCE YOURSELF
FIRST LAST ORGANIZATION TWO
MINUTES WELCOME SIR ABSOLUTELY --
MY NAME'S MICHAEL CLAIBORNE I'M
AN ATTORNEY WITH LEADERSHIP
COUNCIL FOR JUSTICE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY.
WHICH IS AN ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE NONPROFIT BASED IN
FRESNO -- AND WITH OFFICES IN
THESE COACHELLA VALLEY AS WELL.
I'LL START BY THANKING THE
AUTHOR FOR PAST AND PRESENT
EFFORTS TO CHAMPION PAUL --
POLICY TO IMPROVE ACCESS TO SAFE
DRINKING WATER FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS.
AND I'LL ALSO TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO THANK A MEMBER OF
THIS COMMITTEE SENATOR HER HER
TAUGHT -- FOR SECURING AN
APPROPRIATION FOR EXTENSION OF
DRINKING WATER SERVICE TO
TOMBSTONE TERRITORY AND FRESNO
COUNTY IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET.
AND I MENTION THIS PROJECT HERE
BECAUSE IT IS THROUGH OUR
EXPERIENCE WORKING WITH
COMMUNITY RESIDENTS IN TOMBSTONE
WHICH STRUGGLES WITH ONE TWO
THREE T. C. P. NITRATES AND
BACTERIA CONTAMINATION.
THAT WE IDENTIFIED WITH THE
AUTHOR IMPROVEMENTS THE PROCESS
FOR DRINKING WATER CONSOLIDATION --
WHICH ARE CONTAINED IN AB FIVE
AWAIT.
THIS BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION AND
SIGNIFICANT SUPPORT.
TURNING TO THE NEED FOR THE BILL
THERE'S A DRINKING WATER CRISIS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
MORE THAN ONE MILLION PEOPLE
CURRENTLY LACK ACCESS TO SAFE
DRINKING WATER IN THEIR HOMES
AND A SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF
THIS PROBLEM IS -- HOUSEHOLDS
SERVED BY DOMESTIC WELLS WHICH
SERVE TWO MILLION PEOPLE WITHIN
THE STATE.
THIS IS BEEN MADE TO ADDRESS THE
CRISIS SPURRED ON BY THE
TRANSFER OF THE DRINKING WATER
PROGRAM TO THE STATE WATER BOARD
AND THE PASSAGE OF SB.
EIGHTY EIGHT AND AB TWENTY FIVE
A ONE WHICH GRANTED AN EXPANDED
RESPECTIVELY THE AUTHORITY OF
THE STATE WATER BOARD TO MANDATE
DRINKING WATER CONSOLIDATION.
AND AB FIVE OH EIGHT CONTINUES
AND BUILDS UPON THIS PROGRESS BY
MAKING THE MANDATORY
CONSOLIDATION PROCESS MORE
EFFICIENT AND TRANSPARENT.
IT WILL PROVIDE MORE INFORMATION
TO COMMUNITY RESIDENTS
THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS OF EXPAND
AS EXTENDING DRINKING WATER
SERVICE.
THIS INFORMATION INCLUDES NOTICE
OF DRINKING WATER PROBLEM
PROBLEMS IN THE AREA RELATED
HEALTH RISKS AND AVAILABLE
SOLUTIONS.
IT WOULD ALSO PROVIDE FOR THE
COMPLETION OF A FEASIBILITY
STUDY EARLIER ON IN THE PROCESS
WITHOUT THE REQUIREMENT THAT THE
STATE WATER BOARD IS ALREADY
DEMONSTRATED MAJORITY SUPPORT.
OFTEN THIS FEASIBILITY ANALYSIS
IS REQUIRED IN ADVANCE FOR
PEOPLE TO MAKE AN INFORMED
DECISION ABOUT WHETHER TO
CONSENT TO DRINKING WATER
SERVICE.
SO JUST FLIPS THAT PROCESS
AROUND IT MAKES A LITTLE MORE
SENSE.
BY MAKING DRINKING WATER
CONSOLIDATION MORE EFFICIENT AND
TRANSPARENT PASSAGE OF AB FIVE
AWAY WILL SUPPORT EFFECTIVE
PROCESSES TO ENSURE THAT HUMAN
RIGHTS WATER IS REALIZED FOR ALL
CALIFORNIA FOUND FAMILIES.
AND WE URGE THE COMMITTEE
SUPPORT THANK YOU MICHAEL THANKS
FOR BEING HERE WE'RE GRATEFUL.
QUESTION GOOD AFTERNOON GOOD
MORNING SUTTER HER NAME HOUSING
POLICY ADVOCATE WITH THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY HERE
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
WE ARE THE FIRST STATE IN THE
NATION TO RECOGNIZE THE HUMAN
RIGHT TO WATER AND WE'VE IT
FURTHER ACKNOWLEDGE THE
IMPORTANCE OF ACCESS TO CLEAN
DRINKING WATER AND RENTAL
HOUSING THROUGH -- HABITABILITY
LAWS -- WHEN THE LOW INCOME
FAMILIES THAT WE REPRESENT LACK
SAFE DRINKING WATER LACK
INFORMATION ABOUT WHETHER THEY
CAN DRINK OR BATHE WITH THEIR
WATER -- IT CAN LEADS NOT ONLY
ALSO TO HOMELESSNESS JOBLESSNESS
ACADEMIC HARDSHIP.
AND THREATS TO FAMILY AND
COMMUNITY COHESION.
WE'VE SEEN CLIENTS DISPLACED
FROM THEIR HOMES AND COMMUNITIES
DUE TO A LACK OF ACCESS TO CLEAN
WATER AND WE'VE SEEN FAMILIES
STRUGGLE WITH A LACK OF
INFORMATION.
I DON'T KNOW IF THEY'RE WATER
SAFE TO DRINK OR BATHE WITH --
OR WHAT STEPS THEY CAN DO.
TO REGAIN ACCESS TO CLEAN WATER
THEY MAY CHOOSE TO BUY COSTLY
BOTTLED WATER.
TAKE WHATEVER MEASURES THEY CAN
COME UP WITH TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES OR POTENTIALLY IF
THEIR HOMES OUT OF FEAR AND
FRUSTRATION.
THESE ARE SIGNIFICANT AND
CONCRETE HARDSHIPS FOR THE
FAMILIES WE REPRESENT GIVING
CALIFORNIA'S HIGH RATE OF
POVERTY AND LACK OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING -- FOR EXAMPLE I WORKED
WITH RESIDENTES EN LOS ANGELES
STRUGGLING WITH DISCOLORED WATER
AND NOT REALLY KNOWING WHERE
THAT PROBLEM IS COMING FROM.
MANY OF THEM WEREN'T BOILING IT
BECAUSE THEY HAD PAST
EXPERIENCES WITH BACTERIAL
CONTAMINANTS -- AND KNEW THAT
WAS A WAY TO TREAT THAT WATER --
BUT BECAUSE THIS WATER WAS
CONTAMINATED WITH LEAD THAT CAN
ACTUALLY CONCENTRATE THAT
CONTAMINANT AND SUBJECT FAMILIES
TO HIGHER RISKS -- SO
INFORMATION REGARDING LOCAL
WATER QUALITY WILL BETTER EQUIP
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES TO
MAKE APPROPRIATE DECISIONS --
AND INFORMATION REGARDING RIGHTS
AND OPTIONS WITH RESPECT TO
CONSOLIDATION WILL EMPOWER THEM
TO ADVOCATE FOR SOLUTIONS AND
BETTER PROTECT THEIR HOMES AND
FAMILIES WE ARE TO SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH ON BOTH OF
YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY WE NOW
WOULD LIKE TO OPEN IT UP TO
ANYONE.
ELSE WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT FIRST CLASS ORGANIZATION
GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING MATTHEW BIGGER
PLANNING CONSERVATION THE
INSTRUCTOR PUTTING COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
WELCOME BACK.
THANK YOU MELISSA ROMERO THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT
AND I WAS ALSO ASKED TO PASS
ALONG THE SUPPORT FROM SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. ONE
MY MISTER CHAMBERS PRESENTERS
AND I'LL BE HAVE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES IN
SUPPORT.
SO MUCH MORNING MORNING MICHELLE
RIGHT WITH THE COMMUNITY WATER
CENTER IN SUPPORT OF THE SPELL
ANY COMMERCIAL.
WHERE DO A LAST CALL FOR THOSE
WHO ARE IN SUPPORT?
AND SEEN AND WE DO HAVE A MOTION
ON THE FLOOR THE MOTION HAS BEEN
MADE BY SENATOR VALLEY NOW LIKE
AT A LOOK TO ANYONE WHO MAY BE
OPPOSE.
LOOKING FOR OPPOSITION AT THIS
TIME.
WE'RE GONNA DO A LAST CALL FOR
OPPOSITION.
CURRENCY NUMBER NOW WOULD LIKE
TO BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
THE TURN IT OVER THE VICE CHAIR.
THANK YOU MISTER.
WHAT ARE YOU ABOUT THE FACT THAT
WE HAVE A SAFE DRINKING WATER
CONCERNED I'M JUST CONCERNED
ABOUT THE PROCESS I WHAT WHY?
WHY ARE WE OVERLAPPING -- MAY BE
MOVING INTO THE TERRITORY OF
LAUGHTER.
YOU MIGHT I DON'T HAVE THE BUT
EVERY EVERY CREATING A TERRITORY --
FOR HERE OR ARE WE REMAIN BEING
CHARMING.
I I'M JUST CURIOUS.
NO SENATOR NOTICES JUST TO
INFORM THE LANDLORD TENANT.
AND IN THE DISTRICT
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY.
ABOUT THEIR WATER QUALITIES AND
PROVIDE A WAY. FOR THEM -- TO
PETITION FOR CONSOLIDATION OR
EXTENSION OF WATERS.
IT DOES NOT AFTER THE LAUGHTER
PROCESS THAN.
I DON'T THINK A NEW MALL TO
LAUGH CO PRODUCE.
BUT WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT
INCORPORATING.
IS THE USE OF LAND WERE JUST
TALKING TO VOTE PROVIDING.
WATER.
LARA CONSOLIDATE A SMALL WATER
SYSTEM IF THERE'S A OF OF A
LARGER WATER SYSTEM NEARBY THEY
CAN PROVIDE BETTER QUALITY OF
WATER WILL HAVE NOTHING TO DO
WITH SO THAT'S USUALLY JUST ALL
WHEN HE OF THE LAUGHTER -- SO
THAT'S THAT'S WHERE MY CONFUSION
IS MISTER CHURCH WHAT AM I
MISSING IT IS TO LOOK AT THE WAY
IT WILL WORK AND I'LL JUST I'LL
PARAPHRASE IT HERE IS THAT --
PREVIOUS LEGISLATION ALLOW THE
STATE WATER BOARD TO BE ABLE TO-CONSOLIDATE CONSOLIDATE SMALLER
DISTRICTS BECAUSE ALL THE
DISTRICTS THAT HAD CHALLENGES
WITH WATER QUALITY EXCEPT WE SAW.
I SEVERAL WATER DISTRICTS IN MY
COUNTY THAT AFTER THE FIRES.
HI THE ULTIMATE DECISION.
THE WATER BOARD HAS THE
AUTHORITY BUT LAST GOAL HAS TO
PROVE AT THE VERY END OF THE
PROCESS THERE IS SOME --
INVOLVEMENT AT THE END OF THE
PROCESS -- SO LAUGHTER WOULD
STILL TOUCH THAT -- AT THE END
OF THE PROCESS WITH THE
RECOMMENDATION FROM THE WATER
BOARD.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WOULD LIKE TO SEE IF WE HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
WE DO HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
BELL.
HEARING SEEING NO OTHER --
QUESTIONS COMMENTS RETURN OVER
THE SIMPLY NUMBER FOR ANY
CLOSING THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
ARRIVAL.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS APPROPRIATIONS YES I JUST
ROLL CALL PLEASE.
HI.
L. L. I. HERTZBERG RICARDO
[inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
WE THAT CURRENTLY IS A TWO ZERO
A VOTE WE'RE GONNA KEEP THAT
ROLE OPEN AND WILL ADD ON THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU TO OUR
WHEN IS THIS WORTH WHILE.
MEMBERS I WE'RE GONNA TAKE A
QUICK SIXTY SECONDS RECESS AND
WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK WITH YOU
.
WE WELCOME YOU BACK THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
EVAN I SOME QUICK CONVERSATION
AND DO APPRECIATE THIS IN THE
MEMBERS PATIENTS AS WELL WE
WALKING BACK TO SENDING
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE.
IT IS IN GENERAL BEFORE WE COULD
DO SOME NUMBER BONTA WE'D LIKE
TO BE ABLE TO ADD A COUPLE
MEMBERS ON TO OUR CONSENT
CALENDAR IT IS A VERY BUSY DAY --
ACROSS THE CAPITAL WITH
COMMITTEES.
THAT WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
CALL ABSENT MEMBERS ON THE
CONSENT COUNTER MESSING CHESTER.
FAIL HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I WIENER [inaudible]
HI [inaudible] SIX CURRENTLY HE
ENJOYS A SIX ZERO VOTE WE'RE
GONNA KEEP THAT ROLE OPEN.
DAYS IN GERMAN WE'RE NOT GONNA
BE MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER
TWELVE ITEM NUMBER TWELVE IS AB
EIGHT FORTY NINE WE APPRECIATE
ALL THE WORK THIS A MEMBER BONTA.
HAS PUT INTO THIS BILL.
ISN'T OVER THE FLOOR IS YOURS
IT'S ALWAYS GOOD TO SEE AN
COMMITTEE SIR USE WELL MISTER
CHAIR AND COLLEAGUES AND SAFF
GOOD TO SEE EVERYBODY THINKS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT AB.
EIGHT FORTY NINE THANK YOU
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THE BILL TO
WORK ON THE BILL APPRECIATED.
REDISTRICTING IS OF CRUCIAL
IMPORTANCE TO LOCAL DEMOCRACY
HOW CITY OR COUNTY ELECTION
DISTRICTS ARE DRAWN CAN HELP
DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT A
COMMUNITY WILL BE FAIRLY.
REPRESENTED BY THE MOST INTIMATE
AND PROXIMATE GOVERNMENT BODIES
UNLIKE STATE LEVEL REDISTRICTING
THERE ARE VERY FEW REQUIREMENTS
GOVERNING CITY.
AND COUNTY REDISTRICTING TO
ENSURE THE PROCESS IS FAIR AND
TRANSPARENT AND THAT THE PUBLIC
AND ESPECIALLY UNDER REPRESENTED
COMMUNITIES ARE ENGAGED IN THE
PROCESS AB.
EIGHT FORTY NINE WILL BRING
TRANSPARENCY AND CREATE CLEAR
STANDARDS FOR CITIES AND
COUNTIES BY EXPANDING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION. FOR NON ENGLISH
SPEAKING COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
OTHERWISE ALL TOO OFTEN
OVERLOOKED THIS BILL ENSURES
THAT RDISTRICTING MAPS.
ARE MADE AVAILABLE TO THE PUBLIC
BEFORE THEY CAN BE ADOPTED AND
ALONG WITH OTHER TRANSPARENCY
MEASURES SETS A MINIMUM OF FOUR
PUBLIC HEARINGS TO ALLOW FOR
PUBLIC PARTICIPATION.
I'M HAPPY TO REPORT THAT THE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES AND
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION
OF COUNTIES HAVE REMOVED THEIR
OPPOSITION WITH THE RECENT
AMENDMENTS.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
STAKEHOLDERS FOR THEIR
ENGAGEMENT AND DIALOGUE
REGARDING AB EIGHT FORTY NINE I
BELIEVE HE STRUCK THE RIGHT
BALANCE BETWEEN TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY.
I WITH THE CURRENT VERSION OF
THE BILL THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU SENATORS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
WITH ME HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT.
ARE NICHOLAS HARD OR LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATE FOR COMMON CAUSE
CALIFORNIA AND DOOR ROSE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR THE LEAGUE OF WOMEN
VOTERS CALIFORNIA.
YOU SO MUCH AND BEFORE WE GO TO
OUR WITNESSES I DO APOLOGIZE BUT
WE ACTUALLY HAVE ANOTHER BONTA
DEAL THAT WE HAVE TO GET OVER TO
HEALTH -- A AND IT IS ON CONSENT
IN HEALTH IS PAYING IN US -- AND
WE NEED TO GET ONE ADDITIONAL
MEMBER ON SO -- IF IT WORKS YOU
MISTER CINNAMON WE'D LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO CALL -- ABSENT MEMBERS
AND CAN SING COUNTER PLEASE
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MISS INTERESTED BELL.
THERE ARE.
IT IS A SEVEN ZERO WE'RE GOING
TO GET THAT BILL OVER TO HEALTH.
HERE A. S. A. P. THANK YOU SO
MUCH THAT I CONSIDER HOW UNDER
IS OUT AND WE'RE CLOSED ON THE
ROLE ON THE CONSENT COUNTER WITH
A SEVEN ZERO VOTE.
WHO'D LIKE TO BE A KICK **** OFF --
THANK YOU SO MUCH NICOLAS WE'RE
GOING TO TURN IT OVER TO YOU YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES SIR.
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS NICHOLS
HAD ON REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA
COMMON CAUSE WE'RE PROUD CO
SPONSOR AB EIGHT FOUR NINE WHICH
PROVIDES A CRUCIAL SAFETY NET.
AGAINST GERRYMANDERING AND CITY
AND COUNTY REDISTRICTING FERRY
DISSING IS ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL
AT ALL LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT
INJURY REPRESENTATIVE AND
INCLUSIVE DEMOCRACY.
MANY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO A GOOD
JOB OF REDUCING UNFORTUNATELY WE
SOMETIMES SEE LOCAL REDUCING
PROCESS ABUSED THE WAY THAT
UNDERMINE REPRESENTATIVE
GOVERNMENT MOST SIGNIFICANTLY BY
CRACKING VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES
BE A RULE COMMUNITIES WORKING
CLASS COMMUNITIES.
OR MINORITY COMMUNITIES IN A WAY
THAT DILUTES THE POWER OF THEIR
VOTE -- AND UNDERMINES LOCAL
POLITICAL KIND BUILDING.
THIS ISN'T SIGNIFICANT PART
BECAUSE UNLIKE LISTING
CONGRESSIONAL REDUCING THEIR
ALMOST NO MANDATORY STANDARDS TO
GUIDE LOCAL REDUCING TO PREVENT
SUCH ABUSE.
AND TO ENSURE DIVERSE
PARTICIPATION THE PROCESS OF FOR
EXAMPLE UNLIKE PRISTINE
CONGRESSIONAL REDUCING THERE'S
NO REQUIREMENT FOR LOCRI
DESTROYING.
THE COMMUNITIES NEIGHBORHOODS BE
KEPT HOLD -- AND WHERE IS THE
STATE COMMISSION MUST ENGAGE IN
EXTENSIVE -- HEARING PROCESS
STATE LAW REQUIRES LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS HOLD JUST ONE PUBLIC
HEARING.
DARTING MAPS AND HAS NO PUBLIC I
REACH REQUIREMENTS AS A RESULT
MANY COMMUNITIES AND SOCIALLY
NON ENGLISH SPEAKING COMMUNITIES
FILL TO PARTICIPATE LOW REDUCING
PROCESS.
MAY NOT EVEN BE AWARE THAT ITS
CURRENT THESE ARE OFTEN I MIGHT
AT THE SAME CONSTITUENCIES THAT
ARE OFTEN STARKLY AND
REPRESENTED AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
AB FOUR NINE JUST PROVIDES
POLICY GARTNER GIRLS TO SELF
WORSE THESE PIECES AND DOS
MENTOR RAIN CRITERIA MODELED OFF
OF THE STATE'S STANDARDS WHICH
PRIORITIZE KEEPING NEIGHBORHOODS
AND COMMUNITIES INTACT.
AND PERMITS PARTISAN
GERRYMANDERING. NINE ALSO
REQUIRES MORE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
PUBLIC PARTICIPATION IN THE
PROCESS -- IS SO DIVERSE
CONSTITUENCIES ESPECIALLY NON
ENGLISH SPEAKING ONES CAN HAVE A
VOICE IN THE REDUCING PROCESS.
TOGETHER WE THINK THESE CHANGES
A PROPOSED MAYBE IT FOUR NINE
WILL CONTRIBUTE TO MORE
REPRESENTATIVE INCLUSIVE AND
KIND OF A LOCAL MARK SEE.
I JUST WANT TO ECHO THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MENTIONED WITH THE RECENT
STREAMLINING AMENDMENTS.
LOCAL GOVERNMENT ASSOCIATIONS
INCLUDING C. SECONDLY HAVE
REMOVED THEIR OPPOSITION THE
BONE GONE TO NEUTRAL I JUST WANT
EXPRESS MY STRONG GRATITUDE. TO
THOSE SENSATIONS WORKING VERY
CLEVER DEFINITELY WITH US TO GET
TO THIS POINT. FOR ALL THESE
REASONS ON BEHALF OF A BROAD
COALITION OF CIVIL RIGHTS AND TO
GOVERN ORGANIZATIONS WE SPOKE
EARLIER TONIGHT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH WE'RE NOT
RICHARD OR MISS ROSE FROM LEGAL
IN VOTERS TO MORNING CHAIR
REQUIRE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY.
SO THE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE A
REALLY WAS ONE OF THE LEADERS IN
THE FIGHT FOR STATE LEVEL
INDEPENDENT REDISTRICTING AND
THEN ALL OF THE CRITERIA THAT
INCLUDES.
OUR LOCAL LEAGUES WORK TO ENSURE
THAT LOCAL REDISTRICTING IS
TRANSPARENT THAT PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION IS ROBUST THAT IT
IS MEANINGFUL AND THAT EVERY
COMMUNITY IS ENGAGE SO THAT THAT
LINE DRAWING REALLY RESULT IN.
A FAIR REPRESENTATION OF THE
AREA'S DIVERSITY.
BUT IT IS A SPECIFIC IAN
STRUGGLE WHEN DISTRICT MAPS --
DRAFTED INTRODUCED AND ADOPTED
ALL AT ONCE WITHOUT FIRST BEING
PUBLISHED AND SHARED WITH THE
PUBLIC OR WHEN THERE'S NO HARD
STANDARD REQUIRING THAT CITIES
AND COUNTIES RE DISTRICT WITH A
FOCUS ON KEEPING THOSE
COMMUNITIES INTACT.
WE ARE A MAJORITY MINORITY STATE
BUT WE'RE NOT SEEING THAT
DIVERSITY REPRESENTED IN LOCAL
GOVERNMENT.
SO WE NEED INSTITUTIONALIZE
PUBLIC OUTREACH TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT LINE DRAWING IS AN
INCLUSIVE EXERCISE WE NEED IT TO
BE ACCESSIBLE TO PEOPLE WHOSE
FIRST LANGUAGE ISN'T ENGLISH
WHICH THIS BILL PROVIDES.
THE WORK THAT WE DID AT THE
STATE LEVEL PROVIDES A REAL
CLEAR NATIONAL STANDARD OF%
EXCELLENCE AND NOW IT'S TIME TO
FIX REDISTRICTING AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL.
IN CITIES AND COUNTIES BY
REQUIRING TRANSPARENCY BY LAYING
OUT FAIR CONSISTENT CRITERIA FOR
THEM TO USE.
WE HOPE THAT YOU ARE GOING TO
JOIN US IN SUPPORTING AB EIGHT
FORTY NINE AND BRING CALIFORNIA
ONE STEP CLOSER TO THAT
REPRESENTATIVE DEMOCRACY THAT WE
ARE ALL LOOKING.
FOR THANK YOU AND THINK THESE
CITIES AND COUNTIES --
ORGANIZATIONS FOR WORKING WITH
US SO HARD TO MAKE THIS BILL
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN ALL GET
BEHIND.
THANKS MEASURES ROSE THIS IS
IMPORTANT BILL DO APPRECIATE IT
WE'RE GONNA TURN IT OVER TO
THOSE WHO MAY BE IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL WE'RE GOING TO ASK YOU
TO PLEASE COME FORWARD FIRST
CLASS ORGANIZATION.
LOOKING FOR SUPPORT.
A GOOD MORNING MORNING SEMOLINA
ME FROM LEVEL TO AND SUPPORT.
PLEASE A CHAIR WITH ASIAN
AMERICANS ADVANCING JUSTICE
CALIFORNIA PROUD CO SPONSOR IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
MELISSA ROMERO AT THE CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE OF CONSERVATION VOTERS IN
SUPPORT.
MANAGE WORK IN THE OFFICE OF
CALIFORNIANS TRANSPORT.
MORNING.
MADISON RYAN BEHALF THE SILICON
VALLEY COMMUNITY FOUNDATION IN
SUPPORT [inaudible] ONE SIR.
OUR CURRENT LINE CALIFORNIA
MONEY CAMPAIGN IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU ONE OF THEM.
MORNING PAGES EASILY ON BEHALF
OF THE MEXICAN AMERICAN LEGAL
DEFENSE FUND AND SUPPORT.
MORNING.
MORNING ADDRESS HER A RESIDENT
OF THE CITY OF STOCKTON IN
SUPPORT.
MUCH.
THANK YOU TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL.
ALL RIGHT NOW WE'RE LOOKING FOR
THOSE WHO MAY BE IN BETWEEN OR
OPPOSE WE'RE GONNA DO WE HAVE UP
TO TWO WITNESSES WHO MAY BE
SPEAKING IN AND IN OPPOSITION
SIR WOULD YOU LIKE TO GO TO KICK
US OFF EVEN GIVES A FLOWER SO
LAST YEAR.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS DâN
HUTCHINGS THAT REPRESENTING TO
LEAVE CALIFORNIA CITIES AS NOTED
BY THE AUTHOR IN THE SPONSORS WE
HAVE REMOVED PROPOSITION I JUST
WANTED.
TO MAKE A QUICK STATEMENT TO TO
THANK BOTH THE AUTHOR AND THE
SPONSORS WE HAVE WORKED REALLY
ALL YEAR HAD MET SEVERAL TIMES
WITH THE WITH THE MEMBER
DIRECTLY WITH HIS STAFF.
AND INCLUDING THE SPONSORS WE
FEEL WE STRUCK THE RIGHT BALANCE
SPECIFICALLY THE AMENDMENT -- TO
ADDRESS AND COST CONCERNS --
SHIFTING SOME OF THE OF THE ONUS
ON TO THE SECRETARY STATE TO
HELP GUIDE CITIES HAVING A ONE
STOP SHOP WE CAN GRAB THAT THE
INFORMATION NEEDED TO BE ABLE TO
GET PROVIDE THAT OUT REACH --
THINK IT'S A A STRONG BALANCE
AND I I'M HAPPY TO REMOVE
OPPOSITION THANK YOU CAN
DAUGHTERS SPONSORS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANKS FOR ALL
THE WORK THAT HAS GONE INTO SIR
IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU WORKING
TURN OVER TO THE GOOD FOLKS HE'S
ACT.
ACTUALLY JEAN HEARST ARE
REPRESENTING THE EARLY TWENTIES
OF CALIFORNIAN RC RC TODAY AGAIN
I REMOVING OUR OPPOSITION WE
HAVE A NEUTRAL POSITION
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR AND THE
SPONSORS FOR WORKING SO HARD.
WE AGREE THIS IS A A GOOD
BALANCE AND SHOULD RESULT IN A
BETTER PRODUCT FOR ALL INVOLVED.
THANK YOU SO MUCH INTO ADDED A
NEW CLIENT TO MISS HER SAID
JENDA SO DO APOLOGIZE.
I THINK SO MUCH TO FORCE OUR
CLIENT.
TO JEFF NEAL WITH C. SACK ALSO --
DITTO WHAT THEY SAID THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ONE ALEX
GIVES YOUR BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
HALF MOON BAY I AM CURRENTLY IN
OPPOSITION TO THINKING THE
AUTHOR FOR TAKING THOSE
AMENDMENTS AND REALLY APPRECIATE
THE AUTHORED A STAFFER WORKING
WITH US AND LOOKING FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THEM.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANKS FOR
HANGING WITH US TODAY MISTER
JONES MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
DIVISION ABOUT THE CITY PASADENA
WE WILL REVIEW THE CHANGE THE
BILL AND SEE IF WE CAN REMOVE
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU
SO MUCH.
WOULD LIKE TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION IF YOU
COULD PLEASE COME FORWARD THIS
TIME LOOKING PROPOSITION.
WE'RE GONNA LAST CALL.
ALL RIGHT IT'S BRING HIM BACK TO
COMMITTEE.
I DO WAY TO SEE IF WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS MISTER
VICE CHAIR [inaudible]
I COULD YOU DEFINE REMOVING
OPPOSITION VERSES BEING
SUPPORTIVE [inaudible]
WELL OF THANK YOU IT'S ANYONE'S
POSITION SO LIGHT LUCK THERE
THERE ARE STILL -- SOME ISSUES
WITH THE BILL -- WITH REGARDS TO
UNFUNDED MANDATES -- AND SOME
ADDITIONAL RESPONSIBILITIES
PLACED UPON THE GOVERNMENT --
THAT BEING SAID WHEN WE LOOK AT
THE TOTALITY OF THE AMENDMENTS
THAT WERE TAKEN ESPECIALLY WHEN
YOU STARTED OUT WITH A BILL
REQUIRING A TEN TEN PUBLIC
HEARINGS DIFFERENT LOCATIONS.
AND A LOT OF DIFFERENT -- HIGHLY
PRESCRIPTIVE MEASURES IN THE
BILL FROM ITS INTRODUCTION TO
WHERE WE ARE TODAY -- WE BELIEVE
THAT THAT AT THIS POINT -- WHILE --
THE ASSOCIATION CAN GO AS FAR
SUPPORTING THE MEASURE -- WE DO
BELIEVE THAT IT'S SOMETHING THAT
GIVEN THE THE GOOD FAITH A RATE
YOU KNOW WORK REPRESENTED BY THE
SPONSORS IN THE AUTHORED WORKING
TOGETHER TO TRY TO GET TO A
PLACE THAT WE COULD LIVE WITH IT --
IT'S IT'S GOT IS TO POSITION
REMOVED PROPOSITION.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER.
ME TO SHOW QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR
DO WE HAVE A MOTION FROM THE
COMMITTEE AT THIS TIME.
WITH THE MOTION THE MOTION ON
THE FLOOR BY MISTER BELL.
THAT COULD TURN OVER THE SUMMER
TO SEE IF YOU'D LIKE TO BEAT
OFFER SOME CLOSING COMMENTS.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT TODAY THINK THIS MAKES
PROGRESS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL FOR
REGISTRY REFORM I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE DIALOGUE THAT
WE'VE HAD WITH WHAT WERE ONCE
WHO WHO WERE ONCE OPPONENTS WHO
ARE WHO ARE NOW -- NOW ROOM WITH
THEIR OPPOSITION JUST APPRECIATE
THAT PROGRESS THAT WE MADE
TOGETHER AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
DRIVER.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SO MEMBER DO
ONE TAKE A MOMENT IS THAT SAY
THANK YOU TO ALL THOSE FOLKS OF
ENGAGING OVER THESE MANY MANY
MONTHS THOSE WHO WERE IN SUPPORT
THOSE WHO WERE PREVIOUSLY
PUBLISHED ANYWHERE NOW -- EITHER
NEUTRAL OR IN SUPPORT AS WELL
THIS HAS A MOTION TO PASS OUR
PREPARATIONS CENTER STRIPPING
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
HI WHY I'M MORE LONG.
L..
L. I. HERTZBERG TO OUR SECOND.
DOUBLE HEADER THE DAY WE'RE
GOING TO BE -- STARTING ON ITEM
NINETEEN ITEM NINETEEN WHICH IS
AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN IS A
MEMBER CHIU -- AND THEN WE'RE
GONNA TURN OVER TO ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY FIVE AB.
SEVENTEEN SIXTY THREE I WOULD
LIKE TO JUST OFFER SOME REAL
QUICK OPENING COMMENTS AND THEN
OF COURSE TURN IT OVER TO THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
ON AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN AS
YOU ALL KNOW -- AB FOURTEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN CREATES THE BAY
AREA HOUSING FINANCE AUTHORITY --
IT IS.
A BIG LIFT THAT THE SOME A
MEMBER HAS TAKEN ON IN
PARTNERSHIP.
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
ASSOCIATION OF BAY AREA
GOVERNMENTS IN THE METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION.
WE ARE WORKING TOGETHER WITH
DECENTLY MEMBER THE CHAIR OF
HOUSING.
THE CHAIR OF A BAG THE CHAIR OF
MTC IN THE CHAIR OF THE AD HOC
THAT HAS BEEN CREATED. TO BE TO
TAKE A BIT MORE TIME ON THIS
BILL -- BEFORE THIS DELIVER
STARTED LIKE TO JUST LAY OUT A
PROCESS TO THE COMMITTEE.
AND ALSO PASS OUT A LETTER --
THAT WE WILL ALSO PROVIDE A
RIGHT TO THE FRONT -- TO EACH OF
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
FRIDAY'S A LETTER AND THEN I'LL
TURN IT OVER THIS IN THE MEMBER
AGAIN -- THIS IN THE BURKE IS
FANTASTIC. TO WORK WITH THAT WE
WORK TOGETHER A LOT LAST YEAR
AND AT WE'RE HERE YET AGAIN WITH
HIS TWENTY FOUR BILLS THAT HAVE
BEEN IN FRONT OF THE COMMITTEE.
SO -- I'M BEING A BIT SARCASTIC
BUT WE REALLY DO LOVE WORKING
WITH A MEMBER TIãU.
BOTTOM LINE IS THIS TO ALLOW FOR
ADDITIONAL DIALOGUE TO ALLOW FOR
ADDITIONAL DIALOGUE BETWEEN M..
A BAG AND ALL THE MEMBERS.
WE'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO PASS A
BILL.
FOR THAT IS NOW A SHELL.
THAT BILL WOULD THEN GO ON TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
I THEN WOULD GO ON TO THE FLOOR.
THIS WOULD ALLOW THIS LARGE
GROUP OF M..
IN A BAG TO BE ABLE TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT THIS
INITIATIVE OVER THE SUMMER WORK
PERIOD.
THIS BILL WOULD THEN COME BACK
TO BOTH GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE.
AS WELL AS THE HOUSING COMMITTEE.
FOR HEARINGS -- IN.
THE MONTH OF AUGUST.
WE NEED TO BE A MOTION ON THE
FLOOR.
OF THE SENATE TO BE ABLE TO SEND
THE BILL BACK TO BOTH SENATE
HOUSING COMMITTEE AS WELL AS
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE.
WHAT THIS BILL REPRESENTS?
IS AN AGREEMENT.
AGAIN BY. TO NUMBER TWO THE
CHAIR OF HOUSING CENTER WINNER.
MYSELF.
IN THE THREE CHAIRS A BAG IN DC
AND THE AD HOC THAT WAS CREATED
BY BOTH OF THOSE ORGANIZATIONS.
I DO BE ABLE TAKE THIS
ADDITIONAL THIRTY TO FORTY DAYS
TO WORK WITH THE MEMBERSHIP TO
BE ABLE.
TO GET THIS -- ISSUE DONE RIGHT
NOT FAST.
I AND THAT IS WHY WE WANTED TO
BE ABLE TO PROVIDE.
THE COMMITTEE WITH THIS LETTER
TO SHOW THAT THERE.
IS AN AGREEMENT TO BE TO
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS ISSUE.
I'D ALSO LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
KNOWLEDGE IN THE AUDIENCE TODAY
AT A BAD COMMITTEE MEMBER MISS
ACT ECHLIN WHO -- IS FROM THE
NEVADA CITY COUNCIL WE'RE ALWAYS
GLAD WHEN I COUNCILMAN ECHLIN IS
HERE AND WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL.
WOULD LIKE TO BETTER TURN IT
OVER ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO ADD TO
MAKE SURE THAT YOU BELIEVE THAT
I IT LAID OUT THE PROCESS -- IN
IN A PLEASED TO CHAIR OF HOUSING
CENTER WIENER.
PLEASE WOULD YOU LIKE TO SAY A
FEW WORDS THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN I I JUST WANNA.
I SAID I'M I'M VERY VERY
SUPPORTER OF HIS BILL CO AUTHOR
SO ON DECEMBER SUPPORTIVE.
AND THIS -- THIS LEGISLATION TO
ENABLE -- THE BAY AREA TO GO TO
THE VOTERS TO GENERATE REVENUE.
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING -- IS
REALLY ONE OF THE LYNCH PINS OF
OUR REGIONAL AT FOR TO ADDRESS A
HOUSING CRISIS -- IS PUSHING OUR
REGION OFF THE CLASS THAT IS
LEADING TO MASS EVICTIONS TWO
YOUNG FAMILIES BEING PUSHED OUT
OF THE REGION ENTIRELY. TO THE
MORAL -- FAILURE THAT IS DESPITE
IN HOMELESSNESS OF PEOPLE LIVING
IN THEIR CARS -- AND IT'S
HAPPENING THROUGHOUT THE REGION --
AND THIS.
HI THIS MEASURE IS ONE OF THE
LUNCH TENS OF TAKING THIS CRISIS
AS SERIOUSLY AS IT NEEDS TO BE
TAKEN -- SO I KNOW I AM DEEPLY
COMMITTED TO MAKING SURE THAT
OVER THE NEXT MONTH.
HI THIS CUTS RE CRAFTED INTO --
SOMETHING THAT'S GOING TO BE A
STRONG MEASURE FOR THE BAY AREA --
BY -- COMMITTEE THE COMMITTEE
THAT I CHAIR IN MY STAFF'S --
AND I DIRECTLY WILL BE VERY
INVOLVED -- AND I'M A THERE'S
BEEN.
SOME I REALLY.
SOME OF THE DIALOGUE THAT I'VE
HEARD IN THE REGION AROUND US --
TO SOMEBODY ALARMIST RHETORIC
AROUND THIS BILL IS NO DIFFERENT
THAN WHAT WE'VE DONE WITH
TRANSPORTATION.
OR OTHER MEASURES WERE OUR
REGION COMES TOGETHER -- AND
SAYS WE ARE GOING TO IN THE APPS
AND THE FAILURE OF LEADERSHIP
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND
NOT ENOUGH IN THE STATE.
AND THE BAY AREA WE ARE GOING TO
FIND OUR NEEDS THAT'S WHAT THIS
IS ABOUT NO DIFFERENT THAN WHAT
WE'VE DONE.
WITH REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION
MEASURES I JUST WANTED CITY
ALARMIST RHETORIC WE'VE HEARD IN
SOME CORNERS OF THE BAY AREA.
AROUND THIS BILL IS JUST IS
BAFFLING TO ME AND I THINK IT'S
COMPLETELY COUNTERPRODUCTIVE
WE'RE GOING TO GET THIS DONE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AT TO THE
SENATOR WE LOOK FORWARD TO THE
PARTNERSHIP AGAIN JUST WANT TO
REITERATE THIS.
KIMBERLY HITS THE PAUSE BUTTON
THAT WILL ALLOW FOR ADDITIONAL
TIME IN FEEDBACK WITHIN IN DC IN
A BAG MEMBERSHIP.
WHAT TO ENSURE THE PROPOSAL HAS
AN OPPORTUNITY TO BE EXTENSIVELY
THAT IT -- AND WE'VE ALSO BEEN
ABLE TO SIT DOWN WITH AS SOME OF
THE SUPPORTERS EARLIER THIS WEEK
ALSO TO BE ABLE TO HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO BEING ABLE.
TO GET THIS BACK IN FRONT OF THE
COMMITTEE.
THAT AUGUSTFOURTEENTH DATE.
WITH THAT WE TURN IT OVER TO
SOME NUMBER TWO AND AGAIN WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU FOR ALL OF YOUR
WORK ON THIS ISSUE AND FORCES
STEVE AS WELL.
FOR HIS WORK AT BEHIND THE
SCENES AND GETTING THIS THING
CRAFTED HE'S LIVING THE DREAM SO
WE'RE GONNA TURN IT OVER TO THE
GOOD ASSEMBLY MAY.
FIRST OF ALL LET ME JUST START
BY THANKING YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN -
ALL OF US AS LEGISLATORS WORKED
VERY HARD BUT YOU HAVE TRULY
GONE ABOVE AND BEYOND BOTH WITH
THIS BILL AND OTHERS AND AND
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE.
YOUR WORK YOUR STAFFS WORK --
YOUR ENGAGEMENT WITH US ON THIS
AND IN THE YOUR CREATIVE
THINKING OF HOW WE TRY TO PASS
FORD -- THAT ENSURES THAT WE ARE
BUILDING THE DEEP CONSENSUS THAT
WE WANT TO SEE AROUND THIS BILL
IN THE BACK.
AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN IS A
REGIONAL BEAR A BILL TO ADDRESS
THE HOUSING CRISIS IN OUR REGION
UNFORTUNATELY OUR REGION HAS
BEEN THE EPICENTER OF THE
STATE'S HOUSING CRISIS WITH
RECORD HOME PRICES.
THE RECORD RENTS RECORD EVICTION
LEVELS AND RECORD LEVELS OF
HOMELESSNESS.
TAKE REALLY AFTER MANY SAW
HOUSING STAFF AND FUNDING GOT IT
AFTER THE DISSOLUTION OF
REDEVELOPMENT IT'S ESTIMATED AT
THIS POINT.
OUR REGION HAS A TWO AND A HALF
BILLION DOLLARS YEARLY.
NEED FOR FUNDING AROUND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
THE INTENT OF THIS BILLS TO
ENABLE THE BAY AREA TO HELP
OURSELVES TO GIVE THE NINE
COUNTY REGION THE AUTHORITY TO
RAISE FUNDING FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
SIMILAR TO HOW THE REGION HAS
RECEIVED LEGISLATIVE AUTHORITY
TO RAISE FUNDS FOR
TRANSPORTATION.
THANKS TO CENTRE BELL AND OTHERS
AS WELL AS RESTORATION OF THE
SAN FRANCISCO BAY.
MY INTENT IS THE AUTHOR OF THIS
BILLS ALSO TO GIVE THE REGION A
SIGNIFICANT VOICE AND HOW THEY
WANT THIS BILL TO WORK IN TERMS
OF GOVERNANCE.
REVENUE GENERATION AND THE
EXPENDITURE OF FUNDS WE'VE BEEN
WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH OUR TO
BAY AREA REGIONAL BODIES THE
METROPOLITAN TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION AND THE ASSOCIATION
OF BAY AREA GOVERNMENTS.
IN THE PAST MONTH THE MTC IN A
BAG TO PUT TOGETHER AN AD HOC
COMMITTEE SPECIFICALLY TO GIVE
US A MORE DETAILED PROPOSAL ON
WHAT THEY WOULD LIKE TO SEE IN
THIS BILL.
THE BILL THAT YOU HAVE AND PRINT
REFLECTS THEIR INPUT THUS FAR.
BUT THAT BEING SAID I'M IN FULL
AGREEMENT WITH THE CHAIRMAN OF
THIS COMMITTEE THAT THE BEST
PATH FORWARD IS TO GIVE THE FULL
REGIONAL BODIES.
THE OPPORTUNITY TO CONSIDER AND
HOPEFULLY VOTE ON THEIR OWN AD
HOC COMMITTEES RECOMMENDATIONS
THOSE VOTES ARE SCHEDULED TO
OCCUR IN THE COMING WEEKS.
AND GIVEN THAT I'M HAPPY TO
ACCEPT THE MEMBERS PROPOSED
TODAY THAT WOULD REMOVE MOST OF
THE BILL'S DETAILS WITH THE HOPE
THAT WE WILL BE BACK HERE IN A
MONTH WITH THE SUPPORT.
OF THE MEMBERS OF THOSE REGIONAL
BODIES TO DISCUSS FURTHER
DETAILS OF THE BILL.
THAT BEING SAID I WANT TO TURN
IT OVER TO OUR WITNESSES I WANNA
THANK YOU TO ROUTE FROM
ENTERPRISE COMMUNITY PARTNERS.
AND I WANT -- TO FIRST RECOGNIZE
THE MAYOR OF BERKLEY JESSE ARE
GOING.
GRATEFUL THAT YOU'RE HERE TODAY
SIR THANK YOU SO MUCH THE FLOOR
IS YOURS YOUR TWO MINUTES THANKS
RE ADVOCACY ON THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH GOOD MORNING
CHAIR MCGUIRE MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE I WANT TO THANK THE
CHAIR.
HIS WILLINGNESS TO ENGAGE IN A
DIALOGUE WITH THE BILL AUTHORED
WOULD STAY COLD STAKEHOLDERS
OVER THE DETAILS OF THE BILL.
AND TO HELP MOVE THIS BILL FOR A
WHILE WE WORK AN ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS IN THE COMING WEEKS I'M
JUST SITTING IN THE MAYOR OF THE
CITY OF BERKLEY.
THE CITY OF BERKLEY SUPPORTS
ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN EIGHTY
SEVEN AND I WANT TO THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU FOR ALL OF
US LEADERSHIP ON THIS BILL.
MY CITY OF TWELVE ABOUT A
HUNDRED AND TWELVE THOUSAND
RESIDENTS.
IS FACING A GROWING HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY AND DISPLACEMENT
CRISIS MEDIUM AND SMALL SIZED
CITIES IN THE BAY AREA ARE
FEELING THE EFFECTS OF THE STATE
WHAT HOUSING CRISIS.
AND DESPERATELY NEED ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES TO PRESERVE ADDITION
TO PRESERVE EXISTING HOUSING
PROTECT HANDS FROM DISPLACEMENT
AND BUILD NEW AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
THAT'S WHY ASSEMBLY BILL
FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN IS SO
IMPORTANT IT PROVIDES AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CREATE A REGIONAL
SOLUTION TO A HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY CRISIS AND PROVIDE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THE NEEDED
FINANCING TO CREATE.
AND PRESERVE AFFORDABLE HOMES
I'M ALSO THE VICE PRESIDENT OF
THE ASSOCIATION OF THEIR
GOVERNMENTS A REGIONAL COUNCIL
OF GOVERNMENTS REPRESENT THE
CITIES AND COUNTIES THROUGHOUT
THE BAY AREA.
HOWEVER I WANT TO CLARIFY NOT
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION EVENTS THAT.
BOTH THE A BANK EXECUTIVE BOARD
NMTC COMMISSION HAVE ENGAGE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS OVER
THE PAST SIX MONTHS IN
DISCUSSIONS ON LEGISLATION TO
ADDRESS OUR HOUSING CRISIS.
WHAT WE'VE HEARD IS A ESIRE TO
NOT CREATE A NEW BUREAUCRACY?
AND HAVE ROBUST LOCAL GOVERNMENT
INPUT AND HOW FUNDS DERIVED FROM
AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN WOULD
BE ALLOCATED.
BOTH THE EIGHT A BACKBOARD AN
ANTI SEE CREATED IN AND OUT
COMMITTEE AS REFERENCE BY.
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO DEVELOP A
SET OF AMENDMENTS THAT REFLECTS
THE INPUT WE HAVE RECEIVED FROM
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THROUGHOUT THE
BAY AREA.
AND THE COMMITTEE INCLUDING
REPRESENTATION FROM CITIES AND
COUNTIES BIG AND SMALL
THROUGHOUT THE BAY AREA.
WE MET EXTENSIVELY OVER THE PAST
MONTHS I SERVE ON THAT AT ALL
COMMITTEE.
WE ROLLED UP OUR SLEEVES AND DUG
INTO THE DETAILS OF THE BILL AND
I'M PLEASED TO SAY THAT WE'VE
REACHED AGREEMENT.
AND MANY KEY POINTS ALL
REFLECTED IN THE CURRENT VERSION
THE BILL WHICH I DO BELIEVE
REFLECT MANY OF THE CONCERNS
THAT WE'VE HEARD.
FROM GOVERNMENTS OF ALL SIZES IN
THE BAY AREA.
WE APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT OF OUR
OF THE AUTHOR IN THE COMMITTEE
CHAIR TO GET ADDITIONAL TIME TO
WORK WITH A BAG NBC.
DURING THE LEGISLATIVE RECESS WE
CAN BRING BACK UP HILL THAT
ACTUALLY WILL HELP MOVE OUR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING CRISIS FORD.
AND PROVIDE THE RESOURCES
DESPERATELY NEED FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WITH THAT I'D BE
HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR EITHER.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AS TO MAYOR
WE'RE GONNA BE HEADING THERE IN
CASE WE HAVE QUESTIONS AS WE
MOVE FORWARD WELCOME GOOD TO SEE
YOU AGAIN.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES.
HI I'M GIVE THE ROW AND I'M WITH
ENTERPRISE CAN BE PARTNERS AND
WE ARE DELIGHTED TO BE CO
SPONSORING THIS BILL.
OUR MISSION IS TO CREATE
OPPORTUNITY FOR LOW INCOME
FAMILIES THROUGH AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND LAST YEAR I CO
AUTHORED THIS REPORT IT'S CALLED
THE ELEPHANT IN THE REGION
CHARTING THE PATH FOR BAY AREA
MEASURE TO LEAD A BOLD HOUSING
AGENDA.
AND IN THIS REPORT WE LOOKED AT
HOW OTHER REGIONS IN THE ACT AND
THE COUNTRY OR ADDRESSING THEIR
AFFORDABILITY CRISIS.
AND FOR REGIONS THAT ARE DOING
IT WELL.
THERE'S TWO KEY FINDINGS ONE IS
THAT THERE'S THE INFRASTRUCTURE
AND IT'S BUILT ON ASSIST
SUFFICIENT FUNDING AND THE
CAPACITY TO ADMINISTER EFFECTIVE
PROGRAMS.
AND SO WE'RE INVESTED IN THIS
BILL BECAUSE IT IS ACTUALLY THE
FIRST STEP TO BUILDING THE
HOUSING INFRASTRUCTURE -- TO
RIGHT NOW WE RELY ON LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO SOLVE THE
ENTIRE REGIONS HOUSING CRISIS.
AND AS WE'VE HEARD SO MANY OF
OUR LOCAL JURISDICTIONS ARE --
THE BEEN LEFT ESSENTIALLY ANY
MAKE AFTER THE DISSOLUTION OF
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES THEY
DON'T HAVE FUNDING THE STAFFING
NOR DO THEY REALLY HAVE THE
EXPERTISE.
AND SO THIS IS A BILL THIS IS A
BILL THAT WILL HELP THESE
JURISDICTIONS IT'S ALL CARROTS.
AND SO WE'VE BEEN ENGAGING
SEVERAL CITIES IN THE BAY AREA
AND THEY'VE ACTUALLY CAME UP
WITH THESE EXAMPLES OF HOW A
REGIONAL APPROACH CAN HELP THEM.
THE NEXT JUST NATURAL DISASTER
HITS REGIONAL RESOURCES CAN
SWIFTLY BUILD REBUILD HOMES AND
COMMUNITIES.
CAN PROVIDE THE CRITICAL GAP
FUNDING NEEDED FOR TEO DE
DEVELOPMENTS AND SERVICE AND
RICH HOUSING FOR THE HOMELESS.
AND IT CAN -- PROVIDE HOUSING
EXPERTISE TO CREATE EFFECTIVE
RENTAL ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS FOR
THOSE FAMILIES THAT ARE
THREATENED BY DISPLACEMENT.
AND SO IT'S JUST SIMPLY A SET OF
TOOLS IT'S A WAY FOR BEAR Và
BAY AREA VOTERS. TO RAISE FUNDS
AND TO ADDRESS THE WORST HOUSING
CRISIS IN THE COUNTRY.
SO THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY WE ARE TREATING
PHONE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY AGAIN MISMATCH THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE WE APPRECIATE
BOTH YOUR WORK WORKING TURN OVER
THOSE WHO ARE IN SUPPORT.
PLEASE COMPORT FIRST CLASS
ORGANIZATION I CAN MORNING
RESEARCHER CAROLING ABOVE OF
MARYLAND AND BRING THE CITY SOME
SYSTEMS PART GIVING.
THE MORNING MASSIVE OIL BE HAVE
A SILICON VALLEY COMMUNITY
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT WELCOME
BACK.
HOW DAVID ON THE HAVE THE BAY
AREA HOUSING ADVOCACY COALITION
IN SUPPORT?
THANK YOU MORNING.
AND EVANS ON BEHALF OF THE
NONPROFIT HOUSING ASSOCIATION OF
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA SILICON
VALLEY AT HOME.
AS WELL AS HABITAT FOR HUMANITY
OF THE EAST BAY SILICON VALLEY
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH
GOOD MORNING.
HI FOR MANY OF OF CALIFORNIAN B.
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THE MORNING IS AN ANTI I AM
REPRESENTING WORKING
PARTNERSHIPS USA IN ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND ORGANIZED PEOPLE AND
SANTA CLARA COUNTY IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
THE MORNING MORNING UNDER SOME
METERS ON BEHALF OF THE MAYOR OF
OAKLAND AND SUPPORT HE MORNING.
THE MINUS THE SENATE FOR THE BAY
AREA COUNCIL AND AS A BUSINESS
ORGANIZATION WE ARE SUPPORT IF
AND MANY BECAUSE OF THE
COMMERCIAL LEAKAGE FEES ASKED
THAT WERE REMOVED -- THEN WE
BEAM AND FULL SUPPORT OF THIS
IMPORTANT LEGISLATION -- AND I
HAVE LETTERS HERE FOR THOSE WHO
ARE ABLE TO RECEIVE BECAUSE WE
SUBMITTED OUR LETTER LATE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
I WOULD LIKE TO GET INTO A LAST
CALL A LAST CALL FOR THOSE WHO
ARE IN SUPPORT.
SEE NO ONE ELSE WOULD NOW LIKE
TO TURN OVER TO OPPOSITION.
I WILL START WITH A THE
COUNCILMAN AND THEN WE'LL GO TO
A MISTER WOLF.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- SENATOR
MCGUIRE AND THANK YOU OFFER
ALLOW ME AN OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
MY NAME IS PAT ACKLAND.
AND I SERVE ON THE NEVADA CITY
COUNCIL AND I'VE BEEN SERVING IN
THAT CAPACITY FOR OVER TWENTY
FOUR YEARS.
AND I'VE SERVED AS MAYOR SIX
YEARS BECAUSE WE ROTATE LIKE
MOST CITIES IN CALIFORNIA.
I ALSO SERVE ON THE A BAG
EXECUTIVE BOARD.
AND I ALSO AND PAST PRESIDENT OF
THE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES.
I'M SPEAKING TODAY -- ON MY OWN
BEHALF AND FOR ALL THOSE OTHER
ELECTED OFFICIALS IN CITIES THAT
ARE OPPOSED.
TO FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN AND LET
ME TELL YOU FUNDAMENTALLY WHY --
A AND I SUPPORT THIS EXTRA TIME
BUT I'M GONNA NEED YOUR HELP.
THIS LEGISLATION IS
FUNDAMENTALLY FLAWED IN MY
OPINION.
WE DO NOT NEED ANOTHER.
YET ANOTHER REGIONAL AGENCY --
THE BAG HAS THE AUTHORITY AND
HAS BEEN WORKING ON HOUSING. FOR
OVER. FIFTY YEARS SINCE IT WAS
FORMED IN.
NINETEEN SIXTY ONE MTC IS THE
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY WHAT
FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN DOES.
IS IT TAKES THE STORY OF HOUSING
AWAY FROM A BAG AND GIVES IT TO
MTC AND THAT IS WRONG.
A BAG IS THE COUNCIL OF
GOVERNMENTS FOR WE HAVE MEMBERS
HUNDRED AND ONE CITIES AND THE
NINE COUNTIES ARE ALL MEMBERS OF
A BAG THEY PAY DUES THE PAY
MEMBERSHIP.
AND THEY GET SERVICE BACK.
THERE IS WRONG THERE'S A YOUR
STAFF REPORT IS WRONG IN SEVERAL
PLACES AND I'M GOOD IF IN THIS
IS FOCUSING ON ADEQUATE
REPRESENTATION OF CITIES.
MTC STARTED KASA.
THEY STARTED CAST A DECEMBER
TWENTY SIXTEEN WITHOUT A BAGS
KNOWLEDGE. FOR INVOLVEMENT.
WHY DO I KNOW BECAUSE I WAS AT
THAT M. T. C. HEARING?
AND I WAS SHOCKED VERY
DISAPPOINTED.
THE TECHNICAL COMMITTEE AND THE
STEERING COMMITTEE MEMBERS WERE
ALL SELECTED BY MTC A BAG HAD NO.
THE WORDY OR INPUT ON WHO WAS
REPRESENTING -- FOLKS IN FACT ON
THE TECHNICAL COMMITTEE THERE'S
TWO STAFF MEMBERS SAN FRANCISCO.
AND OAKLAND NO SMALL CITIES.
ON THE STEERING COMMITTEE.
THERE WERE -- SMALL CITY ELECTED
OFFICIALS AND BIG ONES BUT
UNFORTUNATELY THEY DID NOT SPEAK
FOR CITIES.
CITIES WERE NOT INFORMED OF
CASTLE FOR OVER TWO YEARS.
THROUGH THIS WHOLE EFFORT CITIES
WERE NOT TOLD WHAT WAS GOING ON
SO CITIES HAVE NOT BEEN
ADEQUATELY REPRESENTED FROM THE
VERY BEGINNING AND I'M SO GLAD
TO HEAR.
THAT YOU'RE GONNA PUT A PAUSE ON
THIS BUT I WANTED TO CALL YOUR
ATTENTION TO THE SIGNATURE PAGE.
THE SIGNATURE PAGE ON THE SECOND
PAGE HAS.
NO CITY REPRESENTED SEPARATE
CITY REPRESENTATIVES.
THEY'RE ALL SUPERVISORS.
THAT HAVE SIGNED THIS LETTER.
I'M A BAG EXECUTIVE BOARD HAS
NOT BEEN INFORMED OF THIS GROUP
THAT HAS BEEN FORMED BETWEEN MTC
IN A BAG.
ON LOOKING AT FOURTEEN EIGHTY
SEVEN WE HAVE NOT BEEN INFORMED
I'M ON THE LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE.
MEETING ON FRIDAY WE HAVE NOT
EVEN BEEN TOLD THAT A SEPARATE
GROUP HAS BEEN FORMED.
LET ME GIVE YOU AN AND I DON'T
KNOW IF THERE'S ADEQUATE CITY
REPRESENTATION BECAUSE LET ME
GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE THEY JUST
FORMED.
A BAG JUST FORMED -- INSERTED
MTC THE COMMITTEE THAT'S GOING
TO LOOK AT THE GOVERNANCE.
THEY HAVE EIGHT SUPERVISORS.
THEY HAD THREE CITY
REPRESENTATIVES AND THEN NICK.
NECK USED TO BE ON PARTY WAS
ELECTED OFFICIAL HE IS NO LONGER
AN ELECTED OFFICIAL ANY SERVICE
ON MTC AS THE MAYOR'S
REPRESENTATIVE FROM SAN
FRANCISCO. THIRTY SECONDS WE
HAVE A HUNDRED WHEN CITIES IS
THREE CITY REPRESENTATIVES ON
THE GOVERNANCE COMMITTEE
ADEQUATE NO.
AND THEY ARE NOT PUTTING PEOPLE
WHO HAVE DIFFERENCES OF OPINION
ON THESE COMMITTEES.
AND SO I IMPLORE.
THIS COMMITTEE AND YOUR
LEADERSHIP.
PLEASE MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S
ADEQUATE CITY REPRESENTATION AND
THAT THERE ARE DIFFERENCES OF
OPINION ON THESE COMMITTEES.
ARE YOU'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
DIVIDE THE CITIES AND THE
COUNTIES.
IN OUR BAY AREA.
I HAVE A LOT MORE TO SAY ON
FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN BUT THAT.
HE AYE WE NED YOUR HELP.
THEY'RE NOT PUTTING PEOPLE WITH
DIFFERENCES OF OPINION ON THESE
COMMITTEES AND AS A CONSEQUENCE --
IT.
I HAVE BEEN IN GOVERNMENT ALMOST
ALL MY LIFE WORK FOR THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT FOR FORTY THREE YEARS
SEVEN MONTHS IN ELEVEN DAYS.
I WORKED FOR THIRTY FIVE YEARS
WITH THE EPA WHERE I HELP
IMPLEMENT FEDERAL AND STATE LAW.
I DID COMBINED THE I. S. C. I.
OURS SO I KNOW GOVERNMENT IN I
HAVE A PASSION FOR GOVERNMENT.
BUT WHAT IS HAPPENING RIGHT NOW
WITH A BAG NMTC.
IS IS NOT APPROPRIATE WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE DIFFERENCES OF OPINION
ARE ENGAGED IN THE DISCUSSION
AND THAT'S THAT'S WHAT'S
HAPPENING THANK YOU SO MUCH
COUNCIL AND WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL --
BEFORE WE TURNED OVER TO MISTER
WOLF QUICKLY SO.
WHAT?
ARE YOU SEE ANY NEED SAID MT
SEEING A BAG HAVE FORMED THIS
JOINT AD HOC.
THAT JOINT AD HOC -- IS BEING
CHAIRED BY MISTER PER DROZ --
FROM THE COUNTY NAPA THE A BAG
REPRESENTATIVES ON THIS AD HOC
IS AT MAYOR AGAIN.
FROM THE CITY BERKELEY --
SUPERVISOR CHAVEZ FROM SANTA
CLARA.
I SUPERVISOR CONNELLY FROM MARIN --
JULIE PIERCE WHO IS FROM THE
CLAYTON CITY COUNCIL.
HI DAVID RABBIT CINEMA
SUPERVISOR IN A WORN SLOCUM.
WHO IS A SAN MATTEO SUPERVISOR
WE ALSO FROM MTC HAVE A
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE RING TO
CITY COUNCIL -- IS WELL.
ON THEIR ALONG WITH CHEN
SPEARING THE SLOT OF SUPERVISORS
I THINK THAT THAT THAT GIVES IT
THE PERFECT EXAMPLE WHAT THAT
THERE'S NOT ADEQUATE CITY
REPRESENTATION THERE'S A HUNDRED
AND ONE CITIES AND NINE COUNTIES.
AND THERE'S NO DIFFERENCES OF
OPINION ON THAT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH COUNCILMAN AND
I'M HAPPY TO SIT BACK DOWN OR
SIT DOWN WITH YOU IN I HAVE A
FURTHER CONVERSATION RETURN OVER
MISTER WOLF -- FOR OPPOSITION.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
I'LL BE BRIEF DAVID WILL FOR THE
HER JERVIS TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION
OPPOSED TAT.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN MEMBERS I
DO UNDERSTAND THE ISSUE HERE
VERY CAR I GREW UP IN MARIN
COUNTY AND I'M ACTUALLY A
GRADUATE OF CINEMA STATE
UNIVERSITY.
SO I DO I DO ABSOLUTELY
UNDERSTAND BAY AREA HOUSING AND
WHAT'S GOING ON HERE THERE IS
FUNDAMENTALLY A HOUSING CRISIS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA ONE
THIRD OF RENTERS SPEND HALF OF
THEIR TAKE HOME PAY.
ON RENT WE NEED A HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY THOUSAND UNITS OF THE
HOUSING YEAR TO KEEP PACE WITH
DEMAND LAST YEAR WE BUILT A
HUNDRED AND TEN OVER THE COURSE
OF HISTORY.
THERE HAVE ONLY BEEN FOUR YEARS
OUT OF THE LAST TWENTY WERE
REBUILT AT LEAST A HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY THOUSAND UNITS OF NEW
HOUSING WE ARE WELL WELL BEHIND
THE CURVE ON THIS.
BUT TO GET AHEAD OF THE CURVE.
BY AUTHORIZING NEW PERSONAL
TAXES WHEN ONLY 30% OF
CALIFORNIANS CAN AFFORD A MEDIAN
PRICED HOME.
MEMBERS IS NOT GOING TO GET IT
DONE NOW WE ARE OPPOSED TO THE
BILL IN PRINT AND OBVIOUSLY I
UNDERSTAND.
YOU KNOW WE'RE PUTTING THIS ON
HOLD FOR A BIT AND WE HAVE A LOT
OF THINGS GOVERNANCE ISSUES TO
WORK THROUGH I UNDERSTAND THAT
APPRECIATIVE OF THAT THANKFUL
FOR THAT I'M ANXIOUS TO SEE HOW
IT ALL WORKS OUT.
BUT AGAIN ONE THIRD OF ONLY ONE
THIRD OF CALIFORNIANS CAN FORTY
MEDIAN PRICE TIMER AGGRESSIVE
PERSONAL TAXES ARE NOT THE WAY
TO GET THAT DONE.
SO -- CERTAINLY ASK FOR A NO
VOTE ON THE BILL AS ITS IMPRINT
AND LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
TO WORK WITH EVERYONE.
YOU SO MUCH MISTER WOLF OF WE'RE
GONNA TURN IT OVER TO MISTER
JONES IN OPPOSITION YES MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBER DAVID JONES ON
BEHALF OF THE MARIN COUNTY --
CITY COUNCIL MEMBERS IN MERS
CAUCUS -- WE SHARE THE CONCERNS
OF THE COUNCIL WOMAN ON
GOVERNMENT SPECIFICALLY --
CREATING ANOTHER LAYER OF
GOVERNMENT IS PROBLEMATIC FOR US
LACK OF STABLE FUNDING FOR THE
EXISTING STAFF.
AT A BAG IN TO SEE TO DO THIS
TASK SO WE HAVE A CONCERNS ALSO
ABOUT CROWDING OUT OF OUR TAXES
IF WE HAVE ONE IN C. RAISING
TAXES IN AN AREA.
THE LOCAL AND HE MIGHT HAVE LESS
OPPORTUNITY TO RAISE TAXES IF
THEY SO WE NEEDED TO DO SO SO
FOR THOSE REASONS WE JOIN IN
OPPOSITION.
BUT WE ALSO APPLAUD THE PAUSE
BUTTON WE THINK THEY'RE THEY'RE
OBVIOUSLY NEEDS A LOT MORE TIME
FOR DIALOGUE.
HAVE MORE OF A CONSENSUS SO
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
JONES. FOR THE MORNING.
GOOD MORNING MICHAEL BARNES
MEMBER OF THE ALBANY CITY
COUNCIL SPEAKING FOR MYSELF.
YES THANK YOU FOR HITTING THE
PAUSE BUTTON I APPRECIATED I DO
WANT TO OBJECT TO WHAT IS
TRANSPIRED SO FAR.
AND THE NOTION THAT THE BAY AREA
IS THE EPICENTER OF THIS HOUSING
CRISIS THAT IS REALLY NOT TRUE
THE BAY AREA IN MANY WAYS
BECAUSE IT'S HIGH SALARIES IS
BETTER OFF.
THAN MANY OF THE OTHER COUNTIES
IN THE STATE LA COUNTY ORANGE
COUNTY WOULD BE BETTER EXAMPLES
OF PROBLEM OF STREET.
WITH THERE'S DEEP PROBLEMS.
SECONDLY A MTC IS.
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION I'VE
NEVER DONE HOUSING I AM BAFFLED
WHY IN T. C. WOULD WANT TO STEP
INTO A AN AREA IN WYOMING WOULD
WANT THEM TO STEP INTO AN AREA
FOR WHICH THEY HAVE NO EXPERTISE.
MEMBER OF A CITY COUNCIL A SMALL
CITY WE ARE WORKING CURRENTLY TO
DEVELOP AN AFFORDABLE HOUSING
UNIT IN OUR TOWN I DO RESENT THE
IMPLICATION THAT.
OUR STAFF IS NOT COMPETENT AND
WE ARE NOT ABLE TO WORK ON THESE
ISSUES.
WE HAVE A VERY COMPETENT STAFF
WE ARE MOVING AHEAD ON
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
FRANKLY I THINK IN DC IS GOING
TO BE AN IMPEDIMENT.
WE WOULD MUCH PREFER THAT THIS
GET FOCUSED AT THE STATE LEVEL.
WE HAVE POSITIVE WORKING
RELATIONSHIPS WITH EACH CD AND
WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE THE
EMPHASIS WITH H. CD.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BEING HERE TODAY WOULD LIKE TO
BE RECEIVED AS ANYONE ELSE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO BE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO COULD PLEASE COME
FOR THIS TIME.
IT'S BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
FOR ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS AGAIN I JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE THAT WE LAY THIS OUT.
CORRECTLY HE THE AD HOC WAS
SELECTED -- ON BEHALF OF BOTH IN
DC IN A BAG.
THEY'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO ME
TO BE ABLE TO FOCUS.
THEY WILL BE MAKING
RECOMMENDATIONS. TO EACH OF THE
TWO BOARDS BOTH A BAG AS WELL AS
IN DC.
IN THIS WILL ALLOW FOR
ADDITIONAL TIME TO BE ABLE TO
FLUSH OUT THE PROPOSAL HERE IN
THE COMING THIRTY TO FORTY DAYS.
AND MY UNDERSTANDING WE DO HAVE
THE MEMBERSHIP HERE.
THEY'VE BEEN VERY FOCUSED ON THE
REPRESENTING THE REGION'S AT THE
BAY AREA UNDERSTAND WHERE THAT
COUNCILMAN HUSSEIN IS.
THERE MAY BE A MORE SUPERVISORS
AND COUNCILMEMBERS BUT THE
REGIONS OF THE BAY AREA.
HAVE BEEN FOCUSED ON ON THIS
ISSUE AS WELL THE TURN IT OVER --
FOR ANY AT SOMEONE WOULD YOU
HAVE TO BE A COMMON JUST WANNA
MAKE IT A COUPLE BECOME IS FIRST
OF ALL TO THE COUNCIL AND I KNOW
YOU CONTACT OUR OFFICE JUST THE
OTHER DAY AND WE HAVE BEEN IN
TOUCH OVER EMAIL BUT I AM MORE
THAN HAPPY TO SIT.
DOWN WITH YOU TO DISCUSS THIS
FURTHER.
THERE ARE FEW THINGS THAT YOU
SAID I JUST WANT TO START THE
CONVERSATION.
FIRST OF ALL -- THIS IS NOT A
CASA BILL CASA DOESN'T EXIST
ANYMORE THIS IS A BILL BECAUSE
MANY WAS.
EVE THAT IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
THERE BE REGIONAL RESPONSE TO
THE CRISIS AND AND SO I WANT TO
SAY THAT.
THEY ARE ALSO BETTER AS YOU CAN
IAGINE A LOT OF CONVERSATIONS
WITH A BAG AND THE M. T. C. AT
THIS POINT AS THE GERAN JUST
MENTION.
THERE'S A JOINT COMMITTEE BUT I
ALSO MENTION THAT THE INITIAL
SKETCH OF AMENDMENTS THAT WE ARE
CONTEMPLATING TO MOVE FORWARD
HOPEFULLY IN A MONTH CONTEMPLATE
A VERY SIGNIFICANT ROLE FOR THE
LEADERSHIP OF A BAG.
MOVING FORWARD AND AND I'M HAPPY
TO DEFER -- TO ARE BERKELEY
MAYOR ON THAT QUESTION BUT I
WANT TO MAKE THAT VERY CLEAR THE
THE ROLE. FOR A BAG AS FAR AS
DEVELOPING POTENTIAL PROPOSALS
AROUND EXPENDITURE AROUND THE
PROGRAMMING OF THAT FUND AROUND
EXPECTED HOW THE MONEY IS REYES
AND HOW THE MONEY IS SPENT.
VERY MUCH CONTEMPLATES A
SIGNIFICANT ROLE FOR A BAG SO I
I WANT TO SAY THAT -- AND THEN --
THERE WAS A SUGGESTION THAT
SOMEHOW WE ARE NOT ENGAGING WITH
THE VERY COMPETENT STAFF OF A
BAG.
COULD NOT DISAGREE WITH THAT
MORE IN FACT I HAD A MEETING
WITH A BAG STAFF A WEEK AGO ON
THIS VERY TOPIC.
I AM VERY MUCH RESPECT THE
LEADERSHIP OF OF A BACK -- TO TO
THE MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE
WHO ARE NOT FAMILIAR WITH THE
SPECIFIC GOVERNANCE OF A BAG IN
THE EMPTY EMPTY SAY I'LL JUST
LAY OUT WHY THIS HAS BEEN
DIFFICULT.
SO INITIALLY WE PROPOSE THERE TO
BE A REGIONAL AGENCY AND WHAT WE
HAD HEARD BOTH IT'S FROM A BAG
AN MTC WAS THERE ARE TWO
REGIONAL AGENCIES ALREADY WHY DO
WE NEED A THIRD.
AND SO IT IS CONTEMPLATED RATHER
THAN CREATING AN ENTIRELY NEW
REGIONAL AGENCY THAT WE HAVE
PASSED ANTI SEEN A BACK TO WORK
TOGETHER. TO FIGURE OUT HOW
COLLECTIVELY THOSE TWO BODIES
CAN TAKE ON THE RESPONSIBILITIES
THAT WE NEED TO MOVE THIS
FORWARD.
SO THAT IS A SIGNIFICANT CHANGE
OF HOW WE'RE DOING THIS BUT I
SHOULD ALSO SAY AS YOU KNOW.
M. T. C. IS VIEWED AS A BODY
IT'S A REGIONAL BODY -- BUT
BECAUSE THERE APPEARS TO BE A
HEAVY AWAY FROM FROM LARGER
CITIES THAT HAS CREATED A RACKED
REACTION FROM SOME OF THE
SMALLER AND SUBURBAN CITIES.
LIKE WISE BECAUSE THE MTC AND
HOW IT'S STRUCTURED TYPICALLY
HAVING ONE VOTE PER CITY IT IS
VIEWED AS BEING MORE
REPRESENTATIVE FOR SMALLER AND
SUBURBAN CITIES AND SO WHAT
WE'VE TRIED TO DO WITH THIS BILL.
IS TO REALLY ASK BOTH BODIES TO
WORK TOGETHER.
IN MOVING THIS FORWARD AND AS
YOU KNOW BOTH ANTI SEEN A BAG
ARE HAVING A CONVERSATION AS WE
SPEAK ABOUT HOW TO DO BETTER
WORK TOGETHER SO THAT IS REALLY.
THE INTENT OF WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO DO HAVING ONE BODY OR THE
OTHER DICTATE FUNDING WOULD BE
LIKE SUGGESTING THAT IN THIS
CASE THE SENATE THE U. S. SENATE.
OUGHT TO DECIDE FUNDING FOR
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE IT HAS ONE OR
TWO VOTES PER STATE.
THAT THAT HAS CREATED A LITTLE
BIT OF REACTION FROM FROM SOME
CITIES THE FLIP SIDE OF THAT IS
JUST HAVING HOUSE DICTATE THAT
WOULD MAKE SENSE SO AGAIN WE'VE
SAID TO AIM TO SEEN A BACK CAN
CAN THE TWO AGENCIES WORK
TOGETHER.
THAT HAS TAKEN SOME TIME BUT MY
HOPE IS AND I'M A VERY -- AGAIN
NOT JUST APPRECIATE THE FEEDBACK
OF YOU ANOTHER -- LOCAL
LEGISLATORS BUT THE FEEDBACK
FROM ALL OF THE REPRESENTATIVES
OF EIGHT AND A BAG AN MTC ON
THIS THIS WILL MAKE THE BILL
BETTER AND THAT IS OUR HOPE OVER
THE NEXT MONTH THAT WE
INCORPORATE THAT FEEDBACK SO
LOOK FOR TO WORKING WITH YOU ON
THAT.
I DON'T KNOW MAY HAVE MAYORIF
YOU HAVE ANYTHING YOU WANT TO
ADD A NEW ONE WANT TO GET BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE AS AS SOON AS
WE CAN THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
MAYOR QUICKLY AND THEN WE'D LIKE
TO TURN OVER TO MY SENATOR ABOUT.
SO I JUST WANNA CLARIFY
INITIALLY WITH BILL SUPPOSE I
DIDN'T SUPPORT CREATING A NEW
BUREAUCRACY I THOUGHT IT WAS
APPROPRIATE THAT A BAG OR MTC.
TAKE ON THIS ROLE OF RUNNING
THIS NEW REGIONAL HOUSING
FINANCE AGENCY THAT WAS THE OVER
RIDING CONCERN THAT WE'VE HEARD.
FROM CITIES OF ALL SIZES THE BAY
AREA AND THE BILL AMENDMENTS
THAT WE WORKED OUT.
THE AUTHORS ACCEPTED WOULD HAVE
A JOINT RESPONSIBILITY FOR BOTH
A BAG NMTC TO MAKE DECISIONS ON
THE EXPENDITURE PLAN.
ON THE ACTUAL ALLOCATION FOR
PROJECTS THIS IS SIMILAR TO WHAT
WE DO AROUND OUR SUSTAINABLE
COMMUNITY STRATEGY PLAN BAY AREA
WE'RE BOTH AGENCIES WORK
TOGETHER TO DEVELOP THE REGIONAL
LAND USE PLAN.
SO I THINK THIS PRESIDENT WE YOU
KNOW WE ARE WORKING TOGETHER AND
THERE'S GONNA BE A MUCH BROADER
CONVERSATION ON SHARED REGIONAL
GOVERNANCE IN THE COMING MONTHS
AND YEARS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AS MAYOR IF I
COULD TURN OVER CONVERSATION IN
THE WALL -- I KNOW THAT MS
SECOND WOULD LIKE ME TO SAY A
FEW WORDS PRIOR -- TO CLOSING --
IT WITH MR CHIU LET'S HAVE THE
COMMITTEE DANCING COMMENTS
QUESTIONS CENTER ABOUT.
WELL AS A MEMBER OF THE
COMMITTEE FROM THE BAY AREA
LET'S BE VERY INVOLVED IN THE
DISCUSSIONS SO -- GENERALLY --
OF FROM SAN JOSE'S PERSPECTIVE --
WE SEE -- A LOT OF HOUSING
BUILDING SAN JOSE THIS
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
AND A LOT OF WORK DONE OVER THE
LAST SEVERAL DECADES.
BUT WE SEE OUR REMAINING
NEIGHBORS NOT PRODUCING -- I'LL
JUST SAY.
THEIR FAIR SHARE.
OR OR OR ACTIVELY ENCOURAGING
THE BUILDING AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
SO IT'S KIND OF LONG STANDING --
PROBLEM.
AND I THINK THAT HAVING A
REGIONAL OF KIND OF APPROACH.
MIGHT BE ONE WAY OF SOLVING THAT
THAT ISSUE.
MY MY PARTICULAR VIEW IS THAT --
OF THE CONDUCT OF THE
LEGISLATORS SHOULD BE.
YEAH WE GOT TO DO IT THE HARD
WAY FOLKS.
THE HARDWARE IS KIND OF LIKE HOW
WE DID REGIONAL MEASURE.
THREE WHICH WAS.
AS ALWAYS ALL THE BERRY
LEGISLATORS KNOW VERY DIFFICULT
TO GET.
THE CONSENSUS AMONG THE BAY AREA
LET LEGISLATIVE DELEGATION.
ARE AND MORE IMPORTANTLY.
AROUND THE BAY THE NINE COUNTY --
CONGESTION MANAGEMENT AGENCIES
AND ALL.
OF THE COUNTY -- AREAS INCLUDING
YOURS -- MADAM COUNCILMAN -- TO
SUPPORT THE THE REGIONAL MEASURE
THREE THE GOT PLACED ON THE
BALLOT.
AS SUCCESSFULLY VOTED ON IN THE
BAY AREA WHEN WE PUT THAT ON THE
BALLOT.
IT WAS VERY SUCCESSFUL AND I
THINK IT WAS VERY SUCCESSFUL AS
YOU KNOW HOW HARD IT WAS BECAUSE
YOU WORKED ON IT VERY HARD WITH
ME.
AND SIR MCGUIRE AND CENTER
WINNER AND EVERYBODY ELSE WAS
VERY SUCCESSFUL BECAUSE WE WORK
SO WE DID THAT PREP WORK THAT
WAS SO DIFFICULT.
THE TWO YET -- SOME PEOPLE SAID
IS LIKE HERDING FERAL CATS YOU
KNOW WITH THE BAY AREA POLITICS
BUT BUT WE HAVE TO DO IT WE HAVE
TO KIND OF WORK TOGETHER.
AND BRING OURSELVES TOGETHER BUT
I BUT I BELIEVE I BELIEVE
STRONGLY.
THERE ARE A REGIONAL
[inaudible]
HOUSING ORGANIZATION.
COULD BE AS SIMPLE ORGANIZATION
BECAUSE IF YOU'RE FOCUSING ON
JUST BUILDING A HOUSING.
GETTING A HOUSING PROGRAMS GOING
JUST YOU KNOW KEEP KEEP IT
SIMPLE -- I TAKE -- WE CAN BE
VERY SUCCESSFUL AND HAVING A AND
A MEDIA TO IMPACT ON ON
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN THE BAY
AREA WHICH WE SO DESPERATELY
NEED.
IT'S IT'S IT'S PROBABLY THE
MAJOR REASON WHY.
OUR ECONOMY COULD LAG IN THE BAY
AREA.
IS BECAUSE A LACK OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IT'S IT'S IT'S WE'RE AT
WE'RE AT A POINT WERE OF PEOPLE
ARE GOING TO START LOSING THEIR
JOBS AND BUSINESSES ARE GOING TO
START TO LEAVE.
AND WE NEED TO FOCUS ON THIS
ISSUE FROM THE REGIONAL
PERSPECTIVE THAT'S WHY SUPPORT
THIS BILL -- GOING FORWARD AND
HAVING TO CONTINUE DISCUSSION IS
GOING TO BE SO IMPORTANT.
THAT -- OF IT'S IT'S NOT ABOUT --
IT'S NOT ABOUT US IT'S ABOUT
THEM I KEEP TELLING MYSELF
THAT'S ONE OF MY SAYINGS I GIVE
MY STAFF IS NOT ABOUT US.
MEETING OUR PAROCHIAL INTEREST
OR WHATEVER OUR PROPUBLICA ABOUT
THEM IT'S ABOUT WHO WE SERVE IN
THE PEOPLE WE SERVE.
AND I THINK WE HAVE TO BE BE --
STRONGLY WORKING WITH ALL THE
COLLEAGUES IT MAYBE HAVE
DIFFERENT OPINIONS AND IT WAS
DIFFICULT MEMBER ARM THREE WAS
VERY DIFFICULT.
REMEMBER THAT -- YEAH.
YEAH THAT MEETING RIGHT OKAY SO
I HAD TO KIND OF PUT THE HAMMER
DOWN A FEW TIMES.
YES YOU DID YEAH AREN'T NOW
WHERE ELSE SOMETIMES WE GO DO
THAT YOU KNOW BUT AS THOSE OF A
PERSON THAT SERVED ON ANTI SEE
FOR TWENTY ONE YEARS AND YOU
KNOW I THINK IN TO SEE CAN
TRANSFORM AND MAYOR TO THE THE
CARD ORGANIZATION WOULD BE
REALLY HELPFUL. TO YOUR
COMMUNITY THAT CAN HELP MAKE
YOUR COMMUNITY A BETTER PLACE TO
LIVE FOR YOUR CONSTITUENTS.
AND HAVE THE HOUSING FOR THE
PEOPLE THAT WORK IN YOUR
COMMUNITY.
PEOPLE THAT YOU KNOW THE DO THE
WORK THAT ARE.
MOVING OUT AND CAUSING A LOT OF
AIR POLLUTION BECAUSE THEY CAN'T
FIND AFFORDABLE.
HOUSING AND OUR OWN PLACES WHERE
THEY CLOSE WHERE THEY WORK SO.
SO I THINK -- IT'S AN
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUE AS WELL AS
ECONOMIC ISSUE AND A KIND OF A
HUMAN RIGHTS ISSUE SO -- I I
SUPPORTED -- THE GERMAN.
FROM THE ASSEMBLY AND EVERYBODY
ELSE -- WORKING ON THIS --
OVERVIEW STRONGLY WORKING ON
THIS OVER THE SUMMER WE HAVE TO
GET THIS JOB DONE.
THIS IS A CRITICAL ISSUE THAT WE
HAVE TO HAVE FOR THE BAY AREA.
WE CONSERVING EXAM OUT AS AN
EXAMPLE OF OTHER.
OTHER AREAS IN THE STATE --
WORKING TOGETHER -- AND I KNOW
WE CAN DO A GOOD JOB IN PULLING
THIS TOGETHER SO I'LL BE HAPPY
TO OF SUPPORTERS.
AND SUPPORTS -- MY EFFORTS TO
FORGE A CONSENSUS WITH YOU AND
THE WORK YOU'RE DOING -- OF A
MISTER CHAIRMAN FOR GETTING TO
BURY IT TOGETHER ON THIS I'LL DO
ANYTHING I CAN HELP YOU ON THAT
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AS CENTER
BALLOT IN WE LOOK FORWARD TO
PARTNERING SENATOR BAIL HEARING
CENTER WIENER.
OVER THE SUMMER WORK PERIOD AND
OF COURSE THE DECEMBER TWO
MEMBERS OF A BAG MEMBERS NTC TO
BE ABLE.
TO GET THIS RIGHT.
SOME NUMBER TWO WOULD YOU LIKE
TO GET A RESPONSE.
THE NOT SO THAT IT WOULD YOU
LIKE ME TO CLOSE OR ARE YOU THIS
IS A CLOSER NO JUST WHEN YOU SEE
I HAVE A FEW NO I AGAIN I'M JUST
VERY GRATEFUL THE CENTRE BELL
KNOWS HOW DIFFICULT --
DEVELOPING CONSENSUS ON THIS IS
BUT ALSO HOW CRITICAL IT IS FOR
US TO ADDRESS OUR REGIONAL.
CHALLENGES AND APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH ALSO CLOSING
COMMENTS IT'LL TURN TO RESCIND
THE VIRTUE FOR HIS CLOSING
COMMENTS BUT PLEASE CANCEL WOULD
YOU LIKE TO BE ABLE TO HAVE.
ANY FINAL COMMENTS PLEASE YEAH
FOR SO I WANTED TO THANK YOU ALL
FOR PUTTING THE POTS ON THIS AND
I WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLYMAN CHIU
FOR REACHING OUT -- AND I STILL
THINK IN ORDER FOR US TO WORK
TOGETHER.
A BAG MTC HAS TO INCLUDE.
INDIVIDUALS AND ELECTED
OFFICIALS.
HAVE DIFFERENCES OF OPINION.
BECAUSE THE STRENGTH OF THE
DECISION AT THE END IS A LOT
STRONGER WHEN YOU HAVE.
OF VOICES ON ALL SIDES.
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING
WHAT TO ADD PROGRESS TO MAKE --
AND YOU MAY BE SEEING ME IN A
MONTH.
NO ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU SO MUCH
AS WOMEN ARE GREAT FOR THE
YOU'RE HERE AS WELL AND FOR ALL
OF YOUR WORK IN MANY MANY YEARS
OF WORK THAT YOU PUT IN.
I'LL JUST BOTTOM LINE IT HERE WE
KNOW THAT THERE IS A LOT OF WORK
AHEAD -- BUT WHAT I WILL SAY IF
FOUNDATION HAS BEEN LAID I AM
GRATEFUL TO THE RECOMMENDATIONS
THAT HAVE ADVANCING ALL
CHARACTERIZES RECOMMENDATIONS AS
PULMONARY.
AS THOSE ULTIMATELY HAVE TO BE
BLESSED BY THE LEGISLATIVE
COMMITTEE -- AND THEN ULTIMATELY
EACH OF THE BOARDS.
AND WHERE WE'RE AT RIGHT NOW IS
THIS WHATWOULD HAPPEN TODAY WE
WOULD PASS THE AMENDED BILL THE
MINUTE BILL WOULD GO TO
APPROPRIATIONS WHAT WE WOULD
HOPE THAT BILL WOULD.
BE PASSED EVER APPROPRIATIONS
AND THEN ON TO THE SENATE FLOOR
WE WOULD IN MAINE ON THE SENATE
FLOOR.
AFTER WE SEE FINAL
RECOMMENDATIONS IT WOULD BE
COMING BACK FROM THIS JOINT AD
HOC MADE UP OF BOTH MTC IS WELL
AS A BAG MEMBERS.
WE WOULD THEN HAVE SECONDARY
HEARINGS INTO POLICY COMMITTEES
BOTH HOUSING AS WELL AS
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE TO THE
WILL HAVE ANOTHER BITE AT THE
APPLE HERE I IN THE COMING
THIRTY TO FORTY FIVE DAYS.
I DO KNOW THAT EVERYONE EVERYONE
IS COMMITTED TO BE ABLE TO WILL
FOCUS ON TRYING TO GET THIS
RIGHT.
WELL EVERYONE BE PLEASE ON THIS.
PROBABLY NOT CAN WE GET CLOSE
YES.
AND I WILL GO BACK TO THE MODEL
A REGIONAL MEASURES.
THREE WE HAD TO WORK WITH.
DOZENS OF JURISDICTIONS.
ACROSS THE NINE BAY AREA
COUNTIES AND WE'RE ABLE TO GET
THAT.
PRETTY CLOSE TO BEING RIGHT.
END.
IT'S GONNA TAKE SOME ADDITIONAL
TIME WHICH IS WHY WE'RE HERE
TODAY AND I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THE HARD WORK OF THIS AND NUMBER.
TWO NUMBER TWO IS NOT AFRAID TO
BE ABLE TO PUT HIS NECK OUT AND
GET INVOLVED IN SOME OF THE
TOUGHEST ISSUES.
THAT THE STATE IN OUR REGION IS
GRAPPLING WITH I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE HIM -- AND WHAT A
GREAT PARTNER HE IS TO WORK WITH
THE STRAIGHT UP.
IN IF WE DON'T AGREE IS ABLE TO
EXPRESS IT AND THERE HAVE BEEN
TIMES WHEN WE BOTH HAD TO
COMPROMISE THAT IS ONE OF
KNOWLEDGE IS SIR.
THAT IT IS GREAT TO BE A TO WORK
WITH YOU AND KNOW THAT WILL BE
ABLE TO GET.
A RECOMMENDATION BACK TO THIS
COMMITTEE IN HOUSING HERE IN THE
NEXT THIRTY TO FORTY FIVE DAYS
WITH THE HELP OF SENATOR BAIL.
SENATOR WIENER -- IS WELL OF
COURSE MISTER MAYOR AND THE AD
HOC AS WELL AND I WITH THE FORTY
HEARING DIFFERENT FEEDBACK FROM
BOTH A BAG IN DC.
CINNAMON REJECTED CLOSE.
LET ME JUST CLOSE BY AGAIN
THANKING EVERYONE FOR YOUR
ENGAGEMENT -- THROUGH THIS AND
EVERYONE'S PATIENCE IS REALLY
FOR THROUGH THIS AND TO THE GOOD
COUNCILMAN FROM NEVADA.
I ABSOLUTELY WELCOME THE
FEEDBACK AND ENGAGEMENT WITH
CITIES AS WE MOVE THIS FORWARD
AND I AGREE WITH YOU THAT
WALKING THROUGH THE DIFFERENCES
IS HOW WE ACTUALLY GET TO THE
BEST RESULT IF THIS DOESN'T WORK.
FOR MARIN COUNTY IF IT DOESN'T
WORK FOR YOUR CITY IF IT DOESN'T
WORK FOR CITIES AROUND THE BAY
IT'S NOT GONNA WORK AND SO MY
HOPE IS TO TO GET US THERE.
I ALSO WANT TO SAY -- TO
LEADERSHIP FOR MARIN COUNTY.
I HAVE OFFERED TO VISIT YOUR
REGION -- AND TO ENGAGE IN A
MUCH MORE DIRECT CONVERSATION OF
THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL SO HAPPY
TO ENGAGE WITH THAT.
LET ME JUST CLOSE BY FOCUSING ON
THE NEED THERE WAS A SUGGESTION
THAT SOMEHOW THE BAY AREA HAS
NOT BEEN THE EPICENTER OF THE
HOUSING CRISIS.
THAT IS A STATEMENT THAT I HAVE
TO TAKE.
OUT SOME DIFFERENCE WITH BECAUSE
THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS.
WE SAW AND WE EXPERIENCE THE
HOUSING CRISIS BEFORE OTHER
PARTS OF THE STATE DID.
YEARS AGO AND TO THIS DAY WE
HAVE THE HIGHEST HOME PRICES WE
HAVE THE HIGHEST RATE LEVELS WE
HAVE THE HIGHEST ADDICTION RATES.
AND UNFORTUNATELY OUR
HOMELESSNESS LEVELS ARE RIGHTLY.
OTHER CHALLENGE PARTS OF THE
STATE WE NEED TO FIGURE THIS OUT
AND OUR HOPE THIS IS A BILL.
REALLY TO SELF HELP BILL TO GIVE
US THE TOOLS TO START TO ADDRESS
THIS OURSELVES BUT OBVIOUSLY
WE'VE GOT TO FIGURE OUT OUR OWN
GOVERNANCE ISSUES IN THE REGION
THAT IS MY HOPE IN THE NEXT
COUPLE WEEKS.
THAT WE CAN WORK THROUGH THESE
CONVERSATIONS AND BRING THIS
BACK TO THIS COMMITTE TO MOVE
THIS FORWARD AND WITH THAT AGAIN
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR SUPPORT AND
TO THE CHAIRMAN.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR INCREDIBLE
GAUGE WHEN ON THIS AS ALWAYS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH NUMBER DO WE
HAVE A MOTION ON THE FLOOR WITH
A MOTION BY SENATOR BELL THE
MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS US GET A ROLL
CALL PLEASE MISSING CHESTER.
CHOIR HIGH WIRE HI MORLOCK.
L..
I HERTZBERG.
RICARDO NIELSEN.
NIELSEN NOW WINNER.
NUMBER TWO ONE TWO ONE VOTE WE
ARE GOING TO KEEP THAT ROLE OPEN
AND WE WILL BE COMING BACK.
ALLOW FOLKS TO BE ABLE TO ADD ON
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE CANCEL THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER WOLF
[inaudible] FOR TWENTY BUT IN
GENERAL WE LIKE TO DO SOME QUICK
HOUSEKEEPING AT TWELVE EIGHTEEN
THAT THIS ROOM IS GONNA BE
TURNING INTO A PUMPKIN AT ONE PM --
AS INSURANCE WILL BE COMING IN.
SO -- WHAT WILL END UP HAPPENING
THERE ARE FIVE BILLS INSURANCE
WE'RE GOING TO BE TAKING A
TEMPORARY RECESS -- DURING
INSURANCE WE WILL THEN RECONVENE
IN THIS ROOM AFTER INSURANCE --
AS WE WILL BE GOING BEYOND ONE
PM TODAY.
HE ENJOYS BEING IN THIS
COMMITTEE SO MUCH WE ARE NOW
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER TWENTY
FIVE THAT'S AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY
THREE SOME NUMBER.
TO FOCUSING ON DENSITY BONUSES
TO MEMBER THE FLOOR IS YOURS
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND AND
LET ME JUST START FIRST BY
AGREEING TO THE AMENDMENTS --
THAT WE'VE DISCUSSED AND
THANKING YOU YET AGAIN AND YOUR
STAFF FOR YOUR JUDGMENT WITH US --
WORKING THROUGH THE ISSUES AND
THE COMPETING CONCERNS -- WITH
THESE AMENDMENTS THIS IS THE
THIRD I THINK FINAL SIGNIFICANT
BILL WE HAVE MOVED TO THIS
COMMITTEE THE CYCLE AND NEXT
YEAR I'M GOING TO TRY TO THINK
ABOUT BILLS THAT MAY NOT HAVE TO
GO THROUGH THIS BUT I LOVE
WORKING WITH YOU ALL THE TIME SO
WE'LL KEEP.
ON DOING THAT -- IN THE MIDST OF
OUR STATE HOUSING CRISIS THIS
BILL WOULD PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
DENSITY BONUSES 41100%
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECTS THIS
BILL HAS NO STATE COSTS.
AND LOCALS CAN CHARGE FEES TO
COVER THOSE COSTS OUR BILL
ADDRESSES SEVERAL CHALLENGES
FIRST THE FACT THAT ZONING I
OFTEN A BEAR TO HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT.
EXISTING ZONING ARE OFTEN TOO
LOW FOR AFFORDABLE PROJECTS TO
PENCIL OUT.
SECONDLY WE ALL KNOW HOW SCARE
SUPPORT A HOUSING FUNDING IS WE
NEED TO STRETCH EVERY DOLLAR TO
BUILD AS MANY UNITS AS WE CAN.
AND THEN THIRDLY FOR THOSE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPERS
THAT ARE COMPETING WITH MARKET
RATE DEVELOPERS MORE DENSITY CAN
MAKE A PROJECT FINANCIALLY
FEASIBLE GIVEN THAT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
ORGANIZATION THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COMPETE FOR SITES UNDER OUR BILL
A 100%. FOR WILL HOUSING
PROJECTS WOULD BE ELIGIBLE 480%
DENSITY BONUSES ABOVE EXISTING
DENSITY.
ZONE DENSITY AS WELL AS WITH
ADDITIONAL INCENTIVES AND
CONCESSIONS.
AND GIVEN THE ENVIRONMENTAL AND
EQUITY BENEFITS OF LOCATING
HOUSING TO EACH YEAR TRANSIT A
100% FOR WILL HOUSING PROJECTS
NEXT TO TRANSIT WOULD BE
ELIGIBLE FOR ADDITIONAL DENSITY
SO WITH THAT.
ME TO TURN IT OVER TO OUR
WITNESSES THANK YOU SO MUCH AS A
MEMBER WE ALWAYS OTHER ONE
LEASES IN COMMITTEES WELL IT'S
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
GOOD TIMES MY GOODNESS.
WE'RE GONNA TURN IT OVER TO OUR
WEEK TWO WITNESSES WHO WOULD
LIKE TO BE TO GO FIRST.
AGO ASKING FOR US IN
ORGANIZATION TWO MINUTES PLEASE
THANK YOU TERRY MEMBERS MARINO
WHITE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING CONSORTIUM REPRESENTING
THE DEVELOPMENT BUILDING
FINANCIAL AND PUBLIC SECTORS
UNITED IN THE GOAL TO PRODUCE
AND PRESERVE HOUSING FOR LOW AND
MODERATE INCOME CALIFORNIANS.
SPONSOR THE BELL REALLY WANT TO
THANK YOUR STAFF FOR THE
EXTENSIVE AMOUNT OF TIME HE
SPENT WORKING WITH US -- TO IT
TO WHAT I THINK IS THAT IS A
GOOD SOLUTION AND APPRECIATE
YOUR SUPPORT ON THE BILL TODAY
THANK YOU.
MY SIX FOR BEING HERE.
JULIE SNYDER WITH EQUITY
ADVOCATES I'M HERE REPRESENTING
HOUSING CALIFORNIA OUR MEMBERS
CONSTITUTE THE MOST
SOPHISTICATED NONPROFIT
DEVELOPMENT COMMUNITY IN THE
NATION -- AND WE'RE VERY PLEASED
TO SUPPORT THIS MEASURE -- IT
WILL ALLOW US TO EXTEND -- THE
VALUE OF EVERY DOLLAR THAT THE
STATE PUTS INTO DEVELOPMENT --
AS WELL AS ENSURE THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO PRESERVE LAND ON THE
EDGES OF CITIES AS OPEN SPACE SO
WHEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR ALL
YOUR WORK ON THIS AND DRIVE OUT
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANKS FOR
BEING HERE.
A GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING
SANDY GEORGE REPRESENTING
AMERICAN PLANNING ASSOCIATION
WERE ALSO IN SUPPORT AND THANK
THE AUTHOR AND THE SPONSORS FOR
WORKING WITH US A CLARIFICATION
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON AGAIN.
ALLEN SHEA CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HOUSING
AUTHORITIES IN CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL HOUSING
FINANCE AGENCIES IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
HI FOR MANY ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIAN THE AND THE
NONPROFIT HOUSING ASSOCIATION OF
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON HEY DON'T GOOD
AFTERNOON ON A LAWLER WITH
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AFTERNOON AFTERNOON BRIAN
AUGUSTA VAST CALIFORNIA RURAL
LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION IN
THE CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR
REAL HOUSING AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON TO DAVID ON
BEHALF OF AREA HOUSING ADVOCACY
COALITION IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MORE TALK ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
YOUR TURN MEMBER SERVICE
SOLUTION ON BEHALF OF CITY OF
LOS ANGELES MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI
IN STRONG SUPPORT AND ALSO HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SANTA
MONICA SUPPORT AS WELL THANK
THANK YOU SO MUCH WOULD LIKE TO
VISITORS ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
LAST CALL.
YOU KNOW LIKE IT WILL TURN OVER
TO THOSE WHO MAY BE OPPOSE.
JONES COMES AT THE TABLE WOULD
YOU LIKE TO BE A IS PLEASE COME
ON FOR ARE WE TO INDIVIDUALS WHO
WILL BE SPEAKING THE IN
OPPOSITION.
WE WELCOME BOTH GENTLEMEN I TO
THE TABLE.
GERMAN WHO WOULD LIKE ME TO GO
FIRST WEBER DOES FOR OLDER THAN
THAT.
ROCK PAPER SCISSORS PLEASE --
PLEASE MISTER JONES -- FIRST
LAST ORGANIZATION YOU HAVE TO
ANSWER DAVID JONES A MAP THE
CITIES OF BURBANK AND SAN MARCOS
AGAIN -- WE UNDERSTAND AND
REALIZE THAT THE EXTREME NEED
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND WE
HAVE A GREAT SYMPATHY FOR
BUILDING THEM SAN MARCOS IS A
CITY THAT IS -- EIGHTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE -- THEY HAVE THREE
THOUSAND AFFORDABLE HOUSING
UNITS THE SECOND MOST AFFORDABLE
HOUSING UNITS BUILT IN ANY CITY
IN SAN DIEGO.
SAN DIEGO COUNTY RIGHT BEHIND
THE CAN THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO SO
THEY HAVE DONE A VERY VERY GOOD --
JOB IN PROVIDING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
THE POSSIBILITY OF HAVING.
YOU KNOW.
HE PERCENT DENSITY GIVEN TO A
VERY LARGE ADDITIONAL THREE
STORIES ON TOP OF THAT WEDGED
INTO SOME OF OUR NEIGHBORHOODS I
MENTIONED EARLIER IN MY
TESTIMONY.
SAN MARCOS HAS THREE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES WITHIN ITS JURISDICTION
WE HAVE A VERY VERY -- IMPACTED
NEIGHBORHOODS ARE CITIZENS ARE
HAVE BEEN VERY GOOD AS FAR AS
ACCEPTING AFFORDABLE HOUSING
WITHIN THEIR THEIR COMMUNITIES
SO WEAK LIKE I MENTIONED EIGHTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE THREE THOUSAND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS THAT
WERE BUILT BY REDEVELOPMENT
MONEY SO.
WE HAVE A REDEVELOPMENT I DID A
FABULOUS JOB AND LOSS OF IT IS
CLEARLY ON OUR MINDS NOW -- BUT
THE PARKING ISSUE FOR US IS IS
VERY EXTREME BURBANK ARE OF THE
CLIENT HAS TWELVE THOUSAND UNITS
OF HOUSING BING -- IN THE
PIPELINE BEING DEVELOPED SO
THEY'RE NOT SHIRKING THEIR
RESPONSIBILITY SO HAVING THE
POSSIBILITY OF HAVING SOME OF
THEIR PARCELS HAVE THIS KIND OF
DENSIFICATION WITHOUT.
OF PARKING REQUIREMENTS WILL
HAVE EXTREMELY IMPACTS ON THOSE
COMMUNITIES IN THOSE
NEIGHBORHOODS THAT WERE ALREADY
BENDING OVER BACKWARDS IN TRYING
TO GET THE COMMUNITIES TO ACCEPT
HIGHER DENSIFICATION.
AND WITH THIS BILL IT WOULD
SUDDENLY THROW A LOT OF THAT OUT
THE WINDOW AND WE POTENTIALLY
WOULD HAVE.
MUCH MORE HIGHER DENSITIES IN
CERTAIN AREAS WHERE THE
COMMUNITIES OF ALREADY MADE THE
MADE THE CONCESSIONS IN THE
COMMUNITIES ALREADY SAID WE WILL
ACCEPT.
HIGHER DENSIFICATION AN THEN TO
HAVE THIS BILL COMING IN AND
SUDDENLY HAVE THAT NUMBER
CHANGED TO A MUCH HIGHER
POTENTIAL DOWN DENSITY WOULD BE
VERY VERY PROBLEMATIC FOR BOTH
OUR CLIENTS SO. FOR THOSE
REASONS WE WOULD OPPOSE THE BILL
THANK YOU HIS CHANCE GOOD
AFTERNOON AFTERNOON -- MISTER
CHAIR JOHN CLAN FOR THE CITY OF
ITS IT IS TO DETERMINE THE SAME
COMMENTS THAT -- MISTER JONES IS
MADE.
SORT OF BIGGER PICTURE FROM --
THE CITY EVEN SINISE RESPECTIVE
DENSITY BONUS TENDS TO ELICIT
STRONG REACTIONS FROM ITS
CITIZENRY IN TERMS OF FEEL THE
THAT IT GOES AROUND THE GENERAL
pPLAN PROCESS AND SETTING THOSE --
APPROPRIATE ZONING SERVE
DIFFERENT ASK PARTS OF THE
COMMUNITY.
I WOULD ALSO SAY THAT AS A
COASTAL CITY.
THE ABILITY TO GO ABOVE HEIGHT
LIMITATIONS DEFINITELY ALSO
CREATES A LOT OF ANGST WITHIN
OUR COMMUNITY AND SO FOR THOSE
REASONS WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE.
SEVENTEEN SIXTY THREE THANK YOU
SO MUCH SIR.
WELCOME HANG IF YOU LIKE WE
WELCOME BACK WITH US.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE BALKANS OFFICER TO BE
AFTER THE SEIZE UPON DEL
THOUSAND OAKS IN TORRANCE WILL
SIMPLY ECHO THE COMMENTS AROUND
THE PARKING ISSUE AND FOR THOSE
REASONS WE ARE OPPOSED.
YOU SO MUCH WE LIKELY TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION IF YOU COULD PLEASE
COME.
FOR THIS IS GONNA BE OUR LAST
CALL FOR OPPOSITION.
WE'RE GONNA BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE TO BE A TO SEE IF WE
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
PLEASE SENATE BILL WOULD
SOMEBODY BUILDS A UNIT THEY
COULD PUT AS MANY PARKING SPACES
AS THEY WANT RIGHT.
YES ALTHOUGH I DO WANT TO DRESS
A PARKING FOR SECOND SO WHAT
WHAT WHAT THIS BILL SAYS IS THAT.
WITH REGARDS TO SPECIAL NEEDS
HOUSING OR SUPPORT OF HOUSING --
THAT'S WHERE WE'RE SAYING WE
DON'T THINK THERE NEEDS TO BE
THAT MUCH PARKING AND THAT'S THE
REALITY OF THOSE PROJECTS THAT
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL DOES.
THAT'S TRUE THAT'S THAT'S THAT'S
ALL WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE SO
MY UNDERSTANDING OF THE
OPPOSITION IS THAT THEY WANT TO
ENSURE PARKING FOR THOSE
PARTICULAR PROJECTS.
THAT IS ONE WHERE WE JUST
RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE THAT
THERE'S A NEED FOR PARKING IN
THOSE SITUATIONS AGAIN FOR
SPECIAL NEED HOUSING AND SUPPORT
HOUSING ALONE BUT I I THINK WITH
THE IMPORTANT CLARIFICATION ON
THOSE TWO ITEMS.
UNDERSTANDING THERE'S SOME --
DIFFERENCES BUT THIS IS NOT
TOUCH THE ISSUE OF PARKING
OTHERWISE FOR WRECKED SO I THINK
THAT'S CORRECT OVER V. ONE TO
BUILD SOME AFFORDABLE HOUSING
THAT'S NOT SUPPORT OF HOUSING.
CORRECT BUT IT WOULD NOT THEIR
CHOICE YES YES SOMEONE EXACTLY
THAT PENCILS -- THEY DO IT THAT
WAY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER ABOUT.
WE WOULD WELCOME ADDITIONAL
CONVERSATION OR MOTION FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
OCEAN A MOTION ON THE FLOOR BY
SENATOR BAIL.
NUMBER TWO WOULD YOU LIKE TO BE
A CLOSER THIS APPRECIATE THIS
COMMITTEE AGAIN AND ALSO WANT TO
SAY -- NOW WAS A MILE STAFF
YOU'VE GOT SOME OF THE STAFF IN
THE BUILDING AND APPRECIATE
THEIR DEEP ENGAGEMENT WITH US
AND OUR COALITION ON THIS SO
THANK YOU KNOW WE LOVE WORKING
WITH YOU SIR WITH LOVE WORK WITH
LISA IN IN TIME HAS BEEN AN ALL
STAR IN IN.
TIME JUST GOT A NEW HOUSE WHICH
IS ALSO EXCITING SO GRADUATION.
THERE YOU GO.
ANYTHING YOUR TELLS IN DONNER
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
ALL THE SENATE JUST GOT AWKWARD
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
SO -- WE DO HAVE A MOTION THE
MOTION BY CENTER BELL THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS MISLAID JUST A
ROLL CALL PLEASE.
HI.
BELL.
WELL I HERTZBERG.
CARO NIELSEN [inaudible]
WIENER.
WE ARE.
CURRENTLY ENJOYS A THREE ZERO
VOTE THAT BILL IS GONNA BE ON
CALL AND WILL ADD ON INFLOWS
COMING THANK YOU CENTERS THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AS A MEMBER
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
NICE JOB.
WE'RE NOW GOING TO BE LET'S SEE
HERE DO WE HAVE MR STONE IS NO
LONGER HERE BUT WE DO HAVE A
SOME NUMBER GLORIA.
LAYS IN GERMAN COMMITTEE.
THIS IS GOING TO BE OUR LAST
BILL.
IN OUR ASK.
MORNING AFTERNOON SESSION AS
THIS ROOM WILL BE TURNING INTO A
PUMPKIN AT ONE PM.
WE ARE GOING TO THEY NEED TO
MAKE ROOM FOR INSURANCE ONCE
AGAIN INSURANCE WILL BE.
HEARING FIVE BILLS.
THIS COMMITTEE WILL RECONVENE.
IMMEDIATELY FOLLOWING INSURANCE.
IN AN AFTERNOON EVENING EDITION
WHICH ARE MISALIGNED CHESTER IS
VERY EXCITED ABOUT [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
UHHUH.
WHEN WE ARE NOW GOING TO WELCOME?
IT'S A NUMBER GLORIA.
WHERE TO KEEP THE STORE CLOSE
THAT'S OKAY IS A MEMBER GLORIA
AB FOURTEEN THIRTY ONE TAKE
MOMENT SAY THINKING THIS A
MEMBER FOR WORKING WITH US?
BUT THIS IS BEEN A BIG ISSUE FOR
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER THE FLOOR IS
YOURS SIR AND WE WELCOME YOU
COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
I'M GONNA BE RELATIVELY --
EXPEDIENT FOR YOU BECAUSE I KNOW
YOU STANDING YOU AND LUNCH BUT I
WANT TO START BY -- ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS WITH A
COMMITMENT -- THAT OUR STAFFS --
WILL CONTINUE TO SPEND THE NEXT
FEW WEEKS -- TO WORKING TOGETHER
TO INSURE.
THAT IS MANY REGIONS ARE
INTERESTED CAN PARTICIPATE -- IN
THE INFRASTRUCTURE IMPROVEMENTS
AT THIS BILL INTENDS TO PROVIDE.
MEMBERS AT FOURTEEN THIRTEEN
SEEKS TO ALLOW -- SUBREGIONS --
THE BENEFIT.
OF A NEW INFRASTRUCTURE
IMPROVEMENTS SHOULD THEY VOTE TO
CHOOSE TO DO SO -- DISRUPTING
THE CURRENT NARRATIVE OR A SMALL
GROUP OF FOLKS -- CAN TAKE AN
ENTIRE MEASURE UNDER THIS BILL
IT'S A FUNNY MEASURES APPROVED
BY THE REQUIRED NUMBER VOTERS
COMMUNITIES WILL BE ENSURED THAT
THE DECISION TO TAX THEMSELVES
WOULD NOT BE IN VAIN.
AND AS THE REVENUE GENERATED
FROM THE SALES TAX WOULD BE
AVAILABLE TO THE COMMUNITIES
DEVOTED TO TAX THEMSELVES --
WITH I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE WITH ME TODAY ARE
REPRESENT IS THE SACRAMENTO AREA
COUNCIL OF GOVERNMENTS AS WELL
AS THE CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION.
AND OUR PARENTS EVEN HERE IN
TIME TO THE NECK EXPEDITE THIS
PROCESS SO I'LL TURN OVER THEN
IF I MAY NAY THANK YOU SO MUCH
WE ARE GONNA HAVE TO WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT TODAY WE LOVE IT WHEN
THE CDC IS HERE.
THE POLICE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
DEDICATE THIS OFF.
MR MEMBERS MIND JAMES CORAL ST
THE EXACT DIRECTOR OF THE
SACRAMENTO AREA COUNCIL OF
GOVERNMENTS ARE SAY CALLED WE
REPRESENT THE SIX COUNTY GREATER
SACRAMENTO REGION TWENTY TWO
CITIES.
ALSO ON BEHALF OF OUR PARTNER
THE PLASTER COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION PLANNING AGENCY
OUR BOARD IS IN SUPPORT FULL
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE -- AT
WHICH EMPOWERS LOCAL
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITIES WITH
EXISTING -- TAXING FOR TO CREATE
THE SUB COUNTY TAXING DISTRICTS
THAT ARE ACTUALLY SO CRITICAL.
I WANT TO GIVE YOU THREE REASONS
WHY THIS IS REALLY REALLY VITAL
TO THE FUTURE OF OUR REGIONAL
ECONOMY HERE IN THE SACRAMENTO
REGION AND FRANKLY OF THE STATE.
FIRST IS THAT THE FUTURE OF
TRANSPORTATION FUNDING IS ABOUT
LEVERAGE IF WE DON'T ACTUALLY
BRING MONEY THE TABLE LOCALLY --
WE'RE GOING TO LOSE OUT ON
FEDERAL AND STATE FUNDS
INCREASINGLY FEDERAL
TRANSPORTATION FUNDS ARE ABOUT
LOCAL LEVERAGE AND SALES TAX
DOLLARS ARE WHERE THAT SITE
NUMBER.
ONE SECOND YES THIS IS ABOUT
DRAWING SMALLER SUB DISTRICTS.
BUT IT'S ACTUALLY ABOUT AN EVEN
BIGGER MUCH LARGER PLAY WHICH IN
OUR CASE IS THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA MEGA REGION OR A
REGIONAL ECONOMY -- THIS WILL
HELP DO THINGS LIKE THE EIGHTY
SIXTY FIVE INTERCHANGING PLASTER
COUNTY THE THIRD TRACK WHICH
CONNECTS ROSEVILLE TO SACRAMENTO
TO THE BAY AREA WE ARE
INCREASINGLY A MEGA REGIONAL
ECONOMY.
THE EIGHTY IS THE ONLY ALL
WEATHER CROSSING THIS YEAR
INTIFADA'S THAT'S GOODS MOVEMENT
ALL THE WAY TO CHICAGO SO EVEN
THOUGH THIS IS A IN OUR REGION
THIS WOULD BENEFIT PLASTER
COUNTY IT REALLY IS A MEGA
REGIONAL.
THING TO BENEFIT THEY'RE NOT
GOING TO PAY THE WHOLE FREIGHT
BUT THAT DOWN PAYMENT IS
CRITICAL AND THIRD.
I HAVE MET PEOPLE AND I'VE MET A
FAMILY RECENTLY THAT WANT TO
MOVE THE LINCOLN CALIFORNIA
GREAT QUALITY OF LIFE GREAT
SCHOOLS THEY DECIDED NOT TO MOVE
TO LINCOLN.
BECAUSE OF THE EIGHTY SIXTY FIVE
INTERCHANGE WE ARE LOSING OUT ON
PEOPLE WERE LOSING OUT ON GROWTH
AND ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY IF WE
DON'T GET MEASURES LIKE THIS
THIS IS HOW IMPORTANT THE SAYS --
BIG LIST OF STAKEHOLDERS
INCLUDING LOCAL CHAMBERS OF
COMMERCE HOUSING ADVOCATES CIVIL
ENGINEERS AIR QUALITY PROPONENTS
PLANNERS AND MANY OTHER PARTNER
ORGANIZATIONS OUR BOARD DOES NOT
TAKE TAX MEASURES LIGHTLY -- WE
DON'T APPROVE ALL OF THEM BUT WE
ARE FULLY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL AND WE ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY GRATEFUL
YOU'RE HERE TODAY.
GOOD AFTERNOON -- SENATE MCGUIRE
AND MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE WE
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE WARM
WELCOME IN THE PATIENTS WAS
GOING THROUGH.
THIS VERY BUSY DAY MY NAME'S
SHUFFLE MORE I'M WITH THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION I'D LIKE TO ECHO WHAT
MR CORAL SAID AND APPRECIATE THE
LEADERSHIP THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GLORIA HAS BROUGHT IN.
IN SPEARHEADING THIS EFFORT EVEN
WITH THE PASSAGE OF THE SENATE
BILL ONE OUR LOCAL COMMUNITIES
ARE STILL STRUGGLING TO BE ABLE
TO COMPLETE CRITICAL
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS NEEDED
FOR QUALITY OF LIFE.
SAFETY ECONOMIC ENVIRONMENTAL
GOALS THIS BILL ALLOWS THEM
ANOTHER -- WAY -- TO ADDRESS THE
FUNDING SHORTFALLS AND BE ABLE
TO HAVE SUSTAINABLE FUNDING FOR
THE NEEDS OF THEIR COMMUNITIES
AND RESPECTFULLY AYE AFTER I
WROTE AND HAPPY ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE THIS TIME.
THANK YOU FOR VERY GRATEFUL SO
THOSE ARE TWO MAIN.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT GERMANY
BOTH MISS WILL FEEL BE OPPOSED.
MISTER CHAIRMAN I'M I'M THANKFUL
TO HAVE COMPANY TODAY SO SWEETLY
INDUSTRY YOUR POSE AS WELL OKAY
GREAT SO WHAT WOULD LIKE TO HAVE
TO DO IS I THINK SINCE WE'RE
GONNA.
ALLOW FOLKS TO BE ABLE TO THE
SUPPORT AND WE'LL COME RIGHT
BACK TO YOU TWO GENTLEMEN IF
THAT'S OKAY WITH YOU PLEASE SIR.
HI MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MARC
WATTS ON BEHALF TO PLUS YOU CAN
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY IN SUPPORT
OF ALSO SITTING HERE IN CASE THE
AUTHOR NEEDS.
SOME TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE THANK
YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS RICHARD
MEMBERS TELLING THE HUNTER ON
BEHALF OF THE VENTURA OUNTY
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE BILL AND
WOULD LOVE TO REMAIN IN.
THANK YOU THANK YOU CENTER.
I'M SUSAN ROHANA REPRESENTING
THE PLASTER COUNTY ASSOCIATION
OF REALTORS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
SO MUCH.
AND IT FEELS IN A STRATEGIES
REPRESENTING A DIVERSE GROUP OF
STAKEHOLDERS IN PLASTER COUNTY
IN SUPPORT THAT INCLUDES A NOR
STATE BE A OF THE CHAMBERS OF
COMMERCE OF THE CITIES OF
ROSEVILLE ROCKLIN LINCOLN AS
WELL AS THE CITIES OF ROSEVILLE
ROCKLIN LINK AND THE LABOR
INDUSTRY THE BASIC.
CRAFTS AND I CONSTRUCTION AND
CIVIL ENGINEERS H. D. R. AND
JACOBS THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH CLASS COUNTIES IN THE HOUSE.
I DON'T BILL JOYCE CLASS ACCOUNT
IN FULL SUPPORT A THANK YOU SO
MUCH SIR.
IT'S GOING IS BACK YES TO BE IN
SUPPORT AYE CAROLING ABOVE THE
SOLANO TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY
IN HUMBOLDT COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS THEY DO SUPPORT THE
CURRENT VERSION OF THE BILL
RECOGNIZE IT'S HAPPENING TODAY
HOPE TO MAKE A GOOD CASE FOR
THEM TO BE ADDED AND IF POSSIBLE.
IN AUGUST THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN RICHARD HARRIS
FOR THE NORSEMAN FIRM ON BEHALF
OF WESTERFELD ECOLOGICAL
SERVICES PROVIDES MITIGATION --
FOR TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS
AROUND THE STATE INCLUDING
HUMBOLDT COUNTY AS WELL AS
PLASTIC COUNTY.
THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU SO MUCH
SIR.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR TURN MEMBERS
KIDDING JOHN YU DURAN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE COUNCIL LABORS
AND SUPPORT.
WHICH GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS COMMITTEE
MARKEL IN SKI WITH THE CITY OF
ROSEVILLE AND FULL SUPPORT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANKS FOR BEING
HERE.
THANK YOU TO DO A LAST CALL FOR
THOSE IN SUPPORT.
AND C. NONE WE NOW THEY TO BE
TURNED OVER TO THOSE WHO WHO ARE
POST MISS WILL PROTECT KICKS OFF
I WOULD NHà MISTER CHAIRMAN
I'LL BE I'LL BE BRIEF CAPSULE A
DAVID WARFARE JARVIS TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION OPPOSED T. A. B..
FOURTEEN THIRTEEN MEMBERS IF FOR
AGGRESSIVE TAXES ARE GOING TO BE
AUTHORIZED AND PASSED.
IT NEED TO BE UNIFORM.
THEY NEED TO BE UNIFORM.
THIS WAS THE ISSUE WITH PLASTER
COUNTY THEY PUT A SALES TAX ON
THE BALLOT A FEW YEARS AGO AND
IT FAILED.
SO NOW WE'RE COMING BACK AND
WE'RE PICKING AND CHOOSING WHO
ARE VOTERS ARE.
WE ARE AUTHORIZING SALES TAX ON
A PORTION OF THE ELECTORATE.
AND THE UNIFORMITY MEMBERS
BEYOND THEIR AGGRESSIVE
AUTHORIZATION THAT I'VE
MENTIONED WITH OTHER BILLS TODAY
IT'S THE UNIFORMITY HERE THAT WE
HAVE THE BIGGEST ISSUE WITH FROM
BUSINESS COMPLIANCE STANDPOINT
WHICH IS WHY CAL TAXES ALSO
OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE.
AUTHORIZING SMALLER SALES TAXES
ACROSS REGIONS MAKE COMPLIANCE
VERY DIFFICULT SALES TAXES COULD
DIFFER ORDERLY FROM STREET TO
STREET HAVE A MEASURE LIKE THIS
IS TO GO THROUGH.
THE TAX DISPARITIES ARE HUGE
PROBLEM HERE IT IS GOING TO
IMPACT CONSUMER BEHAVIOR -- YOU
KNOW ESPECIALLY IN PLASTIC
COUNTY AND OTHER REGIONS SO FOR
THOSE REASONS BEYOND THE
REGRESSIVITY -- WOULD ASK FOR
NUMBER.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR TWELVE
FIFTEEN ANSWER FEET GIVES YOUR
FIRST LASSEN ORGANIZATION IN TWO
MINUTES THANKS FOR BEING HERE
OKAY GOOD AFTERNOON MY CARE
BEATING IN AN INDIVIDUAL.
SPARE IN THE PLASTER COUNTY.
LUCY POSE IT AS IT IS BECAUSE IF
IT PASSES IT WOULD THEY HAVE A
LIST NOW PROJECTS THEY WANT PUT
BACK ON INCLUDING THE THREE
MAJOR HIGHWAY CAPACITY.
INCREASING PROJECTS THAT THE
VOTERS DID NOT APPROVE THE SAME
THE THE FOR US.
BACK IN -- TWENTY SIXTEEN THIS
WOULD MEAN THE THE SALES
TAXPAYERS WILL BE PAYING UP
FRONT WITH HE'S IF HE'S LATER --
NOW THAT THE IT'S THERE ARE.
THERE I'VE HEARD OF PLACES WHERE
THIS COULD BE A VERY GOOD IN
THIS IMPORTANT IN THE SET
NECESSARY BILL.
THE QUESTION IS ARE THERE STATE
POLICY AREAS THAT WERE THIS
WOULD OPEN UP THE GATES AND WE
THINK THAT THAT IS INVOLVED SAY
WITH A A OR B. ISSUES IT WITH
THIS MASSIVE IN A DEVELOPMENT A
ENABLING.
THE ACTION HERE.
BUT ALSO IT IS HAPPEN SO SOON
AFTER THE RECENT THE FAILURE TO
PASS THAT THEY SPEND A MILLION
DOLLARS TRYING TO DEFEAT IT IT
DIDN'T WORK.
SO WE'LL COME BACK TO THE THE
CHANGING THE RULES AT THIS POINT --
WE THINK IT IS JUST IS NOT AN
ADVISABLE SO IT IS NOT ADVISABLE
SO -- WE HAVE A MAP TO SHOW THE
ISSUES AT A FOR ANYBODY
INTERESTED IN TO SHOW THEM THE
PROJECT LIST THAT WOULD BE BACK
ON NEXT YEAR.
WHICH WE THINK RAISES A NUMBER
STATE POLICY QUESTIONS AND WHAT
THIS WILL ENABLE.
IN OUR COUNTY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SIR GRATEFUL
YOU'RE HERE WERE IN HEAVY HANG
WITH US IN CASE WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS VERY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY WE'D LIKE TO GO TO SEE
IF THERE'S ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION IF YOU COULD PLEASE
COME FORTH THIS TIME.
HEARING SEEN NINE WOULD LIKE ME
TO BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE I
HAVE A COUPLE OF COMMENTS BUT
WOULD LIKE TO BE TO SEE IF WE
HAVE -- ANY FOLKS SAID MR VICE
CHAIR.
HAVE A CLEAR.
THESE ARE WISER -- ORANGE COUNTY
IS A SELF HELP.
DOWNEY FURRY TO TIRE COUNTY
MEASURE M. -- AND I IT IS JUST
SAID IT BILL SAYING HEY OF THE
THIRTY FOUR CITIES.
IF WE DID NOT HAVE SELF HELP WE
COULD SELECT THE CITIES THAT
[inaudible]
WOULD PARTICIPATE.
IN TRANSPORTATION IMPROVEMENTS.
AND THOSE WITH.
THEN BENEFIT FROM THAT SALES TAX
AND THE OTHERS WOULD NOT.
YES THE WAY THIS IS GOING TO BE
FOCUSES ON JUST TO COUNTIES IS
THE WAY THE BILL READS IS CAN BE
FOCUS ON SAN DIEGO COUNTY AND
PLASTER COUNTY.
AND WE WANTED TO INSURE SO JUST
BEING VERY CANDID AND AND DO
APPRECIATE.
THE MAYOR WORKING WITH US ON
THIS ISSUE.
IS THIS NUMBER ONE IS THAT WE
NEED TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE
CONTIGUOUS JURISDICTIONS.
SO WE CAN -- WHAT WOULD BE VERY
CHALLENGING IS IF WE'RE TAKING
SPECIFIC SUBDIVISIONS WITHIN AN
UNINCORPORATED AREA?
IN WHAT THE OPPOSITION WHEN THEY
POINTS WERE BROUGHT UP TO BE
ABLE TO FIGURE OUT WHO PAYS WHAT
LEVEL OF TAX WOULD BE A
CHALLENGE.
WHICH IS WHY WE SAID LET'S FOCUS
ON CONTIGUOUS CITIES SO MAKING
THIS UP.
THERE WOULD BE EIGHT CONTIGUOUS
CITIES WITHIN.
THE COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO.
THEY WOULD BE THE ONES THAT
WOULD ASSESS THEMSELVES FOR
TRANSPORTATION IMPROVEMENTS.
IT WOULD BE THE ONES THAT WOULD
ACTUALLY SEE THE BENEFIT SINCE
THEIR PAIN INTO TRANSPORTATION
IMPROVEMENT MEASURE.
OTHER REGIONS WERE NOT PART OF
THAT CONDUCTING TO U. S. FOCUS
AREA WOULD NOT.
I'M IN SAME THING WOULD BE GOING
FOR PLACER COUNTY SO IT WOULD BE
ONE CITY. FOR CONTINUOUS CITIES
LOCATED ACCOUNT.
I AND AT THIS TIME.
THIS BILL WOULD HAVE AUTHORIZED.
AUTHORIZING LANGUAGE JUST TO
COUNTIES SAN DIEGO PLASTER.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU TO SEE IF WE HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR
DO WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE FLOOR.
MOTION BY CENTER WE ARE MAYBE.
ALL RIGHT WE HAVE A AT WE HAVE A
MOTION.
BY AS A GOOD SENATOR RESERVE
CISCO.
THEN THERE WOULD YOU LIKE TO BE
A CLOSE PLEASE I JUST WANT TO
REITERATE MY APPRECIATION YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND YOUR STAFF FOR
HELPING US -- TO PULL THIS BILL
TOGETHER I'D APPRECIATE THAT
CONTINUED A CONVERSATION OVER
THE COURSE THE RECESS TO MAKE
SURE WE HAVE THIS PERFECT.
ASK FOR EVERY SENATOR FOR YOUR
SUPPORT ON THIS TICKET BILL WITH
ASKING ABOUT TAXING PEOPLE FOR
THE BENEFITS THAT THEY WILL
DIRECTLY RECEIVE I THINK IT'S
FAIRLY CONSERVATIVE FISCAL
RESPONSE -- PRINCIPLE -- IS
WORTHY OF EVERY MEMBER OF THIS
COMMITTEE SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE
FLOOR -- THAT MOTIONS BY CENTER
WINNER THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE FLOOR WE THINK
THEY ARE FOLKS WHO ARE HERE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
THOSE WHO ARE IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
MISSING JUST A ROLL CALL PLEASE.
HI.
I'M MORE ALONG [inaudible]
BELL.
HELLO.
NIELSEN.
NIELSEN NO WINNER WIENER ON
TWENTY TWO IS A TWO ONE VOTE.
WE ARE GOING TO KEEP THE ROLE
OPEN.
I SAVED A BIT WE HAVE TO
ADDITIONAL BILLS TO ADDITIONAL
BILLS AND THAT IS IS A MEMBER
GRAYSON THANK YOU SO MUCH. TO
THE MEMBER GRAYSON WORKING WITH
US WE HAVE TWO BILLS IN FRONT OF
THIS ITEM SIXTEEN AB.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY THREE ITEM.
SEVENTEEN AB.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY FOUR ITEMS.
SIXTEEN WE SEE IS RECEIVING
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IS A MEMBER.
AND THEN ITEM SEVENTEEN IS ALSO
RECEIVING BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
WE'RE GONNA ASK FOR A TRUNCATED
VERSION.
OF YOU PRESENTATIONS ONE TAKE A
MOMENT TO SAY.
HEY THERE WE GO WE'LL TAKE A
LONGER SAY THINK IT IS IN THE
MEMBER -- IF HE HAS BEEN VERY
FOCUSED IN THE SPACE OF HOUSING
AND AFFORDABLE HOUSING -- IN HIS
WORK WITH THE COMMITTEE ON ITEM
SIXTEEN EXTENSIVELY ON TAKE A
MOMENT TO ACKNOWLEDGE YOURSELF
YOUR INCREDIBLE TEAM THE FLOOR
IS YOURS SIR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AND I'M PLEASED TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN
EIGHTY THREE MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU TO YOU AND COMMITTEE STAFF --
FOR BEING SO WORKABLE AND
ACTUALLY HELPING BUILD A VERY --
A VERY STRONG BILL.
AND SO I WANT TO BE VERY CLEAR
IT'S NOT MY INTENTION TO MAKE
DATA COLLECTION SO BURDENSOME
THAT IT DETRACTS FROM THE MAIN
JOB OF PLANNING DEPARTMENTS AND
THAT'S ACTUALLY APPROVING
HOUSING.
SO THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS THAT
HAVE BEEN RECEIVED -- SEEK TO
ADDRESS A RANGE OF CONCERNS
RAISED BY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND
PLANNING EXPERTS BY ENSURING
THAT THAT DATA -- THAT WE ARE
COLLECTING IS BOTH VALUABLE TO
POLICY MAKERS AND ALSO READILY
AVAILABLE TO THE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS SO I'M HAPPY TO
ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS AND I
BELIEVE THAT THEY DO MAKE THIS
BILL A MUCH BETTER BILL AND MORE
EFFECTIVE BILL.
AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY THREE WILL
SUPPORT THIS MISSION FOR WAYS.
IT WILL REQUIRE THE COLLECTION
OF ADDITIONAL HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT PIPELINE DATA
INCLUDING THE TIMELINE FOR
APPLICATION APPROVAL WHETHER THE
PROJECT WAS EXEMPT FROM IN MY
OUR ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW VIA
SEAQUEST.
AND WHETHER THE PROJECT RECEIVE
MISTER APPROVAL IT WILL ALSO
REQUIRE CITIES AND COUNTIES TO
TRANSPARENTLY REPORT ON FEES AND
EXACTIONS.
IT REQUIRES A CD TO IMPLEMENT A
COMPREHENSIVE DATA STRATEGY AND
THEN ALSO FINALLY IT WILL
FACILITATE THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
A STATEWIDE GIS PARCEL DATA BASE.
WITH THAT I DO HAVE WITNESSES
WITH ME TODAY THAT I WILL ASK.
PERMISSION TO SELF INTRODUCE
THANK YOU SO MUCH IN AS A MEMBER
WE HAVE A ROOM FOR TWO WITNESSES
TWO MINUTES PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
THE TERM ACQUIRE AND MEMBERS I
LOSE MY DAY WITH CALIFORNIA BE
HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB --
FOURTEEN EIGHTY THREE OUR
MEMBERS WORK ACROSS THE STATE TO
HELP -- CITIES AND AND AND AND
OTHER GOVERNMENTS IMPROVE THEIR
HOUSING -- POLICIES THEY
ADVOCATE FOR HOUSING IN LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND OFTEN RELY ON
THE DATA THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
HAVE -- TO DO THAT AB FOURTEEN
EIGHTY THREE IS A GOOD -- GOOD
GOVERNMENT HOPING GOVERNMENT A
BILL THAT WILL HELP THEM DO
THEIR JOB DO YOU DO THEIR
VOLUNTEER WORK AND HELP THEM
MAKE THEIR NEIGHBORHOODS MORE
WELCOMING TWO NEW NEIGHBORS. FOR
THAT REASON WE'RE IN STRONG
SUPPORT TODAY THANK YOU SO MUCH
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS MY
NAME IS INJURED BECAUSE IT ARE
AND I AM THE SCIENTIST AND
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION.
CBA IS PLEASED TO SPONSOR AB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY THREE A BILL
THAT WOULD BRING TRANSPARENCY TO
FEES SPECIAL TAXES AND PROPERTY
ASSESSMENTS ASSOCIATED WITH
HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS.
BY POSTING THIS INFORMATION
PUBLICLY ACADEMICS CN STUDY THE
CORRELATION BETWEEN FEES TAXES
AND HOMEBUILDING.
CITIES CAN COMPARE THEIR FEES
AND HOMEBUILDING TO THEIR PEERS
ELECTED OFFICIALS CAN MAKE MORE
INFORMED DECISIONS IN A
DISCUSSION ABOUT HOUSING
CONSTRUCTION CAN BE HAD BASED
UPON CLEAR DATA.
IN ESSENCE FOURTEEN EIGHTY THREE
HELPS TO COOLEY VELVET VALUABLE
DATA IN ORDER TO BRING CLARITY
TO THE HOUSING CONSTRUCTION AND
THE ASSOCIATED FEES TAXES AND
PROPERTY ASSESSMENTS FOR THESE
REASONS RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
I'VE OF THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MA'AM IS THERE A AND SOME
COMMENTS BRIEFLY PLEASE YES. FOR
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR A GREAT FOR YOU HERE.
SYLVIA FROM BEHALF OF FACEBOOK
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH
[inaudible]
EVANS BACK.
AARON EVANS ON BEHALF OF HABITAT
FOR HUMANITY TMG PARTNERS AND
THE NONPROFIT HOUSING
ASSOCIATION OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT THANK YOU
SO MUCH WEARING A WHITE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING CONSORTIUM IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
PATTERSON OIL BEHALF OF THE
SILICON VALLEY COMMUNITY
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH TODAY THE BAY AREA
HOUSING AT SIXTY COALITION IN
SUPPORT.
BACK IN MARKETS REPRESENTING
LEADING AGE CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
I DON'T SEE MY SETTLES BERRY
COUNCIL IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU WITH X. RAY TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT
IF YOU COULD PLEASE COME FORWARD.
LAST CALL NOW GONNA MOVE TO
OPPOSITION ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
IF YOU COULD PLEASE COME FORWARD.
HEARING SEEING NO OPPOSITION
WITH A TO BRING IT TO COMMITTEE.
IF YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR DO WE HAVE A MOTION.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY THE VICE
CHAIR THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
VICE CHAIR.
DELIVER WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
I SIMPLY WANT TO THANK EACH AND
EVERYONE OF YOU ESPECIALLY --
MISTER CHAIR AND YOUR STAFF
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
WORK ON THIS AS WELL AS WORKING
WITH STAKEHOLDERS I LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING DIALOGUE AND
WORKING WITH THE MEMBERS.
AND STAFF AS WE MOVE THIS BILL
FORWARD I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
NIGHT.
AND JONASSON NUMBER THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH IN TOWN
FOR ALL OF HIS WORK ON MANY MANY
BILLS IN ON THIS ONE IS WELL --
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO PREPARATIONS A MOTION WAS
MADE BY THE VICE CHAIR
DISINTEREST RICKY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL THE FLYER HI WHY I'M
MORE LONG.
MORE LIKE GOD BEL BIRDS BURKE
RICARDO NIELSEN.
NIELSEN NINE WIENER.
ENJOY THE THREE ZERO VOTE ORGAN
KEEP THAT ROLE THANK YOU SO MUCH
THE MEMBERS THIS IS THE SECOND
OF OUR DOUBLE HEADER OF THE
GRAYSON SHOW WE HAVE ITEM
SEVENTEEN AB.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY FOUR FOCUSING ON
MITIGATION FEES INTO THE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS MR SO MANY OF
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHURCH
SENATORS LET ME -- BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING THE TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS PROPOSED BY THE
COMMITTEE.
ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN EIGHTY
FOUR REQUIRES LOCAL AGENCIES TO
POST AND LIST ALL FEES THAT THEY
LEVY ON HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
PROJECTS ON THEIR WEBSITES.
ALTHOUGH THIS CHANGE IS IN LAW
IS VALUE IN ITSELF.
THE BILL ALSO SERVES ANOTHER
PURPOSE IT WILL ACT AS A VEHICLE
TO IMPLEMENT THE RECOMMENDATIONS
OF AN EIGHT CITY REPORT.
ON THE IMPACT OF FEES ON HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT IN CALIFORNIA IF THE
ADMINISTRATION RELEASES THE
REPORT BEFORE THE END OF SESSION
AND INCLUDES RECOMMENDATIONS
THAT WE WANT TO PURSUE WE WILL
AMEND THE BILL IN THE ON THE
SENATE FLOOR.
I AM MAKING -- THE COMMITMENT.
TO THE COMMITTEE TODAY THAT WE
WILL HOLD A GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE COMMITTEE MEETING ALL UP
OFF OF THE FLOOR PRIOR TO TAKING
THIS BILL UP.
OF BEFORE THE FULL SENATE I WANT
TO THANK THE CHAIR FOR HIS
ENGAGEMENT ON THIS ISSUE AND
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE
DISCUSSIONS ON THIS TOPIC.
AND I DO HAVE WITNESSES WITH ME
AS WELL TO SELF INTRODUCE IF YOU
SO DESIRE THANK YOU SO MUCH TO
MEMBER LOOK AT THIS AND THAT WAS
REALLY TRYING TO WORK HARD ON
THIS ISSUE.
WAITING FOR THE THE REPORT.
GRATEFUL THAT HE'S WILLING TO BE
A TO WORK WITH MYSELF IN THE
VICE CHAIR TO BE TO BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE WE APPRECIATE
THAT COMMITMENT WILL TURN IT
OVER TO THE WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT FOR SOME LASSEN
ORGANIZATION.
INJURED BECAUSE IT OUR CPA CGA
IS PLEASED TO CO SPONSOR AB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY FOUR BY THE
HONORABLE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON  BILL TO REQUIRE CITIES
AND COUNTIES IN AS IS IMPRINT
REQUIRE CITIES AND COUNTIES TO
POST ON THE INTERNET THE TYPE
AND AMOUNT OF DEVELOPER FEES
IMPOSED ON HOUSING.
DEVELOPMENT WE THINK THAT IS
HELPFUL MANY LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
DO NOT PUBLISH FEES OR PROVIDE
ESTIMATES OF THOSE FEES AND THE
EFFECT OF THESE FEES ON HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT IT'S HARD TO
OVERSTATE.
SO AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY FOUR SIX
ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM A BRING A
LEVEL OF TRANSPARENCY TO THE
PROCESS FOR THIS REASON
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR IPHONE.
YEAH IT TO BOTH YOU FOR HANGING
HERE PLEASE FOR SURE IT'S GOOD
TO SEE IT LIKE EVERITT WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS PROUD TO BE A CO
SPONSOR OF THIS BILL AS WELL AND
IN THE INTEREST OF TIME ALL WITH
HOLD MY COMMENTS AND PLEASE ASK
FOR YOUR AYE.
VOTE NO IT'S GOOD THANK YOU SO
MUCH REMAIN WITH THE FOR THE
COMMON SKIN IS WILL.
WE SEE THAT REPORT WILL BECOME
BACK TO COMMITTEE SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR BEING HERE THANK
YOU.
WELCOME BACK.
HAVE A FACEBOOK IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
WELL IS HERE MADISON BY ON
BEHALF OF SILICON VALLEY
COMMUNITY FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
BY DAVID BERRY HOUSING ADVOCACY
COALITION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
KAREN EVANS ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIAN BE HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY THE NONPROFIT
ASSOCIATION OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA SILICON VALLEY AT
HOME AND TMZ PARTNERS.
ALL OVER TO GET THAT WORK IN
RIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH YOU KNOW
ONE OF THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
CONSORTIUM IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
YOU MIGHT SEE SANDERS BERRY
COUNSEL AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
WHERE DO A LAST CALL FOR SUPPORT?
HEARING SEEN NINE ANOTHER TURN
OVER TO THOSE WHO MAY BE OPPOSE
FOR LOOKING PROPOSITION.
HEARING SEE NO OPPOSITION WOULD
LIKE TO RETURN IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE.
IF WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS AS VICE CHAIR.
REMEMBER GRAYSON I'M REMINDED OF
THE PHRASE BE CAREFUL WHAT YOU
WISH.
FOR I'M JUST WONDERING IF -- THE
DATA THAT'S GOING TO BE.
THIS CLOSE IS GOING TO BE A REAL
SH STICKER SHOCK OPPORTUNE.
THAT REMAINS TO BE SEEN WE LOOK
FORWARD -- WE DO LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING THE REPORT IN FULL AND
THE INFORMATION WE CAN GLEAN
FROM THAT.
THAT WE BELIEVE MAY VERY WELL
HELP US IN ADDRESSING.
OF PORTIONS OF THE HOUSING
CRISIS THAT WE'RE FACING IN
CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU FOR THAT OBSERVATION --
THANK YOU SO MUCH DO WE HAVE A
MOTION ON FROM ANY THE MEMBERS
TO BE ABLE TO ADVANCE.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY THE GOOD
CENTER FROM TURN CISCO MISTER
WINNER.
YOUR CINNAMON WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE THIS BY PRESS WHENEVER
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH WE
LOOK FOR TO SEE YOU BACK HERE --
IN AUGUST EARLY SEPTEMBER THE
SAME CHESTER THE MOTION IS TO
PASS IS A MINUTE APPROPRIATIONS
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
REQUIRE REQUIRE I'M MORE LONG
MORE LIKE AYE BELL -- RICARDO
NIELSEN HI NIELSEN AYE WIENER
WIENER.
CURRENTLY ENJOYS A FOUR ZERO
VOTE THANKS SO MUCH OF GIVE THE
ROLE OPEN.
LADIES AND GENTLEMAN MORE TIME
WE WILL BE SEEN YEAH AS SOON IS
INSURANCE.
ADJOURNMENTS IF YOU LIKE ME TO
STAY FOR THE SHOW INSURANCE -- I
KNOW CENTER MORE LOCK WILL --
HE'S VERY EXCITED ABOUT IT.
MY RIGHT WAS A VICE CHAIR.
YEAH I KNOW HOW WITH YES.
WE WILL SEE YOU IMMEDIATELY
FOLLOWING THE INSURANCE.
SAME ROOM THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WE'RE IN RECESS
IN THE ROOM THAT ALREADY ASKING
ME TO GET MOVING [inaudible]
BUT A BECAUSE REMEMBER STONE IS
SO PUSHY I'M GONNA ASK.
ASSEMBLY WOMAN KILEY PETRIE
NORRIS TO COME FIRST.
NO NO NO.
NO I'M I'M RUNNING THE SHOW NOW.
AND AND YOUR WITNESS HAS TO
CATCH A PLANE IS THAT CORRECT.
LET THE RECORD SHOW LET THE
RECORD SHOW THAT I TRIED.
WELCOME RATIO ME WOMAN LAYS.
ALL RIGHT.
I THANK YOU HAVE A BI PARTISAN
SUPPORT.
YES.
THANK YOU SENATOR AT FIRST I AM
PLEASED TO ACCEPT ALL COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AS DETAILED N THE
ANALYSIS.
ORANGE COUNTY LIKE MUCH OF OUR
STATE MASTER FIRST FIRE WATER
PORTFOLIO IN ORDER TO PREPARE
FOR NEXT ROUTE.
AND TO LESSEN OUR DEPENDENCE ON
IMPORTED WATER IN OANGE COUNTY
IN PORT AN IMPORTANT PIECE OF
THIS PUZZLE IS THE SOUTH COAST
WATER DISTRICTS TO HIM THE OCEAN
DESALINATION PLANTS.
THE PROJECTS A WIN WIN AND MY
BILL AB SEVENTEEN FIFTY TWO WILL
ENABLE US TO BRING IT TO
FRUITION.
CURRENT STATUTORY AUTHORITY TO
PROCEED IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA EXPIRES ON
DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST.
TWENTY NINETEEN AB SEVENTEEN
FIFTY TWO WILL EXTEND THE
STATUTORY TIMELINE IN ABLE TO
ENSURE THE STATE AT FINING AND
COMPLETION OF THE PROJECT.
PLEASE TO HAVE WITH ME TODAY
RICK CAN TALK TO THE GENERAL
MANAGER OF THE SOUTH COAST WATER
DISTRICT WILL PROVIDE SOME
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION AND
ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE.
ABOUT THE PROJECT [inaudible]
RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR ALLOWING
ME TO SPEAK TODAY WITH ME TODAY
IS OUR BOARD PRESIDENT BILL
GREEN SPECTER.
AS ASSEMBLY WOMAN PETRIE-NORRIS
INDICATED THE DOUBLE MEANING
OCEAN D. CELL PROJECT WILL BE A
DISTRICT OWNED.
ENVIRONMENTALLY RESPONSIBLE
DROUGHT PROOF WATER SUPPLY
PROJECT.
THE PROJECT WOULD SERVE THE
SOUTH COAST WATER DISTRICT AND
INTERESTED PARTNERS IN SOUTH
ORANGE COUNTY.
AN AREA THAT'S ROUGHLY 90%
DEPENDENT ON IMPORTED WATER FROM
THE METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT
OF CAL OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
FURTHERMORE THE PROJECT WOULD
PROVIDE A CONTINUOUS EMERGENCY
WATER SUPPLY DURING AN
EARTHQUAKE.
IN AN EARTHQUAKE INDUCED
IMPORTED WATER OUTAGE AND COULD
PROVIDE THE MUCH NEEDED FIRE
FLOWS AFTER THAT OUTAGE.
ON THE WILDLAND FIRE FRINGES THE
WILD LAND FRINGES IN SOUTH
ORANGE COUNTY.
THE PROJECT ALSO PROVIDES AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR REGIONAL WATER
SOLUTION REDUCING DEPENDENCE ON
THE STATE WATER PROJECT AND THE
COLORADO RIVER ACCIDENT.
THE SLANT WILL TECHNOLOGY AND A
CO MINGLED BRINE WASTEWATER
DISCHARGE COMPONENTS ARE
CONSISTENT WITH THE OCEAN PLAN
AND ARE ACTUALLY THE PREFERRED
REGULATORY AND ENVIRONMENTAL
APPROACH.
THROUGH THIS BILL WE'RE MAKING
SIX A SIGNIFICANT COMMITMENT
THAT CALIFORNIA ORGANIZED LABOR
IS INVOLVED IN THIS CONSTRUCTION.
WE WILL HAVE A PROJECT LABOR
AGREEMENT AND PREVAILING WAGES
WILL BE PAID.
ODJICK HAS RECEIVED BROAD
SUPPORT BY THE LABOR AND
ENVIRONMENTAL COMMUNITY.
OUR BOARD OF DIRECTORS CERTIFIED
THE E. I. R. ON JUNE TWENTY
SEVEN TWENTY NINETEEN AND WE ARE
STARTING THE PERMITTING AND
CONTRACTED ELEMENT PROCESS.
WITHOUT THIS SPECIAL LEGISLATION
WE WILL LOSE OPPORTUNITY AND
ABILITY. TO DELIVER THE PROJECT
AS A DESIGN BUILD OPERATE OR THE
OPERATOR IS THOROUGHLY INVOLVED
IN THE PROCESS DESIGNED TO
ENSURE IT ALL WORKS AT THE END
OF THE DAY.
WITHOUT THIS SPECIAL LEGISLATION
THE PROJECT WOULD BE A
TRADITIONAL DESIGN BUILD BUILD.
A PROJECT DELIVERY THAT WOULD
RESULT IN UNNECESSARY CHALLENGES
AND RISKS.
DUE TO THE COMPLEXITIES OF THE
SLANT WELL AND THE OCEAN WATER
TREATMENT PROCESS.
LASTLY WE ARE AND OUR REGION
HAVE BEEN AFFORDABILITY CEILING
FOR THIS PROJECT.
IF WE LOSE THE STATE GRANTS AND
LOANS WE WILL LIKELY EXCEED THIS
AFFORDABILITY CEILING WHICH
COULD LEAD TO THE LOSS OF
POTENTIAL PARTNER WATER AGENCIES.
AND MOST SIGNIFICANTLY A
DECISION TO NOT MOVE FORWARD.
WITH THE PROJECT BY OUR BOARD OF
DIRECTORS.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
SUPPORT.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN THE
AUDIENCE THAT WOULD LIKE. TO FOR
THE BILL.
YES MY IS BILL GREEN I'M ALSO ON
THE EXECUTIVE COMMITTEE FOR THE
INDEPENDENCE PERSONAL DISTRICTS
OF ORANGE COUNTY.
AS WELL AS A OF FELLOW MEMBER OF
THE ACC AMERICAN COUNCIL
INTERNET COMPANIES AND WE
SUPPORT THE PROJECT.
COMING OUT MISTER GREEN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE JEREMY SMITH
HERE BEHALF OF THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL.
IF TWO OR SOME OF THESE THESE ON
ASIAN FACILITIES THEY ARE HIGHLY
COMPLICATED HIGHLY TECHNICAL --
PLACES.
TO CREATE MAKE WATER THEY
REQUIRE A SKILLED AND TRAINED
WORKFORCE TO BE COMPLETED
PROPERLY AND ON TIME WE ARE ARE
PLEASED TO SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY THANK YOU.
YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THERE BE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
BEING.
NINE THE WOMAN WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR BEING HERE
TODAY THANK YOU I TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR LETTING US PRESENT
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I'VE
IT.
WILL HOLD UP THE VOTE UNTIL THE
CHAIR ARRIVES.
I I THOUGHT IT WOULD BE EASIER
TO ASK FOR FORGIVENESS THAN
PERMISSION -- BECAUSE I KNOW
YOU'RE WITNESSES HAD TO CATCH A
FLIGHT SO THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR PER SHIP THAT.
WOMEN.
THANK YOU FOR LETTING ME GET IN
TROUBLE.
WHEN YOUR BOSS AROUND?
IF YOU
.
MOVE THE TABLE
GOOD AFTERNOON AND I DO
APOLOGIZE -- IT HAD A BITTER
KERFUFFLE IN A GEO IN ASSEMBLY.
BUT GRATEFUL TO BE WITH ALL OF
YOU AND WE'RE GOING TO TURN IT
OVER TO ITEM -- TURN OVER SOME
NUMBER STONE ITEM NUMBER
THIRTEEN AB.
TWELVE SEVENTY AND EVEN IN THE
IN COMMITTEE THOUGH SO WE'RE
GONNA HAVE YET.
THIS IS IN THE MONEY COME ON UP
AND WE'RE GONNA.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SIR
APPRECIATE YOUR WORK WITH THE
COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU.
PLEASE FOR STARTERS I APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY. TO PRESEN AB
TALL SEVENTY AND FIRST I'D LIKE
TO THANK YOUR COMMITTEE STAFFER
WORKING AS WITH US THROUGH THIS
BILL AND CONFIRM THAT THAT THEY
COMMITTEE MEN IT'S REGARDING THE
INCLUSION OF GROSS RECEIPTS THAT
DEFINITION.
HAPPY TO TAKE THAT AND THE
CLARIFICATIONS THAT THIS BILL
WILL NOT BE APPLIED
RETROACTIVELY THAT WAS NEVER THE
INTENT AND SO PUTTING IN SOME
LANGUAGE TO MAKE SURE THAT IT'S
NOT BEING APPLIED RETROACTIVELY
IS ABSOLUTELY FINE.
SO WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS IS
APPLYING.
FALSE CLAIM STANDARD. TO TAX
DISPUTES THE THERE'S THERE'S A
TAX GAP IT'S BEEN ESTIMATED
ANYWHERE FROM TWENTY FIVE TWENTY
BILLION TO TO TWENTY FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS.
AND WHAT I MEAN BY TAX GAP IS
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN TAXES
OWED.
AND TAXES COLLECTED THAT
NORMALLY THE TAXING ENTITIES DO
A LOT OF THAT WORKING GO AFTER
TAX SCOFFLAWS BUT THERE ARE
CASES.
WHERE AND USING THE FALSE CLAIMS
ACT THAT THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
THROUGH WHISTLEBLOWER STATUTES?
GOES AFTER THOUGH THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO -- LARGE AMOUNTS
OF TAX DOLLARS THAT HAVE NOT
PAID THEM THAT'S REALLY WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO HERE.
IS MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
STRENGTHENING THE BOTH CLAIMS
ACT TO PROTECT WHISTLEBLOWERS.
GIVE THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
APPROPRIATE TOOLS AND MAKE SURE
THAT THEY GO AFTER TAX SCOFFLAWS.
THAT'S WHAT THE BILL IS THAT AND
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE I DO HAVE SOME
MEMBERS OF THE TURNING GENERAL'S
OFFICE HERE. TO GET SOME
TESTIMONY AND ALSO BE PART OF
ANSWERING QUESTIONS AND SHOULD
YOU HAVE ANY ABOUT WHAT WE'RE
DOING AND HOW THAT WORKS THANK
YOU SO MUCH SOME EVER WE WELCOME
OUR WITNESSES IF YOU COULD
PLEASE GIVE US YOUR FIRST LAST
AND AS WELL AS ORGANIZATION
TITLE PLEASE.
IN TWO MINUTES.
HI I'M ANTHONY LIAM A
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE WITH THE
EIGHTIES OFFICE AND WHERE.
THEY TEASE PLEASE THE SPONSOR AB
TWELVE SEVENTEEN IT'S AN
IMPORTANT MEASURE TO PROTECT
PUBLIC DOLLARS IN COMBAT FRAUD
AGAINST THE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS.
WHEN A THING THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER STONE FOR HIS LEADERSHIP
ON THIS ISSUE?
ECHO HIS COMMITMENT TO CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION AND
SOME OF THE REMAINING CONCERNS.
AND WE APPRECIATE THE EFFORTS OF
THE COMMITTEE STAFF AND
OPPONENTS OVER THE LAST WEEK --
THAT ALLOWED US TO MAKE PROGRESS --
AND WE'RE HOPEFUL THAT WE'LL BE
ABLE TO COME TOGETHER -- ON THE
REMAINING ISSUES AS THE BILL
GOES FRWARD AN ATTENDANT OVER
NOW TO MORE AND GO YET. THIRTEEN
ANSWER IF YOU COULD PLEASE
INTRODUCE YOURSELF TWO MINUTES.
GOOD AFTERNOON MARTIN GORE YET
SENIOR ASSISTANT ATTORNEY
GENERAL WITH THE CALIFORNIA AG'S
OFFICE I KNOW I LEAD THE FALSE
CLAIMS UNIT IN OFFICE.
AND WE SUPPORT THIS LEGISLATION
TO STRENGTHEN OUR ABILITY. TO A
COMBAT TAX FRAUD.
IS A FALSE CLAIMS LAW PROVIDES
SOME UNIQUE PROVISIONS THERE
WILL MOTOR VICE WHISTLEBLOWERS
KNOW COUNCILS BRING CASES.
OF VIEW INFORMATION THAT WE
OTHERWISE WOULD NOT HAVE KNOWN
ABOUT IT EVIDENCE SO WE
OTHERWISE DON'T GET.
THE FALSE CLAIMS LAW ALREADY
ALLOWS THESE KIND OF CASES IN
OTHER IN ALL OTHER AREAS.
IT'S BEEN VERY PRODUCTIVE.
OUR UNIT HAS RECOVERED ABOUT A
BILLION AND A HALF DOLLARS FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND I SHOULD ADD THAT WOULD
COMPLETELY SELF FUNDED.
OUT OF THE RECOVERY **** WE
OBTAIN WE'VE BEEN VERY
SUCCESSFUL SO FAR.
I WOULD LIKE TO EXTEND THIS TO
THE TAX AREA -- IN WITH THAT.
I HAVE BEEN ENTERING QUESTIONS
THANK YOU SO MUCH YOU'RE READY
FOR ALL THREE OF YOU HERE WE'RE
GOING TO TURN OVER TO ANYONE
ELSE WHO MAY BE IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL IF YOU COULD PLEASE
COME FORTH THIS TIME PERSON
LASSEN ORGANIZATION.
LAST CALL FOR SUPPORT WE'RE NOT
GONNA WELCOME ALL THOSE WHO MAY
BE IN OPPOSITION. FIVE TWO
PRIMARY WITNESSES TWO MINUTES
EACH WE WELCOME THE GENTLEMAN TO
COME FORWARD.
WOULD LIKE TO GET A KICKS OFF
[inaudible]
RIGHT.
HEY THERE WE GO WELCOME TO
COMMITTEE SIR FLOOR SOURCE TWO
MINUTES THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MIKE BELOW IT ON BEHALF
THE CIVIL JUSTICE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA -- MISTER LEWIS
CORRECT WE'VE HAD PRODUCTIVE
DISCUSSIONS WE HAVE NARROWED THE
ISSUES WE'VE KICKED AROUND
SOLUTIONS.
AND SO HE IS ABSOLUTELY CORRECT
THIS IS A WEIGHTY BUILT THIS
INVOLVES A MAJOR POLICY CHANGE
IN THE LAW.
THE FALSE CLAIMS ACT IN
CALIFORNA WAS CREATED IN THE
EIGHTIES IT HAS NEVER BEEN
APPLIED TO TAX DISPUTES.
BEFORE AND THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
ISSUES RAISED BY THIS -- WELL
LAID OUT IN THE ANALYSIS BY THE
WAY -- THE FALSE CLAIMS ACT IS A
MAJOR GOVERNMENTAL TOOL TO
COMBAT CORRUPTION.
IT IS MAJOR BECAUSE OF THE POWER
INVESTED IN THE GOVERNMENT -- WE
HAVE TROUBLE DAMAGES SO THE
THRESHOLDS IN THE BILL ARE.
GROSS OR NET INCOME OF FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND FOR THE
TAXPAYER AND A TAX DISPUTE OF
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS. TO
CONVERT A GARDEN VARIETY TAX
DISPUTE INTO A FALSE CLAIMS ACT
IS A VIOLATION IS A BIG PROBLEM.
IF YOU HAVE A CREDIBLE BASIS FOR
YOUR POSITION BUT LOSE YOU WILL
BE RESPONSIBLE FOR THE TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS THAT
THE GOVERNMENT HAS BEEN SHORTED
IN A TAXES.
PLUS TREBLE DAMAGES THAT'S
ANOTHER SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND
YOUR NOW 280-010-00 DOLLARS PLUS
ATTORNEY'S FEES AND THERE IS A
REFERENCE NOW TO DAMAGES
INCLUDING CONSEQUENTIAL DAMAGES
I DON'T KNOW WHAT CONSEQUENTIAL
DAMAGES MIGHT BE IN A TAX CASE.
BUT THERE ARE OTHER ISSUES THAT
WE ARE WORKING THROUGH AGAIN
PRODUCTIVELY -- WITH THE AUTHOR
AND SPONSOR INCLUDING THE RIGHT
OF THE GOVERNMENT ENTITIES TO
USE PRIVATE COUNSEL.
WHICH CHANGES THE CHARACTER OF
THE TAX DISPUTE IT IS NO LONGER
THE NEUTRAL TAX COLLECTION
AGENCY OF THE GOVERNMENT YOU NOW
HAVE A PERSON OR LAWYER WITH A
PROFIT MOTIVE.
AND WE HAVE THE ABILITY TO BRING
QUI TAM ACTIONS.
OF WHERE YOU -- A PRIVATE
CITIZEN CAN BRING THE ACTION --
ALLEGING A VIOLATION SO THERE
ARE VERY VERY SIGNIFICANT
CHANGES IN THE LAW HERE AND IT
HAS TO BE DONE RIGHT I KNOW MR
MCHALE AND OTHERS HAVE OTHER
ISSUES THEY'D LIKE TO TALK ABOUT
BUT WE ARE WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR.
ON AND THE AND THE COMMITTEE
STAFF ON PREVENTING A GARDEN
VARIETY TAX DISPUTE WHERE THE
PERSON HAS SUBSTANTIAL AUTHORITY
FOR THEIR POSITION.
ADVERTING THAT INTO A FALSE
CLAIMS ACT WE IS SIMPLY PUT TOO
MUCH POWER IN THE HANDS OF THE
GOVERNMENT TO PUT THEIR THUMB ON
THE SCALE HERE.
SO WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THANK YOU SO MUCH AS
WHAT REGRET FROM SOME KELLY GOOD
AFTERNOON.
YES -- MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS A
CHRIS MAKAYLA ON BEHALFOF THE
COMPUTING TECHNOLOGY INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION AND JUST BRIEFLY I
WANT TO PUBLICLY STATE -- AS I
DID PRIVATELY THAT WERE
APOLOGETIC TO THE AUTHOR OF THE
MEASURE FOR COMING IN LATE.
IN OUR OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
A COUPLE OF THINGS THE FIRST IS
WE KNOW THAT THIS IS PATTERNED
AFTER A NEW YORK AND PERHAPS
ILLINOIS STATUTES -- OTHER THAN
THE ONE SUBSTANTIAL CASE CITED
IN YOUR ANALYSIS.
UNCLEAR AS TO HOW EFFECTIVE OR
WHAT ITS UTILIZATION IN NEW
YORKER ILLINOIS HAVE BEEN.
THERE'S BEEN SOME PRESS STORIES
IN THE ABOUT THE ILLINOIS
STATUTE THAT SEEM HIGHLY
CRITICAL OF IT.
CALIFORNIA TAXI GIN SIS DO HAVE
A A WHISTLEBLOWER PROGRAM IN OUR
INITIAL THOUGHT IS WHETHER OR
NOT THE STATE OUGHT TO CONSIDER
FUNDING -- THE STATE'S WAS
ABROAD PROGRAM WITH THE TO TAX
GENCIES AS YOU'RE PROBABLY
AWARE THE TAX AGENCY'S THIS CD
TFA NOW ON THE FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD HAVE A SUBSTANTIAL NUMBER
OF TOOLS IN THE PROVERBIAL TOOL
BOX. TO INSURE TAXPAYER
COMPLIANCE WITH OUR TAX LAWS AND
OF COURSE WE HAVE A PLACE SYSTEM
HERE MEANING THAT YOU HAVE TO
PAY THE DISPUTED TAXES FILE A
CLAIM FOR REFUND.
AND THEN LITIGATE FIRST
ADMINISTRATIVELY AND THEN
JUDICIALLY -- YOUR TAX DISPUTE --
I KNOW THAT THE PROPONENTS HAD
MADE SOME STATEMENTS ABOUT AN
OPPORTUNITY TO COLLECT MORE
TAXES BECAUSE THEY'VE BEEN
SUCCESSFUL WITH OTHER SCA CLAIMS.
HOWEVER YOUR ANALYSIS KNOWS THAT
THE F. T. B. DOES NOT ANTICIPATE
ANY REVENUE ASSOCIATED WITH THE
BILL SO I'M UNSURE HOW -- TO
COUPLED WITH THOSE TO COINCIDE
IF AT ALL.
NOW TURNING TO THE LANGUAGE WE
HAVE SEEN SOME DRAFT AMENDMENTS
WHICH WE APPRECIATE FROM THE
AUTHOR IN THE COMMITTEE STAFF.
TO PUT SOME SIDE BOARDS ON IT I
JUST LIKE TO RAISE A FEW OTHER
ISSUES ON THE LANGUAGE FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. ONE IS PERHAPS
REQUIRING MORE THAN CONSULTATION
WITH THE STATE AGENCIES BY THE
AG OR THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
THE TAX AGENCIES DESPITE SURE
SOMETIMES MY CRITICISMS OF THEM
DO HAVE VERY KNOWLEDGEABLE TAX
COUNSEL -- WHICH MAY OR MAY NOT
EXIST IN THE AG'S OFFICE OR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS SO PERHAPS WE
MIGHT WANT.
TO HAVE SOMETHING MORE THAN JUST
CONSULTATION.
THE DEFINITIONS OF MATERIAL
ALLAH T. AND THE ADDITION OF
CONSEQUENCE ALL DAMAGES WHETHER
YOU THINK IT'S A PROPER
CODIFICATION OR NOT.
WE DO HAVE SOME CONCERN THAT --
SECTION FOR THE BILL NOTES THAT
THEY ARE DECLARATORY OF EXISTING
LAW WE USUALLY DO THAT TO IMPACT
PENDING LITIGATION AND I WOULD
LEAST INQUIRE OF THE COMMITTEE.
THE NECESSITY OF DOING SO IS
MISTER BELOW MENTION THE
DEFINITION OF PROSECUTING
AUTHORITY.
IN THE FIRST SECTION OF THE
FALSE CLAIMS ACT.
IS EXPANDED TO INCLUDE PRIVATE
COUNSEL THERE'S NO INDICATION
FOR EXAMPLE HOW WILL THEY BE
PAID MANY CITIES DO UTILIZE
OUTSIDE COUNSEL TO DO MUNICIPAL
LITIGATION.
USUALLY THEY'RE PAID ON AN
HOURLY BASIS BUT WE DO KNOW OF
INSTANCES WHERE THEY'RE PAID ON
A CONTINGENCY FEE BASIS.
WE WOULD PREFER TO SEE THEM ON
AN HOURLY BASIS AND NOT A
CONTINGENCY FEE CASE GOING AFTER
A TAX DISPUTE THIRTY SECONDS
OKAY -- THE THRESHOLDS YES ARE
VERY VERY LOW A TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLAR WAGE DISPUTE --
DOESN'T SEEM TO BE -- OF GRAVE
CONCERN TO US ANY FRAUD IS BAD
OF COURSE BUT WHEN WE PURSUED
FOR EXAMPLE A SO CALLED TAX
SHELTERS THEY WERE GENERALLY YOU
KNOW MULTI MILLION DOLLAR THINGS.
AND THEN THERE WAS A NOTE ABOUT
THE WAY THAT THE BILL IS
STRUCTURED BECAUSE YOU ALLOW.
SECURING AUTHORITY TO GAIN
ACCESS TO TAX RECORDS THAT WOULD
INCLUDE OUTSIDE PRIVATE COUNSEL
WE PREFER NOT TO HAVE THAT.
AND THEN LASTLY PERHAPS IF YOU
DO WANT TO MOVE FORWARD IS TO
GIVE SOME CONSIDERATION OF A
SUNSET DATE THANKYOU MATT
MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AS SPECULATE
GONNA HAVE YOU GUYS JUST HANG
THERE -- IF YOU DON'T MIND AND
THEN WE'LL SEE IF WE HAVE
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE WE
WELCOME ANYONE ELSE WHO MAY BE
IN OPPOSITION.
BUT HEALTHY MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
PAUL GLAD FILLED THE ON BEHALF
OF THE MOTION PICTURE
ASSOCIATION OF AMERICA AND ALSO
THE ASSOCIATED GENERAL
CONTRACTORS -- WE REMAIN OPPOSED
BASED ON THE COMMENTS MADE BY
THE PREVIOUS WITNESSES THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
HEY COULD YOU SEE CANCER SYRIANS
CHAIR A RUG MUNCHER FROM CAL
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE REMAIN
OPPOSED WHO WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS THE THANK THE AUTHOR AND
THE THREE CHANNELS OFFICE FOR
THE EXTENSIVE ENGAGEMENT WE'VE
HAD AND WE THINK IT'S BEEN A
GOOD PROCESS WE HAVE TO CONTINUE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH IT'S A
CONVENIENT.
IT'S YOUR TURN SENATORS KEVIN
GOAL TO CALIFORNIA BANKERS
ASSOCIATION AND OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON AFTERNOON --
BENTLEY ON BEHALF OF CAL TAX THE
CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION
ALSO IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL --
WE JUST THINK THAT THE TRANSIT
AUTHORITY THAT IS DUPLICATIVE
AND UNNECESSARY ALSO THE COUNCIL
STATE TAXATION WAS IN ATTENDANCE
EARLIER THIS MORNING BUT IS
UNABLE TO BE HERE AND THEY WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO EXPRESS THEIR
OPPOSITION. TO SLEEP GRATEFUL.
THANKS VERY DO A LAST CALL LAST
CALL FOR THOSE WHO OPPOSE IF YOU
COULD PLEASE COME.
FOR CURRENCY NINE WOULD LIKE TO
RETURN BACK OVER TO THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. TO MEMBER BLOOM LOOK AT
AS WE DISCUSSED EARLIER TODAY I
THINK THERE ARE ISSUES THAT YOU
WERE COMMITTED TO BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE TO FOCUS ON IN YOU WANT
TO BE ABLE TO RESOLVE AND LIKE
TO BE ABLE.
TO GIVE YOU SOME TIME TO BE ABLE
TO RESPOND. TO THOSE WHO MAY BE
OPPOSE AND WE'D LIKE TO OPEN IT
UP. FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE.
SURE WE ARE WORKING WITH THE
OPPOSITION TO TRY AND THERE ARE
SOME OF THE CONCERNS IN FACT
SOME OF THE AMENDMENTS TAKEN
WERE TO ADDRESS THOSE CONCERNS.
WE'RE NOT TRYING TO GO AFTER
LEGITIMATE TAX DISPUTES AND WERE
HAVING CLARIFIED THAT I I WILL
ADMIT SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT
WERE BROUGHT UP.
TODAY FOR THE FIRST TIME THAT
THAT WE HAVE BEEN HEARING ABOUT
THEM.
BUT I DO WANT TO COMMENT WITH
RESPECT TO THE OUTSIDE COUNSEL
LOT OF CITIES DO HAVE THEIR CITY
ATTORNEY IS AN OUTSIDE COUNSEL.
AND THERE'S NO PROHIBITION
AGAINST CITIES SEEKING REDRESS
ON A CONTINGENCY BASIS IN FACT
THAT THAT DOES HAPPEN SO I'M.
THAT'S PART OF THE THE EXISTING
SYSTEM AND A LOT OF WE DO
PROTECT IN THIS CASE IF A KEY
TâM.
PLAINTIFF DOES COME FORWARD IN
THE GOVERNMENT DOESN'T TAKE THAT
UP THEY'RE NOT GONNA HAVE ACCESS
TO ANY OF THE CONFIDENTIAL TAX
RECORDS WE'VE MADE THAT VERY
CLEAR.
OUTSIDE COUNSEL TO A CITY WHO IS
PURSUING TAX FRAUD SHOULD
ABSOLUTELY HAVE ACCESS TO THOSE
RECORDS BUT THAT IS BEING HELD
AND IN THE GOVERNMENT TO CONTACT
AND THERE ARE.
PROTECTIONS BECAUSE WE DO NOT
WANT THROUGH THIS MECHANISM THAT
INFORMATION THAT CONFIDENTIAL
INFORMATION OF EVEN OF A TAX.
FRAUD VIOLATOR TO TO NECESSARILY
BE PUBLIC THOSE THOSE RECORDS
ARE.
ARE TO BE PROTECTED.
SO WE'RE HAPPY TO WORK THROUGH
SOME OF THESE TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE ARE FRAMING THIS IN THE WAY
THAT HE'S ABLE OF GIVING THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL THE ABILITY TO
GO AFTER TAX FRAUD.
CLOSE THAT TAX GAP HAPPY TO TALK
ABOUT THE LIMITS THAT THAT YOU
AND I IT TOOK DISCUSSED EARLIER.
AND MAKE SURE THAT THAT THEY
MAKE SENSE IN THIS CONTEXT
ALTHOUGH FUNDAMENTALLY IF
SOMEONE IS THE FRAUD IN THE
STATE.
AT THE TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLAR LEVEL OF THE TWO MILLION
DOLLAR LEVEL.
AS TAXPAYERS WE SHOULD ALL.
ACTUALLY BE CONCERNED ABOUT THAT.
BUT GIVEN THE PENALTIES THE
PENALTIES ARE IN INTENTIONALLY
STRICT ENOUGH TO MAKE SURE THAT
THIS IS BEING TAKEN SERIOUSLY
AND THAT THE TOOLS.
CAN BE EFFECTIVE THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE REALLY TIES I WOULD NEVER
QUESTION WAS RAISED ABOUT NEW
YORK STATE.
THERE IS SOME PRELIMINARY
INFORMATION ABOUT THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF NEW YORK WE
LOOKS LIKE THAT IS EFFECTIVE AND
I THINK THE AG HAS THAT
INFORMATION AND CAN ADDRESS THAT
ISSUE. FOR SURE SIR WHY NEW YORK.
IN TWENTY TEN NEW YORK ENACTED.
A VERY SIMILAR A STATUTE UPON
WHICH WERE BASING THIS AMENDMENT --
THEY HAVE COLLECTED HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS UNDER THEIR
FALSE CLAIMS XSTRATA STORY.
AS A COMMITTEES A SUMMARY
INDICATES -- DAVID THE LARGEST
SETTLEMENT WAS A THREE AND A
THIRTY MILLION DOLLAR SETTLEMENT
WITH SPRINT -- SO THEY'VE BEEN
VERY SUCCESSFUL.
SO WE'VE FOLLOW THEIR PATTERN
BUT WE'VE MADE SOME WHAT WE
THINK OR SOME IMPROVEMENTS.
OF FOR CALIFORNIA.
OUR STATUES ENTRY MORE
RESTRICTIVE ON WHAT THE PRIVATE
LAWYER A KEY TâM CAN DO.
UNLIKE NEW YORK WE SPECIFICALLY
PUT IN A PROVISION THAT SAYS THE
PRIVATE.
PLAINTIFF CANNOT GET ACCESS TO
THE TAXING AUTHORITIES RECORDS.
WE ALSO HAVE PLENTY OF AUTHORITY
UNDER THE FALSE CLAIMS ACT IN
THE EXISTS.
THE CABIN IN THE WORK OF A
PRIVATE PLAINTIFF OR A A PRIVATE
LAWYER.
WE HAVE THE ABILITY TO GO GET
THE CASE DISMISSED.
WE CAN FORCES SETTLEMENT.
WE CAN LIMIT THEIR PARTICIPATION
IN THE PROCEEDINGS.
AND OUR EXPERIENCE.
IS THAT WE WILL EXERCISE.
THOSE REMEDIES MEANS WE DON'T
WANT.
OUR BOSS CLAIMS ACT WHICH WE USE
ALL THE TIME WE DON'T WANT THAT
TO BE USED FOR HARASSMENT.
HELLO WE RESIST THAT I SHOULD
SAY THAT -- UNDERSTANDING FROM
NEW YORK AND IS A PRACTICE THAT
WE WOULD FOLLOW.
IS THAT IT THEY MAKE IT CLEAR IF
IT WASN'T ALREADY THAT IF THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE IS
CONSULTING WITH THE TAXES SORRY.
AND CONCLUDES THE CASE LACKS
MERIT.
DECLINES THE CASE THAT SENDS A
VERY STRONG SIGNAL TO PRIVATE
COUNSEL -- TTM WHO ARE AFTER ALL
PROFIT MOTIVATED BECAUSE THAT'S
THE WHOLE ENGINE OF THE FALSE
CLAIMS ACT.
IT SENDS A SIGNAL TO THEM THAT
THEY SHOULDN'T SPEND ANY MORE
MONEY CASE IN CASE THERE'S NOT
GOING TO GET ANYWHERE.
AND WE'VE BEEN -- PRETTY
SUCCESSFUL DISCOURAGING PEOPLE
UNDER THE ACT AS IT EXISTS.
AND WE'RE PRETTY CONFIDENT THAT
WOULD.
BE THE CASE.
WITH TAX AUTHORITY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH WOULD LIKE TO
TURN IT OVER QUESTIONS COMES
WITH SEMESTER.
OKAY THANK YOU [inaudible]
TENER.
LIKE TO SEE IF -- CENTER IF YOU
HAVE ANY CLOSING COMMENTS.
I THINK THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
THAT WE ARE.
WORKING ON IN LIGHT OF THE
OPPOSITION BUT THE PURPOSE OF
THIS BILL IS REALLY VERY CLEAR
GIVEN THE AMOUNT OF TAX DOLLARS
THAT ARE OUT THERE ON COLLECTED.
I THINK WE OWE IT TO ALL THE
TAXPAYERS WHO ARE PAYING TAXES
APPROPRIATELY TO DO WHATEVER WE
CAN TO MAKE SURE THAT WE COLLECT
THEM.
AT THE PENALTIES OF SEVERE THE
PENALTIES ARE SEVERE FOR TAX
FRAUD WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
THROUGH THE AMENDMENTS AND
WORKING WITH THE OPPOSITION IS
MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE SETTING.
APPROPRIATE LEVELS AND EXCLUDING.
VIEWS SO THAT THERE'S NOT A
THREAT OF USING A PROVISION LIKE
THIS AS AN UNWIELDY HAMMER.
FORCE FOR A LEGITIMATE TAX
DISPUTE BUT ONCE IT'S DETERMINED
THAT THERE HAS BEEN TAX FRAUD.
WE SHOULD BE ALLOWING THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL TO GO AFTER
THAT TAX FRAUD IN THE PENALTIES
SHOULD BE SEVERE BECAUSE OF THE
OVERALL WHAT IT COSTS TAXPAYERS
WOULD COST ALL OF US WHEN THOSE
WHO ARE NOT PAYING TACK WHO ARE --
TAXES ARE NOT PAYING THEM AND
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AND I'VE THANK YOU SO MUCH AS A
MEMBER -- IS THERE A MOTION TO
BE ABLE TO ADVANCE THE SIDE OF
NUMBER WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO IS
WE'RE GONNA HOLD THIS BILL FOR
THE MOMENT.
I WILL HAVE ADDITIONAL
INDIVIDUALS COMING WE WILL
ADVANCE EMOTION AN ITEM.
THIRTEEN AB TWELVE SEVENTY THANK
YOU WHEN I SAY THANK YOU RIGHT
THANK YOU SO MUCH PLEASE THINK
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S WELL AND
THANK YOU TO OUR OPPOSITION.
MEMBERS WE KNOW WOULD LIKE TO BE
REMOVED FOR AN ITEM NUMBER EIGHT
I WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT TO
RECOGNIZE THE MEMBER GALLAGHER.
SUMMER GALLAGHER HAS BEEN
ABSOLUTE CHAMPION FOR THE FOLKS
AT HE WORKS -- FOR UP IN YOU CAN
IN OF COURSE RIGHT IS DISTRICT --
HE HAS.
BEEN A HONEY BADGER ON THIS
ISSUE -- AND NINE EIGHTY FOUR
THIRTY AND IT IS GOING TO TAKE A
MOMENT. TO RECOGNIZE HIS EFFORTS --
IN TO SAY THANK YOU. FOR YOUR
FOCUS AND I WANT TO TAKE A
MOMENT ALSO TO RECOGNIZE CENTER
NIELSEN WHO'S JUST BEEN
PHENOMENAL I DO BETTER WORK WITH --
CONSIDER YOU TALK ABOUT A
DYNAMIC DUO BETWEEN AYE NIELSEN
AND GALLAGHER IN A FINE LAW FIRM
AS WELL.
SO -- WOULD LIKE A THEIR AGO.
SO -- AND MISTER GALLAGHER YOU
HAVE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT ON A
BEFORE THIRTY WE WELCOME A
TRUNCATED VERSION OF YOUR
STATEMENT.
AND THE FLOOR IS YOURS SIR AND
WELCOME TO COMMITTEE.
YES SIR THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN -- APPRECIATE THAT --
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING VERY HARD
ON THIS ISSUE AND AND MANY
OTHERS AS WE SEEK.
TO RECOVER FROM THE CAMPFIRE --
NOTE THAT WE WERE JUST IN
ANOTHER COMMITTEE TOGETHER ON
ANOTHER ISSUE -- THAT IS ALSO
VERY IMPORTANT JIM GARDNER MERGE
RESPONSE BUT AB -- FOUR THIRTY
IS VERY FOCUSED ON HOUSING.
WE'VE LOST -- 14%.
OF BUTTE COUNTY'S HOUSING STOCK
ALMOST FIFTEEN THOUSAND HOMES.
ARE OF WE'VE FALLEN SEVENTEEN
PLACES MORE THAN ANY OTHER
COUNTY ON THE AFFORDABILITY
INDEX.
SO WE HAVE A SERIOUS PROBLEM
WITH HOUSING IN THE REGION AB
FOR THIRTY WOULD PROVIDE A
MINISTERIAL APPROVAL PROCESS FOR
HOUSING.
IN CITIES WITHIN THE CAMP FIRE
REGION -- AND SO -- IT'S SIMILAR
TO WHAT WE'VE DONE THIS OTHER
LEGISLATION OTHER PIECES OF
LEGISLATION INCLUDING SB THIRTY
FIVE FROM A COUPLE YEARS BACK --
BUT IS FOCUSED ON TRYING TO
STREAMLINED HOUSING PROJECTS.
IN THE AREAS AFFECTED BY THE
CAMPFIRE -- LOT OF DIFFERENT
RESTRICTIONS ON THIS THAT I
THINK MAKE SURE THAT IS GOING TO
BE RESPONSIBLE GROWTH -- BUT THE
WAY TO SUM IT UP IS THIS BILL.
PROVIDES THAT WHERE WE'VE
PLANNED FOR HOUSING IN OUR
GENERAL PLANS IN OUR ZONING.
LET'S BUILD IT.
SO THAT WE CAN GET MUCH NEEDED
HOUSING IN OF ALL LEVELS -- TO
PEOPLE WHO REALLY NEED I THE
FUTURE.
AS WITH THAT ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE I DO HAVE.
THIS WEEKEND LAYING.
ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY THANK
YOU SO MUCH MISTER GALLAGHER
MISS LAYING YOU'VE BEEN HANGING
WITH US ALL DAY WELCOME I THINK
SENATOR WORK I GET AFTER YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS CAN LAYING
ON THE OFF OF THE COUNTY OF
BUTTE.
AND STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
LEGISLATION TODAY I WOULD BE
REMISS IF I DID NOT ACKNOWLEDGE
THE INCREDIBLE HELP HAVE.
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND THE
LEGISLATURE AND ADMINISTRATION
AND OF COURSE SENATOR NIELSEN
AND EVERYTHING THAT'S BEEN DONE
TO HELP YOU COUNTY RECOVER.
THE TOWARD THAT SEVERAL OF US
WENT ON IN JANUARY WAS JUST FIVE
STAGGERING ON THE GO OVER
SEATING LIKE THAT AGAIN IN MY
LIFE AND I DO HAVE FAMILY
MEMBERS WHO HAVE A FOLKS LOST
THEIR HOME IN THE FIRE.
A HOSTING OF FOLKS THAT DID LOSE
THEIR HOME SO HIS PERSONAL FOR
ME AS WELL AND WE ASK FOR AND I
THAT TODAY THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR SOMETHING
WE NOW WOULD LIKE TO WELCOME
ANYONE WHO'S IN SUPPORT FIRST
CLASS ORGANIZATION WELCOME. TO
COMMITTEE JOHN KENNEDY WITH
WORLD COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT
THANKS CANDY.
WELCOME BACK INJURY BECAUSE IT
ARE CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
SILVIO FRY WITH THE CIVIL
JUSTICE CESSATION CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GALLERY NARROW FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN SUPPORT THANKS.
FOR ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT IF
YOU COULD PLEASE COME IN FOR
THIS TIME.
LAST CALL. TO SEE IF THERE IS
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION IF YOU
COULD PLEASE ADVANCE
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
IT NEVER S. WILL HAVE TO REMAIN
INDIVIDUALS WHO -- SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION BASIN MEMBER I WANNA
CONFIRM YOU'RE GONNA BE TAKEN
THE THE IMMINENCE IS WAS YES I
MEANT TO SAY THAT -- THAT I AM
AMENDMENTS YOU'RE GOOD YOU'RE
GOOD -- GERMAN WELCOME THE
COMMITTEE WHO WOULD LIKE TO GO
TO KICK US OFF.
I WILL THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
SENATORS MY NAME IS MATTHEW
BAKER WITH THE PLANNING
CONSERVATION AGAIN UNFORTUNATELY
HERE TO OPPOSE THIS PROPOSAL
TODAY. TWO MINUTES -- TURNING
CONSERVATION LEAGUE HAS GREAT
SYMPATHY FOR THE VICTIMS OF THE
CAMPFIRE AS WE DO WITH ALL THE
COMMUNITY STRUCK BY.
INCREASINGLY DEVASTATING FIRES A
RECENT YEARS AND WE ARE ERY
COMMITTED. TO IDENTIFYING THE
APPROPRIATE STREAMLINING
MECHANISM -- ERROR PROCESS FOR
ACCELERATING RECOVERY IN THESE
COMMUNITIES WHICH COULD INCLUDE.
A SEQUEL STREAMLINING MECHANISM --
WE DID NOT THINK THAT THIS IS
THE CORRECT APPROACH.
WE CAN THEN DISCUSS WITH THE
APPROPRIATE THREE MONEY
MECHANISM IS -- BUT WITHOUT SUCH
A PLAN WE ARE HERE NO VOTE.
AS RECENTLY AS LAST YEAR WE WORK
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE SANTA
ROSA RECOVERY BILL -- TWO TWO
SIX SEVEN THAT BILL BY
COMPARISON WAS ONLY EXPEDITED --
JUDICIAL REVIEW NOT A FULL
SEQUEL EXEMPTION IT HAD STRONG
INFILL CRITERIA IT HAD STRONG
TRANSPORTATION EFFICIENCY METRIC
FOR FOR V. M. T. NGH G..
IT HAD EXPLICIT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING REQUIREMENTS AND AN ANTI
DISPLACEMENT PROTECTIONS --
THESE ARE ALL SIMILAR THINGS TO
SB -- THIRTY FIVE WHICH IS SET
THE STANDARD FOR MINISTERIAL
APPROVAL -- THIS BILL
[inaudible]
WE ARE HAPPY THAT IT HAS BEEN
INCLUDED TO HAVE THESE
EXCLUSIONS OF SENSITIVE AREAS.
AND WE APPRECIATE SOME OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE TO THAT AND WE DO NOT
THINK THAT THAT IS ENOUGH --
BEYOND THAT IS JUST REALLY
GENERALLY -- GENERAL PLAN
CONSISTENCY THAT WOULD BE.
THE WOULD GOVERN THE VERY
SWEEPING SEQUEL EXEMPTION.
AND GENERAL PLANS JUST SIMPLY DO
NOT HAVE THE KIND OF SPECIFICITY.
TO TO IDENTIFY PERSONAL SPECIFIC
IMPACTS OR REGIONAL ACUMINATE
IMPACTS AND QUESTIONS OF
INFRASTRUCTURE WHETHER THEY'RE
CORRECT INFRASTRUCTURE IS IN
PLACE -- GENERAL PLANS ARE NOT
FISCALLY CONSTRAINED THE WAY
REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION DARN OR
ARE THEY A CONSTRAINT TO THE GHG
REDUCTION MANDATES FOR REGION'S.
THREE SEVENTY FIVE THESE ARE ALL
THINGS THAT WE THINK SHOULD BE
IN CONSIDERATION OF WITH A
RECOVERY PLAN AS WELL AS MAKING
SURE THAT WE'RE NOT DUPLICATING
THE FURTHERMORE THE MOST
IMPORTANTLY. TWO TWO SIX SEVEN
DID HAVE A PLAN.
OF WE HAD MAPS WE HAD A
DEFINITIVE PLAN IN PLACE FOR
WHERE THESE INVESTMENTS WOULD GO
AND THEY WERE CONSISTENT WITH A
ALREADY APPROVED.
COMMUNITY VETTED MASTER PLAN FOR
THE DOWNTOWN SANTA ROSA AREA.
WE STRONGLY URGE THE AUTHOR TO
GO BACK. TO THESE COMMUNITIES
AND DEVELOP.
SUCH A PLAN WITH YOU KNOW CROSS
JURISDICTIONAL COOPERATION
ROBUST COMMUNITY INPUT. TO
ENSURE THAT THIS PLAN.
NOT ONLY PROVIDE FOR THE HOUSING
NEEDS OF THE COMMUNITY BUT
REFLECTS.
THE OTHER DESIRES OF THE
COMMUNITY FOR HOW THEY WANT
THEIR COMMUNITY REBUILT.
AND ALSO WOULD DEMONSTRATE
ACHIEVEMENT OF STATE MANDATES
FOR FOR GIGI AND EQUITY.
AND AND WITH THAT WE WOULD SAY.
PLEASE DEVELOP THIS PLAN AT THAT
POINT WE WOULD BE HAPPY TO HAVE
A DISCUSSION ABOUT WHAT THE
APPROPRIATE STREAMLINING
MECHANISM IS.
WITHOUT THAT PLAN THE URGING OF
THAT RESPECTFULLY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH YOU'RE WELCOME
HANG WITH US IF YOU LIKE PLACER
WELCOME PERSON LESS ORGANIZATION
IN THE FOR SOURCE TWO MINUTES
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
ON WILL MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
STAFF MY NAME IS RICHARD HERMAN
I'M GENERAL COUNSEL.
THE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE CENTER.
I'M APPEARING HERE THIS
AFTERNOON ON BEHALF OF OUR
ORGANIZATION.
AND ALSO THE BUTTE ENVIRONMENTAL
COUNCIL AND OTHER COALITION OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE UNDER HERE TO
OPPOSE AS WELL.
OUR POSITION HAS EVOLVED
SOMEWHAT AND I WANTED TO DO
THROUGH THE CHAIR DIRECT MY
QUESTION -- TO THE ASSEMBLYMAN
AUTHOR.
DID HE ASK SAY HE'S ACCEPTED ALL
SIX OF THE AMENDMENTS THAT WERE
REQUESTED THROUGH.
CHAIRMAN ALAN AT THE ENVIRONMENT
QUALITY COMMITTEE MEETING.
WILL COME BACK TO THAT I I HAVE
THAT WRITTEN DOWN AND MAKE SURE
NEVER COME SAGE AND ALSO WE'RE
HERE TO SUPPORT THE PLANNING
CONSERVATION LEAGUES ANALYSIS AS
WELL.
WE THINK THAT'S THE RIGHT WAY TO
GO.
OUR FOCUS THIS AFTERNOON THOUGH
IN THIS COMMITTEE IS LARGELY
FOCUSED ON OUR CONCERNS ABOUT
THE FACT THAT THERE'S BEEN NO
FISCAL ANALYSIS DONE.
OF WHAT THE POTENTIAL UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES ARE.
THE CIVIC LEE WITH RESPECT TO
THE RATE OF GROWTH IN A
RELATIVELY SMALL COMMUNITIES.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE BILL ANALYSIS
THAT WAS PERFORMED BY MS WONG
FOR THE SENATE.
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY COMMITTEE
OF REVIEW.
SHE ADDRESSED THE ISSUES THAT
WE'RE MOST CONCERNED ABOUT.
AND THAT IS IS THAT.
IF YOU HAVE A VERY FAST RATE OF
GROWTH WITH THE GENERAL PLANS
BEING AS THEY ARE NONE OF THEM
ANTICIPATED WHAT'S HAPPENED SO.
TO THE EXTENT THE CHIU GENESIS
THE RAY SHOULD RATE OF GROWTH
AND THE BUILDING SPEED WHICH THE
BILL IS INTENDED TO DO.
YOU'RE GONNA SENSUALLY BLOW OUT
THE GENERAL PLAN IN THE SMALL
COMMUNITIES.
SO THE COMMUNITIES ARE THEN
GOING TO HAVE ADDITIONAL COST TO
HAVE TO UPDATE AND REDO THEIR
GENERAL PLANS WHICH IS NOT
ADDRESSED IN THIS BILL.
SECONDLY WE DON'T THINK THAT THE
SEQUEL EXEMPTION IS NECESSARY IF
THERE'S PROPER INFILL
DEVELOPMENT AND THIRDLY WHAT
WERE LARGELY CONCERNED ABOUT IS
IS THIS BILL IS DESIGNED. TO
FAST TRACK SUBDIVISION --
DEVELOPMENTS OF FIFTY ACRES OR
MORE CUMULATIVELY OR OTHERWISE.
IT WAS BROUGHT TO THE ATTENTION
OF THE COMMITTEE AT THE PREVIOUS
HEARING THE SUBDIVISION MAP ACT
WILL STILL HAVE TO BE COMPLIED
WITH.
AND IN THE AMENDMENTS TO THE
BILL THE AUTHOR IS ADDED A
HEARING PRIOR.
TO THE APPLICATION FOR THIS
STREAMLINED.
OUR PROCESSES PROPOSED IN THE
BILL.
HOWEVER WITHOUT SICK BUT IT'S
YOUR RELEVANT WITH SEQUEL IS NOT
THE PROBLEM.
AND THE STAFF REPORT FROM THE
ENVIRONMENT QUALITY COMMITTEE
ADDRESSES THAT.
AND THE OTHER THING THAT THE
COMMITTEE.
ABOUT THIRTY SECONDS -- THANK
YOU.
THE OTHER THING THAT THE
COMMITTEE ADDRESS WAS THE FACT
THAT WITHOUT HAVING
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW WE'RE NOT
GOING TO KNOW WHAT THE
INFRASTRUCTURE.
COSTS WILL BE NOR DO WE KNOW THE
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED.
AND THE CUMULATIVE AIR QUALITY
MEASURES MEASURES THAT WOULD BE
NEEDED TO BE TAKEN SO WE REMAIN.
OF TO AVAILABLE TO WORK WITH THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER I HAVE AN
APPOINTMENT TO MEET WITH THEM ON
FRIDAY.
BUT AT THIS POINT WE REMAIN
OPPOSED UNLESS IT'S AMENDED TO
ADDRESS THOSE CONCERNS THANK YOU
SO MUCH THANK YOU FOR BEING
COMMITTEE TODAY YOU'RE GONNA
HAVE YOU HANG THERE AND WE'RE
GONNA OPEN UP FOR THOSE WHO RE
ALSO OPPOSED IF YOU COULD PLEASE
COME FORWARD.
LOOKING FOR YOUR FIRST AND LAST
NAME AN ORGANIZATION GOOD
AFTERNOON MA'AM AND THANK YOU
FOR BEING WITH US ALL DAY DELAYS
I'M GRACE MARVIN I'M A RETIRED
SOCIOLOGY PROFESSOR.
AND MY SPECIAL DEARY WAS
COMMUNITY AND I'M NOW ON A
COMMUNITY AND ACTIVISTS IN
CONSERVATION ACTIVISTS.
I'D RATHER THAN REPEAT.
MANY OF THE ITEMS THAT WERE
ALREADY LISTED I'M GOING TO JUST
MENTION A COUPLE OF OTHERS THAT
I WOULD LIKE.
TO HAVE YOU.
CONCERNED ABOUT AND THAT IS ONE
MORE DIRECTLY RELATED TO THIS
COMMITTEE ALTHOUGH THERE ARE
SUPPOSEDLY NO COST ASSOCIATED
WITH A. B. FOUR THIRTY IN ACTUAL
FACT.
THERE ARE TREMENDOUS
INFRASTRUCTURE CLERICAL AND FIRE
FIRE FIGHTING COSTS FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AS WELL AS SOME FOR
THE STATE FOR EXAMPLE REPAIRING
AND EXPANDING ROUTES NINETY NINE
AND THIRTY TO GET CALIFORNIA
TAXPAYERS WOULD HAVE TO BEAR
SUCH COSTS UNDER.
FOR THIRTY WITHOUT THE NECESSARY
INPUT BY THE PUBLIC AND THEIR
ELECTEDOFFICIALS.
SUCH INPUT IS ESSENTIAL FOR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IN ASSESSING
COSTS WATER SEWERS ROSE THAT
WILL INEVITABLY ACCOMPANY THE
URBAN SPRAWL THAT AB FOR THIRTY
PROJECTS WILL.
EMULATE MORE OVER THE BILL'S
TOTALLY INSUFFICIENT REGARD AT
THE DEMOGRAPHIC DATA AND OF THE
NEEDS OF LOW INCOME SURVIVORS OF
THE CAMPFIRE WOULD RESULT IN.
GREATER STATE AND LOCAL
SUBSIDIES FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
IF THERE IS NOT ENOUGH
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR HOMELESS
CAMP FIRE VICTIMS THESE
GOVERNMENTS WILL NEED TO DEAL
WITH EVER GROWING AMOUNTS OF
HOMELESSNESS.
WITHOUT THE BENEFIT OF SEQUEL
LOCAL COMMUNITIES WILL NOT HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO WEIGH IN ON
THE COSTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE.
SUCH AS HARMS TO THE NATURAL
ENVIRONMENT.
AIR WATER PARKS AND PUBLIC
HEALTH AS NOTED IN THE JUNE
TWENTY NINTH.
THE COMMENTS OF THE CENTER FOR
BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY.
THE BLANKET SEQUEL EXEMPTION FOR
NEW HOUSING WILL CONFLICT WITH
EXISTING STATE POLICY AND LAW WE
STRONGLY.
OPPOSE THEM IN IRAQ TYPICALLY
WHAT WE DO WHEN FOLKS ARE THIS
SECTION IS THEY'LL GIVE THE
FIRST AND LAST OKAY I IN I ONLY
HAVE TWO SENSES.
THAT'S OKAY AND I JUST WANT TO
SAY THIS IS GOING TO ASK YOU HOW
MUCH TIME YOU NEED AND WE'RE
JUST GONNA ASK A DIFFERENT
CONCLUSION ABOUT THIRTY SECONDS
HOPE WILL THANK YOU THINK OKAY.
THE BLANKET SEEK WHAT EXEMPTION
FOR NEW HOUSING WILL CONFLICT
WITH EXISTING STATE POLICY AND
LAW WHICH STRONGLY EMPHASIZES
THE NEED TO REDUCE CRITERIA AIR
POLLUTANTS IN CARBON EMISSIONS.
AND FINALLY I'M ASKING YOU
PLEASE DO NOT SUPPORT AB FOR
THIRTY WITH ITS MANY HIDDEN
COSTS TO OUR COMMUNITIES STATE
AND RESIDENT OF CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU I APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE
WITH US THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MA'AM WOULD LET
ME JUST ASK YOU BEFORE YOU GET
STARTED.
KEEP YOUR COMMENTS ABOUT A
MINUTE MA'AM BUT THAT'S THE
APPROPRIATE CAN OKAY PLEASE.
YEAH I'M A LISBETH DEVEREAUX.
AND I'M AN ARCHITECTURAL GLASS
ARTISTS TO HAVE BEEN IN BUSINESS
FOR FIFTY YEARS.
ANAHEIM AN ACTIVIST AS WELL I
WAS ON THE GENERAL PLAN TASK
FORCE IN CHICO.
AND ALSO STARTED THE CAR TO GO
SUSTAINABILITY GROUP -- AND I
THINK YOU KNOW JUST A FEW
COMMENTS ONE IS THAT THERE.
IS NO EVIDENCE YET THAT THE CAMP
FIRE VICTIMS CAN ACTUALLY AFFORD
THE HOUSING THIS PROPOSED.
FOR EIGHTY FOUR THIRTY WE
BELIEVE THIS NEEDS TO BE MORE
DOWNS BUT FIRST WE HAVE TO HAVE
MORE DATA AND I THINK I'M WITH
THE OTHER PEOPLE ON THAT THAT
THERE NEEDS TO BE MORE ANALYSIS
MADE.
BEFORE GOES FORWARD.
AND ALSO -- I THINK IN THE LAST
TEN YEARS THE LEGISLATURE'S
REALLY FOCUSED ON CLIMATE CHANGE.
AND CARBON EMISSIONS AND YOU.
ALSO CALLED THIS EARLIER A
CRITICAL ISSUE AND THE PROPOSED
DEVELOPMENT WILL CREATE COMMUTER
TRAFFIC.
AND CARBON EMISSIONS WHICH CAN'T
BE MITIGATED.
SO THE IRONY OF THIS IS THAT IS
CREATING MORE CONDITIONS WHICH
EXASPERATED THE CAMPFIRE
[inaudible]
EXACERBATED THE CAMP HIKER.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION AND I WOULD OPPOSE
UNLESS THERE ARE AMENDMENTS MADE
AND SOME FISCAL ANALYSIS THANK
YOU SO MUCH ROOM VERY GRATEFUL.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COOPERATION
AND I DO APOLOGIZE ARE MEAN
INTERRUPTED MA'AM THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME INTERRUPT YOU WOULD
LIKE TO BE TO SEE IF THERE IS.
ANYONE ELSE WHO'D LIKE TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION.
XENA WOULD LIKE TO COME BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE I THINK JUST THREE
ITEMS AND THEN I'D LIKE TO TURN
IT OVER TO THE SOME NUMBER TO
GET A COMMENT THAT I LIKE TO
TURN OVER TO CENTER NIELSEN.
AS I KNOW THIS IS CRITICAL FOR
HIM.
ON THE SUIT.
I BELIEVE THAT THERE ARE
APPROXIMATELY SIX IN INFANCY
TAKE A LOOK AT I THINK THIS
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TOOK.
THREE OBVIOUSLY -- ADDING A
PUBLIC MEETING -- IT ADVANCING
REPORT -- TO P. R. -- NGUYEN
THIS BILL IS UTILIZED AND IN
THREE OBVIOUSLY COOPERATING WITH
TRIBES IN FOCUSING ON TRAVEL
RESOURCES AND I KNOW THAT'S THE
ONE THAT'S INVOLVING YOUR
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THE RENTAL
OF THE WORDS IN YOUR MOUTH BUT
PLEASE CONTINUE.
YEAH I MEAN SO.
MR HERMAN'S WELL AWARE IN THE
LAST COMMITTEE ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY WE TOOK THREE OF THEIR
AMENDMENTS WE DID NOT TAKE THE
OTHER.
THREE AND WHAT I SAID I'M TAKING
A MEMBERS I'M TAKING YOUR
COMMITTEES.
AMENDMENTS SO.
IT NO NO NO ABSOLUTELY THAT I'M
JUST GOING OVER THE ONES THAT
WERE YEAH IF YOU.
IN IN AN ENVIRONMENT QUALITY
THOSE THE THREE THE I DISCUSSED
SO THREATENS.
AND CERTAINLY I CAN I CAN'T HELP
BUT RESPOND TO SOME OF THE
THINGS.
YOU KNOW THAT WERE BROUGHT UP.
PERSONAL APPRECIATE MR BUBBLERS
CONCERN -- FOR OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES AND AND PLANNING
PROCESS.
I INTRODUCED THIS BILL EARLY IN
THE YEAR.
THEY JUST RECENTLY CAME ON IN
OPPOSITION LAST WEEK EVEN THOUGH
THE BILL'S BEEN IN PRINT. FOR
MANY MONTHS NOW -- AND MAYBE IF
IF THEY HAD TAKEN THE TIME.
TO INVESTIGATE THEY WOULD KNOW
THAT NUMBER ONE WE'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH THE LOCAL
COMMUNITIES SINCE DAY.
ONE SINCE THE CAMPFIRE --
STARTED AND THE AFTERMATH.
WE CENTER NIELSEN AYE SENATOR
DOLLY HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH ARE
LOCALS AND THEY ALSO KNOW.
EVERY SINGLE CITY AND COMMUNITY.
THAT'S AFFECTED BY A BEFORE.
THIRTY IS AN OFFICIAL SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL -- SO IN TERMS OF THE
PLANNING THIS BEING.
THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE WE'VE BEEN
DOING IT.
AND THAT'S WHY WERE INTRODUCED
IN THIS BILL.
ARE WORKING AND PEOPLE SEEM TO
FORGET THAT THERE IS A GENERAL
PLAN IN PLACE IN EACH OF THE
CITIES.
THAT WENT THROUGH A LOT OF
SCRUTINY -- AND THAT PEOPLE HAVE
MADE PLANS TO DO RESIDENTIAL
GROWTH ALL LEVELS OF RESIDENTIAL
GROWTH INFILL YES.
MULTI FAMILY S. BUT ALSO SINGLE
FAMILY HOMES.
AND I KNOW THE PEOPLE HERE FROM
CHICO SEEM TO KNOW MORE ABOUT.
WHAT PEOPLE IN PARADISE NEED
APPARENTLY?
MENTOR ART ARE HERE DETAINEE
UNTIL IN THOSE PEOPLE THEY
SHOULD LIVE IN DANCE.
HOUSING OBVIOUSLY NOT KNOWING
THAT NINE THOUSAND HOMES IN
PARADISE WERE SINGLE FAMILY
HOMES.
BY THE WAY -- AND ALL WE ARE
TRYING TO DO.
IN THIS CASE IS REPLACE THE
HOUSING STOCK THAT WE HAVE LOST
THAT ALL LEVELS.
I THINK THAT THE OPPONENTS IN
THIS ROOM.
DON'T LIKE SINGLE FAMILY HOMES
WELL THAT'S FINE MAYBE SOME OF
THEM ACTUALLY LIVE IN THEM BUT
THEY DON'T WANT OTHER PEOPLE TO
HAVE A BUT THAT'S BEYOND BESIDES
THE POINT.
THAT DOES NEED TO BE PART OF THE
HOUSING STOCK AND IT WILL HELP
PROVIDE AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN
THE REGION IN ADDITION.
TO ALL OTHER LEVELS OF HOUSING
THAT WORD AND IT WILL BE ALLOWED
TO GO FORWARD IN A MINISTERIAL
STREAMLINED PROCESS.
PURSUANT TO THIS BILL.
THIS DOESN'T ALLOW ANYBODY TO GO
OUTSIDE OF THE GENERAL PLAN.
IT DOESN'T ALLOW ANYBODY TO GO
OUTSIDE OF THE ZONING THAT'S
ALREADY BEEN ESTABLISHED FOR THE
COMMUNITIES.
AND I ALSO WANT TO POINT OUT
BECAUSE THIS KEEPS GETTING.
PRODUCT THAT SOMEHOW THIS IS
GONNA LEAP FROG INFRASTRUCTURE.
FOR THE THERE WERE YOU KNOW THEY
WON'T BE ALLOWED TO BE THE
PLANNING AND THE GENERAL PLAN
YOU HAVE TO BUILD.
AS AS ALL OF US IN LOCAL
GOVERNMENT THAT CAME OUT OF THE
SNOW.
DEVELOPMENT STILL HAS TO FALL
ALL INFRASTRUCTURE IMPROVEMENTS
OUTLINED IN THE GENERAL PLAN.
IN OUTLINE THE DEVELOPMENT
AGREEMENT.
AND THEY START TO PAY ALL
DEVELOPER IMPACT FEES ASSOCIATED
THERE WITH.
THIS BILL DOES NOTHING TO CHANGE
THAT.
ALL IT DOES IS TRY AND
STREAMLINED PROJECTS THAT WE
HAVE ALREADY PLANNED.
FOR IN THE REGION SO I APOLOGIZE
MISTER CHAIR MAYBE GET.
ME AN OVERLY BUT THERE'S A LOT
OF PROTECTIONS IN THIS BILL TO
MAKE SURE IT'S RESPONSIBLE
GROWTH CONSISTENT WITH.
LOCAL PLANS THAT HAVE BEEN
ESTABLISHED.
AND IT IS A MUCH NEEDED THIS IS
AN EMERGENCY SITUATION IS AN
UNPRECEDENTED SITUATION.
WE'VE HAD AN ENTIRE TOWN
DECIMATED IN LAS.
AND WE KNOW THAT WE NEED HOUSING
AND WE DON'T WE QUITE FRANKLY I
DON'T HAVE TIME.
HER NAME BE ISM.
AND I DON'T HAVE TIME. FOR
RADICAL PLANS THAT HAVE NOTHING
TO DO WITH HELPING PEOPLE.
REBUILD IN THE AFTERMATH OF THIS
DISASTER.
WE HAVE WE DON'T HAVE WE CAN'T
GO BACK.
I'M LOSING PEOPLE RIGHT NOW I'M
LOSING PEOPLE MOVING TO OTHER
STATES I'M LOSING.
EMPLOYERS IN OUR REGION ARE
LOSING CRITICAL WORK FORCE AS WE
SPEAK RIGHT NOW EVERY DAY THAT
GOES BY.
IS DRASTICALLY AFFECT IN OUR
COMMUNITY.
AND SO.
I THINK WE'VE BUILT IN AGAIN.
MANY PROTECTIONS THAT ENSURE
THIS IS.
RESPONSIBLE GROWTH -- BUT WE
NEED TO ENSURE A STREAMLINED
PROCESS AND I WILL NOT ALLOW
THINGS ARE GOING.
TO TRY AND GET IN THE WAY OF
THAT AND I APPRECIATE THE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT THAT WE'VE
HAD FOR THIS BILL THROUGHOUT THE
PROCESS SEC PLUS SEVENTY PLUS
VOTES IN THE ASSEMBLY.
AND I ANTICIPATE THAT WE WILL
CONTINUE TO HAVE VERY STRONG
SUPPORT HERE IN THE SENATE
CERTAINLY FROM YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN -- AND I ENDED THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION TODAY
THANK YOU SO MUCH JUSTIN NEVER
WOULD LIKE TO TURN OVER TO
SENATOR NIELSEN PLEASE.
TURN IS HIS WENT EGGMAN
TECHNOLOGY -- HARD WORK SIR.
WELL MISTER CHAIRMAN WITH PARTY
THANKS TO YOU AND OTHERS WHO OF
WORK WHETHER.
SOMEONE GALLAGHER AND I
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR EVER SINCE
THE FIRE. FOR CONSTRUCTIVE
REBUILDING [inaudible]
RELOCATING [inaudible]
PREVENTION.
THERE IS A NEW YOURSELF OF
REPRESENTED A NEW BLAZED A TRAIL
AND YOU HELPED US RAISE OUR
TRADE.
NOW I HAVE TO SAY AND I'M
LOOKING RIGHT IN THE EYES OF
THEM THOSE PEOPLE.
WHO TESTIFIED HERE TODAY?
I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY MINUTES OR
SECONDS ANY OF YOU EVER SPENT UP
IN PARADISE.
BEFORE DURING OR AFTER THE FIRE.
I CAN ONLY ASSUME NOT MANY.
AND I ALSO WISH THAT I COULD
HAVE HAD A LOT OF THE PARADISE
DISPLACED CITIZENS.
SITTING HERE LISTENING TO YOU
TODAY.
WITH YOUR INSENSITIVITY CALLOUS
DISREGARD. FOR THEM.
THEIR FAMILIES THE FUTURES AND
WHAT THEY LOST.
AND SOME OF YOUR ORGANIZATIONS
WHO HAVE FOR DECADES DONE
EVERYTHING THEY CAN. TO
ENCOURAGE THE ENORMOUS GROWTH OF
FUELS AND ARE FORCED AND ON OUR
WILD LAND SET OF RESULTED IN
THESE FIRES.
YOU WANT TO CALL IT GLOBAL
WARMING IT STARTED A LONG LONG
TIME AGO OVER FORTY MORE YEARS
AGO.
WITH CERTAIN POLICIES THAT
PRECLUDED [inaudible]
ANY CLEANING [inaudible]
AND PROTECTIONS.
THE FORCE IN THE WILD LANDS AND
I'VE LISTENED TO YOU FOLKS HERE
FOR DECADES.
IN YOUR TESTIMONY.
AND THE ARROGANCE TO THINK THAT
YOU SHOULD TELL THEM HOW TO LIVE.
WHEN YOU DON'T WANT TO BE TOLD
YOURSELF HOW TO LIVE?
GREAT IDEAS THAT YOU HAVE.
THE CONDITION SIR THAT YOU WOULD
IMPOSE.
PARADISE WILL NEVER GET BACK.
I DON'T THINK I'LL EVER GET BACK
TO TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND NO
MATTER WHAT WE DO.
BUT IT CERTAINLY SHOULD NOT BE
DE POPULATED AS THE SEEMS TO BE
DIRECTION YOU WOULD LIKE THEM TO
GO.
NO YOU SHAKE YOUR HEAD NO SIR
BUT YOUR WORDS SAY DIFFERENTLY
OKAY AND YOUR POLICIES.
OF THE PAST [inaudible]
A DIFFERENT.
ALL WE'RE TRYING TO WORK WITH
HERE.
IS A CONSTRUCTIVE PLAN.
IT IS SAFE FOR EVERYBODY.
PRODUCT DEVELOPMENT YOU THINK
THAT RICH IS GOING TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE LEAPFROG DEVELOPMENT.
I GUESS YOU DON'T KNOW THAT RICH.
YOU DON'T KNOW A LOT OF OUR
AREAS THAT BURNED SO BADLY.
AND I WISH BEFORE YOU MAKE YOUR
CONSCIOUS PRONOUNCEMENTS.
THIS IS A GOOD WORD ARCHES
PRONOUNCEMENTS THAT YOU GO OUT
AND TAKE A LOOK.
AND TALK TO SOME OF THE PEOPLE.
WHO ARE STILL SUFFERING?
AND HAVING HORRIBLE DREAMS.
OF WHAT THEY'VE EXPERIENCED.
AND THEN MAYBE CHANNEL RESOURCES
TO HELP SOME OF US.
DURING THE CONSTRUCTIVE WAY.
TRYING TO ALLOW PEOPLE TO
REBUILD.
THEY HAVE ECONOMIC HEALTH. TO
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY FOR THEIR
CHILDREN AND THEIR GRANDCHILDREN.
TO LOCATE IN THAT AREA AGAIN.
AND FIND EMPLOYMENT SOME DAY
[inaudible]
INSTEAD [inaudible]
THE POPULATION.
MISTER CHAIRMAN.
PRIVILEGED HANG ON ONE SECOND.
SIR I'M GONNA HAVE YOU JUST HANG
ON ONE SECOND I WILL CALL ON YOU
AND I PROMISE YOU THAT ALRIGHT
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
LIKE TO BE TO SEE IF THERE IS
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE BEFORE
WE GO BACK -- TO TESTIMONY.
EIGHTY NINE SIR IF YOU DON'T
MIND IS RECEIVING YOUR FIRST AND
LAST NAME IN OUR ORGANIZATION.
YES PLEASE MISTER CHAIRMAN
RICHARD HERMAN.
I'M AN ATTORNEY HAVE BEEN
PRACTICING LAW FOR OVER THIRTY
FIVE OR FORTY YEARS I'VE
REPRESENTED DEVELOPERS.
MIKE A LITTLE CLOSER.
I REPRESENTED I'M TRYING TO STAY
CALM AND COOL BECAUSE YOU'RE
YOU'RE HEARING WAS SO
INSTRUCTIVE TO THE TO ME THIS
MORNING.
HOPEFULLY I CAN ENGAGED TO THE
CHAIR AND COLLEGIAL DISCOURSE
WITH THE SENATOR HERE.
WE'RE NOT HERE ON IDEOLOGICAL
CAMPAIGN.
WE'RE HERE'S ADDRESSING THIS
PARTICULAR BILL AND THE REASON
FOR THIS PARTICULAR BILL.
AND AS A STAFF REPORT FROM THE
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY COMMITTEE
STATED HOWEVER WHETHER PARADISE
RESIDENTS WILL RELOCATE TO THESE
CITIES IS SPECULATIVE.
AND IN THE MEANTIME OTHERWISE
APPEARS TO BE A FREE PASS FOR
DEVELOPMENT IN.
THE AREA.
THE RIGHT NOW WHAT ARE OBJECTION
IS TO THE MERITS OF THE BILL IS
THE LACK OF RECORD.
EVIDENCE OF THE DATA ANALYSIS OR
OTHER SUPPORT FOR THE CONCLUSION
THAT WE'RE GOING TO NEED SUCH A
RAPID INCREASE IN GROWTH.%
ANYWHERE BECAUSE THE PEOPLE HAVE
ALREADY LEFT SENATOR.
AND THE EXPERTS ON THE ECONOMIC
DISASTER ANALYSIS COMING FROM
STATUS YOU MAY FROM CINEMA STATE.
UNIVERSITY ARE THAT WITHIN ONE
YEARS 50% OF MY GUN AND NEITHER
THE SENATOR NOR THE ASSEMBLY MEN
CAN CHANGE THAT.
SO WHAT WE'RE FOCUSED ON IS THE
DATA AND THE FACTS THAT SUPPORT.
AN ILLOGICAL CONCLUSION THAT IS
THE PREMISE FOR THIS BILL WE ARE
NOT INSENSITIVE SENATOR I'M ONE
OF THE ATTORNEYS REPRESENTING
PEOPLE FROM PARADISE SUING P.
JEANNIE.
I AND I CAN ASSURE YOU SIR WITH
ALL DUE RESPECT I'VE INTERVIEWED
MANY OF THEM AND I KNOW THEIR
PSYCHOLOGICAL ISSUES THE POSTER
EVAN DRAMATIC STRESS DISORDER
HAVE YOU DELIGHT YOUR COMMENTS
TO ME PLEASE I BEG YOUR PARDON
SIR.
BUT I I KNOW FROM I KNOW FROM
HAVING TALKED WITH THEM AND THEN
THE NUMBERS OF THEM THAT ARE
ALREADY GONE THE PEOPLE THAT
HAVE THE MONEY.
ARE ALREADY GONE THE INSURANCE
COMPANIES HAVE ALREADY PAID OFF
MOST OF THOSE PEOPLE THEY'RE
GONE THE PEOPLE WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HERE.
AND THAT ASSEMBLYMAN GALLAGHER
IS A TRY ATTEMPTING TO ADDRESS
IS A RELATIVELY SMALL GROUP OF
PEOPLE THAT CAN'T AFFORD TO BUY
HOUSES ANYWHERE IN CHICO.
NOW BACK TO CHICO ON THAT%
PARTICULAR POINT CHICO HAS FIFTY
EIGHT HUNDRED UNITS ALREADY TO
GO IN THE PIPELINE.
THAT UNDER OUR GENERAL PLAN IN
CHICO WILL ACCOMMODATE THEM THEY
DON'T NEED THIS BILL. TWO FIFTY
HUNDRED FIFTY EIGHT HUNDRED
RIGHT THERE SO WHAT THE PREMISES
THAT HAS TO BE ADDRESSED BEFORE
YOU APPROVE THIS BILL IS.
HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE YOU REALLY
GOING TO BE SERVING HOW MANY
REALLY NEED THIS STREAMLINED
APPROACH WHAT'S REALLY AT RISK
HERE?
IS MASSIVE LARGE SCALE
DEVELOPMENT OF SUBDIVISIONS OF
FIFTY ACRES OR MORE IN SMALL
TOWNS THAT ARE GOING TO BE USING
INFRASTRUCTURE THIS PAID FOR BY
THE TAXPAYERS AND WHEN IT ISN'T
THERE YOU'RE SHIFTING THE COST.
OF THE DEVELOPMENT TO THE
TAXPAYERS IN THE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT THANK YOU
SO MUCH WHAT I'D LIKE TO BE IN
TO DO -- GENTLEMAN IS AT LIKE TO
BE TO SEE IF THERE'S ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS FROM CENTER
NIELSEN.
I THEN WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
SEE -- I HAVE A FEW QUICK
COMMENTS IN ON INTERNET OVER TO
THIS AND THEY WERE TO BE ABLE TO
CLOSE.
THEIR NIELSEN WITH THEIR THEIR
ANY -- CLOSING TIMES YOU'D LIKE
TO BE ABLE TO ADVANCE.
OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH SENATOR
LOOK HE HE HERE'S MY BOTTOM LINE
ON THIS.
NUMBER ONE THERE'S A SUNSET ON
THIS ISSUE.
IT IT'S UNCERTAIN.
TWENTY TWENTY SIX REASON WHY
THERE IS A SUNSET ON THIS ISSUES
BECAUSE FOCUSING ON URGENCY.
WE CAN'T JUST FOCUS ON PARADISE
WHERE TO FOCUS ON THE REGION.
ENTIRE REGION HAS BEEN IMPACTED.
IN TRYING TO BE A TO KEEP.
AS MANY FOLKS WITHIN THE REGION.
TO KEEP THE REGION VIBRANT.
I'M COUPLE OTHER ITEMS.
THERE IS NO PRECLUSION.
IN THIS BILL WILL NOT PRECLUDING
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS FROM
COLLECTING FEES IN WHAT WE KNOW
THAT WHEN WE DO SEE ADDITIONAL
STOCK BUILT.
OF HOMES WHETHER MULTI FAMILY OR
SINGLE FAMILY WE WILL SEE
INCREASE FEES COLLECTED.
THE OTHER CHALLENGE THE PARADISE
HAS.
WHEN IT COMES A MULTI FAMILY IS
THEIR OWN FULL CONSUMERS AREN'T
SEPTIC?
CONCEPT TECH IS THE LARGEST CITY
WEST MISSISSIPPI ON SEPTIC.
SO THAT'S THE OTHER FOCUS THAT
THE SOMEONE NUMBER IS WELL THE
SENATOR HAS IS HOW TO BE ABLE TO
BUILD -- WITHIN THE DOWNTOWN
CORE -- HIGHER INTENSE --
THEY'VE NOT BEEN ABLE TO DO THAT.
PRIOR TO THE FIRE BECAUSE
EVERYONE IS ON THE DAM SECT
SEPTIC SYSTEM.
SO THE STATE.
WORKING WITH LOCALS DRIVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER DRIVEN BY THE
SENATOR -- ALL FOCUS ON TRYING
TO GET THAT SEWER WITHIN THE
DOWNTOWN CORE SO WE'RE BUILDING
SMART HIGHER IN CENTER.
IN TRYING TO BE A TO CREATE THAT
AFFORDABLE STOCK.
AND THIS BILL CANDIDLY WILL BE
ABLE TO HELP.
THAT MULTI FAMILY HOUSING GET
BUILT FASTER.
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE ARE
CONCERNS WITH IT -- THE IS A
MEMBER THE SENATOR BEEN.-RESPONSIVE TO CHALLENGES SO FOR
EXAMPLE CHICO THE ONLY PART OF
THE BILL SHE GOES NO LONGER IN
THE BILL -- IT'S ONLY FOCUS ON A
FOR EXAMPLE OR BILL -- Là
THOUGH GIVE THE CITY MORE THAN
WILLOWS BIGGS GREATLY AND OF
COURSE -- PARADISE SO WHAT I'D
LIKE TO REDUCE TURNOVER THIS A
MEMBER TO BE ABLE TO HAVE SOME
CLOSING COMMENTS.
AGAIN I APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS
SIR -- AND ALSO THE PASSION --
AND THAT IS GREATLY APPRECIATED
AND YOU JUST WANNA IN THE HERE.
CENTER NIELSEN THANK YOU FOR
YOUR WORK YOU'VE BEEN TIRELESS
YOU'VE BEEN DOG -- IN CANNOT SAY
THINKING OFTEN SO GRATEFUL TO
WORK WITH YOU AND I'LL TURN OVER
TO US IN OUR GALLAGHER TO BE
ABLE TO CLOSE.
IT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
AND ALL POINTS -- VERY WELL
STATED -- TO TO MISTER HERMAN
SPECIFIC POINT ABOUT.
DATA.
WE DO KNOW FOR A FACT FROM
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THERE ARE
TWENTY THOUSAND MORE PEOPLE
LIVING IN CHICO TODAY.
THAN THERE WERE PREVIOUS TO THE
CAMPFIRE WE KNOW THERE'S 20%.
MORE PEOPLE IN OR TODAY THAN
THERE WERE PRIOR TO THE CAMPFIRE.
THAT'S NOT BECAUSE THEY BUILT
MORE HOUSING BY THE WAY
OBVIOUSLY IT'S BECAUSE THOSE ARE
PEOPLE WHO ARE REFUGEES.
FROM THIS CAMP FIRE WE KNOW THAT
THERE ARE FEMA CAMP SITES.
IN YUBA CITY.
IN ORLAND [inaudible]
IN GREATLY. FOUR HUNDRED UNITS
ABOUT TO GOING TO GREATLY
THIRTEEN HUNDRED PEOPLE THAT ARE
GOING TO BE LIVING IN GRIDLEY.
BUT ONLY FOR EIGHTEEN MONTHS
BECAUSE THAT'S ALL FEMALE GIVES
YOU AS WE ALL KNOW WELL WELL NOW.
SO WHERE THESE PEOPLE GOING TO
GO.
AFTER THE FACT IN WHERE THESE
PEOPLE IN CHICO.
GOING TO GO IF SHE GO DOESN'T
WANT TO BUILD ANYMORE.
WELL THEN WE NEED TO HAVE THE
REST OF THE REGION HOPEFULLY
BUILD MORE HOUSING NOW THERE ARE
SOME SHOVEL READY POD PROJECTS
IN CHICO HOPEFULLY THOSE WILL
MOVE FORWARD -- THAT PROVIDE
BOTH.
APARTMENTS.
MULTI FAMILY AND SINGLE FAMILY
HOMES.
THOSE OF ALREADY GONE TO A
SEQUEL PROCESS AND HOPEFULLY
THEY WILL.
MOVE FORWARD AND GET BUILT BUT
WE'RE GOING TO NEED MORE HOUSING
IN IN THE REGION.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO HERE THE DEMOGRAPHIC DATA
SHOWS THAT WE NEEDED.
AND I DON'T WANT PEOPLE TO LEAVE
IT AND MEAN THAT THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT I THINK MAYBE IS
A MAYBE THERE'S I DON'T KNOW IF
THERE'S A DISAGREEMENT I HOPE
THERE'S NOT A DISAGREEMENT THERE
BECAUSE WE WANT. TO KEEP PEOPLE
IN THE REGION WE HAVE.
THERE VITAL TO OUR WORK FOR
SURVIVAL TO OUR COMMUNITIES WE
HAVE TEACHERS THE SYMBOL OF
PARADISE HIGH SCHOOL.
BELOVED PRINCIPLES JUST THERE
FOR THE GRADUATION WAS AN
AMAZING EXPERIENCE HE IS LEAVING.
BECAUSE HE CANNOT FIND HOUSING
FOR HIS FAMILY
AND GOING TO ANOTHER COMMUNITY
WE'RE LOSING HIM I DON'T WANT
THAT TO HAPPEN THAT'S WHY THIS
IS IMPORTANT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND I DO HOPE YOU WILL
PASS THIS BILL TODAY THANK YOU
SO MUCH ASSEMBLY MEMBER -- IS
THERE A MOTION.
WE HAVE A MOTIONMOTION BY
CENTER NIELSEN THE MOTION IS DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
THE SCIENTISTS ARE GOING TO
RECALL PLEASE MCGUIRE HI WHY I
AM MORE A LOT MORE LIKE I'D BILL
HERTZBERG HER CONDO NIELSEN.
NIELSEN AYE WIENER. THREE ZERO
THE BRANCH KEEP THAT BILL ON
CALL IN THE ROLE OPEN IN COME
BACK TO THAT SOON.
MASON GENERAL WE'RE GONNA
WELCOME ASSEMBLYMEMBER WEEK
SOMEONE OFFER US IN NUMBER WEEK
SINCE IN THEIR BLOOM AN APOLOGY
YOU'VE BEEN WAITING A LONG TIME
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU TO OUR
WITNESSES BY THE WAY WERE.
IN OPPOSITION ALONG WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GALLAGHER IN
SWELL SENATOR NIELSEN IS WELL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SIR THANK YOU.
A SIMILAR WICKS I APOLOGIZE.
NUMBER BALLOONS THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE ON A TURN THE
FLOOR OVER -- TO IT TOO SEVERAL
WEEKS AND I TO ME TEAM AB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY FIVE SEPTEMBER I
THINK A VOTE IN EDUCATION I'LL
BE RIGHT BACK ON THE TURN THE
GAVEL OVER. TO THE GOOD VICE
CHAIR THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MR VICE CHAIR.
AND I WANT IT BEFORE YOU LEAVE
THANK THE CHAIR FOR
CONVERSATIONS ON THIS BILL AND
THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR THEIR
WORK -- ON THE BILL AS WELL AND
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
TODAY -- WHICH WILL WANT TO LEAD
A REQUIREMENT THAT SUBSEQUENT
APPROVALS MUST BE PROCESS
MINISTER EARLY.
AND SECONDLY CLARIFIED --
CLARIFYING CHANGING COMMENT FOR
OF THE ANALYSIS.
IT'S PRETTY SIMPLE BILL.
I PROMISE AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY
FIVE ALL US CITIES TO STREAMLINE
MODERATE INCOME HOUSING.
THAT'S THAT MISSING MIDDLE THE
FOLKS THAT DON'T QUALIFY FOR
SUBSIDIES HOUSING BUT CAN'T
AFFORD THE CURRENT MARKET RATE.
OF THAT TYPE OF DEVELOPMENT WITH
THE WHEN CITIES DO NOT MEET
THEIR RENEWED IT NUMBERS FOR THE
SPECIFIC INCOME LEVEL THE MOTOR
INCOME LEVEL.
IF THAT'S THE BASIC PREMISE OF
THE BILL ADDITIONALLY IT THE
BILL WILL CLOSE LOOPHOLES THAT
HAVE ARISEN SINCE SB THIRTY FIVE
IMPLEMENTATION.
WE'VE RECEIVED A LOT OF SUPPORT
ON THIS BILL WE HAVEN'T HAD A
SINGLE NO VOTE TO DATE -- IN ANY
OF THE COMMITTEES THAT WE'VE
BEEN IN -- AND IT'S SUPPORTED BY
A LOT OF DIFFERENT ORGANIZATIONS
INCLUDING THE TURNER CENTER AT
UC BERKELEY -- NOT PROFIT
HOUSING ASSOCIATIONS OF A
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA -- THE
BUILDERS -- AND MANY OTHERS AND
WE'VE HAD A LOT OF CONVERSATIONS
WITH STAKEHOLDERS ACROSS --
EVERY THING FROM ENVIRONMENTAL
ORGANIZATIONS.
TO LABOR UNIONS TO THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY AND THE BASIC PREMISE
IS THAT WE HAVE TO BUILD MORE
HOUSING AT ALL INCOME LEVELS NOW
WE HAVE A HOUSING CRISIS IN THE
STATE.
WERE THREE POINT FIVE MILLION
HOMES SHY -- AND I FEEL THIS IN
MY DISTRICT OAKLAND BERKELEY
RICHMOND ARE WITHIN A 43%
INCREASE IN HOMELESSNESS IN THE
LAST TWO YEARS.
AND A LOT OF THAT IS BECAUSE OF
THE HOUSING CRISIS THAT WE'RE
EXPERIENCING -- SO HOPEFULLY
THIS BILL WILL HELP ALLOW FOR
THAT MATTER INCOME HOUSING I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
I'VE BEEN WORKING VERY CLOSELY
WITH THE BAY AREA COUNCIL AND
MANY OTHERS ON THIS BILL.
AND SEE A MURATSUCHI SNEERS
HERE'S IS HERE TO TESTIFY AND I
WOULD -- ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
AND GOOD AFTERNOON AG COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MANY MISSY MINUSES
SANTOS WITH THE BAY AREA COUNCIL
WE ARE IN A PUBLIC POLICY
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION
REPRESENTING THE NINE COUNTY BAY
AREA.
I BECAME FOR STRONG ECONOMY AND
A BETTER QUALITY OF LIFE FOR
EVERYONE WHO THAT'S WHY HOUSING
IS SO IMPORTANT TO OUR
ORGANIZATION.
AND THERE ARE MANY NEGATIVE
CONSEQUENCES TO OUR HOUSING
CRISIS--YOU KNOW AT FOR
EXAMPLE THE UNRAVELING OF
COMMUNITIES WE HAVE SCHOOLS ARE
LOSING THEIR TEACHERS HOSPITAL
LOSING THEIR NURSES AT CITY
STRUGGLING TO HIRE AND MAINTAIN
THEIR FIREFIGHTERS AND POLICE
FIGHTERS AND THAT'S SAD BECAUSE
SAID MISSING.
THAT HENCE THE TERM MISSING
MIDDLE WHO THEY'RE BEING SQUEEZE
OUT AND ON THE LOCAL HEROES CAN
AFFORD TO STAY IN THE PLACE THAT
THEY ARE SERVICING -- THE THE
YOUNG IT'S DISTURBING EVIDENCE
IN MANY WAYS THE UC BERKELEY --
RPM PLACEMENT URBAN DISPLACEMENT
PROJECT DOCUMENTED THAT
DISPLACEMENT IS OCCURRING AND
48% OF BAY AREA.
I NEIGHBORHOODS DIVIDED ALMOST
EVENLY BETWEEN LOW INCOME AND
MODERATE INCOME NEIGHBORHOODS
THE LA REPORT.
HAS THE MYSTERY THAT ONE MILLION
HOUSEHOLDS AT OR ABOVE THE
CALIFORNIA MEDIAN INCOME ARE
CROSS BIRD AND WE ARE PROUD TO
SPONSOR AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY FIVE
BECAUSE IT IS A CREATIVE
SOLUTION TO DELIVER MUCH NEEDED.
HOUSING FOR THE MIDDLE INCOME --
AND I ALSO WANT TO POINT OUT
THAT POSITIVE ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACTS OF THIS BILL -- THAT IS
HARD TO ADD THAT IT'S EASY TO
OVERLOOK -- MOST OF CALIFORNIA'S
NEW MODERATELY PRICED HOUSING IS
LOCATED ON THE URBAN FRINGE AND
SPRAWL STYLE DEVELOPMENTS THESE
UNITS -- PRODUCE MORE ENERGY AND
ENCOURAGE MORE DRIVING AND
THEREFORE CARBON DIOXIDE YOUR
AIR -- THERE FOR NOW THANK
CALIFORNIA IT'S MARINO PROGRESS.
PROJECTS UNDER EIGHTY FOURTEEN
EIGHTY FIVE PROVIDE PREVAILING
WAGES TO SKILLED LABORERS
ENVIRONMENTALLY FRIENDLY INFILL
DEVELOPMENT AND AFFORDABILITY
FOR MIDDLE CLASS CALIFORNIANS.
BY PASSING THIS BILL THE
LEGISLATURE WILL CONFIRM THEIR
STATE AND LOCAL POLICY LEVERS
MUST -- POSE LEVERS THAT SHOULD
PRIORITIZE HOUSING THAT BENEFIT
CALIFORNIA WORKERS CALIFORNIA'S
VERY MIDDLE GOALS AND CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME ON
BEHALF OF A COUNSELOR URGE YOU
TO SAY YES TO AB.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY FIVE THANK YOU
MISS CISNEROS DO I HAVE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER VICE CHAIR I'M
ERIN EVENTS HERE IN SUPPORT ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA EMB HABITAT
FOR HUMANITY SANDEL PROPERTIES.
TMZ PARTNERS SILICON VALLEY AT
HOME AND THE NONPROFIT HOUSING
ASSOCIATION OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON DAVID GARCIA UC
BERKELEY TURNER CENTER FOR
HOUSING INNOVATION IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MASSIVE OIL
BEHALF THE SILICON VALLEY
COMMUNITY FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT.
MARILYN HELL ON BEHALF OF BAY
AREA HOUSING ADVOCATES COALITION
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES.
WE HAVE A MOTION WE HAVE A
CLOSING STATEMENT I TOLD YOU TO
BE AN EASY BILL RIGHT -- WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
THANK YU VERY MUCH.
THEN HIS IS A BE FOURTEEN
EIGHTY FIVE DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS.
ADAM CLERK MISS LANCHESTER.
REQUIRE MORE LOCKED AYE MOORLACH
AYE BELL HERTZBERG RICARDO
NIELSEN.
NIELSEN AYE WIENER.
HE HE WILL.
THAT'S TWO ZERO ONE WILL HOLD
ROLLED OPENING THANK YOU.
IT TAKES IS NOW.
TO MR BLOOM ASSEMBLYMEMBER ROOM
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD EVENING MR VICE CHAIR
[inaudible]
SENATOR NIELSEN.
GOOD TO SEE YOU ALL -- AND FIRST
LET ME -- THANK THE STAFF FOR
THEIR HARD WORK AND THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS WILL BE ACCEPTING ALL
OF THEM AB SIXTEEN FIFTY NINE
WILL ALLOW THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES TO CREATE THE STATE'S
FIRST.
LOCAL HOUSING FINANCE
CORPORATION.
WHICH WOULD BE A NON PROFIT THAT
WILL ISSUE STATE INCOME TAX
EXEMPT BONDS AT BELOW MARKET
RATE.
THE LOW COST BONDS WILL BE THE
WILL BE USED TO FINANCE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECTS AND
ALLOW THE AGENCY TO OFFER LOW
COST MORTGAGES. TO LOW AND
MIDDLE INCOME HOME BUYERS LA'S
NEW HOUSING FINANCE AGENCY WILL
USE AN INITIAL TEN MILLION
DOLLARS TO FUND A PROJECTED ONE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE MILLION.
IN AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECTS.
THE SELF SUSTAINING MODEL DOES
NOT REQUIRE INVESTMENTS FROM THE
GENERAL FUND OR ANY TAXPAYER
DOLLARS AND INSULATES THE CITY
FROM FINANCIAL RISK.
PER THE COMMITTEE'S CONCERNS
WITHOUT AN ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY SAFEGUARDS FOR THE
NEW ENTITY.
AND OF NARAL THE TAX EXEMPTION
TO ONLY THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES.
AB SIXTEEN FIFTY NINE WILL
PROVIDE LA AND INNOVATIVE TOOL
TO CREATE A PREDICTABLE AND
STABLE SOURCE OF FUNDS FOR A
BOARD AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT.
SEAN SPEAR IS HERE HE IS THE
ASSISTANT GENERAL MANAGER IN THE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT BUREAU.
IN MAYOR GARCETTI'S OFFICE AND
HE CAN ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS AND PROBABLY HAS A FEW
COMMENTS THAT HE LIKED AT SURE
THANK YOU SOMEONE.
AGAIN MY NAME IS SEAN SPUR AND
ASSISTANT GENERAL MANAGER WITH
THE HOUSING DEPARTMENT IN LOS
ANGELES.
I JUST WANT TO BRIEFLY MENTION
OF THAT THE WE ARE WHOLE
HEARTEDLY -- IN SUPPORT OF AB
SIXTEEN FIFTY NINE IS ALONG WITH
THE AMENDMENT AS PROPOSED BY THE
COMMITTEE -- THE ASSEMBLY
MINUTES TAKEN THE TIME TO
OUTLINED ESSENTIALLY WHAT THIS --
NONPROFIT ENTITY WOULD DO AND
ITS PURPOSE -- HOWEVER I WOULD
WANT TO JUST GIVE A LITTLE BIT
OF CONTEXT VERY QUICKLY THAT --
THE CITY IS PURSUING AN
AGGRESSIVE AGENDA AROUND --
MEETING OUR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
CRISIS AS WELL AS DEALING WITH
ARE HOMELESS THIS CRISIS AS WELL --
THE THIS ENTITY ITSELF WOULD OF
COURSE LOOK AT IS A NEW TOOL
THAT WOULD ALLOW US TO ACCESS TO
THE CAPITAL MARKETS LIKE WE'VE
NEVER DATE BEEN ABLE TO DO
BEFORE.
LEVERAGING MORE THAN TEN DOLLARS
FOR EVERY LOCAL DOLLAR WE PUT
INTO HOUSING.
GIVING US MUCH MORE FLEXIBILITY
TO CREATE NEW LOAN PRODUCTS THAT
WILL EXPAND THE PIPELINE OF
AFFORDABLE IN SUPPORT OF HOUSING.
AND HELPING US TO ENCOURAGE MORE
MIXED IN INCOME DEVELOPMENTS AS
WELL. FOR THOSE REASONS MAYOR
GARCETTI IS PROUD TO SUPPORT OF
AB SIXTEEN FIFTY NINE AND
THANKFULLY SOME WOMEN. FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP ON THIS MATTER.
ON BEHALF OF THE MAYOR I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER MARKHAM BACK
THANK YOU.
BUT I GUESS SHE QUESTIONS THIS
TIME.
THE ITEM OF THE LAST TIME BUT
CINNAMON BLOOM ID I DIDN'T
REVIEW IF YOU'RE ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS YES THAT'S CORRECT.
DO I HAVE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
DO WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
DO I HAVE A MOTION TO APPROVE.
DO I HAVE A GERMAN TO CONCLUDE
HEY THERE THANK YOU SO MUCH
RIGHT AS VICE CHAIR.
THE WE HAVE A MOTION BY A CENTER
NIELSEN THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO CORPORATIONS WOULD
LIKE TO BETTER TURNED OVER TO MR
BLOOM IS BLOOM THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR WORKING WITH US.
ON THIS BILL -- AND WE ALWAYS
LIKE WHEN YOU'RE COMMITTEE.
CLOSING PLEASE YOU'RE WELCOME
YOU MISSED MY SCINTILLATING
REMARKS -- WELL -- LEAVE YOU
WITH A RESPECTFUL REQUEST FOR AN
AYE VOTE IDEA LOOK AT ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU SO MUCH AS A MEMBER
BLOOM.
AGAIN THE MOTION IS TO PASS IS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS MOTION
BY CENTER NIELSEN RECALL PLEASE
MISSING CHESTER WICKWIRE.
HI I'M MORE ON MORE LIKE I BILL.
HERTZBERG RICARDO.
NIELSEN NIELSEN NINE WIENER.
THREE ZERO FIGURE THAT YOU GET A
BIPARTISAN THIS MONTH. ZERO I
LIKE IT THANK YOU SO MUCH AS A
BLOOM.
FACING GERMAN WE ARE NOW GOING
TO BE -- HUNTING DOWN THE
AUTHORS THAT'S RIGHT WE'RE
LOOKING FOR AUTHORS -- IN IT IS
NOW TIME DO DO OUR ANNUAL OR
WEEKLY QUESTION WEEKLY QUESTIONS.
SINCE THE DANCE DIDN'T GO OVER
VERY WELL -- LET'S SEE HERE.
BUT MR I THINK WE SHOULD ASK.
IS A VICE CHAIR I WOULD ASK WHAT
IS PLANNED FOR THE SUMMER WORK
PERIOD -- I JUST APOLOGIZE THAT
DID NOT MEAN TO FRUSTRATE YOU
KNOW YOU'RE GOOD YOU'RE GOOD
YOU'RE GOOD YOU WANT TO TAKE UP.
ITEM.
TWENTY FOUR WE WE DID HAVE
PRESENTATIONS POLICY THAT
ABSOLUTELY TWO YEAH.
HANG ON ONE SECOND LET US GET
OURSELVES ORGANIZED WILL BE
RIGHT BACK WITH YOU.
IF THERE'S MOTION [inaudible]
I'M MOVING.
WHICH NUMBER SPEAKING.
TWENTY FOUR AND YOU DISPENSED
WITH -- RILEY'S ENGINE WE'RE NOT
GONNA BE GOING BACK TO ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY FOUR IS THERE A
MOTION TO BE ABLE TO PROVE ITEM.
TWENTY FOUR WE HAVE A MOTION BY
THE VICE CHAIR THE MOTION IS DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE FLOOR
MISS LANE JUST IF YOU CAN PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
WIRE HI WHY I'M MORE LONG I
WOULD LIKE AYE BELL.
HERTZBERG RICARDO NIELSEN.
NIELSEN AYE WIENER. THREE ZERO
THAT IS A THREE ZERO TO KEEP
THAT ROLE OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER NO THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISTER VICE CHAIR.
GIVE US A COUPLE MORE MINUTES
I'M GOING TO ADD ON HERE IN JUST
A BIT TO MISS WITH [inaudible]
AND EIGHTEEN YEAH.
PLEASE IN GERMAN WE'RE GONNA BE
ADDING ON ABSENT MEMBERS ON ITEM
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY FOURTEEN EIGHTY
FIVE THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
CURRENT VOTERS TO ZERO MISS
LANCHESTER CHOIR HI WHY I THREE
THREE ZERO WE'RE GONNA KEEP THAT
ROLE OPEN UNTIL WE GET.
THE REMAINING MEMBERS THE SAME
GESTURE HOW MANY MORE BILLS WE
HAVE TO GO FOR TWO DAYS. THREE
MORE BILLS LAYS IN GERMAN THREE
MORE BILLS.
EXCITING.
EVERYBODY'S READY TO ROLL.
THE TELLER WAS REALLY THRILLED
THE SELLING SIDE OF YOUR BODY IS --
MS RICE YEAR.
YES ALL RIGHT THERE YOU GO.
ALL RIGHT.
THE MAN WITH THE LEGEND FROM
ORANGE COUNTY IS HERE MISTER
DAILY MR DALY IS GOING TO BE
[inaudible]
REPRESENTING.
FIND AB.
SEVENTEEN THIRTY SIX THE NUMBER
DALY YOU HAVE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
AND ITEM TWENTY THREE AB.
SEVENTEEN THIRTY SIX ASK FOR
TRUNCATED VERSIONOF YOUR
PRESENTATION THE FLOOR IS YOURS
SIR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THIS BILL REQUIRES LOCAL
AGENCIES TO ADOPT AND MAINTAIN A
POLICY FOR NOTIFYING BIDDERS OF
AN AWARD PUBLIC CONTRACT.
I APPRECIATE THE COOPERATION OF
THE CHAIR AND YOUR STAFF ON THIS
BILL.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE WITH ME IS MR SKIP DOM
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN SUB
CONTRACTORS ASSOCIATION AND WE
INTEND TO BE VERY BRIEF THANK
YOU SO MUCH SEND THEIR MISTER
DOWN THE FLOOR IS YOURS YOU DO A
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR THAT
INFORMATION
COMPRISES OF UNION AND MERIT
SHOP OPERATIONS.
I APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S FULL
RECOGNITION OF THE NEED FOR
PROMISE AND TIMELINESS IN
NOTIFICATION AND CONSTRUCTION
PROJECTS.
IT AFFECTS SCHEDULING HIRING --
PURCHASING MATERIALS ETCETERA SO
WE CERTAINLY APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SIR WE'RE NOW
GOING TO TURN IT OVER TO THOSE
WHO MAY BE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL IF YOU COULD PLEASE ADVANCE
AT THIS TIME WE'RE LOOKING FOR
THOSE WHO ARE IN SUPPORT.
YOU'RE KIDDING RIGHT JOHN
KENNEDY WITH RC RC WERE NOT IN
SUPPORT BUT WE JUST WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR IN THE
COMMITTEES THIS IS GONE THROUGH
WE HAD SERIOUS CONCERNS OF
PREVIOUS VERSIONS OF THE BILL
THOSE CONCERNS OF ALL BEEN
ADDRESSED.
THAT WE APPRECIATE WORKING WITH
YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISS KENNEDY.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT OR
SQUISHY.
XENON WE'D LIKETO BE TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE IN OPPOSITION THE
BILL IF YOU COULD PLEASE ADVANCE.
NO ONE IN OPPOSITION THIS SPRING
A BACKED INTO COMMITTEE TO SEE
IF THERE'S ANY COMMENTS
QUESTIONS OR A MOTION.
MISTER VICE CHAIR. ONE QUICK
QUESTION THOUGH SOMEONE.
DAILY WITH THIS ALSO X. BUT I
PROTESTS WE GET THOSE DONE
QUICKER.
TO LIVE I BELIEVE SO.
GREAT UNDER HIGH BELIEVE SO.
WE HAVE AS I WANTED TO MOVE IT
HEY THERE YOU GO HI DAY.
YEAH WE HAVE A MOTION BY THE
VICE CHAIR THE VICE CHAIR MOTION
IS TO PASS YOUR PREPARATIONS MR
DAILY WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE IT
WILL APPRECIATE YOUR EYES YOUR
AYE VOTE AND AGAIN THANKS FOR
YOUR TIME AND ATTENTION TO THE
BILL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH IS REALLY
MISSING JUST OF COULD PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
YEAH IT WAS.
MCGUIRE HI WHY I. MORE LONG MORE
LIKE I BILL [inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
RICARDO NIELSEN HI NIELSEN AYE
WIENER. THREE ZERO AND KEEP THAT
ROLE OPEN AND WE'LL COME BACK TO
THAT AND I AM GONNA PROMPTLY
NOTIFY MY SUBCONTRACTORS OF YOUR
ACTION TODAY HEY THERE YOU GO
DAVID THIS THAT'S FOR SURE.
EVEN AT PARADES.
ALL RIGHT.
I WE ARE GRATEFUL.
THAT -- MISS GONZALEZ IS IN THE
HOUSE TO HOUSE THANK YOU IT'S IN
THE WOMAN IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU
IT IS CO WELCOME YOU HAD A HELD
TODAY WERE NOW GONNA BE MOVING
ON TO ITEM FOURTEEN AB TWENTY
ONE NINETY SIX ASSEMBLY WOMAN.
YOU HAVE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT ON
THIS BILL IT TAKE A BIPARTISAN
FIST PUMP IT'S EIGHT GREAT BILL
AND HELP SAYS -- GO AFTER PEOPLE
WHO ARE BREAKING THE LAW I
RESPECTFULLY ASK HER AND I'VE
GOT. TO GO.
THIS REALLY IS AN IMPORTANT BILL
THOUGH -- IN VERY GRATEFUL YOU
WEREN'T JUST GIVE US A QUICK
THIRTY SECOND SO I THINK IF
YOU'RE GIVING ME THE A JUST
NOTICED.
IT SHORT NOTICE.
SO AS ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE
NINETY SIX THE WILL ESTABLISH
THE TAX RECOVERY IN THE
UNDERGROUND ECONOMY CRIME
ENFORCEMENT PROGRAM UNDER THE
DEPARTMENT JUSTICE FOR THE
PURPOSE OF COMBATING THE
UNDERGROUND ECONOMY.
BASICALLY THERE'S A TASK FORCE
BUT WE NEED STATUTORY AUTHORITY
AND TO ENSURE ALL THE AGENCIES
CAN WORK TOGETHER AND SHARE
INFORMATION IT'S BEEN SUCCESSFUL
IT WILL BE SUCCESSFUL IN WE WILL
ATTACK THE UNDERGROUND ECONOMY
BY DOING SO.
EXACTLY AS FOR MY ABOUT THINK
YOU SO MUCH FOR ALL YOUR WORK ON
THIS WE WELCOME YOU COMMITTEE
SIR YOU DO A BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MARIO
DIBERNARDO HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL HOBBY OR BUT
SERRA IS A PROUD SPONSOR OF THIS
BILL -- BILLS IMPORTANT TO
PROTECT WORKERS LAW ABIDING
BUSINESSES CONSUMERS AND TO
BRINGS LOS TAX REVENUES TO THE
STATE -- FROM THE UNDERGROUND
ECONOMY RESPECTFULLY ASK DR
THANK YOU CAN ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENT OF THIS CAST OKAY THAT
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU SOMEONE
WE'RE GONNA OPEN IT UP FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS INTO OR
OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT SUPPORT
PLEASE WELCOME.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS CAN BE DONE
HERE DURING WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE COUNCIL LABORS AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANKS FOR
BEING HERE ALL DAY TODAY WOULD
LIKE TO BE TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
NOW LIKE TO TURN OVER TO THOSE
WHO MAY BE OPPOED.
XENA AND WE HAVE A MOTION WITH
THE MOTION BY THE VICE CHAIR THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS A MANAGER
OF OPERATIONS.
IS SOMEONE WE LIKE TO CLOSE.
YOU'RE A FAST TALKER A YEAR AGO.
I RESPECT LAST NIGHT AT HARDING
THANK YOU SO.
HEY THERE AGO.
RIGHT NOW ALL.
A MISSING JUST IF YOU WANNA CALL
THE ROLL REQUIRE NINE WHY I'M
MORE LONG MORE LIKE I FAIL
HERTZBERG RICARDO NIELSEN.
NIELSEN AYE WIENER.
THAT IS A THREE ZERO VOTE WE'RE
GONNA KEEP THAT ROLE BUT IN HAVE
FOLKS AT ON THANK YOU SO MUCH.
BUT TO OUR WITNESS IN SUPPORT
ALONG WITH THE LEADERSHIP OF THE
FROM THE WOMAN COULD YOU SEE A
WE ARE NOW I BELIEVE ON THE HUNT.
FOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS.
DELIVERY THIS IS GOING TO BE
JOINING US SHORTLY.
WE HOPE.
WILL BE RIGHT BACK WITH THE WAIT
WHERE WE HAVE TO DO OUR SUMMER
WORK THREE QUESTIONS AND BY
MISTER VICE CHAIR.
MR RIVAS IS IN THE HOUSE WE HEAR
IT.
ALL RIGHT SO REAL QUICK AS THE
IS SIMILAR IS GETTING SET UP
TELL US ABOUT YOUR SUMMER WORK.
NO GO RIGHT AHEAD SIR JOHN I'M
I'M READY.
MISTER VICE CHAIR TELL US ABOUT
THE THE DENTURES I THE MORLOCK
HOUSEHOLD OVER THE SUMMER WORK.
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE BEEN FLYING
TO WISCONSIN EVERY.
NUMBER TO VISIT THE GRANDKIDS
THIS YEAR WE'RE GONNA FLY THEM.
HERE.
AND THEN.
ENJOY A FEW DAYS BEFORE THE END
OF THE BREAK AND THEN I'M GONNA
INTRODUCE MY GRANDDAUGHTER WHO'S
SEVEN JUST TURNED.
SEVENTY ON THE SENATE FLOOR ON
MONDAY AFTERNOON WITH SOMETHING
THAT SENATOR HANNAH BETH JACKSON
DID -- FEW WEEKS GO TO ONE OF
HER GRANDDAUGHTERS FROM --
CHICAGO SO WHAT WILL HAVE A
GRANDDAUGHTER FROM MILWAUKEE.
TO JUST SHOW OFF TO THE TO MY
COLLEAGUES THAT IS VERY COOL
WHAT'S YOUR NAME.
HER NAME IS GEORGIE JANE JORDY
JANE.
LOOKING TEAM FORTY SEEN JJ.
HEY I LIKE IT THERE IT IS YOU
GOT IT RIGHT THERE RIGHT ALL
RIGHT ON THANK YOU SO MUCH WE'RE
GONNA BE COMING OVER TO SENATOR
RIGHT AFTER THIS REPRESENTS.
WE ARE NOW ON OUR LAST ITEM OF
THE DAY WE'RE GOING TO ASK.
YOU TO PLEASE HAVE ALL SENATORS
PLEASE REPORT TO COMMITTEE HAD
TO BE ABLE TO ADD ON THE FINAL
VOTES IS ITEM NUMBER TWENTY SIX
A. B. SEVENTY THREE IS A MEMBER
WE WELCOME YOU TO COMMITTEE.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS SIR MISTER
CHAIR I APPRECIATE -- THE
OPPORTUNITY AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE IT'S GREAT TO BE HERE
I SO THEY WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF I KNOW WITH THE
HOLIDAY LAST WEEK THE TURN
AROUND. TO GET EVERYTHING DONE
FOR A FOR THIS -- HEARING WAS
INCREDIBLY SHORTS I APPRECIATE
THE CHAIRS ATTENTION TO THIS
BILL AND FOR THE COMMITTEE STAFF
WENT ABOVE AND BEYOND -- TO
PREPARE THE ANALYSIS -- AND TO
WORK THROUGH SOME VERY VERY
THOUGHTFUL AMENDMENTS WHICH I
WAS HAPPY TO ACCEPT I AM VERY
THANKFUL BECAUSE I BELIEVE THAT
THESE AMENDMENTS HAVE MADE THIS
BILL -- MUCH STRONGER SO STAFF --
I REALLY APPRECIATE THAT AND
THANK YOU.
BUT AGAIN I'M VERY PROUD TO BE
HERE THIS AFTERNOON TO PRESENT
TO ASSEMBLY BILL.
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY THREE IT'S A
PRIORITY BILL THE LATINO CAUCUS
NOW AND A PRIORITY FOR THE MORE
THAN NINETY THOUSAND FARMWORKERS --
THAT LIVE IN THE DISTRICT THAT I
REPRESENT AND SO THIS BILL.
IS A CRITICAL STEP FORWARD AND
ADDRESS SEEN OUR FARM WORKER
HOUSING SHORTAGE.
NOT ONLY IN THE DESERT I
REPRESENT BUT IN CALIFORNIA.
FARMWORKERS WITH OUR FAMILY
FARMERS WORK TO BRING THE
FRESHEST PRODUCE TO MARKET.
AND CERTAINLY DO THEIR PART IN
CONTRIBUTING TO THE CALIFORNIA
ECONOMY AND HELPING FEET THE
ENTIRE COUNTRY.
AND LIKE MANY OTHER WORKING
FAMILIES AND PROFESSIONALS IN
OUR STATE TO BECAUSE OF OUR
HISTORIC HOUSING CRISIS.
THERE ARE NOT ENOUGH AFFORDABLE
AND DECENT PLACES FOR
FARMWORKERS TO LIVE IN THE STATE.
ACCORDING TO LOCAL CASE STUDIES
SEVERAL LOCAL AND STATE WIDE
NEWS REPORTS.
FARMWORKERS CERTAINLY THE
DISTRICT I REPRESENT ARE LIVING
IN SUBSTANDARD AND APPALLING
ABSOLUTELY APPALLING CONDITIONS.
WE ARE FARMWORKERS LIVING IN
GARAGES.
TENTS VANS ABANDONED BUILDINGS.
WE HAVE MULTIPLE FAMILIES LIVING
IN THE SAME ONE BEDROOM
APARTMENT.
AND ACCORDING TO A LOCAL FARMER
HOUSING STUDY AN ACTION PLAN ON
AVERAGE MORE THAN SEVEN PEOPLE
SHARE A ONE BEDROOM UNIT.
AND THAT'S JUST THE AVERAGE.
SEVEN UNFORTUNATELY IT'S NOT
JUST THE WORKERS THAT.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IT'S OUR
CHILDREN AND IT'S THEIR EXTENDED
FAMILIES.
IN RURAL MONTEREY COUNTY THE
DISTRICT I REPRESENT ONE IN TEN
STUDENTS.
THIS HOMELESS.
AT TWELVE SCHOOLS THAT NUMBER IS
ONE IN.
FIVE AND AS I MENTIONED MANY
TIMES THIS SITUATION -- IT'S A
HUMANITARIAN CRISIS RIGHT HERE
IN OUR OWN STATE WHAT WE LIKE TO
CALL THE GOLDEN STATE.
AS I INTRODUCED THIS LEGISLATION
I INTRODUCED LEGISLATION BECAUSE
I BELIEVE THAT WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY WE HAVE A MORAL
OBLIGATION. TO DO SOMETHING AND
TO ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM.
AND THIS BILL IS AN IMPORTANT
FIRST STEP.
OFTEN PROGRAM A PROGRAM THAT IS
DESIGNED TO STREAMLINE THE
PROCESS BY WHICH DECENT.
QUALITY FARM WORKER HOUSING IT'S
BUILT.
IT DOES NOT ADD ADDITIONAL RED
TAPE FOR FARMERS INSTEAD.
IT HELPS MAKE IT EASIER FOR
FARMERS AND NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS TO BUILD DIGNIFIED
FAMILY FRIENDLY HOUSING.
HOUSING FOR THE WORKERS WHO
DESPERATELY NEEDED.
SO THIS IS THIS IS THIS IS BUILT
UPON STEP THEN PARTS OF THE
RIGHT DIRECTION.
AND AS MANY OF YOU KNOW I'M VERY
PASSIONATE ABOUT THIS ISSUE A
PASSION ABOUT THIS ISSUE BECAUSE
I GREW UP AND FORMER HOUSING.
IT WAS MY GRANDFATHER WHO WORKED
AT ALMADEN VINEYARDS AND PISCINE
THIS CALIFORNIA.
HE WITH MY GRANDMOTHER MY MOM
WAS A SINGLE PARENT THEY RAISED
MY BROTHER AND I AND REFLECTING
ON THIS EXPERIENCE NOW.
REFLECTING ON WHERE I CAME FROM.
HELLO I BEEN TOLD AS A CHILD.
WHO WAS LIVING IN THAT FORMER
HOUSING UNIT?
LIVING IN OVERCROWDED CONDITIONS
WITH TEN MEMBERS OF MY FAMILY.
THAT ONE DAY I'D BE SITTING HERE
SERVING IN THE CALIFORNIA STATE
LEGISLATURE.
WITH ALL OF YOU.
I WOULDN'T HAVE BELIEVED IT.
BECAUSE I WOULD NOT HAVE THOUGHT
IT POSSIBLE.
MY FAMILY DIDN'T HAVE MUCH.
BUT WE ARE FORTUNATE TO HAVE HAD
A ROOF OVER OUR HEADS.
OUR HOUSING WAS BASIC BUT A
DECENT.
AND OUR HOUSING COMPLEX WAS
LOCATED RIGHT BESIDE THE
VINEYARDS WHERE MY GRANDFATHER
WORKED FOR OVER FORTY YEARS.
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY OUR SMALL
FORMER HOUSING UNIT THEY GAVE
OUR FAMILY THE OPPORTUNITY.
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR A BETTER
LIFE.
UNFORTUNATELY FARMWORKERS THEN
AND NOW.
WE'RE NOT AND ARE NOT SO LUCKY.
THIS BILL WILL MAKE A DIFFERENCE
MAKE A DIFFERENCE IN THE LIVES
OF THOSE WHO WORK THE FEELS LIKE
MY GRANDFATHER DID.
AND IT'S GOING TO SERVE AS A
TOOL.
A TOOL TO HELP GET MORE PEOPLE
THE HOUSING THAT THEY
DESPERATELY NEED.
AND WE MUST ENSURE THAT OUR
CURRENT GENERATION OF
FARMWORKERS THAT THEIR CHILDREN
ALSO HAVE.
THE CHANCE AT A BETTER LIFE AND
A BRIGHTER FUTURE.
AND I APPRECIATE THIS
OPPORTUNITY ONCE AGAIN MISTER
CHAIR I APPRECIATE YOUR
ENGAGEMENT ON THIS BILL
ESPECIALLY ON IN THE LAST FEW
DAYS -- WITH THE QUICK
TURNAROUND TO THE FOURTH OF JULY --
SO I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEE STAFF AYE AYE I TRULY
FEEL THE AMENDMENTS THAT -- THAT
WE HAVE THE BIT THAT BEEN ABLE
TO MAKE HAVE A THIS BILL MUCH
STRONGER AND ADDRESS SOME LOCAL
CONCERNS -- AT THE COUNTY LEVEL --
BUT AT THIS TIME -- I'M GONNA
GIVE TIME FOR SPONSORS AND
SUPPORTERS TO INTRODUCE
THEMSELVES AND SPEAK ABOUT THIS
BILL THANK YOU MISTER THANK YOU
SO MUCH SOME MEMBERS WHO WOULD
LIKE TO GO TO KICK US OFF FIRST
LAST NAME ORGANIZATION OF TWO
MINUTES WE WELCOME YOU TO
COMMITTEES GOOD TO SEE SIR
[inaudible]
AMERICA.
NOW WAS WITH THE FOUNDATION --
JEREMY FOR HER WORK ON STROKES.
CALIFORNIA ALABAMA SO WORKABLE
AND INADEQUATE HOUSING
CONDITIONS BUILT ON A FARM
WORKER HOUSING SYSTEM CREATED AT
THE BEGINNING OF THE LAST
CENTURY.
THE HISTORY OF FARM WORKER
HOUSING POLICY AND OUR STATE
BEGINS WITH LABOR CAMPS.
LABOR CAMPS DID NOT HAVE ANY
TENDENCY PROTECTIONS.
LABOR CAMPS DID NOT HAVE TITLE
TWENTY FOUR REGULATIONS.
THEY DO NOT HAVE RENTS STABILITY.
LABOR CAMPS WERE COLD DAMP.
AND IN DECENT PLACES TO LIVE.
AND THEY WERE CONTROLLED BY
EMPLOYERS [inaudible]
TODAY.
FARMWORKERS ARE LIVING IN
GARAGES.
IN BARRACKS STYLE HOUSING IN
TRAILERS WITH NO AIR
CONDITIONING THAT MAKE.
SUMMER LIVING BRUTAL.
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER ROBERT RIVAS
IS FARMER HOUSING ACT PROPOSES
TO SIMPLE THINGS. ONE IS TO
EMPOWER GOOD ACTORS TO BUILD
FARM WORKER HOUSING AND DO SO
QUICKLY [inaudible]
WHILE ALSO.
PREVENTING STATE MONEY FROM
ADVANCING THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION'S IMMIGRATION
POLICIES.
INCLUDING A PROGRAM.
THAT HINDERS A FARMWORKERS
FREEDOM TO LIVE FREE FROM
CONTROL OF ANOTHER.
IT'S WORTH RESTATING THAT THIS
BILL IS VOLUNTARY.
AND OPTIONAL.
IF.
YOU DON'T AGREE WITH ANY OF THE
CRITERIA SET FORTH IN THIS BILL --
AS IT IS WRITTEN YOU CAN
CONTINUE EVERYTHING YOU'RE DOING
RIGHT NOW UNDER EXISTING LAW.
IT'S ALSO WORTH RESTATING THAT
THE H. TWO A. VISA PROGRAM
REQUIRES THE EMPLOYER TO PROVIDE
HOUSING.
AS A CONDITION OF BRINGING
WORKERS HERE FROM ANOTHER
COUNTRY.
THAT'S WHAT IT THAT'S WHAT
EMPLOYERS AGREE.
TO AS PART OF THE VISA PROGRAM
TODAY.
AND THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE DOING
NOW.
AS A RESULT STATE MONEY IS NOT
NEEDED [inaudible]
BECAUSE H. TO A GUEST WORKERS
ARE ALREADY PROVIDED HOUSING.
SO WE THANK YOU AND WE ASK FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION.
YOUR TESTIMONY ACOSTA FORCE OR
SIR THANK YOU BRIAN AGAINST ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA RURAL.
LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION ON
BEHALF OF OUR LOW INCOME --
CLIENTS INCLUDING FARMWORKERS
AND RURAL COMMUNITIES WIENER
HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
WE'VE HEARD FROM THE AUTHOR
ABOUT THE TREMENDOUS NEED FOR
FARMWORKERS HOUSING.
IN THE STATE.
THE VOTERS RECENTLY HAVE MADE A
NUMBER OF INVESTMENTS IN
ADVANCING THE PRODUCTION OF
QUALITY.
FAMILY HOUSING FOR FARMWORKERS
BOTH THROUGH THE RECENTLY
APPROVED BOND AND DID THROUGH SB
TWOS INVESTMENT OF OF ANNUAL
RESOURCES BUT WE NEED TO GO THE
NEXT STEP AND REDUCE IMPEDIMENTS
SIR.
PRODUCTION OF HOUSING AND THIS
BILL HELPS US TO DO THAT TO
REMOVE SOME OF THE LOCAL
BARRIERS HELPS CREATE.
AS PRESCRIBED INVOLUNTARY
PARTNERSHIPS WITH LANDOWNERS TO
USE AG LAND TO HELP -- PRODUCE
THAT HOUSING -- WE THINK IT'LL
BE AN IMPORTANT A TOOL FOR
ADVANCING THE PRODUCTION OF GOOD
QUALITY LONG TERM AFFORDABLE
HOUSING TO ADDRESS THE NEEDS.
OF FARMWORKERS INTO.
AND IMPROVE THE LIVING
CONDITIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
DESCRIBED WE'RE ALSO VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE TENER
PRODUCTIONS AT THE BILL PROVIDES
FOR WORKERS WHO WERE LIVING.
IN FORMER HOUSING FOR THOSE
REASONS -- WE ARE CHEN ABOUT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR TEST MEANS
FOR WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE
SUPPORT PERSON LAST SAME
ORGANIZATION SEVENS THANKS AGAIN
FOR HANGING WITH US ALL DAY THE
FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AARON
EVANS ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
DMV IN SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WELCOME BACK.
THANK YOU -- INJURED BECAUSE IT --
WITH THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION WELL WE
DIDN'T GET OUR TOP LETTER IN IN
TIME -- FOR IF YOU FOLKS IN THE
ANALYSIS WE JUST WANT TO SAY
WE'RE HERE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHARGING HEARST
HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
SANTA CRUZ COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HI MARILYN HELL ON BEHALF OF BAY
AREA HOUSING ADVOCATES SKILLED
COLLISION OFTEN SUPPORT THANKS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
RECEIVED AS ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT OR ANYONE WHO MAY BE
SQUISHY.
YEAH ALL RIGHT JOHN KENNEDY WITH
RC RC -- ONE SAY WE DON'T HAVE
AN OFFICIAL POSITION ON THE BILL
WE APPRECIATE EXTENSIVE
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE AUTHOR
STAFF.
WITH COMMITTEE STAFF THEY'VE
BEEN VERY PRODUCTIVE DISCUSSIONS
WE SHARE THE AUTHORS CONCERNED
WITH TRYING TO DRAMATICALLY
INCREASE THE HOUSING STOCK FOR
AGRICULTURE EMPLOYEES -- WE WERE
LOOKING TO PRESERVE OUR ABILITY
TO ENSURE THE HEALTH SAFETY AND
WELFARE OF THESE RESIDENTS WOULD
BE PROTECTED OVER THE LONG TERM
WE THINK THESE AMENDMENTS TO DO
THAT -- SO WE APPRECIATE AGAIN
EFFORTS TO WORK WITH ALL OF YOU
AND LOOK FOR TO REASSESS AND OUR
POSITION AS THE BILL MOVES
TOWARD THANK YOU VERY MUCH THEY
CAN SCAN A BUT I COULD SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE NOT GONNA
WELCOME THOSE WHO MAY BE OPPOSE
FOR GONNA HAVE TO INDIVIDUALS TO
BE SPEAKING.
GERMAN WE'RE GONNA HAVE BUT I
JUST THINK ROOM FOR OUR
OPPOSITION IN WELCOME YOU BACK
UP HERE IN A MOMENT.
WELCOME.
WHO LIKE A VERY KICK US OFF?
HI WELL I RIDE THE WORKING
COMMITTEE OF TWO MINUTES FIRST
LASSEN ORGANIZATION THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR BEING HERE.
AND THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS TAYLOR RUSSIAN WITH A
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU ALONG
WITH.
SEVERAL OF OUR COUNTY FROM YOURS
WE ARE OPPOSED -- TO SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY THREE OUR EMPLOYEES OUR
FAMILY AND WE SHARE AN INTEREST
JUST AS YOU ALL DO ABOUT MAKING
SURE THAT THEY HAVE SAFE
AFFORDABLE -- AND HEALTHY
HOUSING AND WHAT WE APPRECIATE
THE ATTENTION ON THE BILL WE
RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE THAT THIS
BILL MOVES THE NEEDLE IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION -- AND WE
BELIEVE IT'LL ACTUALLY HAVE THE
ANTITHETICAL EFFECT OF LIMITING
WHAT SHOULD BE VERY -- NECESSARY
HOUSING FOR OUR COMMUNITIES.
FIRSTLY WE HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT
PROHIBITING THE USE OF STATE
FUNDING SPECIFICALLY -- FOR
THOSE PROVIDED IN SB TWO FOUR
HOUSING OF H. TWO EMPLOYEES WE
CONDUCTED A SURVEY OF OUR FORTY
THOUSAND MEMBERS AND 40% ARE
EXPERIENCING LABOR SHORTAGES
RIGHT NOW.
WHEN THAT HAPPENS WE HAVE TO
UTILIZE THE H. WAY PROGRAM IT'S
A MEASURE OF LAST RESORT -- AND
UNFORTUNATELY.
ALL OF OUR DATA SHOWS THAT AGE
WE POPULATIONS WILL CONTINUE TO
GROW HERE IN CALIFORNIA SO
RESTRICTING FUNDING TO BUILD NEW
HOUSING DOESN'T TO TURN ROMAN IN
THE PROGRAM.
BUT IT DOES TIGHTEN THE
AVAILABILITY OF THE EXISTING
HOUSING STOCK IN CALIFORNIA.
I ALSO WANT TO TAKE AN
OPPORTUNITY JUST SPELL SOME
MISCONCEPTIONS ABOUT THE AGE TO
A PROGRAM THE FIRST IS THAT IT'S
A TRUMP ADMINISTRATION POLICY.
THE TRICK PROGRAM'S BEEN IN
PLACE FOR ALMOST THIRTY FIVE
YEARS WE KNOW IT'S NOT THE BEST
AND WE ADVOCATE ON A FEDERAL
LEVEL FOR CHANGES FOR THAT
PROGRAM.
AT THE SECOND IS THAT.
THE TREE PROGRAMS UTILIZED ONLY
BY LARGE SCALE FARMS THAT'S NOT
CORRECT TO FORM OF ALL SHAPES
AND SIZES PRODUCTION STYLES AND
REGION'S UTILIZE EMPLOYEES FROM
THE H. TO A PROGRAM -- AND SO IF
THE PERSPECTIVE IS TO WITHHOLD
FUNDS IN THIS BILL FROM THOSE
WHO HAVE A READILY AVAILABLE
ABILITY TO PAY.
THAT'S NOT THE CASE -- AND THEN
FINALLY IT'S NOT AS THOUGH --
ALL FORMS EITHER UTILIZED
COLLEGE TO EMPLOYEES OR NO AGE
TO EMPLOYEES WE HAVE A LOT OF
FARMS THAT UTILIZE A MIX OF AGE
TO WEIGH IN ON EACH -- TO EIGHT
SO UNDER THIS BILL IF I HAD A
HUNDRED EMPLOYEES AND ONE
HAPPENED TO BE IN AGE TO
EMPLOYEE I WOULD BE PRECLUDED
FROM USING ANY STATE FUNDING TO
BUILD FOR THE REMAINING.
NINETY NINE WE DON'T THINK THAT
A SERVICE THE BROADER PURPOSE --
RESTRICTING FUNDING FROM ONE
GROUP ACTUALLY RESTRICTS FUNDING
FROM ALL AND WE DON'T BELIEVE
THAT AFFORDABLE HOUSING SHOULD
BE A ZERO SUM GAME.
ADDITIONALLY WE HAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT THE INCENTIVE OFFERED IN
THE BILL THE WE CAN APPRECIATE
IT IS A TOOL THAT THE AUTHOR IS
OFFERING JUST ONE OF MANY --
IT'S REALLY AND ACCESSIBLE.
A FORMER BE RESPONSIBLE UNDER
THIS BILL FOR FUNDING AND
CONSTRUCTING A HOUSING UNIT AND
THEN SEATING ALL OPERATION AND
MANAGEMENT OF IT TO A THIRD
PARTY.
WELL THE RETAIN ALL LIABILITY
AND RESPONSIBILITY AND THAT IS
TOO MUCH OF A RISK FOR OUR
PARTIES TO TAKE -- YOU HAVE TO
BE A RISK TAKER TO BE A FARMER
YOU'RE AT THE MERCY OF NATURE
AND THE MARKET -- BUT WE DON'T
BELIEVE THAT EMPLOYEES HOUSING
SHOULD BE SOMETHING YOU GAMBLE
ON ONCE AGAIN WE APPRECIATE THE
ATTENTION OF THE PROBLEM BUT THE
BUILDING OF THE CARE THAT WE
JUST CAN'T TAKE ADVANTAGE OF WE
BELIEVE PERHAPS MOST ACUTELY ARE
FROM COMMUNITIES HAVE SERIES
HOUSING PROBLEMS AND WE NEED
SERIOUS.
SOLUTIONS THE DEPLORABLE
STANDARDS THAT -- THE AUTHOR AND
SPONSOR DESCRIBED IS IN THE
ABSENCE OF EMPLOYER PROVIDED
HOUSING WHICH IS WHAT WE NEED TO
ADVOCATE FOR IN THIS BILL --
UNFORTUNATELY WITH THESE FUNDING
RESTRICTIONS AND THE INCENTIVE
AS A MISSED OPPORTUNITY WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE BILL.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
OF GOVERNMENT IN AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR HEARING -- MICHAEL BILL
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
WINE GRAPE GROWERS -- WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AND THAT
TESTIFIED IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL IN ANY KAMALA THE PROCESS
BECAUSE WE AGREE WITH THE AUTHOR
WHOLE HEARTEDLY THERE IS A
SERIOUS PROBLEM.
AND WE NEED TO ADDRESS IT.
BUT THIS IS NOT THE SOLUTION.
IN ACTUALITY BECAUSE LOOK AT A
COMMON SPEND FARM BUREAU.
WE ASSOCIATED WITH THOSE
COMMENTS WE ACTUALLY THINK THIS
BILL ACTUALLY GOES OUT TO
DIRECTOR OF SOLVING THE PROBLEM.
WE WERE HOPEFUL THAT ALONG THE
WAY BECAUSE THE COMMANDER THE
AUTHOR WHICH WE TOTALLY RESPECT
APPRECIATE THE MEMBERS COULD B
WORKED OUT TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THE CONCERNS.
THAT HAS NOT HAPPENED SO
REGRETFULLY WE ARE HERE TODAY IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
FUNDAMENTALLY THE BILL IS A
WORKABLE IT'S JUST AN UNWORKABLE
APPROACH OF DOES WORK FOR THREE
REASONS ONE IT ACTUALLY REDUCES
FUNDING FOR HOUSING AT A TIME
WHEN FUNDING IS CRITICALLY
NEEDED. FOR TO US THAT DOESN'T
MAKE ANY SENSE -- TO UNDER THIS
BILL LANDOWNERS WILL BE EXPOSED
TO ADDITIONAL LIABILITY BECAUSE
OF THIRD PARTY MANAGEMENT
REQUIRED UNDER THE BILL.
WHICH IS AS POINTED OUT MAKES IT
A WORKABLE THREE THE BILL
CREATES A STREAMLINED PROCESS.
THAT JUST DOES NOT WORK.
AND WHILE IT IS REFERRED TO AS
ADOPTED IN.
IF IT HAS A 0% CHANCE OF SUCCESS
NO ONE'S GOING TO OPT IN THERE'S
NOTHING TO OPT INTO.
IT REALLY IS DOWN UP DOWN.
BECAUSE OF THE REDUCE WORKFORCE
MORE MORE GROWERS ARE HIRING AGE
TO A WORKERS.
IT AS IF IT'S A FACT OF THE
INDUSTRY AND SITUATION WE HAVE
TODAY -- I'VE TOUR IS TO A
HOUSING I'VE DESERVE THE HOUSING
AND HAVE TO PUT A GET TOGETHER
TOWARDS FOR YOU IF YOU'D LIKE
THAT HOUSING IS NOT SUB STANDARD
IN ANY WAY WHATSOEVER.
IT IS.
FINE HOUSING -- IT IS OF
REQUIRED UNDER FEDERAL LAW IT IS
EXPECTED ELLIE BY THE STATE IS
APPROVED BY THE US DEPARTMENT OF
LABOR -- AND TO GO OUT THAT
HOUSING I'M NOT QUITE SURE WHAT
THE REASON IS ESPECIALLY SINCE
THAT HOUSING IS ALSO USED TO
HOUSE OTHER WORKERS -- WE AGREE
THAT THERE NEEDS TO BE
STREAMLINED PROCESS BUT THE
PROCESS HAS TO WORK A
FUNDAMENTAL PROBLEM WITH THIS
PROCESS IS A NO LENDER IS GOING
TO LEND MONEY FOR THIS KIND OF
HOUSING.
IF YOU'RE A LENDER AND GROW
COMES USES A HEY I WANT TO TAKE
VENGEANCE STREAMLINED PROCESS I
NEED A LOAN THE LENDER IS GOING
TO SAY.
HOW MUCH OF A GOOD FOR CLOSE ON
THE PROPERTY WHEN THIS CAN BE A
FIFTY FIVE YEAR CONDITION ON
THAT PROPERTY WITH A THIRD PARTY
MANAGEMENT COMPANY?
ON TOP OF THAT WELL THE SPONSORS
CLAIM THAT THEY WANNA SEPARATION
TO THE LANDLORD OF THE EMPLOYER
THIS BILL DOESN'T ACTUALLY DO
THAT.
BECAUSE THE EMPLOYER STILL ON
THE HOOK FOR EVERYTHING SO WHAT
WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE IS IF
THERE'S A MANAGEMENT COMPANY
DOING IT THEY SHOULD ASSUME ALL
RESPONSIBILITY ALL LIABILITY SB
TRANSPARENCY.
THERE'S GOT TO BE A PROCESS
WHERE YOU CAN NEGOTIATE BASED ON
ON THE VALUE OF THE PROPERTY AND
A CAP IS SOMETHING WHERE
SUDDENLY.
THE THIRD PARTY COMES IN AND
TAKES OVER THE OPERATIONS AND
ADMINISTRATION OF THE PROPERTY
WHILE THE ROVER IS STILL ON THE
HOOK FOR EVERYTHING ELSE THE
DOESN'T ACCOMPLISH THE INTENDED --
STATED INTENT OF THE BILL THIRTY
SECONDS THANK YOU SO AS I STATED
WE SUPPORT THE INTENT OF THE
BILL WE FULLY AGREE THERE IS A
PROBLEM.
BUT THERE NEEDS TO BE A REAL
SOLUTION AND ABSENT A REAL
SOLUTION.
THIS BILL GOES IN THE OPPOSITE
DIRECTION THANKS FOR YOUR TIME
THANK YOU SO MUCH SIMILAR WE'D
LIKE TO GET A WELCOME ANYONE
ELSE IN OPPOSITION FIRST CLASS
ORGANIZATION GOOD AFTERNOON YES
GOOD AFTERNOON -- MATTER ALONG
WITH WESTERN GROWERS ASSOCIATION
WE ARE STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THE
BILL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH [inaudible]
WELCOME BACK.
VALERIE NARROW FOR THE
pWE ARE STILL POST THANK YOU.
FIFTEEN THIRTY BOILS IN BEHALF
AMERICANS DASHER GROWERS IN
CALIFORNIA SHRUBBERY COMMISSION
OPPOSITION THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WE LIKE TO GO TO DO A LAST CALL
ON ANYONE WHO IS OPPOSED TO THE
BILL IF YOU COULD PLEASE ADVANCE
IN THIS TIME.
HEARING SEEN.
NINE WE'RE GONNA ASK -- IF WE
CAN HAVE THE SERGEANTS -- BRING
A COUPLE MORE CHAIRS UP AND WE
WELCOME THOSE TWO NO IT'S OKAY
THE THE FOLKS WHO WERE IN
OPPOSITION TO STAY.
AND IF -- EITHER ONE OF THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WOULD LIKE TO BE
ABLE.
TO COME BACK UP WE WELCOME THEM
AS WELL.
THIS BRING IT INTO COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR CONVERSATIONS WE'RE
GONNA START WITH THE VICE CHAIR
MISTER MORLOCK.
MISTER CHAIR IN THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS AND THANKS
FOR MEETING WITH ME I REALLY
APPRECIATED -- BROUGHT BACK OKAY
TO MEMORIES MY MY MOTHER GREW UP
ON A FARM.
SHE HAD FIVE BROTHERS THEY ALL
WHEN IT AGRICULTURE THREE OF
THEM IN AND HAVE THEIR OWN FARMS.
ONE WITH INTO DAIRY BUSINESS
WHERE I LIVE FOR AWHILE AND
ANOTHER ONE THAT WAS IN A
INDUSTRY -- I BUT I'VE EVER IS
YOU'RE SHARING WITH THEM I I AS
A CHILD I DIDN'T.
RECALL ANY FRICTION BETWEEN.
THE HELP AND MY UNCLES THEY ALL.
WORK TOGETHER REALLY WELL THEY
WERE JUST CRITICAL ASSETS ADD TO
THE TO THE OPERATION SO I'M.
ARE STILL HAVING DIFFICULTY WITH
WITH THE BILL BUT I WAS JUST
CURIOUS ON IDEAS -- INSIDE THIS
IS SORT OF HIT ME A AND I'M JUST
WANTING MISTER FERNANDES -- DOES
DOES THE UFW INVEST IN HOUSING
AS A AN OPPORTUNITY AND AND
PROVIDE THAT AT ALL AS AN
INVESTMENT EITHER ON YOUR
BALANCE SHEET OR MAYBE IN YOUR
PENSION PLAN.
A TO MY NO.
WE'RE JUST OR EVEN LIKE GETTING
INVESTORS TOGETHER TO TRY AND DO
SOMETHING WOULD HELP.
HELP THE UFW AND AND AND YOU'RE
MEMBERS IT WAS JUST.
JUST AGAIN JUST TRYING TO THINK
OUTSIDE THE BOX SO OKAY THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR THAT'S THAT'S
ALL I HAD.
THE SWITCH WAS VICE CHAIR TO
HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
COMMENTS WE ALSO WELCOME MOTION
FOR IN TURN OVER CENTER ABOUT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN STRONG
SUPPORTER OF THIS BILL -- NO
SURPRISE.
THE BILL -- HELPS WITH --
PROVIDING.
OF FARM WORKER HOUSING -- IT'S
ONE OF THE REASONS WHY.
PROPOSITION ONE WAS SO
SUCCESSFUL IN THE LAST OF YEARS
BALLOT WHEN WE PUT THE JOE CERN
A HOUSING -- FUN IN THE
PROPOSITION -- IT -- PULLED
WIDELY SUCCESSFUL AND IT WAS
SHOWN TO BE IS ONE OF THE MAJOR
DRIVERS IN SUPPORT FOR
PROPOSITION -- ONE AND I WAS
QUITE PLEASED TO DO THE JOE
SERRANO BECAUSE I KNEW JOE
SERRANO.
AND I KNOW OF COURSE WE ALL KNOW
PHIL -- WHO IS -- STRONG
SUPPORTER AS WELL SO I THINK --
MR REEVE ASSEMBLYMAN RIVAS IS
NOT A GOOD JOB -- WE'RE WE'RE
WE'RE ON OUR WAY -- TO FINDING
MORE HOUSING THIS IS NOT.
THE ONLY SOURCE OF FUNDS FOR
HOUSING WE'RE ON OUR WAY -- TO
OF COMPLETELY REVAMPED OF OUR
FARM WORKER HOUSING PROGRAM
WE'RE TAKING STEPS WE DID LAST
YEAR WE DID PROP ONE THREE
HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS. THREE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS.
WE WORK HARD TO GET IN A LOT OF
PEOPLE SO WHAT ARE YOU DOING
THIS SHOULD BE JUST THE GENERAL
CATEGORIES A NO NO.
WE GOT HAVE FORWARD HOUSING UNIT
UNDERSTAND I WAS A FARM WORKER
FOR TEN YEARS I WORKED IN THE
FIELDS.
HOEING VEGETABLES FOR TEN YEARS
PAYING MY WAY THROUGH HIGH
SCHOOL AND COLLEGE I KNOW WHAT I
KNOW WHAT I KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE
TO BE -- LIVING IN A TENT ALONG
THE RIVER IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
RIVER SO I KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE.
SO I WAS NOT DONE AS TOLERATE.
THAT KIND OF SQUALID CONDITIONS
IN CALIFORNIA WE SAY THAT'S
UNACCEPTABLE WE GOT A GOOD CLEAN
SAFE FARM WORKER HOUSING.
NOT ONLY IT NOT ONLY AND AND AND
WE WANT IT FOR EVERY EVERY OF
THE STATE SO THIS IS JUST A
FIRST DOWN PAYMENT AS FAR AS I'M
CONCERNED. FOR FARMWORKERS
HOUSING WE OUGHT TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE FARM GIRL.
THE U. S. W. OTHER ORGANIZATIONS
THAT SUPPORT.
GOOD CLEAN HOUSING. FOR
FARMWORKERS AND JUST SAY THAT WE
JUST DON'T TOLERATE -- PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA LIVING IN HOUSING
THAT'S NOT.
NOT NOT OF GOOD QUALITY AND I
THINK ROBERT RIVAS -- FOR
INTRODUCING THIS BILL AND BE
HAPPY PROUD TO BE A CO AUTHOR
FEES ACCEPTING THAT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH DRIVING TO
SHOW QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS AND
WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE FLOOR
[inaudible]
THE PLEASE [inaudible]
BETTER CENTER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I JUST
WANTED TO ASK A COUPLE QUESTIONS
JUST TO SEE KIND OF IF ANYBODY.
HAS THE ANSWER -- PLEASE FEEL
FREE -- TO ANSWER.
OP IN READING THE ANALYSIS -- I
NOTICED THAT THE THE NUMBER OF
JOBS CERTIFIED -- ROSE FROM
200-062-2000 -- SIXTEEN
WONDERING IF THAT THOSE ARE THE
SAME NUMBERS THAT YOU ALL HAVE
IN TERMS OF AGE TO AV SAYS AND
CALIFORNIA.
IS IS THAT A PRETTY ACCURATE
NUMBER TO YOU ALL.
PLEASE TAYLOR OCEAN BUT THE
DEPARTMENT WHERE I'M SORRY
TAYLOR RUSSIAN TO CALIFORNIA.
WE DO I BELIEVE THAT THOSE
NUMBERS ARE ACCURATE BUT AS I
HAD MENTIONED WE DID A FARM
BUREAU -- SURVEY OF OUR FORTY
THOUSAND MEMBERS AND THEY HAVE
NOTED INCREASES AND CONTINUAL
INCREASES IN THEIR LABOR
SHORTAGES WHICH WILL IN.
RESULT IN INCREASES IN EACH TO
EMPLOYEES HERE IN CALIFORNIA SO
WE EXPECT THAT NUMBER TO RISE.
AND WHAT PERCENTAGE OF OF THE
TOTAL EMPLOYEES MAKE IT DOESN'T
TO BE -- EACH TO A WORKERS MAKE
UP IN TERMS OF FARMWORKERS.
WITHIN CALIFORNIA [inaudible]
YEAH.
PLEASE MISTER MILLER IN IF YOU
KNOW ME AND MY NAY RETURNS
YOURSELF I WAS A LESS THAN 10%
[inaudible]
SO.
OKAY LESS THAN 10% OKAY AND THE
DO IT DO YOU ARE YOU AWARE OF
ANY SHORTAGE -- AND IN TERMS OF
YOU KNOW HOW ZINE FOR EXISTING
WORKERS RIGHT NOW I MEAN ARE YOU
HAVING IT CHALLENGING TO BUILD
MORE WHAT.
I MEAN WHAT'S YOUR UNDERSTANDING
OF WHEN YOU'RE MEMBERS ALSO FOR
GROWERS IF YOU'RE A GROWER AND
CINEMA FOR EXAMPLE IF YOU HAVE
AGE TO A HOUSING IF YOU.
IF YOU HAVE A STREET WORKERS YOU
HAVE HOUSING AS TYPICALLY ON
PREMISES RIGHT BY -- IF YOU HAVE
OTHER FARMWORKERS MANY THEM
COMMUTE FROM THE LATER THE
COMMITTED LARGE DISTANCES SO
PART OF THE PROBLEM IS TO FIND
LOCALIZED HOUSING TO MAKE TO
REDUCE THAT COMMUTE. TO DO SAID --
IMPACT ON THE ENVIRONMENT
EVERYTHING ELSE.
AND SEVERAL OF OUR FARM
EMPLOYERS PROVIDE HOUSING AS A
CONDITION AS AN INCENTIVE SO IT
DOESN'T REQUIRE AN OBLIGATION
FOR AN ABILITY TO PAY BY THE
EMPLOYER IT'S OFFERED AS AN
INCENTIVE AND NOT SO PART OF THE
APPROACH TRAINING COURAGE PEOPLE
TO LIVE.
CLOSE TO WHERE THEY WORK JUST AS
WE ALL WOULD APPRECIATE THAT AND
TO BE ABLE TO ACCESS DOMESTIC
LABOR FORCES INSTEAD OF HAVING
TO PURSUE THE AGE TO A PROGRAM.
I AM CENTER THAT IS IT THAT'S
ALL I HAD ENOUGH YEAH AND YOU
KNOW IF I COULD ADD SOMETHING I
THINK YOU KNOW IT IT'S REALLY
POINT TO KEEP IN MIND THAT.
NO AGE TO A IS IS FROM THE
HIGHLY REGULATED YOU KNOW OF A
FEDERAL PROGRAM AND PART OF THE
YOU KNOW THOSE REGULAIONS IS A
HIGH STANDARD OF OF OF HOUSING
YOU KNOW THE THE GROWER THE FARM
OPERATION.
HAS TO PROVIDE THE HOUSING YOU
KNOW THERE'S A HIGH STANDARD
ABOUT THAT QUALITY.
AND SO.
YOU KNOW THE ONE FACTOR YOU KNOW
IN MEETING WITH WITH WITH WITH
LOCAL -- AGRICULTURAL -- FOLKS
IN IN MY DISTRICT AND THEY'RE
HERE IN SACRAMENTO CERTAINLY THE
MISSING FACTOR THE STABILIZING
FACTOR TO LABOR'S HOUSING.
AND WHEN YOU KNOW BY THE
DEFINITION THERE IS NOT A LACK --
FOR YOU KNOW A LACK OF HOUSING
FOR EXISTING AGE TO A WORKERS.
BECAUSE WORKFORCE HOUSING IS
OBVIOUSLY REQUIREMENT THE
PROGRAM WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
IS YOU UTILIZING LOCAL DATA A
FARM WORKER HOUSING -- PLAN AND
WAS A A FORMER HOUSING STATE
ACTION PLAN -- THAT WAS THE IT
WAS A REPORT THAT WAS DONE OVER
A YEAR THAT THAT IDENTIFIED --
THIS THIS FORMER COLLABORATION
IN THIS LOSE VALUE THE PARLE
VALLEY SAN BENITO COUNTY.
IDENTIFIED OVER NINETY THOUSAND
FARMWORKERS THAT BASICALLY SAID
THERE'S BEEN AN EMPHASIS ON
TEMPORARY FORMER HOUSING WHERE
THEY'RE NEEDED THE NEED IS FOR
FARM WORKER FAMILY HOUSE.
AND SO THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL
TAKE THIS LIMITED APPROACH TO
ADDRESS THAT AND TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE DIRECTING ARE LIMITED
STATE RESOURCES. TO ADDRESS THIS
PROBLEM IN WHAT WE WERE YOU KNOW
WE FEEL IT'S GOING T HAVE THE
MOST BENEFIT FOR EXISTING
FAMILIES FARMWORKER FAMILIES
HERE IN CALIFORNIA [inaudible]
THE LITTLE.
BELL HAS A MOVE THE BILL.
AT THE MOTION IS TO PASS IS A
MINUTE APPROPRIATIONS WOULD LIKE
ME TO SEE IF WE HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
HEARING SENIOR CENTER WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE AGAIN I AM I
APPRECIATE THIS OPPORTUNITY
MISTER CHAIR -- AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE RESPECT THAT'S
WHEN I THANK YOU SO MUCH AGAIN
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS A
MINUTE APPROPRIATIONS THE MOTION
MAKER WAS CENTER BELL CENTRE SIR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
I'M MORE LONG.
WARLOCK NOBEL.
WELL I HERTZBERG.
FIRST REGARD HER CONDO.
YOUR TOTAL AYE NIELSEN.
NIELSEN NOW WIENER YEAH.
FOUR I CURRENTLY ENJOYS A FOUR
EIGHT ZERO VOTE WE'RE GONNA KEEP
THAT ROLE OPEN AND THAT WE WILL
BE GETTING BACK TO YOU.
EXCUSE ME I APOLOGIZE FOR TO
FOUR TWO AM TO STAND CORRECTED
IS A FOUR TO VOTE RICKY
DEVELOPING -- AS CENTER WIENER
IS HAS FIND COMMITTEE WE THINK.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER THOSE WHO WERE
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT AND THOSE
WHO WERE TESTIFYING IN
OPPOSITION.
LAYS IN GERMAN I GIVE US A FEW
MOMENTS WE'RE GONNA GET OUR
ITEMS COLLECTED WILL BE RIGHT
BACK WITH YOU TO BE ABLE TO ADD --
NUMBERS ON AND BEFORE WE DO WHAT
WE WHAT WE FIND CENTER WIENER IN
SEE IF YOU STILL COMMITTEE
.
THE HOUSE.
LARA'S IN TURN IT OVER TO MAYES
HURTADO TO BE ABLE TO DO OUR
SENATOR LARA AWARD FOR THIS IS
OUR FINAL ONE PRIOR TO THAT --
RIGHT OVER HERE SO -- IT WE ARE
GOING TO BE HAVING HEARING BY
THE WAY HE MEMBERS ON AUGUST
FOURTEENTH WE WILL BE HAVING
HERE IN AUGUST FOURTEENTH --
NINE THIRTY WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
A THIS IS -- SENATOR MORE
WALKING CENTER HERTZBERG
FAVORITE HERE IN THE YEAR OUR
ANNUAL TAX LEVY HERE.
SO YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO WEAR
YOUR FESTIVE TAX LEVY SWEATERS --
INTO THE TO THE COMMITTEE THAT
DAY AND WE'LL BE HEARING THE
AMENDED M. T. C. A BAG BILL THAT
WILL BE BROUGHT FOR BY SOME
NUMBER CHIU -- DATACENTER BOWS
AND WIENER MYSELF AN ESTIMATE
YOU'LL BE WORKING.
RIGHT NOW WITHOUT FURTHER DO WE
HAVE AN ANNUAL AYE TRADITION
HERE I DO GIVE YOU THE CENTER
LARA AWARD IN WHO USUALLY GIVES
IT OUT IS A CENTER TITLED Là
SHE'S THE ONE THAT WINS.
HEY ANGIE MAYBE SECOND RUNNER UP --
SO I'M GETTING THE SITTERTITLE
WHO YOU LIKE TO PRESENT HERE
TODAY.
SENATOR DAY'S JOURNAL IN THE
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS THE LATEST TO
COMMITTEE TO DATE AS CENTER LARA.
HERTZBERG I THINK GIVE A FEW A
FEW WORDS YES PLEASE BECAUSE I
DO THINK THAT INTO WAS TWO
POINTS I WANT TO MAKE NUMBER ONE
IS.
YOU KNOW IT IS CHALLENGING FOR
ME TO BE THE RECIPIENT OF THIS
AWARD AS AS THE EMERITUS CHAIR
OF THIS COMMITTEE EIGHT THREE OR
FOUR WEEKS IN A ROW BY THE WAY
BUT THE SECOND POINT EXACTLY
WHAT WAS SAY IS NOT ONLY A
WINNING IT FOR THE ONE MEETING.
BUT I THINK I WANTED MOSTFOR
ALL MEETINGS SO I THINK I GET IS
A SOME KIND OF SUPER DUPER --
SENATOR ROOT LOWER AWARD BECAUSE
I AM NOT JUST FOR THIS MEETING
BUT COLLECTIVELY FOR THIS ENTIRE
LEGISLATIVE SESSION AND TO THAT
I I APOLOGIZE TO ALL OF THE
PRESENTERS.
AND TO THE EIGHTY SIX MILLION
FANS OF US -- ON TWITTER. FOR
THE IN IN OUR AND WATCHES ON
THIS BROADCAST THANK YOU SO MUCH
THE IT TO THE PEOPLE TO THE
PEOPLE LAYS IN GERMAN ONE MORE
TIME.
OUR RICARDO LARA AWARD WINNER OF
MULTIPLE TIMES.
MOST.
MAJORITY LEADER ROBERT HERTZBERG
EVERYBODY EVERY GOD RIGHT.
AND THAT'S FANTASTIC
CONGRATULATIONS -- TO THE GOOD
SENATOR -- FROM THE LOS ANGELES
SO I LAYS ON THE WAY IF YOU'RE
GONNA BE INTEL IS THAT HE'S
BINDER WILL BE COLD -- ON AUGUST
FOURTEENTH SO HE'LL HAVE A GOAL
BINDER -- A. S. A. THERE WE GO
SO HERE'S WHAT WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN WE'RE GOING TO START WITH
THE ITEM NAME DO WE HAVE OR
CONTENT.
THAT'S RIGHT IT'S IT'S MOVES
DISPENSED WITH.
SO THIS YEAR WE'RE GONNA START
WITH ONE AND WORK OUR WAY
THROUGH SO HERE WE GO.
WE HAVE ABOUT TWENTY THREE ITEMS
TO BE ABLE TO MOVE ON TO LET'S
START WITH ITEM NUMBER ONE I DO
NUMBER ONE AB.
SIXTY EIGHT THE MOTION IS TO
PASS APPROPRIATIONS THE CURRENT
VOTE IS FOUR ZERO PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS MISS
LANCHESTER TO BURKE.
HERTZBERG AYE WIENER. ZERO FIVE
ZERO THE BILL IS OUT WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE.
PLAYS IN GENERAL.
WE'RE NOT CLOSE THE ROLE QUITE
YET -- THAT'S RIGHT CONSIDERABLE.
ALL RIGHT WAS ENDING A BILL
WE'RE GONNA KEEP THE ROLE OPEN --
THEY SEEM CHEN WHEN YOU HEARD
THAT ON TAPE KEEP IN THE ROLE OF
BUT ITEM NUMBER TWO AB.
ONE FORTY TWO THE MOTION IS DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
KERN VOTE IS THREE ZERO MISSING
CHESTER.
HERTZBERG BOB HERTZBERG I IN THE
FOR ZERO FOUR ZERO FOUR ZERO
WERE GIVEN THE ROLE OPEN BRADY --
IS HERE FROM CENTER WINNERS
OFFICE I'M SURE AT BRADY HE'S AT
TRACKING DOWN MY RED SIR.
ALL RIGHT HE'S ALL OVER IT ITEM
NUMBER THREE AB ONE SIXTY EIGHT
THE MOTION VIA A POINT OF
PERSONAL PRIVILEGE PLEASE YOU
GOT TO TALK ABOUT RACE
ORIGINALLY FROM CENTER
HERTZBERG'S OFFICE HE IS ONCE
AND ALWAYS HERTZBERG EASTER.
PART OF THE FAMILY HEY THERE WE
GO.
AT HERTZBERG D. SOUND LIKE IT.
NICE WELL IN A MMENT.
HI DAVE ITEM NUMBER THREE AB ONE
SIXTY EIGHT THE MOTION IS TO
PASS APPROPRIATIONS OCCURRED
VOTE IS FOUR ZERO THIS LANCASTER
HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE HER TITLE THE
TITLE ALL RIGHT.
THAT IS A SIX ZERO VOTE WE'RE
KEEPING THE ROLE OPEN FOR
SENATOR WIENER I AM NUMBER FOUR
EIGHTY ONE SEVENTY THREE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS APPROPRIATIONS
CURRENT VOTE IS THREE ONE THE
SAME GESTURE.
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG GUY HER
CONDO.
THE CATTLE ON IT. FIVE ONE
WORKING. FIVE ONE GIVEN THE ROLE
OPEN I WILL COME BACK TO THAT
NOW WE'RE MOVING ON TO ITEM
NUMBER SIX EIGHTY TO NINETY SIX
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS A
MEDICINE APPROPRIATIONS.
THE CURRENT VOTERS THREE ONE THE
SAME GESTURE THAT'S BURKE.
REGARD HER CONDO.
RICARDO I FIND ONE THAT IS A
FIVE ONE THE BIRD KEEP THAT ROLE
OPEN CENTER WIENER.
NOW MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER
EIGHTY BEFORE THIRTY THE MOTION
IS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS THE CURRENT
VOTERS THREE ZERO MUSLIM CHESTER
FAIL.
BILL I HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG UNDER TITLE.
I SIX SIX ZERO WE'RE KEEPING THE
ROLE -- ITEM NUMBER NINE EIGHTY
FIVE ZERO EIGHT MOTION IS TO
PASS APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT VOTE
IS TWO ZERO I THANK CHESTER
HERTZBERG.
IT'S REGARDING HER TITLE.
HELLO ALL RIGHT FOUR ZERO FOUR
IS ZERO OR KEEPING THAT ROLE.
NOW ON TO ITEM NUMBER TEN EIGHTY
FIVE SEVENTY THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE FLOOR CURRENT VOTERS
THREE ONE DISINTEREST.
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG ALL RIGHT
RICARDO.
THE TITLE ON IT. FIVE ONE MISTER
CHAIRMAN.
BE CAREFUL AND ACCUSE YOU OF
CUSSING AT ME I WAS VERY FUNNY
ACTUALLY.
ALL RIGHT GOOD TIMES.
ALL RIGHT CENTER WIENER.
WE'RE GOING -- TO WE'RE GOING TO
ADD YOU ON HERE IF YOU DON'T
MIND ITEM NUMBER -- TEN EIGHTY
FIVE SEVENTY MISSING JUST A CAN
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBER WIENER.
WE ARE ONLINE SO YOU HAVE. FIVE
TWO FIVE TO WEAR CLOTHES IN THE
ROLE.
LAYS IN GENERAL NOW MOVING ON TO
ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN
TWENTY THREE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO HOUSING.
KERN VOTE IS TWO ZERO MUSLIM
CHESTER.
HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE HER CONDO.
WIENER.
WIENER ON FOUR ZERO FOUR ZERO
IT'S OUT WERE CLOSE IN THE ROLE
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE AB EIGHT
FORTY NINE THE MOTION IS DO
PASTOR PROCREATION CURRENT CODE
IS THREE ONE MISSING CHESTER
HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE HER CONDO.
THE TOTAL I ONE FIVE ONE IT'S
OUT FOR CLOSE IN THE ROLE.
ITEM NUMBER -- THIRTEEN EIGHTY
TWELVE SEVENTY THIS NEEDS A
MOTION.
I DO HAVE A MOTION FOR ITEM
THIRTEEN A. B..
TWELVE SEVENTY WE HAVE A MOTION
BY SENATOR HER TADO THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
AS A GESTURE CHOIR HI WHY I'M
MORE LARA.
NOBEL BILL I HERTZBERG.
FIRST REGARD RICARDO.
RICARDO AYE NIELSEN.
YES AND NO WAY -- WIENER ON FIVE
TWO THAT IS A FIVE TO THE BILL
IS OUT WE'RE CLOSE IN A ROW.
WE'RE NOW MOVING ON TO ITEM
NUMBER FOURTEEN AB TWELVE NINETY
SIX THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS THE
CURRENT VOTERS THREE ZERO MISS
LANCHESTER.
BELL.
BILL ALL RIGHT HERTZBERG.
WHICH REGARD RICARDO.
THE TITLE AYE WIENER.
WITH HIGH SEVEN SEVEN ZERO THE
BILL IS THAT WE'RE CLOSE IN THE
ROLE ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN MAYBE
FOURTEEN THIRTEEN THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE FLOOR
CURRENT VOTE IS TWO ONE MISS
LANCASTER.
FELL.
BILL ALL RIGHT HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE HER TITLE
[inaudible] FOR FOUR ONE THE
BILL IS OUT WE'RE CLOSING THE
ROLE FOR NOW MOVING ON TO ITEM
NUMBER SIXTEEN AB FOURTEEN
EIGHTY THREE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS THE CURRENT VOTE
IS.
THREE ZERO THIS LANCASTER BELL.
THE ALL RIGHT HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE HER TITLE.
WIENER.
WIENER I SIX ZERO YEAH.
NUMBER SIX ZERO I THAT VOTE IS
SIX ZERO THE BILL IS OUT WERE
CLOSING THE ROLE WE'RE NOW
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM SEVENTEEN
A. B. FOURTEEN EIGHTY FOR THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS FOUR ZERO
MISSING CHESTER BELL.
TELL AYE HERTZBERG AYE HERTZBERG
AYE HER CONDO. SIX ZERO SIX ZERO
THE BILL IS OUT WE'RE CLOSING
THE ROLE.
WE'RE NOW MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
EIGHTEEN A. B. FOURTEEN EIGHTY
FIVE THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
IS LANCASTER.
BELL BILL ALRIGHT HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE HER CONDO.
RICARDO AYE WIENER.
WIENER AYE SEVEN SEVEN ZERO THE
BILL IS OUR CLOTHES IN THE ROOM.
WE'RE NOW MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
NINETEEN EIGHTY FOURTEEN EIGHTY
SEVEN THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED APPROPRIATIONS THE
CURRENT VOTERS TO ONE MISSING
CHESTER HERTZBERG.
FIRST BURKE I HER CONDO
[inaudible]
WIENER.
I FOR ONE FOR ONE THAT BILL IS
OUT WE'RE CLOSING THE ROLE.
WHEN I'M GOING ON A FILE ITEM
TWENTY AB FIFTEEN EIGHTY THREE
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT VOTE IS
FOUR ZERO MISS LANCASTER DEL?
VALLE I HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE WIENER.
WIENER AYE SEVEN THAT IS A SEVEN
ZERO VOTE WE'RE CLOSING THE ROLE
THE BILL IS OUT.
NOW MOVING ON TO ITEM TWENTY ONE
A. B. SIXTEEN FIFTY NINE THE
MOTION IS DO PASSES A MINIATURE
PREPARATIONS THE CURRENT VOTE IS
THREE ZERO MISS LANE CHESTER L..
I HERTZBERG HERTZBERG I RICARDO.
YOUR TOTAL AYE WIENER.
WIENER.
THAT IS A SEVEN ZERO VOTE THE
BILL IS OUT WE'RE CLOSING THE
ROLE.
ITEM TWENTY THREE AB SEVENTEEN
THIRTY SIX THE MOTION IS TO PASS
OR PERFORATIONS CURRENT VOTE IS
THREE ZERO MISS LANE CHESTER
THEY'LL.
THEY'LL I HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE HER TITLE.
I WIENER.
WIENER HI SEVEN SEVEN ZERO
BIPARTISAN FIST PUMP THE BILL IS
OUR TO PROPOSE THE ROLE.
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY FOUR AB
SEVENTEEN FIFTY TO THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE FLOOR
CURRENT VOTE IS THREE ZERO MISS
LANCASTER.
I HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE HER CONDO.
THE TOTAL AYE WIENER.
WIENER AYE SEVEN NO.
CURRENT THAT FINAL VOTE SEVEN
ZERO THE BILL IS OUT WILL CLOSE
IN THE ROLE. TWO MORE LAYS IN
GERMAN FILE ITEM TWENTY FIVE AB
SEVENTEEN SIXTY THREE THE MOTION
IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
APPROPRIATIONS THE CURRENT VOTE
IS THREE ZERO MISS LANE CHESTER.
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG ANCHOR CARLO.
FORCING.
THE AIRLINE YOUR RECORD IS A
TYPE OF LARA [inaudible]
LARA TIME [inaudible]
THAT'S FINE.
THAT IS A FIVE ZERO THE BILL IS
OUT WE'RE CLOSE IN THE ROLE.
FINAL ITEM OF THE DAY ITEM
NUMBER. TO GO TO THE FIRST YEAH
WITH A BACKHAND WINNER ON YEAH
FILE ITEM FOR THE GROUP FILE I'M
TWENTY SIX A. B. SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY THREE THE MOTION IS DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO PREPARATIONS.
KERN VOTE IS FOR TO MISS
LANCASTER WIENER.
ITEM TWENTY SIX AB SEVENTY THREE
WIENER ALL RIGHT. TWO FIVE TO
THE BILL IS OUT AND WE'RE CLOSED
ON ROLE BEFORE WE ALL LEAVE I
THINK WE NEED TO GIVE A ROUND OF
APPLAUSE THE GOVERNMENT FIVE
STAFF.
YEAH WE'RE GONNA ADD IT WINNER
ON JUST WANTED MOM TO SAY THANK
YOU SO MUCH TO THE ENTIRE STAFF
TEAM -- TO ALL OTHER THE
REPUBLICAN SIDE AT THE GAME AS
WELL THANK YOU FOR THE
PARTNERSHIP -- THIS YEAR TO THE
VICE CHAIR THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THE PARTNERSHIP WE DO NEED TO
ADD A CENTER WIENER ON QUITE A
FEW STARTING WITH NUMBER ONE
GOING THROUGH ITEM AYE AYE AYE.
THROUGH NUMBER.
NINE SO -- THERE YOU GO BUT
EVERYONE ELSE IS IT FREE TO
LEAVE BUT IF GORE IS WE'RE GONNA
HAVE TO ADD ON CENTER WIENER.
SO -- I WE LOVE CENTER WIENER
IT'S GOOD STUFF.
PART OF OUR YOU KNOW ABSOLUTELY.
SO I SAID WIENER YOU USE IT HE'S
GOING TO GET A GOLD BINDER --
FOR AUGUST FOURTEENTH.
IT'S GONNA BE VERY IMPRESSIVE.
YES.
GOLD BINDER.
ALL RIGHT LAYS IN GENERAL NOW
MOVING ON WE'RE NOT GOING TO
MOVE BACK WE'RE GONNA TAKE UP
ITEMS [inaudible] ONE TWO THREE
FOUR SIX EIGHT AND NINE CENTER
WIENER YOUR ENROLL.
ALL RIGHT THIS TO IT FILE ITEM
ONE AT SIXTY EIGHT KERN VOTE IS
FIVE ZERO MISS LANCASTER WIENER.
WIENER I SIX SIX ZERO THE BILL
IS THAT WE'RE CLOSING THE ROLE
ITEM NUMBER TWO AB ONE FORTY TO
THE MOTION IS DO PASSES AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS THE CURRENT
VOTERS FOUR ZERO MISSING JESTER
[inaudible]
WIENER. FIVE ZERO THE BILL IS
OUT WE'RE CLOSING THE ROLE ITEM
NUMBER THREE AB ONE SIXTY EIGHT
THE MOTION IS TO PASS
APPROPRIATIONS THE CURRENT VOTE
IS SIX ZERO MISS LANE CHESTER
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT. ZERO WE'RE CLOSING
THE ROLE THE BILL IS OUT WE'RE
NOW MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOUR AB ONE SEVENTY THREE
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS OCCURRED VOTE IS.
FIVE ONE THE SAME CHESTER WIENER
WIENER ONLINE SIX ONE FINAL VOTE
SIX ONE THE BILL IS OUT WE'RE
CLOSING THE ROLE ITEM NUMBER SIX
AB TWO NINETY SIX THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED ISN'T
APPROPRIATIONS.
THE CURRENT VOTE IS FIVE ONE MS
LANE CHESTER WIENER.
WIENER ONLINE SIX ONE FINAL VOTE
SIX ONE RECALLS IN THE ROLE.
BILL IS OUT FILE ITEM NUMBER
EIGHTY FOUR THIRTY THE MOTION IS
DO PASSES AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS OCCURRED VOTE IS
SIX ZERO MISS LANCASTER WIENER
[inaudible]
WIENER I FINAL FINAL VOTE SEVEN
ZERO THE BILL IS OUR CLOSE THE
ROLE LAYS IN GERMAN AND HERE WE
GO FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE EIGHTY
FIVE ZERO EIGHT THE MOTION IS TO
PASS.
THROUGH PERFORATIONS CURRENT
LOTUS FOUR ZERO THE SAME CHESTER
WIENER.
WIENER AYE. FIVE ZERO FINAL VOTE
BILL IS OUT WILL CLOSE THE ROLE.
SPECIAL THANKS ARE SERGEANTS IS
WELL TO THE ALL THE STATS TEAMS
WERE WORKING WITH THIS --
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR.
WE'LL SEE AUGUST FOURTEENTH FOR
OUR ANNUAL TAX LEVY.
HEARING JONATHAN AND MARTY RT
SHOPPING FOR THEIR TAX LEVY.
SWEATERS ARE A HOLIDAY TAX THAT
IS WHAT IS MY RIGHT.
BE EXCITING ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
SO MUCH WE'RE JOINED